SUBCOMMITTEE THREE WILL COME TO
ORDER. GOOD MORNING IN RESPONSE
TO THE COVERT EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS ENDED
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
TO ENSURE THAT THE PUBLIC
CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WE'RE
HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE HEARINGS
IN THE CAPITAL WITH SOME
MEMBERS ABLE TO PARTICIPATE
REMOTELY HOWEVER ALL MEMBERS
TODAY WILL BE HERE IN PERSON.
THOSE PROVIDING TESTIMONY
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE TODAY ARE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY AND FOR
THOSE REMOTE PARTICIPANTS
PLEASE MUTE YOUR PHONES OR
COMPUTERS THIS WILL GREATLY AID
IN ELIMINATING ANY ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK. AND I ASK THAT EACH
TIME YOU WISH TO RECOGNIZE USED
TO RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURED IN
THE PROGRAM AND THEN ONCE YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. AT THE WILL BE
TAKEN OFF MUTE AND WHEN YOU ARE
FINISHED YOU WILL BE PLACED
BACK ON MUTE. TO ALLOW THE
PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE ALSO
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO TWO HEARING ROOMS TO THE
EXTENT THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING.
IS AVAILABLE. FOR INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER. AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. AND IT WILL BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND I
WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN. TWO TWO SIX EIGHT
ONE FIVE TWO AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS EIGHT ONE EIGHT. TWO
EIGHT ONE SEVEN. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THIS WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE
AND OR SENATE WEBSITE. PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
ACCUSED ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU
MUST ALSO MUTE THE DEVICE THAT
YOU ARE WATCHING THE HEARING ON
PRIOR TO GIVING YOUR TESTIMONY.
OTHERWISE WE'RE GONNA HAVE
FEEDBACK. WE WILL ALSO HAVE AN
EIGHTY LINE EIGHTY EIGHT LINE
FOR THOSE WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THROUGH THE SIGN
LANGUAGE INTERPRETER. THE
EIGHTY EIGHT LINE IS EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN. THREE THREE SIX.
FOUR FOUR THREE SIX IN THE
ACCESS CODE IS. THREE FOUR
EIGHT ONE ZERO THREE TWO. I
WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING
THE HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY IN
ANY INDIVIDUAL WHOSE
DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE REMOTE MEETING ROOM OR AND
HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED.
WELL EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE
TO STREAMLINE THE HEARING
PROCESS AND CONDUCT OUR
HEARINGS IN A MANNER AS CLOSE
AS POSSIBLE. THIS BIT BUT
SOMETIMES DOES TAKE LONGER AND
WE ASK THAT YOU BE PATIENT. SO
THAT ALL PARTIES CAN
PARTICIPATE. IN TODAY'S HEARING
WILL BE DISCUSSING THE MANY
REVISED PROPOSALS FROM BOTH
VARIOUS HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES RELATED DEPARTMENTS.
FOR TODAY'S HEARING WILL BE
TAKING A SPECIAL COMMENT
SECTION ON ISSUE NUMBER ONE. ON
THE SPRING BUDGET CHANGE
PROPOSAL. DEAF COMMUNITY FOR
THOSE WISHING TO UTILIZE EIGHTY
LIKE EIGHTY EIGHT LINE AND
PROVIDE COMMENTS ON THAT ISSUE.
AFTER THAT PUBLIC COMMENT
PERIOD WE WILL WAIT UNTIL ALL
ITEMS IN PART A AND PART B.
HAVE BEEN HEARD BEFORE TAKING
PUBLIC COMMENT AGAIN. NOW WILL
BEGIN. WITH PART A OF OUR
AGENDA AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES I
BELIEVE WE HAVE A DIRECTOR.
LARGE MEN WITH US TODAY DIRECT
DEPARTMENT ARE YOU HERE. I AM
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS- I AM THE US
DEPARTMENT DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENT
SERVICES- I HAVE WITH ME TODAY
CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR BRIAN
WINDSHIELD- AND WE'RE GOING TO
SPEAK TO ISSUE ONE- AND THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT OUR PROPOSAL- ON ISSUE
ONE WITH THE- FOCUS ON.
SUPPORTING THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE REGIONAL CENTER CONSUMERS
WHO ARE ALSO DEATH IS AN AREA
IN WHICH WE HAVE BEEN FOCUSING
ON ON A MORE TARGETED BASIS
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS-
SOME OF THE EFFORTS THAT WE'VE
IMPLEMENTED WAS REALLY
LISTENING TO THE COMMUNITY
HAVING SOME FOCUSED. DISCUSSION
WITH THE SELF ADVOCATES FAMILY
MEMBERS. ALSO REGIONAL CENTERS
HEARING WHAT THE CHALLENGES
WERE IN- PROVIDING SERVICES AND
I'D LIKE TO JUST REMIND THE
COMMITTEE- ONE OF THE AREAS
THAT WE'VE BEEN REALLY FOCUSED
ON. OVER GOSH CERTAINLY OVER
THE LAST FIVE YEARS- A BIT
BEFORE BUT CONCENTRATED EFFORT
IN THE MOST RECENT YEARS ON
SERVICE ACCESS AND EQUITY TO
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE NOT
ACCESSING SERVICES AT THE
REGIONAL CENTER THE SAME AS
OTHERS THAT ARE FULLY ACCESSING
PRIMARILY- WITHIN OUR WHITE
COMMUNITY- WE HAVE FOUND
THROUGH OUR WORK THERE'S BEEN
SOME REAL UNIQUE. NEEDS OF
INDIVIDUALS WITHIN VARIOUS
COMMUNITIES AND WE'VE REALLY
LEARNED A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
THE SENSITIVITY WITHIN CULTURAL
LINGUISTIC SENSITIVITY AND
THAT'S CERTAINLY APPLIES TO OUR
DEAF COMMUNITY AS WELL- BUT
WHILE WE'VE TAKEN A- IN
APPROACH TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE
ISSUES- TO INCLUDE ASSURING
THAT REPRESENTATION WITHIN OUR
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES TASK
FORCE- WHICH IS A TASK FORCE
THAT HAS- STAKEHOLDERS. THAT IS
REALLY IMPORTANT TO THE
DEPARTMENT IN HEARING FROM THE
COMMUNITY- ON INPUT ON POLICIES
THAT HAVE BEEN DEVELOPED OR
IDENTIFY VARIOUS WITHIN OUR
SERVICES- WE FOUND THAT THERE
ARE- NEEDS TO BE SOME INCREASED
EFFORTS AND FOCUS. IN ASSURING
THAT WERE INTERESTING BUT THE
UNIQUE NEEDS OF OUR OUR
INDIVIDUALS WITHIN THE REGIONAL
CENTERS- WHO ARE ALSO DEATH. SO
MR WINFIELD IS GOING TO WALK
YOU THROUGH THE PROPOSAL I'M
TODAY SO THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER BUT BUILT. GOOD MORNING
MADAM. IN OF THE CAN. TO BUILD
ON WHAT DIRECTOR MARGIN AND HAS
TALKED ABOUT AND ADDRESS AND
SERVICE ACCESS AND EQUITY
ISSUES WITHIN OUR SYSTEM- THIS
PROPOSAL UNIQUE SEEKS TO MEET
THE INDIVIDUALS ARE NEEDS OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE WHO ARE GAS
AND THEIR UNIQUE CULTURAL
NEEDS- BEING DEAF IS NOT A
QUALIFYING DIAGNOSIS REGIONAL
CENTER SERVICES BUT CERTAIN
REGIONAL CENTERS TO. SERVE
INDIVIDUALS WITH INTELLECTUAL
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITY OR
ALSO GAS. SOME OF THE OVER
ARCHING CONCERNS FOR MEETINGS
WITH STAKEHOLDERS AND ADVOCATES
HAVE BEEN- HAVING ACCESS TO
EFFECTIVE COMMUNICATION ACROSS
DIFFERENT SERVICE CATEGORIES.
THAT ESPECIALLY IN RESIDENTIAL
IN CASE SERVICE SINCE- THE LACK
OF FORMAL COMMUNICATION
ASSESSMENTS WHEN A DEATH
INDIVIDUALS AND TO THE SYSTEM
SO THAT THOSE SERVICES THAT ARE
DEVELOPED AS A PART OF THE
INDIVIDUAL PROGRAM PLANS CAN BE
PROVIDED IN A VERY PERSON
CENTRED WAY AND INDIVIDUALS
HAVE RIGHTS TO EFFECTIVE
COMMUNICATION. AND ALSO THE
NEED FOR GDS TO PROVIDE THAT
STATEWIDE LEADERSHIP TO ADDRESS
BARRIERS TO ACCESSING
APPROPRIATE SERVICES SO THIS
PROPOSAL- SIX NINETY FOUR
TWENTY TWO POSITIONS- ONE
STATEWIDE COORDINATOR AND GDS-
TO PROVIDE THAT SUBJECT MATTER
EXPERTISE. LEADERSHIP AND THE
STATEWIDE COORDINATION AND THEN
TWENTY ONE- MUTUAL CENTER
POSITIONS WHO WOULD WORK AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL WITH THE SERVICE
BUT NATION STAFF WITHIN THE
REGIONAL CENTERS TO- WORK ON
TEACHING THE KITCHEN
ASSESSMENTS TO. ADAPT EXISTING
SERVICES OR TO WORK ON AN
ENVELOPE IN ADDITIONAL RESEARCH
SERVICES TO WORK ON ACCESSING
GENERIC RESOURCES AND TO DO
THAT STATEWIDE COORDINATION
AMONG THE REGIONAL CENTERS ON
THE GDS TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
THIS VERY UNIQUE POPULATION.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OKAY OPEN A FINANCED YOU
ANYTHING. BUT CERTAIN ALL THE
PARTNER TRYING NOTHING FOR TO
ADD MY- W. A MAN AND PUT A GOOD
THE L. A. WE'VE THE AND DON'T
GENERALLY DON'T HAVE ANY
CONCERNS WITH IT OTHER THAN TO
SAY THAT IT WOULD BE GOOD IF
THE DEPARTMENT WOULD REPORT
BACK TO LEGISLATIVE STAFFER
QUARTERLY BRIEFINGS ON
PROGRESS- IN DEVELOPING THESE
RESOURCES AND SERVING-
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE DEAF. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH YEAH I
WOULD I WOULD AGREE IS OUR
STARTING NEW PROGRAMS AND
STARTING TO AND WE ARE OF
COURSE VERY PLEASED THAT YOU'RE
GOING TO BE DOING MORE OUTREACH
WITH ART WITH ART. THAT THE
DEAF COMMUNITY. FOR THE
COMMUNITY AS WELL AS THEIR
THEIR FAMILY- BUT I WOULD AGREE
THAT MAYBE A QUARTERLY REPORT
BACK TO THE LEGISLATIVE BUDGET
STAFF WOULD BE A GOOD WAY FOR
US TO. CHECK THE PROGRESS OF
MATTER WE KNOW THAT NOT LABOR
THE LABOR MARKET- CONTINUES TO
BE CONSTRAINED IN SOME AREAS
AND SO. IT'S IMPORTANT EFFORT
OF. A DESIGNATE MONEY THAT
WE'RE ABLE TO HIRE FOLKS AND
MAKE SURE THAT. SERVICES ARE
AFFECTED. THE COMPANION THING
ON THIS. OKAY NO. OKAY SO NOW
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE- FIRST TO
THE WITNESS WAITING ROOM TO SEE
IF ANYBODY IS THERE. ARE SEEING
NOBODY. WILL GO TO THE EIGHTY
EIGHT LINE FIRST- SO MODERATOR.
ARE YOU READY ON THE ADA LINE.
YES WE ARE OKAY MAYBE GIVE THE
INSTRUCTIONS YES PLEASE DO.
THANK YOU LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
ON THE EIGHTY A LINE IF YOU
WISH TO MAKE PUBLIC COMMENT
TODAY PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO. EIGHTEEN T. OPERATOR
WILL GIVE YEAR LINE NUMBER
OFFLINE AND THEN PLACE YOU BACK
INTO THE QUEUE SO AGAIN IF
YOU'D LIKE TO MAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT AT THIS TIME PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. ON YOUR PHONE.
ONE MOMENT MADAM CHAIR IS WEAK
IT PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP.
THANK YOU KNOW WHEN YOU'RE
READY THE FIRST CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU. AND I'M GONNA GIVE
THE INSTRUCTIONS ONE MORE TIME.
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. PROBABLY WILL GIVE YOUR
LINE NUMBER OFFLINE COMPLETION
BACK INTO THE QUEUE THEY DO OF
ONE CUED UP. WE WILL GO TO LINE
TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD
TWENTY SIX. WELL. HELLO YOU YOU
HAVE A PURSE. EVEN FINALLY TO
THE VIDEO RELAY SERVICE AND
ENTER NUMBER SIX SEVEN NINETY
IN THIS CALL FOR YOU I'LL GET
YOU CONNECTED. YEAH THING HELLO.
MY NAME IS. THERESA NOPE. I AM
HERE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF.
THE PROPOSAL. I AM A PARENT OF
A YOUNG MAN WHO'S TWENTY THREE
YEARS OLD. HE IS STAFF WITH
SOME ADDITIONAL DISABILITIES.
ARE YOU ABLE TO HEAR ME. YES
YOU SOUND LOUD AND CLEAR THANK
YOU. OKAY PERFECT THANK YOU SO.
MY SENATE STAFF BUT HE ALSO HAS
A CP CEREBRAL PALSY. AN EMOTIVE
SYNDROME. WE ARE NEW TO THIS
STATE. AND WE MOVED HERE LAST
SUMMER. THE FOUR OF US AND MY
FAMILY THERE ARE- THREE DEATHS
OF THE FOUR OF US. I CONTINUE
TO BE SURPRISED AT HOW IT'S
STILL A STRUGGLE. TO ADVOCATE
FOR NECESSARY COMMUNICATION.
AND THE TWENTY THREE YEARS THAT
I'VE BEEN RAISING HIM. AND ONE
HUGE THING THAT I'VE NOTICED
HERE IS BAD. THE ACCESS CENTER
THE REGIONAL ACCESS CENTERS
SEEMS TO NOT UNDERSTAND THE
NEED FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE THAT.
IT TOOK A VERY LONG TIME TO GET
INTO THE SYSTEM AT FIRST AND-
SECONDLY THE CASE MANAGER
INFORMED US THAT THE SUPERVISOR.
I HAD SAID THAT HE COULD NOT
PROVIDE AN INTERPRETER EVERY
TIME WE HAD A MEETING. AND THAT
WAS A RED FLAG FOR ME. OUR SON
IS ONE OF FOURTEEN THOUSAND
INDIVIDUALS. WHO IS DEAF AND
ESTERIFIED THE REGIONAL CENTER
IN THE AREA. WHILE. FOURTEEN
THOUSAND. HOW ARE WE REALLY
SUPPORTING THEM. HOW ARE WE
ADDRESSING THEIR COMMUNICATION
NEEDS. I'M NOT SURE HOW MANY OF
YOU ARE FAMILIAR WITH. THE
PERSON CENTER PRACTICE. BUT WE
REALLY NEED TO FOCUS ON THAT.
AND BY THAT I MEAN THAT WE
REALLY NEED TO TREAT PEOPLE.
WITH DIGNITY AND RESPECT. WE
NEED TO BUILD THEIR STRENGTH
AND THEIR SKILL SETS. SO THAT
WE CAN HELP THEM TO BE
CONNECTED WITH THE COMMUNITY
AND TO DEVELOP RELATIONSHIPS.
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE CONTINUE
TO SUPPORT THIS BUDGET INCREASE
TO MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE WHO
ARE DEAF OR HARD OF HEARING.
HAVE THEIR NEEDS MET. AND THAT
THEY CAN BE IMPORTANT TO THE
SYSTEM. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'RE SORRY
YOU'RE YOU'RE A YOU'RE WELCOME
TO CALIFORNIA WASN'T ALL THAT
STUFF THAT YOU WANTED BUT WE'RE
HOPEFULLY GETTING GETTING
HEARING YOU AND GETTING YOUR
NEEDS MET- NEXT LINE MODERATOR.
YOU KILL AND AGAIN I AS A
REMINDER IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
QUEUE UP FOR PUBLIC COMMENT ON
ITEM FORTY THREE HUNDRED PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT
THIS TIME ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO
AN EIGHTEEN T. OPERATOR WILL
GIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER AND NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE TWENTY SEVEN.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I. PLEASE GO
AHEAD TWENTY SEVEN VIDA. DO I
NEED TO ENTER CODE TEN SECOND.
NO. I DIDN'T THINK SO EITHER
BUT- YOU ARE OPEN I DON'T KNOW
WHICH ONE CAN YOU HEAR ME
YOU'RE GOOD YES. YES I WANT TO
MAKE SURE CONNECTED WAIT OKAY
NOW CORRECT. OKAY YES HI THERE-
THANK YOU SO MUCH THIS IS
CONVENER THE POLYA- I WORK FOR
THE CALIFORNIA AGENCY IF THE
DATA FIND THE PRESIDENT THAT
ORGANIZATION SO WE COVER ALL OF
THE- THE DEAF AND HARD OF
HEARING COMMUNITY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. AND I ABSOLUTELY
SUPPORT THIS PROPOSAL BECAUSE
IT ISN'T. IT WOULD BE WONDER
FALL TO HAVE ON CENTERS THAT
ARE VERY SPECIFICALLY- MADE FOR
THE DEAF AND HARD OF HEARING
COMMUNITY AND THEIR SUCCESS.
ALLOWING THEM TO HAVE THE FULL
ACCESS TO EVERYTHING- I HAVE
ALREADY EXPERIENCE DIET FOR MY
EXPERIENCE IT IS WELL OVERDUE.
TO HAVE THAT THIS SORT OF THING
PUT IN PLACE AND TO HAVE THIS
KIND OF- INCLUSIVITY. AND
COORDINATION IN PLACE- ENTER
ALL OF THE CENTERS TO HAVE
THESE POSITIONS AVAILABLE FOR
HIRING- IT'S A THAT WE CAN HAVE
FULL EQUITY. AND COMMUNICATION
ACCESS FOR EVERYONE. IT'S JUST
SURFACED THIS PROPOSAL IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT AND I 1100%
AND THEN SUPPORTIVE AT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU. NEXT
CALLER PLEASE MODERATOR. THANK
YOU OUR NEXT WE'RE GOING TO GO
TO LINE EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD
LINE EIGHT. HELLO MY NAME IS
LISA GONZALES AND I AM THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF DEATH
PLUS ADULT COMMUNITY. AND I AM
MORE THAN THRILLED TO SEE THAT
THIS WAS ON THE AGENDA FR
TODAY. THIS ORGANIZATION IS IN
FULL SUPPORT OF IT. AND TO THE
LOCAL AREA HERE IN FREMONT
CALIFORNIA. AND WE HAD A VERY
VERY LARGE- POPULATION ADEPT
INDIVIDUALS HERE WHO ALSO HAVE
INTELLECTUAL DISABILITIES. AND
IN THE EAST BAY AREA WE ALSO
HAVE TO DEATH CASE MANAGERS WHO
WORK WITHIN THE REGIONAL CENTER
WHO ARE REALLY REALLY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS PROGRAM WE HAVE
OVER FIFTY FIVE CLIENTS WHO ARE
DASHED. AND OUR- AND IN OUR
PROGRAM CENTER WE REALLY REALLY
LOOK FORWARD Q. YOU KNOW
ESTABLISHING SOME MORE PLACES
WE HAVE ON THE TWENTY ONE
DEATHS SERVICE COORDINATORS AND
TWENTY ONE REGIONAL CENTERS SO
WE HAVE A LOT OF OTHER REGIONAL
CENTERS AS WELL. THAT ARE
OFFERING MORE ACCESS IN CERTAIN
PROGRAMS SHE CAN BE DEBT
EXPERTS ARE REALLY THE ONES YOU
NEED TO BE OUT THERE LOOKING
FOR MORE PROGRAMS AND MORE
ACCESSIBILITY. SO WHAT DOES
THAT INDIVIDUALS WHO YOU KNOW
ARE DEPRIVED OF LANGUAGE OR
HAVEN'T HAD LANGUAGE FOR A VERY
LONG TIME. THAT WE CAN PROVIDE
THEM BETTER SERVICES AND ALSO
THIS BILL WILL REALLY HELP THE
REGIONAL CENTERS TO DEVELOP
THEIR IN HOUSE TRAINING FOR THE
CASE MANAGERS AS WELL. AND- BE
ABLE TO OFFER A LOT MORE
OPTIONS FOR SERVICES AND OUR
DEAF COMMUNITY HERE WOULD
DEFINITELY ABSOLUTELY BENEFIT
FROM THIS SO I'M REALLY REALLY
HAPPY TO SEE THIS- PROPOSAL ON
THE FLOOR AND WE ARE IN FULL
SUPPORT OF IT. AND THERE'S NO
QUESTION THAT THIS WILL
DEFINITELY BENEFIT OUR
COMMUNITY ON A STATE LEVEL. AND
IT WOULD DEFINITELY BRING A LOT
MORE RESOURCES AND THAT WOULD
ENCOURAGE A LOT MORE PROGRAMS
TO- YOU KNOW GET SET UP AND
START THEIR POLICIES TO
ENCOURAGE MORE BUSINESSES. TO
BE INCLUDED IN THE- ACCESS TO
COMMUNICATION SO YES WE ARE IN
FULL SUPPORT AND- WE APPRECIATE
EVERYTHING YOU CAN DO THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU AND
THE FINAL REMINDER- PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO
DIDN'T. SHOW UP FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT ON ITEM. FORTY THREE
HUNDRED. MADAM CHAIR NOBODY
ELSE'S QUEUING UP AT THIS TIME.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH A
MODERATOR CAN YOU OPEN UP. THE
PUBLIC COMMENT LINE IS. THE NOW
AT THIS TIME. YES AND OUT FOR
THE OTHER PARTICIPANTS PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY THE ZERO
TWO YOU UP FOR PUBLIC COMMENT
ON ITEM FORTY THREE HUNDRED AND
WILL BEGIN TODAY WITH LINE
EIGHTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
EIGHTY TWO YOU ARE OPEN. I
THINK YOU TOOK YOURSELF
BARBECUE PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AGAIN AND
WE'LL GO TO LINE NINETY SEVEN.
GOOD MORNING EVERYONE- THIS IS
DOCTOR AND I'M DOUBLE THE FUN
HEY I'M THE DENTAL DIRECTOR FOR
SACRAMENTO COMMUNITY REALLY. I
WANTED TO SHOW MY SUPPORT FOR
THEM TO MANAGE CARE. WILL BRING
THE ELIMINATION OF DENTAL
MANAGED CARE MEDICARE ADVANTAGE
PROGRAM SH- I HAVE WORKED WITH
DAN MANAGE IT FROM THAN THE-
AND MANY FEEDBACK MANAGED HAS
HELPED ME MANY. TO PROVIDE
QUICK QUALITY TO MIGHT BE- HERE
TO FIND THE TRUTH TO PROVIDE.
WHICH MEANS US TO PROVIDE TO
PROVIDE CONTINUE OF CARE TO
PATIENTS AND ONE COULD BE A
PROGRAMS SH IT ALSO ENABLES US
TO INTEGRATE NEW INFORMATION
AND MAKE DECISIONS EFFECTIVELY.
WITHOUT EXTENSIVE INVESTIGATION
ALTHOUGH CONTRIBUTE SH IT ALSO
BUILDS A GOOD PATIENT PROVIDER
RELATIONSHIP AND ENHANCES
QUALITY OKAY. MANAGEMENT HAS
ALL TO MEET REPORTERS TO
SPECIALISTS THE. IT'LL BE TO
FORTY. AND WALDRON BUDGET
OFFICE DENTAL ALL RIGHT I'M
DONE IT MY BE EXCUSE ME CAN YOU
HEAR ME I BELIEVE YOU'RE YOU'RE
A ABOUT A DIFFERENT. I RIGHT
NOW WE'RE ON TO DEATH SERVICES.
OKAY SO SHOULD OF BACK Q. YEAH
JUST GO BACK IN CUBA IT'LL BE
AWHILE BECAUSE WE'RE NOT GOING
TO UP BECAUSE PUBLICLY NOW THE
END OF THE ANTI. HERE ON THE OF
THE ITEM. OKAY SORRY ABOUT THAT
THAT'S OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MODERATOR ANYBODY ELSE ON ISSUE
FORTY THREE HUNDRED AGAIN WE
ARE ONLY TAKING CALLS RIGHT NOW
ON ISSUE FORTY THREE HUNDRED
THE DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES ON THE DOT THE BUDGET
CHANGE PROPOSAL FOR THE DEAF
COMMUNITY. AND AS A MATTER OF
CARE SAID- TO QUEUE UP FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT FOR ITEM FORTY
THREE HUNDRED PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO QUEUE UP
FOR ITEM FORTY THREE HUNDRED.
MADAM CHAIR NOBODY ELSE'S
QUEUING UP AT THIS TIME OKAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WE THINK
THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE CALLED IN-
AND THAT WILL UNLESS ANYONE OUT
HOUSES AS ANYTHING ELSE WE WILL
MOVE ON FROM THIS ITEM I AM.
PLEASED TO THE DEPARTMENT IS
DOING SOMETHING NO ONE OF MY
AUNTS WAS A AT SIGN LANGUAGE
DEAF INTERPRETER AT NAPA STATE
HOSPITAL FOR HER CAREER GOD
REST HER SOUL- SO I KNOW THE
IMPORTANCE. THAT THIS PROVIDES
FOR PATIENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES
AND THE ENTIRE COMMUNITY IF WE
CAN HELP EVERYBODY BE ABLE TO
RISE TO THEIR FULL POTENTIAL
AND BE ABLE TO HAVE ACCESS TO
NEEDED SERVICES SO WE THINK
THAT APARTMENT FOR BRINGING THE
FIRST FORWARD- AND NOW WE WILL
MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER TWO. AB
WITH JOE. I HAVE YEARS OF
HAVING. A HOW DO YOU SAY IT
DIRECTOR. EXAM HERE THANK YOU
OKAY WELCOME. SO FIRST OF ALL-
GREETINGS TO YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE-
JOKES IF YOU'RE DIRECTOR FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF
REHABILITATION I'M ALSO JOINED
TODAY BY OUR CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR AND THE MAGIC THAT YOU
WILL HEAR FROM- AND THE SECOND.
WE CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO THIS
ITEM AND TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THAT YOU HAVE. THE
GOVERNOR'S COMEBACK PLAN.
INCLUDES THIS ITEM WHICH IS
REALLY FOCUSED ON EMPLOYMENT
FOR INDIVIDUALS WITH
DISABILITIES. AND REALLY ALSO
INTERVENES ARE ADDRESSES THE
INEQUITIES- THAT PEOPLE HAVE-
AND SO WE'RE VERY HAPPY TO BE
HERE TO ADDRESS THIS. ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT I WOULD WANT TO
KNOW RIGHT UP FRONT. IS HOW
EMPLOYMENT IS SUCH A POSITIVE
IMPACT ON THE HEALTH THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR PEOPLE TO LIVE
IN THE COMMUNITY AS WELL AS A
PATH OUT OF POVERTY FOR THE
INDIVIDUALS THAT WE SERVE. WE
REALLY SEEK TO ADDRESS ADDRESS
TWO AREAS OF THIS ONE IS FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WITH
DISABILITIES WHO LOST THEIR
JOBS AS A RESULT OF THE
PANDEMIC AND TWO MORE WIDELY.
FOCUSED ON INCREASING
EMPLOYMENT OUTCOMES FOR
INDIVIDUALS WITH DISABILITIES.
IN FACT IF YOU LOOK AT THIS
FROM THE CONSUMER'S LANDS THE
INDIVIDUALS LANDS. IT'S I CAN'T
GET THROUGH THE SCREENING- I
DON'T GET AN INTERVIEW OR I
DON'T GET THE JOB AND SO WHAT
REALLY WHAT WE ARE DOING- I'M
HERE IN ONE OF THE QUESTIONS I
WAS ASKED TO SPEAK TO IS WHAT'S
DIFFERENT ABOUT THIS APPROACH
WE ARE REALLY GETTING AT. THE
INDIVIDUALS THAT MAKE OF THE
HIGHER AND HELPING TO CHANGE
THAT MINDSET FROM THE DEMAND
SIDE OF THE EMPLOYMENT OF
INDIVIDUALS WITH DISABILITIES.
THE PARADIGM IS REALLY SHIFTING
HOW BUSINESS LOOKS AT HIRING
INDIVIDUALS WITH DISABILITIES
FROM IT'S A GOOD THING TO DO
IT'S A TERRIBLE THING TO DO. TO
THESE ARE INDIVIDUALS THAT
COLLECTIVELY WITH THEIR
FAMILIES AND FRIENDS HAVE A
LARGE MARKET PLACE- AT
PURCHASING POWER. AND THAT
REPRESENTATION IN THE BUSINESS
COMMUNITY. PROVIDES ACCESS TO
THAT MARKET BY THE BUSINESS. SO
AT THE END OF THE DAY THIS IS
REALLY TO TRANSFORM THAT MIND
SET FROM A TRANSACTIONAL
ENGAGEMENT WITH BUSINESS TO
REALLY SHIFTING THEIR ATTITUDES
ON HOW WE ENGAGE HOW DO WE
ADDRESS THIS- WONDER WHAT THE
WAY THAT WE LOOK AT- IS TO
INITIATE. A MARKETING- START A
TARGET MARKETING CAMPAIGN BUT
I'M GOING TO STOP HERE AND TURN
THIS OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE AND
NEED TO SPEAK TO THE DETAILS
ABOUT AS WELL AS THE INCENTIVES
ON. THANK YOU WELCOME CHIEF
DEPUTY DIRECTOR. THANK YOU IT'S
A PLEASURE TO BE HERE THIS
MORNING SO- AS DIRECTOR YOU
SAVE YOUR MENTIONED THERE ARE
THERE ARE ACTUALLY THREE PARTS
TO THE PROPOSAL THE FIRST YEAR-
ALL SPEAK TEAR AND THEN ON THE
THIRD PART IS LED BY OUR
PARTNERS AT TDS SO- THE FIRST
TWO PIECES ARE A MEDIA
CAMPAIGN. AND THEN INCENTIVES
FOR EMPLOYERS TO HIRE PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES SO FOR THE
MEDIA CAMPAIGN- WE ARE SEEKING
TWO MILLION DOLLARS IN GENERAL
FUND. TO SUPPORT- THREE
SUBCOMPONENTS SO- THE FIRST
YEAR IS USING THE STATE'S
CONVENING POWER- TO BRING-
EMPLOYERS TOGETHER AND TO
COMMIT TO YOU OFFERING
INTERNSHIPS WORK EXPERIENCES
AND TO HIRE. INDIVIDUALS WITH
DISABILITIES- ONE ONE MOM UP
THE- IS THAT- FIRST. EQUAL PAY
PLAN ON WHICH SHE- I'M WITH THE
CALIFORNIA COMMISSION ON THE
STATUS OF WOMEN AND IT'S REALLY
A CHALLENGETO EMPLOYERS TO
COMMIT TO INCREASING GENDER
DIVERSITY IN THE WORKFORCE AND-
THAT THAT- THAT. CANTEEN HAS
PROVEN TO BE SUCCESSFUL WITH-
CURRENTLY FIFTY MAJOR
EMPLOYERS- COMMITTING TO THAT
LANDS ON THE SECOND COMPONENT
OF THE MEDIA CAMPAIGN IS. RANT
TOLAR STATUE CHAMBERS OF
COMMERCE OR TRADE
ORGANIZATIONS- FOR THEM TO
ESTABLISH A BUSINESS CHAMPIONS
CAMPAIGN TO FORMALLY RECOGNIZE-
EMPLOYERS WHO ARE LEADERS IN
THE PROVISION OF INTERNSHIPS
WORK EXPERIENCES AND HIRING
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES- WITH
WITH- THE GRANT- ONE OF THE
CONDITIONS WE ANTICIPATE-
PLACING ON THE GRANT DOLLARS IS
ON. ESTABLISHING PUBLICIZING AN
ONLINE LIST OF INCLUSIVE
EMPLOYERS INTERNET ON DIRECTOR
OF SENIOR MENTIONED- THIS
REALLY IS TEARS SHIP THE
PARADIGM FROM- YOU KNOW KIND OF
PICTURE AND I'M NOT SURE WHAT
MODEL- REQUESTING EMPLOYERS TO
HIRE PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES
TO REALIZING THAT- THERE IS
SIGNIFICANT BUYING POWER IN THE
DISABILITY COMMUNITY AND SO
WHEN PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES.
SEE A LIST OF INCLUSIVE
EMPLOYERS- THEY ARE MORE LIKELY
TO FREQUENT THOSE BUSINESSES
THAT APPEAR ON THOSE. LISTS-
AND THEN THE THIRD PARTY THE
MEDIA IS A PUBLIC IN. FOR
MISSION CAMPAIGN ARM THROUGH
TRADITIONAL AND SOCIAL MEDIA.
TOUTING THE ECONOMIC BENEFITS
OF HIRING PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES AS AS PART OF
EFFORTS TO. CREATE AND MAINTAIN
A DIVERSE WORKFORCE. THIS
SECOND COMPONENT- THE- BECAUSE
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS TO A
DEPARTMENT OF REHABILITATION TO
ESTABLISH EMPLOYER INCENTIVES
TO HIRE AND HERE. IN TRAIN
PEOPLE WITH INDIVIDUAL PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES- AND THEY'RE
ALSO THREE COMPONENTS JIM THIS
IS. HE'S THE FIRST IS PROVIDING
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
FUNDING- PRIMARILY TO SMALL AND
MEDIUM SIZED EMPLOYERS. TO MAKE
THEIR WORKPLACES ACCESSIBLE
AND- AND AGAIN THERE WOULD BE
ON THERE WOULD BE REQUIREMENTS
ATTACHED TO THE GRANT DOLLARS
FOR THOSE EMPLOYERS TO SET
HIRING GOALS- THE SECOND
COMPONENT OF THE EMPLOYER
INCENTIVES- WOULD BE A
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE SOCIETY
FOR HUMAN RESOURCE MANAGEMENT.
AND COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO
CREATE TRAINING- ON STRATEGIES
FOR EMPLOYERS TO RECRUIT SCREEN
HIGHER INDIVIDUALS WITH
DISABILITIES AND THEN THE THIRD
COMPONENT OF THE EMPIRE-
INCENTIVE. WHICH. FOR
INDIVIDUALS WITH DISABILITIES
ARE PLACED. AT WORKPLACE OUT
LEARNING IN AN EXPERIENCE THAT
WOULD THEN TO. EMPLOYMENT AND-
FOR THAT FOR THE- THESE TWO
PROPOSALS. WE'VE WAITED HIGHER
ONE LIMITED TERM- STAFF MEMBER
TO- TO OVERSEE THAT THE
PROGRESS THAT PROJECT- I'M
GONNA TURN IT OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUE SAID DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES TO TALK.
ABOUT THAT THIRD COMPONENT.
THANK YOU THIS IS NANCY BARGE
MEN I DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES AND I AM- JOINED-
AGAIN BY CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR
BRIAN WINDSHIELD IS WILL BE
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER QUESTIONS
SHOULDN'T NEED PRESENTS AND
THEN WILL LATER IN THE AGENDA
BE PRESENTING ON OUR PROPOSALS
RELATED TO. COMPETITIVE
INTEGRATED EMPLOYMENT AND
PERFECT AND THE- IF THE
PARTICIPANTS OR THE INCENTIVE
PROGRAM THAT WE HAVE FOR
INDIVIDUALS. SO REALLY REALLY
PLEASED TO PARTNER WITH
DEPARTMENT OF REHAB AND WHILE
WE'VE HAD IT AND OF LONG
HISTORY OF PARTNERSHIP WITH.
WITH OUR COLLEAGUES OVER AT
DEPARTMENT OF REHAB THIS IS
REALLY A VERY TARGETED.
COLLABORATION THAT- I'M VERY
EXCITED ABOUT- AND WHEN WE LOOK
AT THE OPPORTUNITY WITHIN
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES- OF OUR
PROPOSED USE OF TEN MILLION
DOLLARS AS PART OF THIS
APPROACH- OUR EFFORTS REALLY
ARE. GEARED TOWARDS EXPANDING
OUR CURRENT APPROACH TO
INCREASING COMPETITIVE
INTEGRATED EMPLOYMENT AND THEN
ALSO WITH ARE PAID INTERNSHIP
PROGRAMS THAT AS A PATHWAY- TO
ACHIEVE INCREASED OPPORTUNITIES
FOR INDIVIDUALS. BUT WHAT ONE
OF THE AREAS THAT- I A COLLEGE
EYES I'M GOING TO BE REPEATING
A LITTLE BIT OF WHAT OUR
COLLEAGUES SHARED BUT I THINK
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO ALSO
EMPHASIZED THE COMMITMENT- CHIU
CREATING THESE OPPORTUNITIES
BUT ALSO REALLY CREATING A
SHIFT IN THINKING. AND REALLY
TRYING TO MOVE FORWARD- NOT
ONLY WITHIN THE COMMUNITY OF
OURSELF AVOCATS BECAUSE THEY
WANT TO WORK THEY'VE EXPRESSED
THE BONTA WORK WE'VE HEARD THAT
THEY WANT TO WORK THEY WANT
OPPORTUNITIES. AND I'VE
PERSONALLY SEEN- HOW BE
DEDICATION THAT- ARE SELF
ADVOCATES HAVE MADE TO BE JUST
PHENOMENAL EMPLOYEES AND QUITE
HONESTLY I WILL TELL YOU THAT
THEY TEND TO BE THE MOST
RELIABLE- INDIVIDUALS THAT THAT
YOU'LL MEET BECAUSE OF MUCH OF
THEIR PASSION- BUT WE ALSO NEED
TO HELP SHIFT THE THINKING OF
THOSE WHO WOULD HIRE THEM. YOU
KNOW SEEING THE VALUE OF THE
CONTRIBUTIONS THAT INDIVIDUALS
WITH INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
BRING ON TO AN ORGANIZATION-
AND- AND PART OF THE WORK FORCE
SO THIS IS REALLY I'M BUILDING
UPON OUR EXISTING EFFORTS. ON
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE-
PROVIDING THE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
THOSE CONNECTIONS- SO IN IN
ADDITION TO SUPPORTING THE WORK
THAT DEPARTMENT EDGE- REHAB IS
PRESENTING- WE REALLY DO SEE
THIS AS AN OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE
A VERY TARGETED GRANTS. THAT
WOULD BE EARMARKED TO BE ABLE
TO PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
THAT WOULD BE- WITH- THE SMALL
FOR EXAMPLE SMALL BUSINESS.
ASSOCIATIONS AND SMALL
BUSINESSES AS- IN A THAT THERE
IS A LOCAL. BETWEEN CENTERS
PROVIDERS AS WELL AS A SMALL
BUSINESSES ENGAGING WITH
CHAMBERS OF COMMERCE I'M SO WE
CAN REALLY ENHANCE THAT
PATHWAY- WE SEE THIS AS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO BUILD UPON SOME
OF THE EFFORTS THAT HAVE BEEN.
DONE BASED ON CUSTOMIZED IN
EMPLOYMENT FOR INDIVIDUALS
ASSURING THAT THERE'S
INDIVIDUAL PLACEMENT SUPPORTS
THAT CAN BE AVAILABLE TO BE
THAT BRIDGE WAY- OF SUPPORTING
AN INDIVIDUAL AND TO- HELP
BEING THAT SUCCESS- NOT ONLY
FOR THE INDIVIDUAL BUT FOR THE
BUSINESS THAT IS- DOING THE
HIRING SO WE CAN HELP PREPARE
THEM- FOR THE EXPERIENCE AND
THE OPPORTUNITY. WE WOULD BE
LOOKING TO BUILD- STAKEHOLDER
ENGAGEMENT PROCESS AND SO WE
HAVE SUCCESS WITH HAVING GRANT
PROGRAMS AS AN EXAMPLE WITHIN
OUR- SERVICE ACCESS AND EQUITY
WE'VE LEARNED A LOT OVER THE
LAST- FOUR TO FIVE YEARS OF
IMPLEMENTING A GRANT PROGRAM WE
WOULD USE SOME OF THOSE
PRACTICES THAT HAVE BEEN-
REALLY HELPFUL IN THOSE LESSONS
LEARNED IN ESTABLISHING THE
GRANT PROGRAM. ONE STAKEHOLDER
ENGAGEMENT FOR- WHAT- WOULD BE
IMPORTANCE TO INCLUDE FOR
OUTCOMES AND MEASURES AND TO BE
ABLE TO IDENTIFY WHAT IS THE-
BENEFIT- OF THIS INVESTMENT SO
HOW MANY INDIVIDUALS ARE ABLE
TO SECURE EMPLOYMENT. WHAT IS
THAT OUR REGION BEING ABLE TO
TRACK AS TO WHAT IS THAT
ENGAGEMENT AND THOSE
CONNECTIONS THAT ARE BEING
MADE- AND SO WE LOOK FORWARD TO
AND TRACKING- THE SUCCESS OF
MORE OF AN ON GOING BUT ALSO
ADDRESSING THE MORE RECENT
ISSUES AS DIRECTOR DAVE YOUR
HAD NOTED. THAT WE HAVE HAD A
SIGNIFICANT DECREASE AND-
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE-
COMPETITIVE COMPETITIVELY AND
CHLORATE AS A RESULT OF THE
PANDEMIC- WE HAVE EXPERIENCED A
PRETTY HIGH UNEMPLOYMENT RATE
FOR THE- WHO ARE REGIONAL
CENTER CONSUMERS- BUT IT
CERTAINLY WAS MAGNIFIED DURING
THE PANDEMIC- SO WE THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT
THIS PROPOSAL AND- AND DO LOOK
FORWARD TO THE COLLABORATIVE
EFFORT WITHIN THE COMMUNITY AND.
WITH OUR PARTNERS AT DEPARTMENT
OF REHAB. THANK YOU MUCH THE
FOR ANYTHING- CHRIS O'NEILL
DEPARTMENTS FINANCE NOT BEEN
BROTHER THAT MEASURE. ED
MISTAKE ANYTHING. JUST REAL
BRIEFLY MANAGER THANK YOU
SENATE HEADED FROM THE L. A. O.
WE WOULD JUST NOTE THAT- IT
REALLY HAS BEEN A LEGISLATIVE
PRIORITY IS THAT PARTICULARLY
SINCE THE LEGISLATURE PASSED TO
THE EMPLOYMENT FIRST LAW IN
TWENTY THIRTEEN TO ENCOURAGE
EMPLOYMENT COMPETITIVE AND
INTEGRATED EMPLOYMENT AMONG
INDIVIDUALS WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES. AND SO THE ONE
WELL WE DON'T HAVE THAT
ARTICULAR CONCERNS WITH THIS
PROPOSAL AND LOOK FORWARD TO
LEARNING MORE ABOUT HOW THESE
EFFORTS ARE CARRIED OUT-
WOULDN'T ONE INTENTIONAL THING
WE'D RAISE FOR LEGISLATIVE
CONSIDERATION IS JUST THE
IMPORTANCE OF PAYING PARTICULAR
ATTENTION TO THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WHO ARE STILL WORKING AT SUB
MINIMUM WAGE. JOBS AND THIS IS
PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT GIVEN
THE POTENTIAL POSSIBILITY THAT
THERE COULD BE POLICY CHANGES
AT EITHER THE FEDERAL OR STATE
LEVEL TO SORT OF- SHE'S OUT-
SUB MINIMUM WAGE FOR PEOPLE
WITH DEVELOPMENTAL.
DISABILITIES THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR AS A AT A
GOOD POINT- POLICY I AM GLAD TO
SEE THIS COLLABORATION BETWEEN
THE TWO DEPARTMENTS I THINK IT
MAKES SENSE TO THINK IT'S SMART
AND THEN YOU'RE- YOU ARE USING-
THE DEPARTMENT EVERY HAVE FOR
THINGS THAT THEY'RE BETTER AT
AND YOU CAN CONTINUE THEN TO.
TO DO YOUR PART SO THIS SEEMS
TO MAKE SENSE I HAVE A QUESTION
JUST JUST BASED ON A AND I HAVE
NOT BEEN IN DIRECT PRACTICE.
FOR A LONG TIME BUT I'M JUST
WONDERING. DO YOU KNOW ANY
EDUCATION AND- OUT WE
COMMUNICATION WITH PARA OF
THOSE WITH THE BILL THIS. HIGH
I REMEMBER- IN THE PAST ANYWAY.
IT'S PITCH BEEN A WHILE BUT
THAT. I HAVE ESPECIALLY LATINO
FOR TO TEN TO TENDED TO BE VERY.
VERY CLOSE KNIT AND- AND CARE
GIVER FOR THEIR- ADULT CHU- BUT
SOMETIMES. I THINK IT WAS TOO
MUCH FOR THEM TO GO TO WORK WAS
BEING VERY PROTECTIVE AND
WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
WERE OKAY. IT DOES THAT REMAIN
AN ISSUE. WITHIN THE DD
COMMUNITY THAT THAT SOMETIMES
FAMILY MEMBERS ARE. NOT AS
WILLING TO LET- FOLKS THAT
SPREAD THEIR WINGS AND FLY A
LITTLE BIT MORE UP TO THEIR-
FULL CAPACITY AND IF. SO DO. DO
WE NEED A DIRECTED SERVICES FOR
THAT. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR-
WHAT AN EXCELLENT QUESTION- AND
IN AWARENESS OF- AARON
INDIVIDUALS HER GOING THROUGH
SCHOOL THERE'S BEEN SIGNIFICANT
EFFORT OVER THE LAST MANY
YEARS- BRINGING AWARENESS TO
WHAT IS THE CAREER PATH OR WHAT
IS THAT PASSED THAT INDIVIDUALS
ARE CHOOSING ONCE THEY'RE
LEAVING HIGH SCHOOL- AND EARLY
ENGAGEMENT AND TALKING WITH
INDIVIDUAL AND FAMILIES OF
THOSE TRANSITIONS FROM- HIGH
SCHOOL TO- EMPLOYMENTS-
STARTING AT AGE SIXTEEN AND-
YOU KNOW AS THEY GO THROUGH IN
THE CONVERSATIONS THAT HAVE
OCCURRED- ON. THE CONCERNS THAT
WE HAVE HEARD THAT YOU KNOW AND
I THINK IT'S A REALLY GOOD
QUESTION TO CONTINUE TO RAISE
AND MAYBE EVEN A SPOTLIGHT ON
TO SEE WHAT TRAINING
OPPORTUNITIES WE SHOULD BE
CONSIDERING- BUT I WILL SAY
THAT WE HAVE HEARD FROM
FAMILIES- FROM VARIOUS
COMMUNITIES- THAT. SOME
CONCERNS ABOUT YOU KNOW WHAT
HOW DOES THIS IMPACT- MIGHT
BENEFIT YOU KNOW WHAT ARE THE
OPPORTUNITIES TO MANAGE THROUGH
THOSE CONCERNS WHAT IS THE SAFE
WAY TO GET TO THE JOB YOU KNOW
IT'S TRANSPORTATION AVAILABLE
AND SO ABSOLUTELY ALL OF THOSE
DISCUSSIONS ARE REALLY
IMPORTANT YOU KNOW AND AS WE
HAVE OPPORTUNITIES WITHIN CAL
ABLE AND HAD INDIVIDUALS BE
ABLE TO HAVE- CAL ABLE ACCOUNTS
YOU KNOW AND TO TALK ABOUT. YOU
KNOW WHAT DOES THIS MEAN TO
BENEFITS THAT EDUCATION ELEMENT
IS REALLY IMPORTANT AND I- I
THINK WHAT I'M GONNA DO IS
ACTUALLY TAKE THAT ALSO BACK TO
OUR STAKEHOLDERS FOR FURTHER
DISCUSSION AND MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE EXPLORING WHATEVER
OPPORTUNITIES AND BUT- THAT WE
CAN LET THAT PERTAINING TO
FAMILY SO THANK YOU FOR RAISING
THAT QUESTION. THANK YOU THANK
RICHARD. OUR DEPENDENCY THING
ON THIS. THANK YOU AND I
APPRECIATE THE WORK. THE BEING
DONE TO TRY TO- TO- A. N.
PLAMEN AND A AS IT IS AND IT'S-
NOT AS A HOME. CERTAINLY NOT
CHARITY- AT MY CORE I GUESS IS
IN TERMS OF OUT REACH I KNOW
THIS IS A IT'S A SO TEND TO BE
MORE COMFORTABLE WORKING WITH
OTHER BIG INSTITUTIONS AND SO-
YOU KNOW YOU TALK ABOUT
CONVENIENCE LAWYERS AND- YOU
KNOW WORKING CHAMBERS AND SO
FORTH- YES WHO YOU SPEAK TO.
HELP INSTANCE ONLY TWO MILLION
BUT- WE- D. O. R. IN TERMS OF
HOW YOU GOT OUT REACH
PARTICULARLY TO SMALL
BUSINESSES I MEAN THERE'S A LOT
OF THEM BUT THEY DO GENERATE-
THERE ABOUT DEL 45% OF ALL THE
JOBS AND SO FORTH OUT THERE-
AND MANY OF THE ENTRY LEVEL
ONES- HOW DO YOU HOW DO YOU SEE
THESE EFFORTS- IN TERMS OF-
REACHING OUT TO SMALL
BUSINESSES AND LIKE LOCAL
CHAMBERS AND SO FORTH TO
ENCOURAGE EMPLOYMENT OF PEOPLE
DISABILITIES. THANK YOU SENATE
ALL START THAT UP CONVERSATION
JONES AND YOUR- AND WE HAVE SO
YOUR YOUR RESPOND ON WHEN YOU
TALK ABOUT SMALL BUSINESS BEING
FRANKLY COLLECTIVELY THE
LARGEST EMPLOYER IN THE STATE
AND SO YES WE WANT TO LEVERAGE-
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE SAYS BOTH
THE STATE LEVEL CERTAINLY AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL AS WELL AS
TRADE ORGANIZATIONS WE REALLY
WANT TO FLIP THIS PARADIGM AND
COME AT IT FROM. WHERE
BUSINESSES CONNECTED CONNECTED
THERE ARE AND PROVIDE THEM
WITH- YOU KNOW THE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE GRANTS THAT ANDY
DESCRIBED BUT BUT ALSO REALLY
TO. LEAN INTO THE HIRING
PROCESS WITHIN THOSE BUSINESSES
AS WELL AS A POTENTIALLY EVEN A
COMMUNITY COLLEGES SO THAT THE
INDIVIDUALS WERE DOING THE
HIRING AND LEADERSHIP IN THOSE.
RESPECTIVE ORGANIZATIONS-
REALLY LEANING INTO ONE HELL OF
A JUST A DIFFERENT MIND SET
ABOUT HIRING INDIVIDUALS WITH
DISABILITIES SO. COULDN'T AGREE
WITH YOU MORE THAT THAT IS WHAT
WE'RE GOING TO TARGET THAT WILL
BE DEVELOPING THAT IN THE
COMING WEEKS. OKAY THANK YOU-
SAID SINCE. A LARGE VISIBLE
EASIER BECAUSE THEY'RE BIG AND
WE'RE BIG- BUT- I THINK THAT
SPECIAL TALK ABOUT GRANTS AND
OTHER TYPES OF THINGS IN YOUR
SMALL BUSINESS HELD MANY OF THE
BARRIERS ARE MORE SUBSTANTIAL
OF YOU DON'T HAVE A WHOLE HR
DEPARTMENT THINGS LIKE THAT
YOUR LESLIE HE'LL LOOK AT GRANT
AND GRANT REQUIREMENTS YOU MAY
BE DISCOURAGED FROM. PURSUING
THOSE BECAUSE THE AMOUNT OF
WORK IT MIGHT INVOLVE WORSE A
LARGER BUSINESS WITH THAT H. R.
DEPARTMENT LEGAL DEPARTMENT NOT
SO MUCH OF THE NATION MAY BE
LESS OF AN ISSUE SO-
APPRECIATE- YOUR THOUGHTS ABOUT
THAT BE SURE THAT WE HAVE A
SMALL BUSINESSES THAT CAN GET
ACCESS TO THESE THINGS TO
ENCOURAGE AGAIN SMALL BUSINESS
EMPLOYMENT OF PEOPLE
DISABILITIES SO APPRECIATE THE
EFFORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. OKAY SHOULD WE
CONTINUE ON UNDER DEPARTMENT-
WITH THE ISSUE ISSUE NUMBER
THREE. YES THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND SO ON AND- ISSUE
THREE WHICH IS. MANY OF THE
ITEMS ARE REFERENCED AND THANK
STAFF FOR OUTLINING THE
PROPOSALS ON PAGE FIVE TO SEVEN
HUNDRED AND THAT IF THEY DID A
GREAT JOB AND ASK THAT YOU NOT
GOING TO A LOT OF DETAIL ON.
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THE-
PROMISE YOU I WON'T. YEAH IF I
COULD GO AHEAD AND HIGHLIGHT A
FEW THINGS OF COURSE. WE TRUST
YOUR JUDGMENT. HELLO AND FEEL
FREE TO LET ME KNOW IF THERE'S
TOO MUCH DETAIL WATER WE'RE
HAPPY TO AND- RESPOND TO THAT
AS A COMMITTEES- WISHES- THE-
AREAS THAT WE ARE GOING TO
FOCUS MORE ON- ON THIS AGENDA
AND ISSUE ITEM IS SELF
DETERMINATION IMPLICIT BIAS AND
LETTERMAN ACT PROVISIONAL
ELIGIBILITY. AND BE COMPETITIVE
INTEGRATED EMPLOYMENT AND THEN
THE PAID INTERNSHIP PROGRAM
CHANGES I'M JUST OF NOTES WHEN
WE WERE PREPARING THE- PROPOSED
BUDGET THERE REALLY WERE KIND
OF FOUR PILLARS ARE FOR AREAS
THAT I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE WERE BUILDING YOU KNOW
REALLY UNDER THE SAME LANDS OF.
THE GOVERNOR'S I'M FOCUSED ON
ON BUILDING KIND OF STRENGTH
AND LOOKING AT HOW WE CAN MOVE
CALIFORNIA STRONGER AND SO THE
AREAS IN WHICH WE WERE FOCUSED
ON WAS CONTINUED EFFORTS AND
IDENTIFYING WAYS TO DO SYSTEM
CAPACITY ENHANCEMENT AND
STRENGTHENING. AND THEN SERVICE
ACCESS AND EQUITY ARE CONTINUE
TO WORK- TO SUPPORT INDIVIDUALS
TO ACCESS- SERVICES THROUGH THE
REGIONAL CENTER SYSTEM. AND
THEN ALSO OUR SAFETY NET
SERVICES AND THEN CONTINUING
TO- FOCUS IN RESPONSE TO PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISIS AS IT RELATES TO-
COALBED AS WELL AS LONGER TERM-
STRATEGIES FOR EMERGENCY
RESPONSE. I'M SO I JUST WANT TO
MAKE NOTE OF A FEW THINGS
WITHIN THE SYSTEM CAPACITY
ENHANCEMENTS IS ON BEING ABLE
TO ELIMINATE THE UNIFORM
HOLIDAY SCHEDULE CONTINUED B.
EIGHT POINT TWO PERCENT-
SUPPLEMENTAL- RATE INCREASE FOR
PROVIDERS- AND THEN I'LL ALSO
REALLY LEFT ENOUGH THE
IMPORTANCE OF OUR WORKFORCE OUR
DIRECT SERVICE PROFESSIONALS.
AND WILL GO INTO MORE DETAIL
LATER IN THE AGENDA ON OUR
PROPOSAL THERE BUT WE ALSO HAD-
AN AREA A PROPOSAL. TO BE ABLE
TO- PROVIDES TYPE IN TO OUR
WORK- ARE WITH SERVICE PER- FOR
BILINGUE PAY- AND THEN- MOVING
TO SERVICE ACCESS AND EQUITY
CERTAINLY MANY OTHER THINGS
WHICH WE'RE GOING TO I'M SURE
BRIEFLY ON- REGARDING LIKE THE
PROVISIONAL ELIGIBILITY IS
DIRECTLY RELATED TO HAVE BEEN
ASSURANCE THAT. WE ARE ON BEING
MINDFUL OF- ARE VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES AND HAVING ACCESS
TO SERVICES- AT THIS VERY YOUNG
AGE ALSO LOOKING AT ENHANCING
SERVICE COORDINATION FOR
INDIVIDUALS AND CONSUMERS WITH
LOW OR NO PL WEST WHICH IS IN
ALIGNMENT. WITH THE SERVICE-
ACCESS GRANT PROGRAMS AND
EXPANDING- A SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM
THAT. WAS DEVELOPED BY EAST LA
REGIONAL CENTER ON AND THEN- MY
COLLEAGUE- A CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR- MR WINFIELD WILL BE
ADDRESSING AND PROVIDING A
REVIEW AND THEN PLACED UP BY
US- AND THEN. GOING TO THE
SAFETY NET SERVICES AS I NOTED
THAT WE WOULD BE EXPANDING
EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS IN OUR
START SERVICES SO I'VE BEEN
ASKED TO FOCUS ON THOSE AREAS
THAT NOTED SELF DETERMINATION
AND SUPPORTS- WE'RE PROPOSING
AN INCREASE OF TEN POINT THREE
MILLION DOLLARS TOTAL FINE. OF
WHICH IS SIX POINT EIGHT
MILLION A GENERAL FUND TO
REALLY IMPROVE THE ON BOARDING
OF BRINGING INDIVIDUALS TO-
SUCCESSFULLY- PARTICIPATE AND
SELF DETERMINATION PROGRAM.
JUST REAL QUICK BY WAY OF
BACKGROUND AND A REMINDER THAT
ON THE STATUTE WAS A- IN TWO
THOUSAND THIRTEEN IT WAS UNDER
SENATE BILL FOUR SIXTY EIGHT.
IN WHICH THE SELF DETERMINATION
PROGRAM WAS AUTHORIZED TO BE
DEVELOPED. IT HAD A THREE YEAR
PHASE AND- IT THAT TIME. AND
DURING THE THAT TIME WE WERE
ABLE TO- BRING ABOUT FIVE
HUNDRED FIFTY INDIVIDUALS- INTO
SELF DETERMINATION TO ACTIVELY
SPEND UNDER THE NEW PROGRAM.
AND BE ABLE TO HAVE AND TO
PARTICIPATE UNDER THE KEEP
FUNDAMENTAL PRINCIPLES OF- UP
TO TERMINATION WHICH IS ABOUT
FREEDOM CONTROL AND
RESPONSIBILITY. HOWEVER WE WORK
YOU KNOW DURING THAT TIME WOULD
HAVE HAD THE ABILITY TO SUPPORT
AB TWO G. TWO THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED AND WE CERTAINLY. MORE
SHORT OF THAT. YEAH AND SO
DURING THIS TIME WE DID SEE
SOME OF THE BARRIERS AND I'M
CERTAINLY ADVOCATE SOME FAMILY
MEMBERS WERE VERY VERY GOOD
ABOUT SHARING WITH US THOSE
STRUGGLES AND THE CHALLENGES
AND RECOMMENDATIONS ON HOW TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THOSE BARRIERS.
YOU KNOW HAPPY TO REPORT THAT
WE ARE MOVING FORWARD WITH
OPENING STATEWIDE AS OF JULY
FIRST- THAT WOULD BE CONSISTENT
WITH OUR WAIVER- AND THEN
MENTOR- RENEWAL OF THE SELF
DETERMINATION PROGRAM. MANY OF
THE VARIOUS IT THAT WE HEARD
THAT WE ARE INTERESTING WITH
THIS PROPOSAL IS- LOOKING AT
HOW CAN WE STANDARDIZE- EFFORTS
TO BE ABLE TO ENSURE THAT
ACROSS THE STATE INDIVIDUALS
WHO ARE LEARNING ABOUT SELF
DETERMINATION ARE LEARNING. YOU
KNOW CONSISTENTLY. THROUGH
ORIENTATION A- TRAINING THAT
WOULD BE AVAILABLE TO. ANY
BUDDY WHO'S INTERESTED ANY
CONSUMER AND FAMILY MEMBER
INTERESTED IN SELF
DETERMINATION. ADDITIONALLY IT
WOULD THEN PROVIDE AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR FREQUENCY OF
TRAINING- AND HAVE INSURANCE
THAT WE ARE ALSO DOING IT
MULTIPLE LANGUAGES. AS WELL AS
FOCUSING ON PLAIN LANGUAGE FOR
ACCESSIBILITY FOR INDIVIDUALS-
WE ARE ALSO PROPOSING A LIMITED
TERM RESOURCE FOR PARTICIPATING
CHOI SPECIALIST AT THE REGIONAL
CENTERS- CERTAINLY FOUND THAT
REGIONAL CENTERS- DUE TO SHORT.
AND OTHER- HIGH CASELOADS AND
I'M NOT ABLE TO REALLY MOVE
FORWARD WE ARE SAYING THAT WE
NEED TO HELP SUPPORT NOT ONLY
THE FAMILIES- AND TARGET- I'M-
STOP ADVOCATE CHEN
TRANSITIONING THROUGH- BASED ON
SOME OF THE SUPPORT WE CAN
PROVIDE BUT ALSO THE REGIONAL
CENTERS TO BE A REALLY KEY
SUPPORTER- AND- I'M KIND DO IT
TO SUCCESS. SO WE ARE
PROPOSING- OF THE TEN- AT TEN
POINT THREE MILLION THAT THERE
WOULD BE SEVEN POINT TWO
MILLION THAT WOULD GO TO
PARTICIPATE CHOICE SPECIALISTS
THAT WOULD BE AT THE REGIONAL
CENTER. THIS ASSUMES BETWEEN
FIFTY FIVE AND SIXTY-
SPECIALISTS THAT WOULD BE
AVAILABLE THAT WOULD REALLY
KNOW AND SELF DETERMINATION AND
SUPPORT INDIVIDUALS TO MOVE
TIMELY- THROUGH THE PROCESS AND
ACHIEVING PARTICIPATION- WE
ALSO HAVE NOTED THAT WE ARE
SUBMITTING A AND I'M REALLY
SEEN A SELF DETERMINATION PLAN.
THAT IS OUTLINED TO ADDRESS
SPECIFIC BARRIERS AND TO HAVE-
SUPPORT INTO THOSE KEY
PRINCIPLES OF SELF
DETERMINATION. AND AGAIN SOME
OF THOSE AREAS THAT WERE
WANTING TO DO IS TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE SUPPORTING
INDIVIDUALS AND THAT WOULD BE
AN INCREASING TRANSITION
SUPPORT- AND THE FUNDING THAT
WOULD BE PART OF THAT TEN
MILLION WOULD NEED TO GO TO
SUPPORT INDIVIDUALS TO
TRANSITION QUICKLY AND THAT CAN
BE. THROUGH COMMITTEE BASED
ORGANIZATIONS HELP. IN OUR
FAMILY RESOURCE CENTERS AND
OTHER SECOND HELPING. WHO ARE
RELEASED TO COULD BE OF
LANGUAGE OUT. THERE COULD BE A
NUMBER OF REASONS I'M SO WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
INVESTING AND HELPING THEM MOVE
ON QUICKLY THROUGH THE PROCESS.
WE ALSO REALLY WANT TO
STRENGTHEN THE PROGRAM TO HAVE
INSURANCE TO SUSTAINABILITY AND
THE FUTURE AND SO WITH THAT THE
PLAN. AND THE THINGS THAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT IT ON BUILDING INTO
THE PROGRAM IS. MAKING SURE
THAT WE ARE ALSO BEING VERY
MINDFUL OF HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE
GOING THROUGH THE PROGRAM- AND
VARIOUS COMMUNITIES- WE ARE
ALREADY SEEING A IN EQUITY AS
TO ACCESS TO THE SERVICES BASED
ON. ETHNICITY THAT WE ARE
SAYING THAT OUR CONSUMERS WHO
ARE WHITE ARE MOVING THROUGH
AND SUCCEEDING IN INTO THE SELF
DETERMINATION PROGRAM FASTER
THAN- OTHER- ETHNICITIES AND
PARTICULARLY WITHIN OUR LATINO
AND ARE. AFRICAN AMERICAN
COMMUNITY WE'RE STILL SEEING
SOME DIFFERENCES- OF INEQUITY
OF SPENDING IN THIS PROGRAM-
AND SO WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WERE ALSO ADDRESSING AND
SUPPORTING THE PROGRAM TO BE
ABLE TO. EARLY ON- HAVE
ASSURANCES THAT WE'RE
ADDRESSING THOSE CONCERNS
BECAUSE WE ARE SEEING THAT-
AGAIN AND IT'S EARLY ON WE ONLY
HAVE FIVE HUNDRED FIFTY MORE TO
LEARN BUT IT'S ALSO A GREAT
TIME TO BE ABLE TO SAY. HOW DO
WE HELP OUR LATINO AND AFRICAN
AMERICAN FAMILIES BE ABLE TO
MOVE THROUGH THAT THE PROGRAM
AND BE ABLE TO- APPROPRIATELY
ACCESS AND ACHIEVE SUCCESS. ON
BOTH THE PARTICIPATION BUT
ACCESSING SERVICES AS WELL. I'M
SO HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS ON ON SELF
DETERMINATION AFTER. WE FINISH
WITH IT TOO TWO OTHER AND-
ITEMS WHICH IS IMPLICIT BIAS
TRAINING. AS WELL AS BEING ABLE
TO PROVIDE INFORMATION
REGARDING PROVISIONAL
ELIGIBILITY AND- BRIAN WINFIELD.
WILL BE PROVIDING THAT TO YOU
TODAY. MISTER WINTER. I
APOLOGIZE I LOST CONNECTION
THERE FOR A MINUTE. WE ALL DO
SIR. SO THE NEXT TOPIC I WILL
COVER IS THE LIST OF BIAS
TRAINING- THIS IS A REQUEST FOR
FUNDING OF SEVEN HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN TOTAL FUNDS
AND FIVE HUNDRED FIFTY THREE
THOUSAND GENERAL FUND THE VALUE
OF IMPLICIT BIAS TRAINING IS
THAT IT RAISES AWARENESS OF OUR
OWN BIASES THAT COME FROM MY
OWN LIFE EXPERIENCES THAT WOULD
MEAN I NEED TO BE WARE OF-
PROVIDE STRATEGIES AND TOOLS
YOU CAN USE TO DISTRACT
INSPIRED SINS. AND HELPS TO
ELIMINATE THESE BIASES THAT
CONFIDENCE TO MAKE DECISIONS
THAT FAVOR WORKS AND OTHER
PEOPLE SHRUM WE'RE REQUESTING
THIS FUNDING FOR THE TRAINING
FOR A REGIONAL CENTER STAFF WHO
ARE INVOLVED IN- ELIGIBILITY
DETERMINATIONS AND INTAKES. AND
THE SPECIFICALLY TARGETED GENE
TO THOSE CLINICIANS AND. INTAKE
WORKERS AFTER REGIONAL CENTERS.
M. SIR REGIONAL CAN TOWARD
ENOUGH I NEED TO IMPROVE
CULTURAL MARKERS COMMENT IN
THIS. WITH ADDITIONAL TRAINING
REGIONAL CENTER STAFF AND
SERVICE PROVIDERS SO IT'S THE
DRESSES. THAT ISSUE. STUDIES
HAVE FOUND THAT AFRICAN
AMERICAN CHILDREN HAVE NOT BEEN
PROPORTIONATELY DIAGNOSED WITH
AUTISM SPECTRUM DISORDER. WHAT
HAPPENED STEVEN AUTISM SPECTRUM
DISORDER DIAGNOSIS SEVEN OLDER
AGE AS COMPARED TO CHILDREN WHO
ARE WHITE. DELAYED DIAGNOSIS
INSTANT ACCESS TO SERVICES CAN.
CREATING LIFELONG IMPACTS-
SOMEONE SUMMARY IN PLACE BIAS-
TRAINING FOR ELIGIBILITY
DIFFERENT TERMINATIONS CAN LEAD
TO. THE DELAY DIAGNOSIS AND
ACCESS TO SERVICES AND- CAN BE
AN EFFECTIVE STRATEGY CHIU
JEANS DISPARITIES IMPROVE
SERVICE ACCESS INEQUITY IN OUR
SYSTEM. OKAY THANK YOU. NEXT I
WILL COVER THAT PROVISIONAL
ELIGIBILITY. THIS IS A REQUEST.
FOR TWENTY THREE POINT EIGHT
MILLION IN GENERAL FUND FOR
BOTH REGIONAL CENTER OPERATIONS
AND JOHNSON- PURCHASE OF
SERVICE- HASN'T PREVIOUSLY
MENTIONED WE HAVE SEEN A
SIGNIFICANT DECLINE IN THE
NUMBER OF CHILDREN WERE
SEARCHING THE EARLY START
PROGRAM. AS OF MARCH TWENTY
TWENTY ONE THIRTY START
ENROLLMENT IS DOWN 10% AS
COMPARED TO THE SAME MONTH LAST
YEAR. BEFORE THIS DECLINE THE
DEPARTMENT WAS ALREADY%
REVIEWING DATED JULY WITH THE
NUMBER OF CHILDREN. LEAVE EARLY
START AND LATER RE ENTERED THE
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES SYSTEM
INDICATING THAT LANTERN ACT
ELIGIBLE DISCIPLINES MAY NOT BE
SOLELY RECOGNIZED AT TWO YEARS
AND NINE MONTHS WHEN
ASSESSMENTS CHEN TRANSITIONS.
TO THE SCHOOL SYSTEM ARE
CONDUCTED. BY CREATING
PROVISIONAL. THIS SIXTEEN.
ELIGIBLE FOR CHILDREN
PREVIOUSLY LEFT THE REGIONAL
CENTER SYSTEM AND LATER
RETURNED AS WELL AS OTHER
CHILDREN AGES THREE AND FOUR
YEARS OLD. WHO HAVE
DISABILITIES WHICH RESULT IN
SIGNIFICANT FUNCTIONAL
LIMITATIONS AND MAJOR LIFE
ACTIVITIES ARE CURRENTLY NOT
NEED LAMPEN ACT ELIGIBILITY
CRITERIA. THIS PROPOSAL DOES
NOT REQUIRE THAT CHILDREN AGES
TO REFORM BE SERVED IN THE
EARLY START PROGRAM FIRST.
ANALYSIS OF GST TO IDENTIFY
CHILDREN WHO PARTICIPATED IN
THE EARLY START SERVICE INSTANT
EXITING THE SERVICE INSTRUMENT
AGE THREE OR LATER. DETERMINED
ELIGIBLE FOR LAND CONNECT
SERVICES OF THE OVER SIXTY TWO
THOUSAND CHILDREN AGES FIVE TO
JUNE YOU SEEN MANSION ACCIDENTS
SINCE BEEN JANUARY TWENTY
TWENTY APPROXIMATELY EIGHT
PERCENT- OF THESE CHILDREN
EXPERIENCED A GAP. BETWEEN
BERNIE STARTIN LANTERN NEXT
SERVICE SINCE. THE CHILDREN
HAVE EXPERIENCED THE GAP IN
SERVICES HAVE AUTISM 75% OF US
HAVE AUTISM. ALTHOUGH
CLINICIANS ARE ABLE TO MAKE
RELIABLE DIAGNOSES OF AUTISM IN
TODDLERS DETERMINING WHETHER
IT'S FOR YEAR OLD CHILDREN THE
CURRENT DEFINITION OF
SUBSTANTIAL DISABILITY UNDER
THE LANHAM ACT. PRESENTS A
SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGE. THIS NEW
SYSTEM. THAT WITH LONG TO WHO
HAVE GAS IN SIR IN DURING
CLINICAL EXPERIENCE. AND A
PROVISIONAL IS GOING REPRESENTS
AN INDO OF THE- THAT WOULD BE
REDUCE ABOUT MY RAINS IMPROVE
ONE TERM NOW. MAXIMIZING THE
EXAM TO KEEP CHILDREN FAMILIES
HOME AND THE NEED FOR MORE.
SERVICE. AND LASTLY I WILL ON
COVER THE- PAID INTERNSHIP
PROGRAM AND THE- COMPETITIVE IN
GRADING PLAN THAT. INCENTIVE
PAYMENTS. WE ARE PROPOSING. TO
SENATE PAID INTERNSHIP PROGRAM
BECAUSE SERVICE PROVIDERS ARE
NOT FUNDED FOR DEVELOPMENT IN
PLACEMENT INTO THESE PAID
INTERNSHIPS WE'RE PROPOSING
FUNDING AT THE THIRTY DAY MARK
AND THAT SIXTY DAY MARK AFTER
THESE EIGHT INTERNSHIPS HAVE
BEEN DEVELOPED AND FOR THE
INCENTIVE PAYMENTS- WE
CURRENTLY SERVICE PROVIDERS CAN
SEE INCENTIVE AFTER THIRTY DAY
MARK WHEN A PERSON HAS AND
COMPETITIVELY EMPLOYED. AND THE
SIX MONTH MARK AND A TWO YEAR
MARK WE ARE PROPOSING TO
ADDITIONAL PAYMENTS ONE AT
EIGHTEEN MONTHS AND ANOTHER ONE
THAT TWENTY FOUR MONTHS. AND
LASTLY WITH REDUCTIONS
ENTERTAINMENTS MMHM DURING
BUDGET YEAR WE'RE PROPOSING
ADDITIONAL FUNDING ON TOP OF
THE CURRENT INCENTIVES THAT THE
THIRTY DAY MARK IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY MARKING THIS IS JEAN
INCENTIVIZE- KIND OF THAT WE DO
DEVELOPMENT PLAN THAT- AS WE
MOVE OUT OF THE PANDEMIC TO
HELP INDIVIDUALS THAT WE SERVE
BECOME COMPETITIVELY.
EMPLOYABLE THANK YOU. OKAY
THANK YOU MUCH- BERMAN FINANCE.
CHRIS ONEONTA OF FINANCE- TOOK
THIRD- TO ADD ON TO- SESSION OF
THE LAST PROPOSAL I'M CLEAR FOR
ITS IT'S- AB THE REVISIONS
QUESTIONING AT- NEW FUNDS FOR
THE PURPOSES OF THESE INCENTIVE
PAYMENTS THAT WERE YEARS AREN'T
EXISTING FUNDS ARE ALLOCATED
THROUGH AB. ACTS YOU WANT IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN- IT'S TWENTY
NINE MILLION DOLLARS THAT'S
AVAILABLE. FOR THESE PURPOSES-
AND- MUCH THAT BECAUSE I
EXPANDED RIGHT NOW AND SO THESE
ADDITIONAL INCENTIVE PAYMENTS
TO COME OUT OF THOSE EXISTING
EXPENDITURES APPROPRIATIONS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR THAT
CLARIFICATION BELIAU. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR SENATE HEADED FOR
THE L. A. O. I HAVE JUST TWO
OVER ARCHING COMMENTS A QUICK
POINT ABOUT THE INTERNSHIP
PROGRAM AND THEN I FIND A
COUPLE OF FINAL POINTS ABOUT
THE SELF DETERMINATION-
PROPOSED CHANGES. SO FIRST A
NUMBER OF THESE PROPOSALS
REALLY SEEK TO PROMOTE GREATER
ACCESS TO SERVICES PARTICULARLY
TO THOSE PREVIOUSLY UNDER
SERVED AND GENERALLY WE'D SAY
THAT THE INTENDED GOALS OF
THESE- PROPOSAL SEEM TO REFLECT
WHAT JUST LATER PRIORITIES
BASED ON PREVIOUS ACTIONS TAKEN
BY THE LEGISLATURE TO. INCREASE
ACCESS TO SERVICES AND ALSO TO
REDUCE DISPARITIES ALONG-
DISPARITIES IN AND PURCHASE OF
SERVICE ALONG RACIAL AND ETHNIC
LINES. AND WE WOULD SAY HOWEVER
THAT MOST OF THE PROPOSALS EVEN
IF THEY HAVE MERIT DO LACK- A
LOT OF DETAIL ON HOW THE FISCAL
ESTIMATE WAS DERIVED SO JUST
FOR EXAMPLE WE'RE NOT EXACTLY
SURE HOW MANY A BILINGUAL STAFF
TEDIOUS- ESTIMATES WILL RECEIVE
THE WAGE DIFFERENTIALS AND
WHETHER THIS IS IN LINE WITH
SORT OF THE ESTIMATES OF THE
NUMBER OF CONSUMERS WHO MIGHT
NEED THOSE SERVICES. AND WE
HAVE TO PUT IN A REQUEST FOR
THIS INFORMATION FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION AND I WILL BE
HAPPY TO SHARE THOSE DETAILS
WITH BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE STAFF
WHEN WE RECEIVE IT. ON THE PAY
INTERNSHIP- THE PROPOSED
CHANGES TO THE LANGUAGE ON FOR
UNPAID INTERNSHIPS WE WOULD
NOTE THAT- CURRENTLY- PAID
INTERNSHIPS ARE CAPPED AT AN
ANNUAL AMOUNT BASED ON AN
EARLIER AND LOWER STATEWIDE
MINIMUM WAGE. SO IN ADDITION TO
THE PROPOSED AT THE CURRENT
PROPOSAL LANGUAGE THE
LEGISLATURE MIGHT ALSO CONSIDER
ANOTHER REFINEMENT SO AS TO NOT
NECESSARILY A LIMITATION
INDIVIDUALS CHANCE TO WORK ON.
IT FULL TIME INTERNSHIP OVER
THE COURSE OF A SINGLE YEAR. NO
ON THE PROPOSED CHANGES TO SELF
DETERMINATION- TO THE EXTENT
THAT THESE ARE CHANGES TO THE
PROGRAM EASE ENROLLMENT OR-
HE'S HE'S IN AS A SUCCESSFUL
TRANSITION TO THE PROGRAM. THAT
WOULD REALLY SEEM IN LINE WITH
LEGISLATIVE INTENT TO MAKE THE
PROGRAM AVAILABLE TO ANY
INTERESTED CONSUMER WE ARE
STILL REVIEWING THE- TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE THAT WAS JUST
RELEASED YESTERDAY BUT WE DO
HAVE TO INITIAL OBSERVATIONS
THAT WE WOULD LIKE TO FLAG FOR
THE SUB COMMITTEE. SO FIRST WE
DO THINK IT SEEMS REASONABLE TO
REQUIRE REGIONAL CENTERS IN DDS
TO REVIEW ON A REGULAR OR
ANNUAL BASIS THAT INDIVIDUAL
BUDGETS THAT EXCEEDS SPECIFIED
SPENDING THRESHOLDS IN ORDER TO
KEEP THE PROGRAM COST EFFECTIVE.
A SECOND POINT IS IF WE ARE
INTERPRETING- THE PROPOSED
LANGUAGE CORRECTLY IT APPEARS
TO REQUIRE THAT SELECTION OF
SPECIFIC SERVICE PROVIDERS
FOLLOW CURRENT STATUTE. WHICH
REQUIRES THAT CONSUMERS
SELECTED THE LEAST COSTLY
PROVIDER AMONG COMPARABLE
SERVICE PROVIDERS. NOW IN SOME
WAYS THAT STRIKES US AS
POTENTIALLY INCONSISTENT WITH
THE WHOLE POINT OF SELF
DETERMINATION WHICH IS TO
INCREASE CONSUMER CHOICE AND SO
OUR QUESTION- THAT THE
LEGISLATURE MAY WISH TO ASK OF
THE ADMINISTRATION IS. IF THE
INDIVIDUALS TOTAL SPENDING
REMAINS WITHIN THEIR APPROVED
BUDGET MIGHT IT BE POSSIBLE TO
ADD SOME LEEWAY TO THE
CONSUMERS CHOICE OF THEIR THEIR
INDIVIDUAL SPECIFIC SERVICE
PROVIDERS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH A- MS
BARTON ARE YOU ARE YOU WILL
OBSERVER ABLE TO SPEAK TO THAT
RIGHT NOW ABOUT THE ISSUE
AROUND SELF DETERMINATION AND
CHOICE. I THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND CERTAINLY THE INTENT OF THE
LANGUAGE IS NOT TO TAKE AWAY
CHOICE FLEXIBILITY AND REALLY
NO CENTRAL CORE VALUES OF WHAT
SELF DETERMINATION IS ABOUT AND
WE WOULD- WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WERE NOTING THAT THAT IS
ABSOLUTELY NOT WANTING TO
CHANGE THOSE THOSE VERY KEY
PRINCIPLES- AND HAPPY TO HAVE-
DISCUSSIONS AROUND THE LANGUAGE
OF COST EFFECTIVENESS BECAUSE
REALLY BE. LOOKING AT AT THE
COST EFFECTIVENESS IS NOT ABOUT
LIMITING CHOICE HEY- IT WE'RE
LOOKING AT IN THOSE INSTANCES
WHEN YOU HAVE- OPPORTUNITIES
WHERE THEY'RE KIND OF EQUAL
CHOICE YOU KNOW YOU HAVE THE
SAME OPTIONS AVAILABLE TO
INDIVIDUALS THAT- REALLY BEING
MINDFUL OF HOW ARE YOU GOING
TO- HAVE KIND OF DECISION
MAKING OF USING MORE AT THE
LEAST COSTLY- THIS REALLY IS A
MAIN- AGAIN NOT TO LIMIT THE
CHOICE. BUT TO ADDRESS SOME OF
THE EARLY DATA THAT WERE SEEN-
AND THE EXPENDITURES FOR SELF
DETERMINATION- AND WE ARE-
ABSOLUTELY UNDERSTANDING AND
SUPPORTING AND AS YOU KNOW
WE'RE VERY COMMITTED TO MAKING
SURE THAT INDIVIDUALS-
PARTICULARLY COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR WHO HAVE HAD A REAL
STRUGGLE IN ACCESS TO SERVICES
UNDER TRADITIONAL SERVICES A
GOOD EXAMPLE IS THAT- IF-
INDEPTH FAMILY WHO IS WHO IS
MONOLINGUAL. AS THE SPANISH
THAT HAS RESPITE SERVICES BUT
THEY CAN'T ACCESS THE RESPITE
SERVICES BECAUSE THERE'S NOT A
SPANISH SPEAKING- M. AS THE-
SUPPORT WERE THAT CAN GO INTO
AND PER SERVE. THAT'S CLEARLY
SOMETHING THAT THE FAMILY IS
NOT ABLE TO HAVE EXPENDITURES
IN WHICH- PRIOR TWELVE MONTHS
EXPENDITURES YOU DRIVE WHAT THE
BRIGHT BUDGET IS FOR THE SELF
DETERMINATION PROGRAM BILLS ARE
UNMET NEEDS AND ABSOLUTELY NEED
TO BE ADDRESSED AND MAKE SURE
THAT IT'S NOT A BARRIER FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS- SO INTEL
CUTTING GETTING CLARITY AND TO
WHAT HE- WHAT'S DRIVING SOME
OF THE INCREASES. FROM THE
TWELVE MONTHS PRIOR EXPENSES OF
PARTICIPANTS TO BUDGET- IS WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO HAVE VISIBILITY
INTO AND AS I NOTED ONE OF OUR
OUR GOALS ALSO IS
SUSTAINABILITY OF THE PROGRAM.
SO JUST AS A REAL BRIEF EXAMPLE
YOU KNOW AND WHEN WE ARE
LOOKING AT KIND OF THOSE
AVERAGE EXPENDITURES- WE ARE
SEEING- CERTAINLY DIFFERENCES
OF THE PRECUT OF- EXPENDITURES
AS TWELVE MONTHS PRIOR TO SELF
DETERMINATION- THERE'S AN
AVERAGE SPEND AND THEN WHEN YOU
TAKE A LOOK AT THOSE BUDGETS.
IT'S ACTUALLY- NOTABLY HIGH. SO
WE ARE LOOKING FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH OUR STAKEHOLDERS-
AND UNDERSTANDING THEIR
CONCERNS AND TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE ARE ADDRESS SEEN- THAT
THERE'S NOT SOMETHING
PRESENTING- A BARRIER TO EITHER
DELAYING THE PROGRAM. OR BEING
A BARRIER TO ACCESSING SERVICES
WE LOOK FORWARD TO TALKING TO
OUR STAKEHOLDERS AS WELL AS ON
WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE ON
ANY QUESTIONS. OKAY THANK YOU
AND THEN NINE DID YOU TALK
ABOUT REDUCING BARRIERS FOR OUR
COMMUNITY COLOR COUPLE TIMES
AFRICAN AMERICAN AND LATINO-
BUT I ALSO JUST AT THE API
COMMUNITY AND WHO'S ALSO-
LANGUAGE OFTENTIMES SPANS.
MULTIPLE DIFFERENT KINDS OF
LANGUAGES IN INDIANA I FEEL
SURE YOU'RE TAKING THAT INTO
CONSIDERATION AS WELL. YES MATT
INSURANCE CERTAINLY WE'RE WE'RE
WE'RE SEEING- SUMMIT THAT NOT
ONLY WITHIN THE LANGUAGE
BARRIER BUT- IT BUT CULTURALLY
AS WELL AND BEING VERY
SENSITIVE PARTICULARLY AND- BIG
COMMUNITY AND ENTERING INTO A
PROGRAMS. EARLY ON WHETHER IT'S
WITH EARLY START YOU KNOW AND-
BUILDING THAT TRUST WITHIN THE
COMMUNITY WITH THOSE THAT ARE
FROM THE COMMUNITY TO- HAVE
SOME- CULTURAL SENSITIVITY AS
WELL AS- ADDRESSING LANGUAGE
BERRIER SO CORRECT. THANK YOU
GREAT I'D- AND I WOULD DEBTS TO
FOR ALL OF THESE AYE I THINK AS
YOUR AS YOU'RE GETTING AND NEW
AND IMPROVED FUNDING. FOR SOME
OF THESE NEW PROGRAMS I THINK
IT'S GOOD TO KEEP CHECKING BACK
WITH US AT LEAST QUARTERLY TO
LET US KNOW HOW THESE THINGS
ARE COMING ALONG- AND I UNTIL
JUST A DAY BEFORE I START TO
PANIC HE HAS ANYTHING- AS YOU
KNOW I'M VERY SUPPORTIVE OF- OF
THIS DEPARTMENT I'M VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF BEING ABLE TO.
REIMBURSE BY OF BUT SOME OF OUR
PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN PROVIDING
THIS CARE THROUGH THE PANDEMIC
WELL WITH THE STATEMENTS AND
THINGS LIKE THAT SO- AND AS
YOU'RE GOING FORWARD I YEAH I
JUST WANNA PROBABLY RECOGNIZE
IT'S THE FIRST TIME YOU'RE
DEPARTMENT HAS. HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE ABLE TO
REALLY DREAM ABOUT HOW WE FULLY
FUND SOME MORE OF YOUR
PROGRAMS- SO- I GUESS
CONGRATULATIONS THAT- THAT
YOU'RE YOU'RE BEING ABLE TO
SHARE- AND SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT I KNOW YOUR DEPARTMENT
OFTEN FEELS AND THE COMMUNITY
THAT YOU SERVE. OFTEN FEELS A
LITTLE LEFT OUT. WHEN GOOD
THINGS HAPPEN. DR GRANT. I
THANK YOU JERRY WENT ACTUALLY
JUST. A QUICK PER QUESTION
ISSUED FOUR WHICH IS ALSO
CONSENT PROGRAM OR WE- DID WITH
THE INCLUDED IN THIS
PRESENTATION BECAUSE WE TALKED
BROWN SAID PROGRAMS- WE AT TO
GET TO THAT- ISSUE FOR. I THINK
WE WERE JUST DOING IT TO THREE
RIGHT NOW THAT'S WHAT I THOUGHT
WE WERE TALKING CENTER PROGRAMS.
SURE WE DON'T HAVE AN OVERLAP
THERE OKAY- IN TERMS OF MY
QUESTION SO FIRST OF ALL I DO
APPRECIATE THE ADMINISTRATION-
GREEN WITH- WITH US IN TERMS OF
THE ELIMINATION OF THE-
PROVIDER RATE INCREASES PENSION
AND- UNIFORM HOLIDAY SCHEDULE
SO THANK YOU- YOU KNOW THAT
SOMETHING WE- TALKED ABOUT FOR
MANY YEARS HERE- I ALSO. AND I
KNOW THAT- DR APARTMENT YOU YOU
KNOW WE'VE WE'VE HAD NUMEROUS
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT- BEING SURE
THAT- WE ADDRESS I THINK-
DISPARITIES- IN THE- TV SYSTEM-
AND APPRECIATE THE- DIFFERENT
INVESTMENTS HERE OBVIOUSLY THE
OUTCOMES ARE GONNA BE IMPORTANT
TO HER AND WE TALKED- ALSO
ABOUT. THE. IMPORTANCE OF
CULTURE CHANGE. AND IN IT AND
THE SYSTEM AND TOUGH. SOME NO
STORIES ABOUT WHERE FOR SOME
CLIENTS OF SELF STATUS- THEY
COMPLAINED OUR STATE MADE NOTE
OF SIDE CHALLENGES THAT THEY
HAD THEIR COMMUNITY THAT THEY
MIGHT EVEN BE DENIED SERVICES
AND THEY FELT. VULNERABLE IN
THAT WAY AND HOW TO BE SURE
THAT. THAT WAS IN THE SITUATION
AS WELL- BECAUSE WE NEED PEOPLE
BILL SPEAK OUT WHEN THEIR
CULTURAL OR OTHER BARRIERS- TO-
PEOPLE GETTING CARE SO. I DO
AGAIN IN PRE IN APPRECIATE THE-
IMPLICIT IMPLICIT BIAS
TRAINING- AND- SOME OF THEM.
AND THE ALSO THE BILINGUAL
STAFF DIFFERENTIAL I'D
APPRECIATE CHAIR RANG UP FOR
THE API COMMUTING WHICH ACCESO
EVEN WITH BILINGUAL MY GUESS IS
THAT WE'RE STILL HAVE A LOT OF
LANGUAGE. BARRIER SO. I REALLY
THINK HOPE THAT WE CAN LOOK
CLOSELY AT HOW THAT BECAUSE IS
A VERY FOR A FIFTY P. I.
COMMUNITY- SO- SO I GUESS I'D
THAT SO AGAIN- YEAH. LOOKING
FOR JUST CONTINUE MONETARY BOTH
MONITORING BUT ALSO LOOKING AT-
THE OUTCOMES THAT COME FROM
THESE INVESTMENTS TO BE SURE
THAT WE'RE ACTUALLY CONTINUE TO
MOVE THE NEEDLE. AND IT IS TO
ENSURE THAT WE HAVE EQUAL
ACCESS TO THESE VERY IMPORTANT
SERVICES THAT I KNOW YOU THAT
YOU IN YOUR DEPARTMENT AND THE
REGIONAL CENTERS SO MUCH- SO
FORTH. REALLY BELIEVE AND SO-
SO OF CERTAINLY ONE BE SURE WE
CONTINUE TO PAY ATTENTION AND
CONTINUE TO WORK TOWARD BEING
TRUE WE ELIMINATE THOSE
DISPARITIES. THANK YOU AND- AND
MISTER WHEN PHIL DID YOU DO
NUMBER FOUR I THOUGHT YOU WERE
DOING THE COMPETITIVE
INTEGRATED EMPLOYMENT AND PAID
INTERNSHIP PROGRAM BUT PERHAPS-
DR PANDA'S CORRECTING YOU
SLIPPED INTO ISSUE NUMBER FOUR.
AS WELL ARE WE STILL GOING TO
DO NO MISS PARKER'S CHICKEN ARE
AT OKAY. ALL RIGHT. SO LET'S
MOVE ON TO ISSUE THE NUMBER FOR
THEM. THANKS FOR THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR. YES ON ISSUE FOR-
THAT PERFORMANCE INCENTIVE
PROGRAM- IT'S REFERENCED IN-
HAS FURTHER ETAILS BECAUSE ALL
I'LL JUST DO SOME BRIEF
HIGHLIGHTS FOR YOU BUT FURTHER
DETAIL ON YOUR AGENDA STARTING
ON PAGE SEVEN AND I'VE BEEN
ASKED TO ADDRESS A COUPLE OF
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS. I'M STILL A
BIT PAID INTERNSHIP PROGRAM-
FOR BUDGET YEAR HAS PROPOSAL.
SIX MILLION TOTAL FUND OF WHICH
IS FOUR MILLION IN GENERAL FUND
AND THEN INCREASES. I'M AND OUT
YEARS TO EIGHT POINT NINE OUR
STORY EIGHT EIGHTY NINE POINT
FOUR MILLION TOTAL FINE OF
WHICH SIXTY ONE MILLION. AND
THE BREAKDOWN FOR THAT IS- TO
FOCUS ON BUDGET YEAR TO
ESTABLISH A STRUCTURE FOR A
PERFORMANCE INCENTIVE PROGRAM-
WELL WE INTRODUCED- AND HAD A
PRIOR PROPOSAL- THAT WAS
SIMILAR TO THE LAST WEEK WE DID
HEAR FROM THE COMMUNITY AND
CONCERNS FROM ADVOCATES ON.
CERTAIN ELEMENTS OF OUR PRIOR
PROPOSAL. SO WE LISTENED AND
WE- PROVIDED SOME
MODIFICATIONS- WHILE WE STILL
BELIEVE THAT THE RIGHT- PATH
FOR WORDS TO- IMPROVING SOME OF
THOSE. CONCERNS THAT DR PAN
ALSO JUST SHARED- AS WELL AS
JUST IMPROVING THE OVERALL
EXPERIENCE WITHIN OUR SYSTEM
TO- STOP ADVOCATE SOME FAMILY
MEMBERS- IS REALLY TO LOOK AT
HOW ARE WE MEASURING. THOSE
AREAS IN WHICH THAT ARE
IMPORTANT- TO INDIVIDUALS BUT
THEN ALSO- AREAS THAT ARE
MOVING FORWARD AS THE SYSTEM IS
GOING TO BE REALLY IMPORTANT SO
TO GIVE SOME EXAMPLES. THAT WE
DON'T WANT TO HAVE A
PERFORMANCE INCENTIVE PROGRAM
THAT IS- NOT FULLY THOUGHT OUT
AND MAKING SURE THAT IT IS NOT
OVERLY COMPLICATED- BUT IS
REALLY CLEAR AND SAYING OKAY
WHAT ARE THOSE THINGS THAT WE
DO KNOW THAT THERE IS-
OBVIOUSLY SELF DETERMINATION AS
AN EXAMPLE IS AN EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT PROGRAM. TO OUR
COMMUNITY- OUR CUSTOMER.
SATISFACTION AND UNDERSTANDING
HOW INDIVIDUALS EXPERIENCES
ARE- IS ALSO IMPORTANT OUTCOMES
ON EMPLOYMENT YOU KNOW ARE WE
HELPING INDIVIDUALS BE
COMPETITIVELY INTEGRATED- IN IN
THE COMMUNITY- AROUND
EMPLOYMENT- AND LOOKING AT
THESE KEY METRICS AND MAKING
SURE THAT- REGIONAL CENTERS
ARE. IMPROVING SO THIS FIRST
YEAR WE'RE GOING TO ESTABLISH
BENCHMARKS THAT WOULD BE FOR
STATEWIDE WE WOULD THEN HAVE
BENCHMARKS BY EACH REGIONAL
CENTER- BECAUSE ONE OF THE
QUESTIONS THAT'S RAISED ERE.
IS YOU KNOW HOW WOULD WE HAVE
SOME ASSURANCES THAT THE
INDICATORS AND TARGETS. YOU
KNOW OUR OUR MEETING THE NEEDS
OF KIND OF THE BROADER
COMMUNITY. SO THAT'S ONE OF THE
AREAS THAT WE WOULD BE DOING IS
MAKING SURE THAT- REGIONAL
CENTERS I'M NOT ONLY HAVE A
MEASURE ACROSS THE STATE BUT
THEY WOULD ALSO BE ABLE TO HAVE
TARGET. THAT DEMONSTRATE
PROGRESS WITHIN EACH OF THEIR
CATCHMENT AREAS ANOTHER ELEMENT
OF THIS WOULD BE REQUIRING
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT- SO EACH
REGIONAL CENTER WOULD HAVE TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY HAD
ENGAGEMENT WITH OUR COMMUNITY-
AND SO THERE'S TRANSPARENCY NOT
ONLY AT THE STATE LEVEL BUT AT
A LOCAL LEVEL AS WELL- I'VE
BEEN ASKED TO ALSO KIND OF
ADDRESSED THE ISSUE OF-
CASELOAD RATIOS- SO AS- AS I
NOTED THAT. IN OUT YEARS THAT
THERE'S BE REQUEST FOR A TOTAL
FINE OF EIGHTY NINE POINT FOUR
MILLION AND THAT REALLY IS. THE
THAT THE LION'S SHARE OF THAT
IS FOCUSED ON REDUCING CASELOAD
RATIOS SO AN ADDITIONAL MEASURE
THAT WE WOULD WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE REPORTING ON AND
MIND ALIVE IS WHAT ARE THOSE
CASELOAD RATIOS RIGHT NOW WE'RE
SEEING ON AVERAGE ABOUT ONE TO
EIGHTY- AND WHEN WE WERE
LOOKING AT. THE PROPOSAL- WE%
WERE IDENTIFYING THAT TO BE
ABLE TO- FIND APPROXIMATELY-
SIX HUNDRED SERVICE
COORDINATORS- THAT THAT PRETTY
PROJECTION DEBT THAT WE HAVE
PRESENTED- WOULD BE ABLE TO
ACHIEVE THAT. AND THERE WOULD
BE A SMALL SMALLER PORTION THAT
WOULD BE EARMARKED FOR THOSE
INCENTIVES AND PAYMENTS TO
REGIONAL CENTRES- SO WERE WERE
REALLY LOOKING FORWARD TO BEING
ABLE TO STRENGTHEN OUR SYSTEM-
AND THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
OUR DEPARTMENT TO MOVE FORWARD
AND TO. NOT ONLY ADDRESSING THE
ISSUE OF CASELOAD RATIOS THAT
IS GOING TO HAVE A DIRECT
IMPACT TO BENEFITS OF CONSUMERS
AND FAMILIES BUT ALSO MAKING
SURE THAT WE'RE REPORTING OUT
ON WHAT IS THAT- I'LL COME IN
THE BENEFIT OF THIS INVESTMENT-
BUT IT IT IT DOES KIND OF LEAD
US INTO A AB. PERFORMANCE
OUTCOME MEASURE- AT AND HAVING
PAY MY THAT- WOULD BE TIED TO
THAT. SO HAPPY TO ANSWER
DECISIONAL QUESTIONS- RELATED
TO THIS PROPOSAL. DOCTRINE
THANK YOU JUST JUST A
CLARIFICATION ON YOUR TESTIMONY
BECAUSE- YEAH SO BOTH COULD YOU
MENTION THAT. OF THE EIGHTY
NINE POINT THREE BEGAN TWENTY
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE. THERE
YOU SAID OF LARGE PORTION YOU
CAN SPECIFY HOW MUCH OF THIS
WAS ACTUALLY GOING TO CASELOAD
REDUCTION SO THERE'S THAT AND
THEN AND THEN A PORTION. WOULD
BE FOR INCENTIVES SO I JUST
WANNA BE. ARE YOU SAY THAT OF
THE FOR THERE'S A PORTION TO
STRICT FOR K. LOW THAT'S REALLY
AND SEND AND THERE'S ANOTHER
PORTION FOR AND- OURS AT ALL
FRIENDS. I JUST CLARIFY THAT.
JONES AS FAR AS THE CPAS I'M
WHAT LOOKING AT IS. WORK
THROUGH THE- OVER THIS YEAR IS
TO KIND OF THAT BREAK DOWN BUT
IT TO ANSWER THE LATTER PART OF
YOUR QUESTION IS THAT- IT
REALLY IS INTENDED TO REDUCE
CASELOADS. AND THEN TO HAVE A
PORTION OF IT THAT IS BEEN
EARMARKED SPECIFICALLY FOR
INCENTIVES OKAY SAID. YES OKAY
SO THAT'S A GREAT THAT THEY
DOES ON THE CLIFFS IT WHICH
MEANS THAT THE PORTION OF IT.
IS NOT REALLY CALLED AND SENT
IT IS TO LITERALLY. GET THE
CASELOAD DOWN SO AND THEN THIS
OTHER PORTION THAT'S ACTUALLY
BEING USED AS THE INCENTIVES
PORTION SO THAT DOES ALL OF
THAT. DATA ACCURATE CORRECT.
THAT'S ACCURATE OKAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE. ALL
RIGHT SO LET'S MOVE ON AND
ISSUE NUMBER FIVE OF ILIO IT
WAS CONSIDERED WARY DALY- DID
YOU HAVE SOMETHING ON THIS ONE
ARE SORRY. WE DO AND IF I HAD A
PERMIT FRANCE WANTS TO GO FIRST
THAT'S I'M FINE WITH THAT TOO.
OF THEIR FIVE FIRST SINCE I
UNDERSTOOD WHAT THE WILL BE
RESPONDING TO THANK YOU. CHRIS
ARNOLD APARTMENT PLANES ARE
ACTUALLY NOTHING FURTHER AT. I
THINK. THANK THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- NOT INSURED AND MEMBERS
AND WE HAVE A FEW COMMENTS ON
THIS PROPOSAL SO WITHOUT
PREJUDICE TO THE MERITS OF A
PROTECT THE POTENTIAL MERITS OF
A PERFORMANCE INCENTIVE PROGRAM
WE DO NOT THAT THE GDS SYSTEM
STILL HAS THE SAME THREE
FUNDAMENTAL CHALLENGES THAT
COULD MAKE IT DIFFICULT TO
ACHIEVE SUCCESS WITH THE
PERFORMANCE BASED INCENTIVE
PROGRAM. THE FIRST IS OUTDATED
SERVICE PROVIDER RATE SEVEN
OVERLY COMPLEX RATE STRUCTURE.
THE SECOND WHICH HAS ALREADY
BEEN DISCUSSED OR THE SERVICE
COORDINATOR CASELOADS THAT ARE
OUT OF COMPLIANCE WITH STATE
STATUTE AND FEDERAL
REQUIREMENTS. AND THEN THE
THIRD ISSUE WE- IT THAT YEAH
CHALLENGES THE SYSTEM IS A LACK
OF- GOOD DATA AND DATA SYSTEMS
AND THE ABILITY TO REPORT. ON
OUR ON REPORT INFORMATION ON A
REGULAR BASIS. SO WE KNOW THAT
THE PROPOSAL AS DISCUSSED WILL
BEGIN TO ADDRESS CASELOAD
RATIOS BUT IT WOULDN'T DO THIS
UNTIL- TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE.
AND WHILE WE DO UNDERSTAND THE
DDS HOPES TO LINK. ANY NEW
REGIONAL CENTER OPERATIONS FOR.
TO THE NEW LEADER- PERFORMANCE.
WE ALSO THAT LET'S CONTINUE
GROW AND- HAS AN IN. ON THE CAN
SIR- AND TO. IS THAT THE SHORE.
OF SERVICE CALL. MAYBE IS HIS
HUNDRED AND SIXTY. A RED THAN
THIS HUNDRED PREVIOUSLY
MENTIONED- IT AND THAT'S IN
TURN OF- WHAT STATURE AND
REGULATIONS REQUIRE. THE
LEGISLATURE COULD CONSIDER
ALLOCATING SOME OF THE FUNDING
THAT'S PLANNED FOR TWENTY TO
TWENTY THREE IN THE BUDGET YEAR
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO TO BEGIN
TO ADDRESS THE SERVICE
COORDINATOR SHORTFALL EVEN
WHILE RETAINING A PORTION FOR
THE INCENTIVE SCHEMES THAT
WOULD NOT START UNTIL THE
FOLLOWING YEAR. AND WE THINK
THAT THE PERFORMANCE INDICATORS
DEVELOPED THE FOLLOWING YEAR
COULD THEN BE APPLIED TO THESE
NEW HIRES EVEN IF THE HIRES TO
PLACE THE PREVIOUS YEAR- THE
OTHER THING THAT WE WOULD WANT
TO POINT OUT IS- EDS DATA
SYSTEMS ARE CURRENTLY FAIRLY
BRITTLE AS WE UNDERSTAND THEM
AND LIKELY CANNOT SUPPORT SOME
OF THE SYSTEMATIC DATA
COLLECTION REPORTING THAT WOULD
MAKE A PROGRAM LIKE THIS VERY
SUCCESSFUL. WE KNOW THAT IN THE
PROPOSAL DDS INDICATES THAT IT
WILL BE TRYING TO IDENTIFY- NEW
DATA COLLECTION SYSTEMS AND
TOOLS IN THE FIRST YEAR- BUT
THE LEGISLATURE YOU KNOW WE'VE
WE'VE MADE THIS. RECOMMENDATION
FOR SEVERAL YEARS SO APOLOGIZE
FOR SOUNDING LIKE A BROKEN
RECORD. BUT THE LEGISLATURE
COULD CONSIDER- A MORE ROBUST-
DATA SYSTEMS OVERHAUL IN THE
DDS SYSTEM NOT ONLY WOULD THIS
HELP WITH THIS PROPOSED PROGRAM
BUT IT WOULD ALSO HELP THE-
LEGISLATURE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION MAKE MORE
INFORMED POLICY AND FISCAL
DECISIONS WHEN IT COMES TO THE
GDS SYSTEM GENERALLY. AND THEN
THE LAST POINT THT I WANTED TO
MAKE IS THAT- YOU MAY BE AWARE
THAT WHEN THE AMERICAN RESCUE
PLAN. ACT WAS PASSED TO THERE
IS A THERE IS GOING TO BE SOME
ADDITIONAL FUNDING THAT BECOMES
AVAILABLE TO STATES FOR THEIR-
HOME AND COMMUNITY BASED
SERVICES THIS WILL BE SORT OF
TEMPER A TEMPORARY. SORT OF
ONETIME INFLUX OF FUNDING THAT
YOU CANNOT SUPPLANT SIMPLY ON
STATE FUNDING. AND WE'RE WE OUR
OFFICE IS WONDERING IF SOME OF
THESE PLANNING COSTS AND ANY
SORT OF CHANGES TO THE DATA
SYSTEMS MIGHT BE ELIGIBLE-
EXPENDITURES. UNDER THE
GUIDANCE FROM CENTERS FOR
MEDICAID AND MEDICARE SERVICES-
FOR USE. OF THIS ONE TIME
FUNDING. THE YOU VERY MUCH
MANAGER. THANK YOU FOR MUCH- TO
WANT TO RESPOND TO THAT THE
MORE MONEY UP FRONT TO GET THE
WE'RE CLOSER TO NINE HUNDRED
STAFF THAT WE NEED RATHER THAN
SIX HUNDRED AND IF WE'RE NOT IF
WE'RE DOING ALL THESE A
OUTREACH PROGRAMS. RIGHT THAT
THAT'S THAT IS GONNA HOPEFULLY
PEOPLE CAN BOOST COMING BACK IN
THE SYSTEM WE CAN'T SERVE THEM.
AND WE CAN'T MEET OUR CASELOAD
NUMBERS NOW YOU CAN HEAR THE
CONCERN AND HOW WE'RE GOING TO
MEET EVEN MORE- THAN TO BE ABLE
TO BUILD. THE FENCE FOR EXTRA
MONEY CAN YOU SPEAK TO THAT
WOULD MAKE SENSE TO FRONT LOAD.
I APPRECIATE DID YOU STAGING
THINGS OUT.BUT IS THERE A
CRISIS NOW THAT WE NEED TO MOVE
MORE QUICKLY. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR- SO. FIRST I WANT TO
THANK ANESTHETIC FOR.
REITERATING WHAT MY TESTIMONY
WAS AS FAR AS THE REFERENCE TO
THE PROTECTION OF THE NUMBER
OF. COORDINATORS IF I SAID SIX
HUNDRED I NEED TO CLARIFY THAT
I APOLOGIZE FOR THAT- IS
ACTUALLY OUR PRODUCTION- FOR-
WITHIN THAT REQUESTED FIND DEAN
IS ACTUALLY ESTIMATED ON-
AROUND EIGHT HUNDRED- SERVICE
COORDINATORS. SO IT ALL DEPENDS
IT AGAIN ON KIND OF THE HIRING
AND WHERE REGIONAL CENTERS ARE-
BUT- I DID WANT TO MAKE THAT
CLARIFICATION AS WELL- SO. WE
DO WANT TO DO THIS RIGHT- AND I
APPRECIATE- THE- ISSUES THAT
WERE JUST RAISED- BUT WE DO
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE USE
THE FIRST YEAR TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE- ESTABLISHING A
PROGRAM THAT. IS NEW TO
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES AND-
CERTAINLY EVALUATING WHAT IS
THE BEST INFRASTRUCTURE- PER
PLATFORM- IT'S KIND OF THAT-
FRAMEWORK AND PLATFORM FOR
TRACKING AND REPORTING OUT- BUT
THEN ALSO MAKING SURE THAT WE
HAVE THE RIGHT MEASURES. WE
ALSO WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
ARE IMPLEMENTING THE OTHER
POLICIES AND- PRIORITIES THAT
WE- WE'VE PUT FORWARD- FOR
IMPLEMENTATION- BEARS THE
SERVICE COORDINATOR. AND HAVE
SERVICE COORDINATOR RATIOS- ED
CASELOAD FOR INDIVIDUALS HAVE
ZERO OR NO POS- AS WELL AS SELF
DETERMINATION- SO THERE'S BEEN
A NUMBER OF THINGS THAT WE DO
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WERE
ALSO ABLE TO SUCCESSFULLY
IMPLEMENT AS WE'RE MOVING
FORWARD- I'M- SO. HAPPY TO
ANSWER. ANOTHER THING ON THIS-
THIS IS IT JUST THE COMMENT-
THE FIRST YEAH THAT. EVEN THE
NUMBER OF COORDINATORS THAT WE
NEED GAS THAT- I WOULD THINK
TECH DOING AT LEAST TRYING
CLOSE SOME OF THE GAP OF AND-
DOESN'T- IT PREVENT US DOING
THE OF PLANNING WE NEEDS I'D
I'M CAN ABOUT FACT THEIR LATEST
ABOUT THE LAW GAS- BUT THE
OTHER. IS A AGAINST ONCE AGAIN
TALKING ABOUT I. T. SO YOU KNOW
WE DURING TOTAL WE HAVE TO DEAL
EACH AND I. T. SWEETS A CAR
ABOUT HEALTH AND THE AYE. AND
I'M HEARING ABOUT A BRUTAL
SYSTEM. FOR D. AND- HAVING SOME
SO- SO HOPE THAT WE CAN
CONSIDER IF THERE ARE SOME. SO
LEAST DO THAT ABOUT. OF THE I
SAYS. AND FIGURE OUT WHAT MIGHT
NEED TO DO TO MY- THE ITC.
BECAUSE THEY YEAR WE IT OFF
MEANS IT'S GOOD OLDER AND
GETTING MORE BRITTLE. AND- AND
AGAIN NOT HAVING THE DATA THAT
WE NEED. MAKES MORE DIFFICULT
FOR US TO MAKE THE RIGHT POLICY
DECISIONS AS WELL SO- SO I HOPE
THERE'S SOME CONSIDERATION OF-
EVALUATING OUR- EIGHTEEN NEEDS
AND DD- AND BEING SURE THAT WE
HAVE. THE APPIUS SYSTEMS AT
LEAST INVESTMENT DOING THAT NOW.
TAKE WITH THAT WOULD BE WHAT.
STIFF WITH THE- FINE SO. PHONE
SETTLED THANK YOU. THANK YOU
YES SEVERAL. PRETTY SILENTLY RE
OUT TO MISSPOKE THAT IS- OKAY
BOB HERTZBERG COOL WE SHOULD WE
MOVE ON ISSUE NOT FIVE. THE
FINAL ONE FOR YOU YES YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND- AS NOTED ON START ON
PAGE A IS THE PURPOSE FOR THE
DIRECT FOR WORK ON TRAIN AND
THAT THE- AND AGAIN THIS IS
LEFT IN A THE EMPTY OF
PROVIDING OFF. FOR DRUGSTORE
I'M PROGRESS- BED CHEN JUSTIN
AND I JOB IN NEXT THAT SOFT
FOCUS ON THE PRICE THAT WERE
CHRIS- AS FAR AS YOU KNOW IT
LOOKS AT THE TOP. THAT WOULD BE
AN AND THEN ARE WE LOOKING ACT
EIGHT CURRICULA- OR YOU SOME ON
IS SIX- SO AS WE ARE LIKE AT
OUR WE LOOKING AT A TWO YEAR
LEVEL SO. OF TRAIN BECAUSE THAT
WOULD ALLOW THE AND FOR END OF
ALL VOLUNTEER TO THROUGH THE
DIFFERENT YOU'RE A LOT THAN ANY
EACH STAGE TO BE ABLE TO HAVE-
AN INCREASE IN THEIR WAY- THAT
WERE BE IT SHE AT EACH OF THOSE-
SO THE FIRST CERTAINLY FIRST
YOU WERE LIKE TO DO- A VERY
TOUGH- AREA OF REALLY CENTERING.
FOR WHERE WE'RE GOING INTO A
THE SCOPE WHAT WE'RE FOR IN THE
TRAY ANSWERED PROGRAM AS WELL
AS TO BE ABLE TO TRACK THE
STAFF THAT- HEY A THIS OF. OUR
IN THE IS TO MAKE THAT THE END
OF THE THIS PERSON WHO HAS THE
THAT SORT OF. THAT SALARY JUST
BUT THERE WITH THAT NO MATTER
WHERE THEY WERE I'M IN WORK AND
IN WHAT CAN THE DEVELOPER
SERVICE SISTER SO WE ALL NEED
HAVE A EIGHT AB OF. SHORTLY
AFTER THE FISCAL. YEAR AND THEN
BE ABLE TO DO THE REVIEW OF THE
PROPOSAL CERTAINLY IN THAT TIME
PERIOD WE WOULD ENGAGE
STAKEHOLDERS AND DISCUSSION-
AND THEN ALSO TO HAVE A
TARGETED DATE FOR LATE IN THE
CALENDAR YEAR. AND L. I'M
CERTAINLY NO LONGER THAN EARLY
ON THAT- TWENTY TWENTY TWO THAT
WE WOULD BE ABLE TO HAVE THE-
CONTRACT AWARDED TO THE
WINNING- PARTICIPANT. OR THE-
BETTER ON IT- AND BE ABLE TO-
LATE IN THE FISCAL YEAR SO
MAYBE THE FOURTH QUARTER- TO BE
ABLE THAT HAVE- IMPLEMENTATION
AND REALLY START HAVING
INSURANCE THAT- STAFF FOR BEING
ABLE TO PARTICIPATE. IN THIS
NEW OPPORTUNITY AND THEN BE
ABLE TO START MOVING FORWARD
WITH- THE- DIFFERENTIAL. IN AND
LOOKING AT THE CURRICULUM
THERE'S A NUMBER OF STATES THAT
ACTUALLY- OF MY COUNTERPRTS
THAT HAVE ALREADY IMPLEMENTED
COMPETENCY BASED TRAINING. AND
SO THERE'S MANY OPPORTUNITIES
WE ARE GOING TO PUT THE REQUEST
FOR PROPOSAL OUT- AND CERTAINLY
THAT LIKELY BETTER COULD BE
SOMEBODY THAT IS ALREADY
PROVIDING A COMPETENCY BASED
TRAINING THAT WOULD NEED TO
THEN TAILOR IT SPECIFICALLY FOR
CALIFORNIA. BECAUSE WE DO WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
INCLUDING KIND OF THE CORE
VALUES THAT WERE LOOKING FOR
CULTURAL LINGUISTIC
COMPETENCIES MAKING SURE THE
PERSON CENTERED PLANNING- SO
THERE'S A NUMBER OF THINGS WERE
GOING TO WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
IS INCLUDED IN TWO OF THOSE-
COMPETENCY BASED TRAINING
PROGRAMS. SO I'LL HIGH- NEW
YORK MINNESOTA JUST TO NAME A
FEW ALREADY HAVE SOME THEORIES-
VARIOUS- COMPETENCY BASED
TRAINING. AS WELL AS EVEN IN
CALIFORNIA THERE SOME-
DIFFERENT COMPETENCY BASED
TRAINING CENTER ALSO IN
CALIFORNIA BUT WE ARE NOT-
LIMITING IT TO AN EXISTING THAT
WE WOULD BE OPEN TO-
OPPORTUNITIES FOR A NEW BUILD
AS LONG AS IT DOESN'T DELAY
IMPLEMENTATION. I'M SO HAPPY.
TO ANSWER ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
DEPART FINANCE. YOUR DEPARTMENT
NOTHING FURTHER ABOUT NOT.
HELLO THANK YOU ANY PANIC L. A.
O. AND WE THE NEW FOR PETRI-
DURING SERVICE PROFESSIONALS
WAS WAS IDENTIFIED IN THE RATE
STUDY THAT CAME OUT A FEW YEARS
AGO SO WE DON'T HAVE COMMENTS
ON THE PARTICULAR MERITS OF
THIS IDEA HOWEVER WHAT WE WOULD
SAY IS THIS IS ONE ALONG WITH
THE PERFORMANCE INCENTIVE
PROGRAM THIS IS THE OTHER MAIN
PROPOSAL IN THE DDS BUDGET THAT
HAS A SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN
FUNDING IN THE OUT YEARS RIGHT
NOW THE- THE MAIN REVISION
MATERIALS NOTE THAT IT WOULD
INCREASE TO FIFTY ONE MILLION
IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE.
HOWEVER WE DON'T HAVE A LOT OF
INFORMATION ABOUT HOW THAT
ESTIMATE WAS DERIVED WE HAVE
REQUESTED ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION AGAIN WOULD SHARE
THAT. SENATE COMMITTEE STAFF
WHEN WE GET IT- BUT WHAT I
WANTED TO POINT OUT. BY
BRINGING UP THIS THIS POINT
ABOUT THE FISCAL. ESTIMATE IS
THAT- EVEN WITH THE PROPOSED
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE VERY
LITTLE IS KNOWN RIGHT NOW ABOUT
HOW THIS TRAINING PROGRAM WOULD
WORK AND HOW D. DS PEAS WOULD
BE PAID DIRECTLY OUTSIDE OF THE
SERVICE PROVIDERS RATE- SO ONE
POSSIBILITY THAT THE
LEGISLATURE COULD CONSIDER. IS
APPROVING ONLY THE REQUESTED
FUNDS FOR PLANNING IN THE
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO YEAR. AND
THEN REQUIRE THE ADMINISTRATION
TO COME BACK- AB GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE TO SUBMIT. A MORE
DETAILED- PROPOSAL FOR PROGRAM
IMPLEMENTATION FUNDS- FOR THE
FOR THE TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE. AND SUBSEQUENT YEARS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RESPECT
SEEMS TO THAT HAS A ES MAKES
SOME SENSE TO THAT- YEAH I WE
KNOW THAT THINGS ARE MOVING
VERY QUICKLY AND THERE ARE NOT
A LOT OF DETAILS. ON SOME OF
THE PROPOSALS RIGHT NOW BUT
PERHAPS BUT NOPE NOBODY
QUESTIONS THE NEED- BUT I THINK
WE ALL JUST WANT THINGS TO BE
AS SUCCESSFUL AS POSSIBLE AND
SOMETIMES THAT CAN TAKE A
LITTLE BIT MORE TIME. SO THAT
THAT IDEA HAS SOME MERIT LIKE
LET'S GET THIS STARTED AND
THEN. MAKE SURE THAT WERE
ACTUALLY BEING EFFECTIVE AND
HITTING THE OUTCOMES THAT WE'RE
LOOKING FOR A DEPEND ANYTHING
FURTHER ON THE STOCK. FOR ITS
GOOD OKAY. I THINK AND WE WILL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
WORK. TODAY WAS PARTNERS COULD
SEE YOU. AND I WILL MOVE ON TO.
THE DEPARTMENT OF COMMUNITY
SERVICES AND DEVELOPMENT. I
THINK WE'RE GONNA HAVE ACTING
DIRECTOR AND CHIEF COUNSEL
DAVID SCRIVNER. THANK YOU TO
THE CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO DISCUSS THE MAY REVISED
PROPOSALS FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
COMMUNITY SERVICES AND
DEVELOPMENT- THE FIRST PROPOSAL
CENTERS ON THE LOW INCOME HOME
ENERGY ASSISTANCE PROGRAM ALSO
REFERRED TO AS LIGHT HE- ALLY
HE PROVIDES MORE CALIFORNIANS.
ARE EIGHT TO HELP PAY THEIR
UTILITY BILLS AND REDUCE THEIR
ENERGY COSTS. CST IS SEEKING
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TO
ACTUATE THE BETTER UTILIZATION
OF SUPPLEMENTAL LIGHT HEAT
FUNDING APPROPRIATED UNDER THE
AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. THESE FUNDS WILL BE
USED TO ADDRESS ENERGY UTILITY
RARITIES ACCRUED BY LOW INCOME
FAMILIES DUE TO AND YET THE
ECONOMIC IMPACTS. OF THE
CUPBOARD NINETEEN PANDEMIC THAT
PROVIDE OTHER RELATED ENERGY
SERVICES. CALIFORNIA HAS
RECEIVED TWO HUNDRED THREE
MILLION AND MARK SUPPLEMENTAL
LIKE FINDING THIS FUNNY DOG
MATCHES WITH REGULAR WHY HE
FUNDING. AND IS INTENDED TO BE
ADMINISTERED LIKE BY HE JUST
WANNA MERGE THE BASIS THAT IT
DOESN'T NEED AS A RESULT OF THE
COVERED NINETEEN PANDEMIC.
ECONOMIC GIVE THAT OF THE
CUPBOARD NINETEEN PANDEMIC LED
TO LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS
ACCRUING HISTORIC LEVELS OF
ENERGY TO. THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION
DATA MARCH TWENTY TWENTY ONE
REPORT ONE POINT FOUR MILLION
LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS ARE
BEHIND ON THEIR ENERGY BILLS.
BUT TOTAL ARREARS OVER SIX
HUNDRED MILLION. AND WITH MANY
OF THEM POTENTIALLY AT RISK OF
LOSING ENERGY UTILITY SERVICES
DUE TO NON PAYMENT. THE
PROPOSAL ALLOWS U. S. B. TO
SUSPEND SPECIFIED CODE SECTIONS
IN ORDER TO DEVOTE A HIGHER
PERCENTAGE OF SUPPLEMENTAL
LIGHT FUNDING APPROPRIATED
UNDER ART. TO PROVIDE FINANCIAL
SYSTEM PAYMENTS FOR A WHOLE
ENERGY- HELP LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS MANAGE THE REPAYMENT
OF HISTORICALLY HIGH ENERGY
BILL ARREARS. UNDER THE
GOVERNMENT COAT. SHE'S NOT
REQUIRED TO ALLOCATE SPECIFIC
PERCENTAGES OF WHY HE POINTED
TOWARDS BERRIES PROGRAM
ACTIVITIES INCLUDING UP 225%
THE WEATHER'S ATION SERVICES.
THE PROPOSAL GIVES YES THE
POSSIBILITY TO ESTABLISH
PERCENTAGES THAT WILL BE
ALLOCATED TO UTILITY ASSISTANCE
AND WEATHERIZATION BEST. MEET
THE NEEDS OF MORGAN
CALIFORNIANS. THIS LANGUAGE
MIRRORS A SIMILAR WAIVER
GRANTED BY GOVERNOR NEWSOM
EXECUTIVE ORDER AND DASH
SEVENTY TWO DASH TWENTY THAT
APPLIED TO THE FORTY NINE POINT
FIVE MILLION A SUPPLEMENTAL
LIKE HE FUNDING CST RECEIVED
UNDER THE CARE ACT. THE SECOND
PROPOSAL THIS FOR THE LOW
INCOME HOUSEHOLD WATER
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM ALSO
REFERRED TO AS LIGHT WALK. THE
PROPOSAL GIVES YES GIVE FORTY
TO ADMINISTER THE NEWLY CREATED
FEDERAL LOW INCOME WATER
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM. LIVE UP
WILL PROVIDE ONE TIME FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE TO LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS PARTICULARLY THOSE
WITH THE LOWEST INCOMES THAT
PAY A HIGH PROPORTION OF
HOUSEHOLD INCOME FOR DRINKING
WATER AND WASTEWATER SERVICES.
ASIAN WIDE CONGRESS
APPROPRIATED A TOTAL OF ONE
POINT THREE BILLION FOR THE
FEDERAL WATER ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM WELL NO GRANT FIGURES
HAVE BEEN RELEASED BY THE US
DEPARTMENT HEALTH HUMAN
SERVICES. CST ESTIMATES
CALIFORNIA'S A PREPARATION TO
BE IN A RANGE OF EIGHTY TO
NINETY MILLION. FORTY ONLY
FINANCES PUT A PLACE HOLDER IN
THE BUDGET FOR NINETY MILLION.
US DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES HAS ADVISED THE
STATE SO THAT LIGHT WALK WILL
CLOSELY FOLLOW STATUTORY AND
REGULATORY GUIDELINES
ESTABLISHED FOR LIGHT HEAT. AND
IN RESPONSE GOVERNOR NEWSOM
IDENTIFIED CST IS THE
DESIGNATED AGENCY TO ADMINISTER
A LIE WALKING CALIFORNIA. CST
IS COORDINATED WITH THE STATE
WATER BOARD NCPC TO PREPARE FOR
THE DELIVERY OF WHY WHAT
FUNDING. WILL CONTINUE TO
ENGAGE WITH OUR STATE PARTNERS
AND OTHER STAKEHOLDERS AS WE
DEVELOP ALLY WHAT STATE PLAN.
FINAL PROGRAM DESIGN AND
REQUIREMENTS HAVE NOT BEEN
RELEASED BY THE US DEPARTMENT
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES BUT
CSP IS INFORMED IT WILL BE HIS
BILL WOULD BE BASED LARGELY IN
PART. ON WHY HE- TIMELINES FOR
EXPENDITURE OF NOT YET BEEN
IDENTIFIED BY FEDERAL OFFICIALS
BUT SIXTY IS FOCUSED ON
IMPLEMENTING WHAT I WALKED IN
DELIVERING WATER RATES SERVICES
TO LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS
EFFECTIVELY AND EFFICIENTLY. I
PARTICULAR THERE IS AN
ADDITIONAL QUESTION FOR ALL I
WANT IN THAT THE TRAILER BILL
ASSOCIATED WITH THE DEVELOPMENT
OF LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLD WATER
PROGRAM INCLUDES OR ALLOWS THE
DEPARTMENT TO DEVELOP A STATE
PLAN REQUIREMENTS AND
GUIDELINES. WITHOUT TAKING
REGULATORY ACTION. AND THE
QUESTION CENTERED ON WHAT WAS
THE RATIONALE FOR THIS
EXEMPTION FROM DEVELOPING
REGULATIONS. THE DEPARTMENT
ALSO ALLOW UP IS BASED ON A ONE
TIME FUNDING AND ACCORDING TO
THE US DEPARTMENT HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES WILL BE CLOSELY
MODELED ON LIFEKEEPER PROGRAM
THAT CSU ALSO WILL MINISTERS.
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF STILL
WAITING CONCRETE GUIDANCE FROM
HHS OF WHAT SPECIFIC ELEMENTS
LIKE IT WILL BE APPLIED TO WHAT
I WANT BUT AT A MINIMUM SAYS HE
DOESN'T KNOW. THAT OUR STATE
PLAN FOR WHAT I WANT BUT WILL
BE NECESSARY AND THROUGH THAT
STATE PLAN THERE'LL BE THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR PUBLIC INPUT.
BEFORE. SUBMITTAL TO THE
FEDERAL OFFICIALS FOR APPROVAL.
SHE'S THE PLANS ON. WITH IN THE
LEGISLATURE IT DEVELOPS THE
STATE PLAN AND PROGRAM IN THE
DESIGN AND A RELEASE TO THE
FEDERAL OFFICIALS. WHILE THE
DEPARTMENT IS NOT RULING OUT
THE DEVELOPMENT OF REGULATIONS
FOR LIVE UP INCLUDING THE
POTENTIAL MODIFICATION OF LUCKY
BREAKS DEPENDING ON THE FEDERAL
GUIDANCE. BUT IT DEPARTMENT
DOES FIND ON BALANCE BECAUSE OF
THE LIMITED NATURE OF THE
PROGRAM ITSELF THE STATE PLAN
PROCESS MEANING REQUIREMENTS
SIMILAR TO THE REGULATORY
PROCESS. AN EXEMPTION CAN HELP
EXPEDITE THE DEPARTMENT'S
ABILITY TO DELIVER LIVE WHAT
FUNDED SERVICES TO LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS. FINALLY THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISE ALSO
INCLUDES A BUDGET PROPOSAL FOR
CST TO ADMINISTER A NEWLY
CREATED CALIFORNIA RESEARCH
PAYMENT PROGRAM. A PROPOSED ONE
BILLION FROM THE STATE'S
ARBELLA CATION WILL BE USED TO
ESTABLISH THE CALIFORNIA RICH
PAYMENT PROGRAM FOR CAP.
OFFERING FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE
TO LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS
EXPERIENCE FINANCIAL HARDSHIPS
RELATED TO THE ECONOMIC IMPACTS
OF THE CODE NINETEEN THAT DEVON.
AS PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED OVER
ONE POINT FOUR MILLION I'LL YOU
LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS ARE
BEHIND ON THEIR ENERGY BILLS-
IN ROUGHLY SIX HUNDRED MILLION.
THESE LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS ARE
POTENTIALLY AT RISK OF LOSING
ENERGY UTILITY SERVICES. SIXTY
ALSO PRESUME SIMILAR TRENDS
WITH ACCUMULATED ENERGY UTILITY
DEBT AND PAYMENT DELINQUENCY
EXISTS WITHIN PUBLICLY OWNED
UTILITY SERVICE AREAS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. BASED ON
THIS PRESUMPTION CST ESTIMATES
THE TOTAL NUMBER OF ENERGY
UTILITY CUSTOMERS IN ARREARS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE TO BE
SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER THAN WHAT
HAS BEEN REFLECTED IN CQC
STATISTICAL REPORTING. CAP
WOULD BE ADMINISTERED BY CSP
AND LEVERAGE THE EXISTING
LIKELY MECHANISMS FOR PROVIDING
FINANCIAL ENERGY ASSISTANCE.
CAP IS DESIGNED TO MOBILIZE A
STRONGER STATE RESPONSE TO THE
ENERGY UTILITY DEBT LOW INCOME
CUSTOMERS ARE CARRYING AND WILL
EXPEDITE THE DELIVERY OF
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE TO THESE
CUSTOMER ACCOUNTS. BY WORKING
DIRECTLY WITH UTILITY IT OVER
WITH ENERGY UTILITIES TO
IDENTIFY AND CREDIT THE
ACCOUNTS OF LOW INCOME
CUSTOMERS PRIORITIZE FOR KAPPA
SYSTEMS. BY USING THIS METHOD
OF ADMINISTRATION CAP BENEFITS
CAN BE DELIVERED TO A
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF THE LIKE
WHAT LOW INCOME CUSTOMER
ACCOUNTS. VIA A SINGLE PAYMENT
TRANSACTION. IS ANTICIPATED
THAT THE MAJORITY OF LOW INCOME
LOW INCOME CUSTOMER
BENEFICIARIES WILL NOT NEED TO
APPLY FOR ASSISTANCE. FOR
CUSTOMERS IN AREAS WHERE
UTILITIES ELECT NOT TO
ADMINISTER KAPPA SYSTEMS
DIRECTLY CSP PLANTS ARE
PARTNERING WITH COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS TO PROVIDE
OUTREACH AND ENROLLMENT
SERVICES AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
SIMILAR TO LIKE A- THE GOAL OF
THE PROGRAM IS TO AID THE
MAJORITY OF LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS FACING RAGES. AND
HOW QUICKLY THIS FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE REACHES VULNERABLE
CALIFORNIA'S WILL ULTIMATELY
DEPRIVED DEPEND ON HOW
SUCCESSFUL. THE STATE AND
ENERGY UTILITIES CAN WORK
TOGETHER TO EXPEDITE THE
DELIVERY OF BENEFITS. HE IS HE
IS CONFIDENT THAT THE PART WILL
BE ABLE TO DELIVER THIS RELIEF
EFFICIENTLY AND EFFECTIVELY TO
HELP LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS KEEP
THEIR LIGHTS ON AND THE HOME'S
COOL COMFORTABLE AND SAFE.
APPROXIMATELY NINE HUNDRED
NINETY THREE POINT FIVE MILLION
WILL BE DEVOTED TO LOCAL
SYSTEMS. WITH SIX POINT FIVE
MILLION RETAIN BY CSP FOR STATE
APPROPRIATIONS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- DEPARTMENT
FINANCE. ONE ONE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WE DON'T HAVE ANY
FURTHER COMMENTS THANK YOU.
DELEO MAJORITY CASHIER HAND.
THANK YOU MANAGER ANGELA SHORT
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE WE HAVE JUST A FEW BRIEF
COMMENTS ON- THE THREE
PROPOSALS THAT ACT ACTING
DIRECTOR SCRIBNER JUST
DESCRIBED- FIRST REGARDING THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE THAT
WAIVES CERTAIN PROVISIONS FOR
THE USE OF THE SUPPLEMENTAL LOW
INCOME HOME ENERGY ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM OR LIHEAP FUNDING THAT
WAS PROVIDED UNDER THE AMERICAN
RESCUE PLANS. WE REVIEWED THAT
LANGUAGE AND HAVE NO CONCERNS
AND WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT-
SIMILAR FLEXIBILITIES WERE
APPLIED TO PREVIOUS FEDERAL
SUPPLEMENTAL FUNDS FOR LIKE
HEAT THAT CAME TO THE CARE ACT.
GOING ON TO THE PROPOSED
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TO
PROVIDE AUTHORITY FOR CST TO
DEVELOP AND ADMINISTER THE LOW
INCOME HOUSEHOLD WATER
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM OR LIE WHAT-
WHICH AS YOU HEARD IS A NEW
PROGRAM SPECIFIED IN THE
AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN. WE VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THE ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION THAT ACTING
DIRECTOR SCRIBNER JUST
PROVIDED- IN RESPONSE TO THE
QUESTION IN YOUR AGENDA
CONCERNING THE EXEMPTION OF THE
PROGRAM FROM THE REGULATORY
PROCESS THIS IS THE QUESTION.
WE HAD AS WELL. AND WE ALSO
UNDERSTAND- THAT FEDERAL
GUIDANCE FOR THIS PROGRAM HAS
NOT YET BEEN FINALIZED AND MANY
DETAILS HAVE YET TO BE
DETERMINED FOR THE PROGRAM.
SAID ONE THING THE LEGISLATURE
MAY WISH TO CONSIDER REGARDLESS
OF WHETHER REGULATIONS
ULTIMATELY ARE DEVELOPED FOR
THIS PROGRAM. IS WHAT MECHANISM
WOULD HELP ENSURE THAT THE
PROGRAM ULTIMATELY IS IN LINE
WITH LEGISLATIVE PRIORITIES TO
THE EXTENT ALLOWABLE BY THE
FORTHCOMING FEDERAL GUIDANCE.
SO FOR EXAMPLE THE LEGISLATURE
COULD REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT TO
NOTIFY- THE LEGISLATURE. OF THE
PROGRAM IMPLEMENTATION PLAN-
ALONG WITH THE PROPOSED
ALLOCATION METHODOLOGY FOR THE
FUNDING PRIOR TO IMPLEMENTATION
TO ENSURE THAT THE LEGISLATURE
HAS- I GIVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
REVIEW AND PROVIDE FEEDBACK. IN
ADDITION THE LEGISLATURE COULD
REQUIRE REGULAR PROGRAM
REPORTING FROM CST- THREE
STATUTES. AND FINALLY ARE
MOVING ON TO THE LAST ITEM ON
THE BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL FOR
THE CALIFORNIA RAGE PAYMENT
PROGRAM FOR CAP- WITH A
PROPOSED ONE BILLION DOLLAR
BUDGET FROM THE AMERICAN RESCUE
PLAN. WE ARE JUST NOW THAT THIS
IS- A LARGE AUGMENTATION FOR
THE DEPARTMENT AND WE ARE
CURRENTLY WORKING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION TO BE SURE WE
FULLY UNDERSTAND- THE PROPOSED
IMPLEMENTATION PLAN TIME FRAMES
FOR DISTRIBUTING FUNDS WHAT
POSSIBLE OVERSIGHT MECHANISMS
THE LEGISLATURE WILL HAVE. AND
OTHER TECHNICAL ISSUES AND WILL
BE SURE TO FOLLOW UP WITH STAFF
AS WE DEVELOP OUR OWN
UNDERSTANDING ON THESE POINTS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISS SHORT
AND- I THINK WE ALL WE ALL WANT
TO MAKE SURE THE THOSE OF US
WHO HAVE BEEN HIT HARDEST BY
THE PANDEMIC ARE ABLE TO- THEY
HAVE THE RELIEF THAT THESE
PROGRAMS ARE OFFERING. ON SNAP
SURVATION EVERY NEW PROGRAM IS
A NEW ACRONYM- BUT I WILL ASK
GUYS DOCTOR PULLED TO NOTE
THAT. WE MAY WANT TO SEE THIS
AGAIN BEFORE IMPLEMENTATION- AS
WELL AS A- AS SOME ONGOING
OVERSIGHT OF MAKING SURE THAT
IT'S ACTUALLY WORKING BECAUSE-
AS YOU KNOW WE OFTEN HEAR ABOUT
THIS IN OUR COMMUNITY WHEN
THINGS DON'T WORK. A SENIOR
THEN THEN LATER- THAT WOULD BE
MY COMMENTS ON THIS AND AGAIN
WE ALL WE ALL WANT PEOPLE TO
HELP. MEET THESE BASIC NEEDS
OUT THERE- BUT WE JUST WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT IT IS DONE MOST
EFFECTIVELY- AND IT ALWAYS
MAKES LITTLE BIT NERVOUS WHEN
WE SAY WE NEED TO MOVE QUICKLY
AND DON'T NEED REGULATIONS- AND
I KNOW THAT'S NOT EXACTLY WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING. AB WE WANT TO
KNOW WHAT THE F. THE FEDERAL
GUIDELINES ARE GOING TO BE AND
HOW WE'RE GOING TO MEET THEM.
TECH PAN ANYTHING ON THIS- JUST
I THINK THAT SOME OF THE WHAT
YOU SAID- AT. THE REGISTER.
FREESHEET THE NEED FOR
FLEXIBILITY BUT ALSO
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR OUTCOMES
AND- SO. WITH THAT- HOPE YOU'RE
LOOKING FOR TO OF WHAT YOU'RE-
GETTING FEEDBACK. OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. MISTER SCRIBNER-
OKAY LET US MOVE ON TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF AGING IS MISS
CANACCORD THEIR DIRECTOR OF
QUITE. YES GOOD AFTERNOON. ALL
RIGHT ISSUE NUMBER. ONE THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH YOU'RE
EGGMAN INSIDER PLAN FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT THE
MINISTRATIONS BOLD PROPOSALS TO
SUPPORT AND EMPOWER OLDER
ADULTS CENTER AGING AND
DISABILITY SERVICES NETWORK
THROUGH THE DEPARTMENT OF AGING
SAID OLDER ADULTS AND ALL
CALIFORNIA AND FAMILIES COME
BACK FROM THE PANDEMIC AND IS
TO GATHER WE IMPLEMENT THE
MASTER PLAN FOR AGING AND ALL
THE CALIFORNIA FOR ALL AGES
OFFERS A VERY BRIEFLY ON THE
THREE ISSUES ON THE AGENDA AND
HAPPY TO DO WALL ONES ARE TAKEN
ONE BY ONE IF YOU PREFER- AND
THEN ANSWER THE TWO QUESTIONS
ON ISSUE THREE. CARBON JUST GO
AHEAD AND DO ALL THREE OF THEM
COULD FALL. THANK YOU TO GATHER
THEY WILL- THEY'RE MEANT TO
ADDRESS THE SEVERE REGULATIONS.
THAT BECAME EVEN MORE SEVERE
FRANKLY DURING THE PANDEMIC AND
WELL AS WELL AS AS WELL AS
BOOST. HEALTH AND WELL BEING
THAT WE- WE SAW THE SUFFERING
EVEN AMONG FOLKS WHO WEATHERED.
THE PANDEMIC THE PANDEMIC OF
STAYING ON AT HOME ALSO HAS ITS
IT'S A- THE FIRST PROPOSAL
ISSUE. BEYOND THAT ALL DAY-
SERVICES THREE SEA BASS. UP IF
THE WORKLOAD PROPOSAL FOR OUR
DEPARTMENT SCHEME TO BETA DAHLE
SERVICES OF ONE POINT NINE
MILLION AND THEN TWO POINT FOUR
MILLION I'M- TEN NEW POSITIONS.
ON THE LADY. FIVE ADULT DAY
CENTERS AROUND THE STATE- AND
THIS WOULD ALLOW US TO OUR WITH
A HUNDRED AND THIRTY TWO
APPLICATIONS OF OB PROVIDERS
HOPING TO ADD. A CENTERS OF THE
NETWORK AND THIS PROPOSAL WOULD
ALLOW THE DEPARTMENT TAKE TO
PROCESS DOES WORK QUICKLY AND
CERTIFY WHERE APPROPRIATE.
ISSUE TWO THE DRUG TO NUTRITION
SENIOR TRADITIONAL TOP PRIORITY
OF THE ADMINISTRATION OR
LEGISLATIVE PARTNERS AND MANY
STAKEHOLDERS. DIRECTOR QUIT LET
ME START BE WAS LIKE AND JUST
MAKE SURE I'M GONNA CHECK WITH
IT UP WITH L. A. O. AND
APARTMENT FINANCING YOU CAN BE
ABLE TO KEEP UP AND DO ALL
THREE AT THE END OF WOULD YOU
RATHER US BREAK THEM UP. OKAY
HERE OKAY ALL RIGHT ROLANDE.
THE PROPOSAL IS TWO MILLION. TO
RETURN AGAIN TO CONGRESSIONAL
REACH TO OLDER ADULTS. AND
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES WHO
ARE RECEIVING OUTSIDE WERE MADE
ELIGIBLE COUPLE YEARS AGO FOR
THE CALIFORNIA SITUATION
PROGRAM TO HELP WITH GROCERIES.
AGAIN WE'RE ALL VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT THE RISE IN IN ON
NUTRITION NEEDS OF THAT WAS
MADE MORE SEVERE BY THE
PANDEMIC. AND THE COMING
THROUGH CLICK THIS ON FEDERAL
RESOURCES. AND SOME COPING
RESOURCES AND SO GETTING MORE
CLOSE CONNECTED TO CALFRESH. IS
A PRIORITY. OF OURS AND OUR
AGING NETWORK AND OF COURSE
THIS WOULD BE IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES AND OVERSEES THE
CALFRESH. AND THE CALFRESH
OUTREACH PROGRAM. THE PROPOSAL
WHICH IS I'M ONE HERE'S OLDER
DAY RECOVER AND WAS. FUND THIS
IS A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN
NEW FUNDING FOR- A LOCAL
SERVICES AROUND THE STATE AS
WELL SIX MILLION FOR STATE
OPERATIONS. TO INVEST IN NINE
DIFFERENT NEEDS. THAT WE HAVE
SEEN GROW MORE INTENSE DURING.
THE PANDEMIC AND I'M JUST GOING%
TO TAKE A SECOND AND LIST THEM
ALL. ONE SENIOR NUTRITION THIS
IS FOR MEALS BOTH AT HOME AND
AT COMMUNITY CENTERS AS WE SEE
OLDER ADULTS RETURN WHICH IS
STILL VERY MUCH. A WORK IN
PROGRESS TO SENIOR LEGAL
SERVICES DEALING WITH ISSUES
FROM ADDICTION TO FRAUD TO
ABUSE THAT HAVE- AGAIN BECOME
MORE SEVERE. THIRD FALL
PREVENTION. AND HOME
MODIFICATIONS OF PEOPLE CAN
LIVE IN THE HOMES OF CHOICE AND
PROVIDE UP WITH THOSE FALLS
WHICH ARE. ON THE NUMBER ONE
INJURY CAUSE OF DEATH IN OLDER
ADULTS PARTICULARLY OVER
EIGHTY. OR DIGITAL CONNECTIONS.
I KNOW THIS IS A SURE PRIORITY-
WE KNOW FROM OLDER ADULTS WHO
WERE ABLE TO BE ONLINE DURING
THE PANDEMIC IT WAS A VERY
DIFFERENT EXPERIENCE WHETHER
CONNECTIONS YOUR TELEHEALTH. TO
LOVED ONES TO CONGREGATION
SERVICES TO ALL KINDS OF
CONTENT- AND SO WE WANT TO DO
MORE TO PROVIDE ADVICE IS
PROVIDE BROADBAND AND PROVIDE
IT SUPPORT. TO HELP PEOPLE GET
AND STAY CONNECTED. NUMBER FIVE
A SENIOR EMPLOYMENT TO HELP
MORE ADULTS WHO BOTH NEED TO
AND WANT TO WORK- GET THE
TRAINING AND SUPPORT TO DO SO.
PERSONS ARE RUN DOOR AGING INTO
THE- RESOURCE CONNECTS AS WELL
ALLOW US TO EXCEL EVEN. THAT
HAAB FOR PEOPLE TO. IT FOR ON
THE TO. GET THAT PERSON
CENTERED CARE PLANNING CARE. IN
CONNECTION TO COMMUNITY
SERVICES HEALTH SERVICES COUNTY
SERVICES. TO HELP YOU PRIVATE
HOME. SEVEN IS OUR BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH FRIENDSHIP LINE WHICH
WERE BOTH PROUD AND ALSO A
QUITE QUITE- MOVED BY THE FACT
THAT IT CONTINUES TO RECEIVE
HUNDREDS OF CALLS A DAY. FROM
OLDER ADULTS LOOKING TO OUR
REACH OUT AND HAVE A CHAT AND
HAVE A CONVERSATION AND AVOID
LONELINESS WHICH IS- SO
PERVASIVE. EIGHT FAMILY
CAREGIVING SUPPORT WE HEAR ALL
THE TIME AND- PERHAPS SOME OF
US HERE A FAMILY CARE GIVERS
WHO HAVE HAD BOTH THE PRIVILEGE
YOU CAN'T- THE STRESSORS OF
CARING FOR OUR LOVED ONES
DURING THIS TIME AND SOME MORE
SUPPORT ARRESTED IN BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH. FOR FAMILY CAREGIVERS-
AND THEN LAST BUT NOT LEAST ON
COUNCIL THAT WAS CALLED FOR IN
THE MASTER PLAN AGAIN BREED
TOGETHER ALL THE MANY STATE
DEPARTMENTS AND AGENCIES ARE
COUNTY AND FEDERAL PARTNERS OR
STAKEHOLDERS TO REALLY MAKE
SURE WE'RE DOING ALL WE CAN TO
PREVENT. I WAS NOT A FACTOR
COOLEY AND WITH AN EQUITY LENS
TO ABUSE NEGLECT FRAUD AND
EXPLOITATION. ABOUT PACKAGES-
THE HUNDRED MILLION A ONE TIME
OVER THREE YEARS TO REALLY BE
THAT RESPONSE ON AND INVESTED.
RECOVERY RESILIENCY AND COME
BACK. THERE WERE QUESTIONS I
SPEAK TO THAT WOULD HOOKED.
PLEASE A PROBABLY. MY QUESTIONS
GOING TO BE A- HOW ARE YOU CAN
BE WORKING THE CHARACTER. REESE
CENTERS THAT ARE ALREADY KIND
OF OUT THERE DOING SOME OF THIS
WORK WITH THE COORDINATION AND
YES. THEY ARE- CORE PARTNERS OF
OURS- TO BE SURE. SO WE HAVE
THIRTY THREE AREA AGENCIES ON
AGING. AND ABOUT TWO THIRDS OF
THEM- RIGHT INVESTOR CAREGIVER
RESOURCE CENTERS WITH THE
CAREGIVER RESOURCE CENTER SO IN
SACRAMENTO AND SAN JOAQUIN FOR
EXAMPLE THEY ABSOLUTELY ARE
WORKING WITH THE DELL'ORO.
CAREGIVER RESOURCE CENTER.
OTHERS MONIES OTHER USED THEIR
FUNDS FOR THINGS LIKE ADULT DAY
SERVICES WHICH WE TALKED ABOUT
EARLIER. ALZHEIMER'S SPECIFIC
DIMENSIONS SUPPORT SO THERE IS
A NEED FOR BOTH THAT
COMBINATION OF PARTNERSHIP WITH
THE CAREGIVERRESOURCE CENTER
CITY ACS AS WELL AS SOME LOCAL
FLEXIBILITY. BUT THE MAJORITY
OF OUR- TRIPLE A.'S AND R.
DOLLARS ARE- IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE CARE GIVER RESOURCE
CENTERS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR. DEPARTMENT FINANCED YOU
HAVE ANY. ON ANY OF THE THREE
PROPOSALS. THERE WAS A FINANCE
NOTHING THAT AT THIS TIME THANK
YOU OKAY LMAO ANYTHING ON THESE
THREE PROPOSALS AND MAYBE THE
LAST ONE MOST SUSPECT
ESPECIALLY. THAT'S TRYING TO
PROCEED WITH THAT LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST OFFICE AS FOR THE FIRST
PROPOSAL RELATED TO SEE BASS
OUR COMMUNITY BASED ADULT
SERVICE SAYS- IN GENERAL WERE
STILL IN THE PROCESS OF
REVIEWING THE BCP BUT AT THIS
TIME NO MAJOR CONCERNS A
BROADER POINT THOUGH I'D LIKE
TO RAISE. THAT WE DID MAKE AND-
JANUARY WAS OUR OFFICE I'M GLAD
FOR THE LEGISLATURE THAT IT MAY
WANT TO CONSIDER MAINTAINING-
TEMPORARY CODE NINETEEN PROGRAM
CHANGES THAT NOW LOOKING BACK
MAY HAVE IMPROVED PROGRAM
ACCESS OR PROGRAM OUTCOMES. AND
WE KNOW THAT IN THIS AND SEE
BASS IN PARTICULAR I'M PROGRAM
CHANGES WERE MADE IN WHICH
RECIPIENTS COULD RECEIVE
SERVICES IN HOME ORTON
DOORSTEP- BUT ALSO VIA AND
TELEHEALTH- AS A SUBSTITUTE FOR
THE CONGREGATE CENTER. ARMS OF
THE LEGISLATURE IS INTERESTED-
MOVING FORWARD AND LEARNING
FROM CALL THE NINETEEN AND
ADOPTING SOME OF THOSE PROGRAM
PRACTICES I'M COS AS A POSSIBLE
AREA IN WHICH THE LEGISLATURE
COULD REQUEST ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION ON HOW
SUCCESSFUL WERE THOSE PROGRAM
FLEXIBILITIES TO WHAT EXTENT.
ARE ARE THEY POSSIBLY NEEDED IN
A POST COLD IN NINETEEN WORLD-
AND WHAT WOULD IT COST- TO
MAINTAIN THOSE FLEXIBILITIES
MOVING FORWARD- FOR ISSUE
NUMBER TWO RELATED TO- CAL.
ADDITIONAL DOLLARS FOR
CALFRESH. OUTREACH WITHIN THAT
TROUBLING NETWORK WE WERE JUST
FLYING THAT THIS GENERALLY
ALIGNS WITH PRIOR LEGISLATIVE
ACTION TAKEN A FEW YEARS AGO
WITH THE BROADER EXPANSION OF
CALFRESH WHEN IT CAME TO THE US
ISIS P. POPULATION. AND
ESSENTIALLY TRIPOLI'S WERE
GIVEN ONE TIME DOLLARS TO DO
CALFRESH OUTREACH- SO THIS
PROPOSAL ESSENTIALLY IS
RESTARTING THOSE REACH
ACTIVITIES. THAT WERE DONE IN
THE PAST. AS FOR THE THIRD
PROPOSAL THE OLDER WERE. AND
RESILIENCY PACKAGE. ONE THING
THAT WE WOULD NOTE IS AN AREA
IN WHICH- THERE WAS A LINE
MEANT RELATIVE TO ACTIONS
TAKEN- LAST WEEK OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE IT WAS. OF THE
SUSPENSION OF THE ELIMINATION
OF THE SUSPENSION LANGUAGE TIED
TO THE EIGHTY OR SEEN SENIOR
NUTRITION FUNDING. SO WITH THAT
THESE ADDITIONAL DOLLARS
PROPOSED UNDER THIS BROADER
PACKAGE WOULD BE IN ADDITION TO
THAT NOW PERMANENT BASE FUNDING
FOR THOSE TWO PROGRAMS- BUT A
BROADER POINT TO. VERY MINOR
TECHNICAL ISSUE THAT I WANTED A
FLAG FOR THE SUB COMMITTEE IS
THAT OUR OFFICE IS REVIEWING
ALSO THE ACCOMPANYING-
PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE ATTACHED
TO THESE DOLLARS IT'S OUR
UNDERSTANDING THAT- THE
ADMINISTRATION DEPENDING ON
PROGRAM MEANS OVER THE PHONE
AND THREE YEARS IN WHICH THE
DOLLARS WOULD BE APPROPRIATE
FINDINGS AROUND- TWO DIFFERENT
PROGRAM BUCKETS ARE LINE ITEMS
I'M SORRY OFFICE IT WILL JUST
LOOK AT THAT PROVISIONAL
LANGUAGE TO SEE IF THERE. ARE
OPPORTUNITIES TO- BUILD IN
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT SO WE'RE
AWARE OF WHERE THE FUNDS ARE
SHIFTING BASED OFF OF PROGRAM
NEED AND DEMAND- IT ALSO IS
SIMILAR TO WHAT WAS RAISING
YOUR STAFF COMMENTS- WITH
COLBERT NINETEEN WE DID SEE AN
INCREASE AND SOME OF THE
SERVICES WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT
OF AGING I THINK THAT BIGGEST
EXAMPLE AS SENIOR NUTRITION- SO
THERE IS A QUESTION OF. POST
CALLED THE NINETEEN WHAT IS
THAT ONGOING SERVICE NEED TO
GET A LOOK LIKE AND I KNOW I'M
PROGRAM PRIOR HEARINGS THE
DEPARTMENTS WHEN IT CAME DOING
TO KEEP A FOOT IN SECURITY THE
FLAG JUSTICE TO STICK A FORK ON
THE NINETEEN- ABOUT EIGHT
THOUSAND ELEVEN- EIGHT HUNDRED
ELEVEN THOUSAND OLDER ADULTS
THAT WERE FOOD INSECURE. I'M SO
THE QUESTION IS WITH THIS
ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO WHAT
EXTENT ARE WE MAKING PROGRESS
AND MEETING ANY POTENTIAL UNMET
NEED TO IMPROVE AND SECURITY
AMONGST OLDER ADULTS BUT THEN
ALSO ACKNOWLEDGING THAT THE
STATE DID RECEIVE ONE TIME
FEDERAL DOLLARS SOMEONE'S THOSE
RANT DOWN- AND IT WAS THIS
TEMPORARY FUNDING ALSO RAMPS
DOWN WHERE IS THE STATE ACT IT
WILL IN TERMS OF PERMANENT
FUNDING LEVELS ON AN ONGOING
BASIS AND MEETING THAT I MAY
NEED AND THAT MAY THEN HELP THE
LEGISLATURE. I UNDERSTAND IF I
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES ARE NEEDED
IN THE SPACE THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT ANALYSIS
INDICATED ONE MORE QUESTION FOR
YOU IT IT'S. THEIR IS THEIR I.
T. SYSTEM BRITTLE TO. AND OF
TRYING PROGRAM OUTCOMES.
DEFERRED TO- THE DE. I BEEN
BROUGHT UP IN PRIOR HERE. ON
EGGMAN AYE CHEER MEN- I CAN
GIVE YOU THE GOOD NEWS BAD NEWS
ANSWER THAT NO IT IS NOT REAL
BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE ONE SO
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE ARE
PROPOSING IS A CRM FOR OUR
AGING I SHOULD SAY MORE
ACCURATELY THE AGING NETWORK IS
IN FOUR DIFFERENT C. R. ENDS OF
THE STATE DOES NOT HAVE ACCESS
TO. SO THE GOAL THAT WE ARE
MOVING TOWARDS WITH THE NUMBER
ON YOUR SYSTEM ALL MIGRATING TO
A COMMON CRM THE INTEROPERABLE
HAS INTER OPERABILITY WITH OUR
MEDICAID PROGRAMS WITH OUR
COUNTY SOCIAL SERVICE PROGRAMS
IN OUR CBO SO I KNOW WE ARE NOT
BRITTLE BUT WE ARE NOT YET ANY
UNIFIED PROGRAM AND- SYSTEM AND
THAT IS ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WILL BE DELIVERING WITH A NO
WRONG DOOR INVESTMENTS I LOVE
THAT. OKAY- THANK YOU THIS IS
THIS IS A IMPORT AGAIN I YOU
WERE. INTO WHO HAS NOT.
EXPERIENCED A FLUSH OF
RESOURCES IN THE PAST AND SO.
TRYING TO PUT THEM TO THE BEST
USE POSSIBLE. AND WE TALK A LOT
ABOUT. ABOUT EQUITY AND- ISSUES
AROUND OUR COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
LGBT BUT ALL BUT I ALSO JUST
WANT TO RAISE THE ISSUE THE
LGBT COMMUNITY AND MAKE SURE.
WE ARE REACHING THAT
DEMOGRAPHIC AS WELL I HAD MY-
MY FIRST. POST COOPER DINNER
PARTY THIS THIS WEEKEND AND WE
HAD SOME OF OUR- THE G. B. T.
FRIENDS WHO ARE ARE- AT AT
AROUND EIGHTY. AND I WAS JUST
AMAZED. BY THE DIFFERENCES OF
THEIR COVERT EXPERIENCE BASED
ON THEIR FAMILIARITY WITH
TECHNOLOGY- AND YOU KNOW MANY
IN OUR COMMUNITY DON'T ALWAYS
HAVE KIDS OR OR FOLKS AND- ONE
COUPLE WHO LIVE FAR VERY.
TECHNOLOGY THAT FLUID THEY THEY
HAD. THE TOP LIGHT HOUSE TOURS
AND COOKING CLASSES IN EUROPE
ALL ONLINE. AND MY OTHER FRIEND
JUST SAID IT WAS VERY VERY HARD
ON ME AND HE DOESN'T HE DOESN'T
HAVE ACCESS- SO WE KNOW THAT
PEOPLE COMING OUT ON THIS OTHER
SIDE ARE REALLY. GOING TO BE
STRUGGLING. SO WE APPRECIATE
THIS- THIS INFUSION AND- AND
THE INTENT. TO PROVIDE MORE
SERVICES AS WELL AS THE INTENT.
TO GET ALL OF OUR PROGRAMS
HARMONIZER THAT THERE WON'T BE
A PROBLEM DOOR WHEN PEOPLE
REACH OUT FOR HELP BECAUSE IT'S
A IT IS A- FRIGHTENING TIME FOR
MANY. OKAY BUT DEPENDING THING
ON THIS. HELLO THANK YOU AND I
JUST WANT TO BRIEFLY RECOGNIZED
I SEE HERE OF NO FAULT
PREVENTION HOME MODIFICATION
AND I. WANT RECOGNIZE OUR
FORMER COLLEAGUE- CENTER HANNAH
BETH JACKSON WHO HAS NOW TURNED
OUT BUT I KNOW SHE- BUT I WAS
TRAINED SUBCOMMITTEE SHE'S SHE
KEPT COMING TO ME ABOUT. ABOUT
FUNDING. THIS AND CERTAINLY IT
WAS VERY. GOD PREVENTIVE. YOU
KNOW SOMEONE IN THE BREAKER I
MEAN OF A INCREASE READ MORE.
IS WELLS MORBIDITY. SO- THAT
THAT THEY JUST WANT RECOGNIZE
THAT AND THANK. THE SENATE
JACKSON FOR HER LEADERSHIP IN
THE PAST THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. OKAY LET'S AS WITH
THIS IS THAT THE END OF THIS
SECTION AND SO WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE OVER I BELIEVE. ASSEMBLY
UNLESS I MADE ANOTHER MISTAKE
WHICH IS POSSIBLE. BOB GOOD ALL
RIGHT OKAY SO WE ARE GOING TO
PROBABLY LET'S TAKE A ABOUT A
FIVE MINUTE RECESS SO WE CAN
PREPARE FOR DIFFERENT STAFF TO
COME IN- SO WE WILL RECONVENE
AND LET LET'S LET'S SAY WILL
RECONVENE AT ONE PM.
OKAY WE'LL
CALL THIS SUB- COMMITTEE
HEARING TO ORDER AND- WE ARE
GOING TO START OFF AS THE FIRST
ONE WE ARE HEARING IS ISSUE
NUMBER ZERO FIVE THREE ZERO
CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY ISSUE NUMBER
ONE. HIS LANGUAGE ACCESS. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND DR
PAN THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE MY NAME
IS MARK MEECHAN THE DEPUTY
SECRETARY FOR PROGRAMMING
FISCAL AFFAIRS AT THAT
CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY I'M TO BE
RELATIVELY BRIEF YOUR STAFF DID
AN EXCELLENT JOB OF OUTLINING
BOTH ARE INTENDED TO AND
BACKGROUND- WITHIN THE AGENDA
BUT I DO WANT TO SPEND A FEW
MINUTES JUST HIGHLIGHTING. A
FEW THINGS SO STARTING WITH THE
LANGUAGE ACCESS PROPOSAL REALLY
THE INTENT HERE IS TO AUGMENT
OR ADDS TO WHAT WE HAD PROPOSED
AS PART OF THE EQUITY CENTER
PROGRAM PACKAGE AT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET I TO REALLY
LIFT UP OUR ABILITY TO
IMPLEMENT LANGUAGE ACCESS
ACROSS THAT THE AGENCY OR
TWELVE DEPARTMENTS AND FIVE
OFFICES AND WHAT I WILL SAY
HERE IS THAT THE GOAL IS TO
MAKE SURE THAT ALL OF OUR
DEPARTMENTS ARE TRANSLATING IN
PROVIDING. IN LANGUAGE SERVICES
TO VITAL DOCUMENTS THAT WE POST
ARE RELEASED TO CONSUMERS AND
FAMILY MEMBERS AND TO REALLY
WORKING ACROSS THE AGENCY TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE DOING
THAT- WHAT I WANT TO REALLY
FOCUS HERE ON IS KIND OF THE
THAT WITH THE WORK THAT WE PLAN
TO DO WITH THIS WITH THESE
FUNDS FIRST AND FOREMOST
LOOKING AT THE DOCUMENTS THAT
ARE CURRENTLY POSTED. ON OUR
WEBSITE AND DOES THAT ARE
TRANSLATED TO ENSURE THAT WE
HAVE A GOOD SENSE OF WHICH WE
NEED TO TRANSLATE ADDITIONALLY
WE'RE NOT ONLY JUST FOCUSING
AROUND THE TRANSLATION OF
DOCUMENTS BUT ALSO LOOKING AT
ORAL IN SIGN LANGUAGE
INTERPRETATION SERVICES TO WEB
CONTENT OR OTHER CONTENT THAT
WE HAVE LOOKING AT ALSO LOOKING
AT PERIODIC LANGUAGE NEEDS
ASSESSMENTS TO DETERMINE
THRESHOLD LANGUAGES FOR
DOCUMENTS SO WE KNOW THAT THIS
CHANGES TIME AND TIME AND SO
REALLY BEING ABLE TO
PERIODICALLY ASSESS AND
DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT THE
LANGUAGE ARTS WERE TRANSLATING
IN ARE THE RIGHT LANGUAGES ARE
AND WHETHER OR NOT WE NEED TO
BE CHANGING AND THIS ALSO
VARIES BY REGION OF THE STATE
AND SO REALLY THINKING ABOUT
WHAT THAT LOOKS LIKE. WE ALSO.
WANTED TO KEEP THAT A TAKE A
CLOSER LOOK AT HOW WE- AND
STREAMLINE INTERPRET. OF THE
AGENTS. MANY OF OUR DEPARTMENTS
AND INDEPENDENT CONTRACTS AND
SO THINKING ABOUT HOW DO WE
GAIN ECONOMIES OF SCALE. AND
LEVERAGE THE STATE'S PURCHASING
POWER TO DRIVE DOWN COSTS ON
LANGUAGE TRANSLATION AND
TRANSLATION SERVICES TO BE ABLE
TO DO THAT- AND THEN I DO TO
ADDITIONAL THINGS WHICH IS WHY
DO QUALITY CONTROL MEASURES TO
ENSURE THAT THE ACCURACY
RELIABILITY. AND CULTURAL
APPROPRIATENESS IS OF THE
DOCUMENTS WERE TRANSLATING TO
REALLY MAKING SURE THAT WHEN WE
DO HAVE CONTRACTORS TRANSLATING
THAT WE'RE ALSO. DOING SOME
QUALITY CONTROL IN THE
DOCUMENTS THAT WERE PUTTING
OUT. AND FINALLY DOING SOME AB
ROBUST ENGAGING WITH OUR
STAKEHOLDER PARTNERS. TO ENSURE
CONTINUOUS IMPROVEMENT ON
LANGUAGE ACCESS ACROSS THE
AGENCY ACROSS THE DPARTMENT
OUR COMMUNITY STAKEHOLDERS BOTH
INDIVIDUALS WERE CONSUMERS OF
OUR PRODUCTS BUT AS WELL AS-
ASSOCIATIONS AND OTHER PARTNERS
ARE IMPORTANT- ACT ASPECT OF
OUR WORK CONSERVE REALLY
ENGAGING WITH THEM. AND BEING
ABLE TO UNDERSTAND WHAT THEY'RE
HEARING HOW WE CAN IMPROVE THEM
WORKING WITH THEM TO MAKE THOSE
IMPROVEMENTS. THE MANAGER ALL
PAS THERE I THINK THE ENGINE IT
DOES A NICE JOB OF LAYING OUT
THE PIECES AND WOULD BE HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS TO YOU
OR OTHER MEMBERS HAVE. THANK.
YOU VERY MUCH DEPARTMENT
FINANCE ANYTHING. OTHER WORDS
FARMING TO FINANCE SOMETHING.
DEPARTMENT OF FARRER LU. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR SONIA PETTICOAT
THE L. A. O. I WE JUST WOULDN'T
KNOW WHICH THAT IMPROVING
LANGUAGE ACCESS IS OBVIOUSLY A
VERY GOOD AND IMPORTANT IDEA
BUT WE HAVE SOME CONCERNS ABOUT
THE PROPOSAL ITSELF SO THE
ORIGINAL PROPOSAL IN JANUARY
WAS FOR THREE HUNDRED AND SEVEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR TO LIMITED
TERM POSITION IS TO DEVELOP A
LANGUAGE ACCESS FREE MARKET
POLICY FOR THE HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY THESE POSITIONS
WILL BE LOOKING AT ISSUES SUCH
AS LEGAL COMPLIANCE- SORT OF
FIGURING OUT THE STANDARDS FOR
BILINGUAL STAFF TESTING
COMPLIANCE OTHER HR ISSUES AND
ENGAGING. STAKEHOLDERS TO SORT
OF DETERMINE LANGUAGE ACCESS
NEEDS AND THE LIKE THE
THRESHOLD LANGUAGES INSTRUMENT
SHOULD MENTION I'M THE NEW
PROPOSAL IS FOR TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS TWENTY THREE YEAR
LIMITED TERM POSITIONS ACROSS
MULTIPLE DEPARTMENTS AND
FUNDING FOR VARIOUS CONTRACTS
FOR INTERPRETATION TRANSLATION
AND LANGUAGE SERVICES. SO WHAT
OUR CONCERN IS AT THE MOMENT IS
THAT IT'S NOT CLEAR WHAT EACH
OF THESE TWENTY POSITIONS WOULD
BE DOING OR HOW MUCH THEY WOULD
COST THERE'S BEEN A FACT SHEET
PUT OUT- BUT IT DOESN'T HAVE
SOME OF THESE DETAILS SO FOR
EXAMPLE EVEN IF WE ASSUME THAT
THE POSITIONS THEMSELVES COSTS
MAYBE BETWEEN TWO AND THREE
MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR IS SORT
OF UNCLEAR WHAT THE REMAINING
SEVENTEEN TO EIGHTEEN MILLION-
HOW THE SET REMAINING SEVENTEEN
OR EIGHTEEN MILLION WOULD BE
SPENT ON THE CONTRACTS THAT
WERE PREVIOUSLY DESCRIBED BY MR
LEACH. SO ONE OPTION THAT WE
WOULD SUGGEST FOR WHAT IT THE
LEGISLATIVE CONSIDERATION IS TO
APPROVE A SMALLER AMOUNT OF
FUNDING- IN THE TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO BUDGET YEAR FOR SOME
STAFF TO DEVELOP THE FRAMEWORK
AS ORIGINALLY PLANNED AND THEN
TO TARGET SOME RESOURCES TO THE
OBVIOUS- YOU KNOW I'M SURE
THERE WILL BE SOME OBVIOUS
NEEDS R. FOR LANGUAGE ACCESS
AND CHANGES. BUT THEN- THE
LEGISLATURE COULD REQUIRE THE
ADMINISTRATION TO COME BACK AT
THE TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE
GOVERNOR'S. BUDGET WITH A MORE
DETAILED PLAN FRAZIER I SEEING
THAT THAT REALLY KNOW THIS. OF
LANGUAGE ACCESS TO CRY HEALTH
AND SERVICES DEPARTMENTS AND
PROGRAMS AND PROVIDE CERTAIN
CLEAR JUSTIFICATIONS FOR THE
PARTICULAR AMOUNTS REQUESTED.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISS PATRICK- DIRECTOR I WOULD
I WOULD. ECHO THAT SENTIMENT
SOME WE WENT FROM UP A SMALLER
SMALLER ASK THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND TO UP TO TWENTY
MILLION- AND I THINK ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT YOU MENTIONED WAS
WANTING TO DO SOME MORE OUTRAGE
WITH YOUR STAKEHOLDERS TO SEE-
WHAT SERVICES WERE ACTUALLY
REQUIRED. AND I KNOW DOCTOR PAN
WILL ALWAYS SAY THAT WE NEED TO
BE CAREFUL WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
TRANSLATION VERSES
INTERPRETATION AND THOSE ARE
TWO DIFFERENT THINGS AND AS
WE'RE REALLY TALKING ABOUT-
TAXES AND REACHING OUT TO AS
MANY PEOPLE AS POSSIBLE WE HAVE
TO KEEP THOSE KINDS OF THINGS
IN MIND AS WELL- AND AS YOU
KNOW WE ARE. NO OR VERY BIG
STATE WITHOUT INCREDIBLY
DIVERSE POPULATION. I CLOSE MY
EYES AND I SEE MY COMMUNITY.
AND I KNOW. MULTIPLE LANGUAGES
ARE. ARE ARE USED ACROSS THE
SPECTRUM SO. THESE ARE ALL
THINGS THAT I THINK NEED TO BE
WORKED OUT BEFORE WE JUMP ALL
THE WAY AND WE ALL AGREE. WITH
THE EFFORT YOU'RE TRYING TO
MAKE- BUT I THINK WE NEED TO
ALSO THEN. MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
ENGAGING WITH OUR STAKEHOLDERS.
AND FOLKS SO WE ACTUALLY. GET
IT RIGHT. WE'RE GOING FORWARD
DR GRANT MEETING ON THIS. NO
THANK YOU AND- FREESHEET. THE
CAUTION- FROM THE LA- ALTHOUGH
I WOULD ALSO PERHAPS MENTIONED
THAT- DOESN'T TAKE A WHOLE YEAR
TO DO THE EVALUATION AND THEN
PERHAPS WE CAN DO IS THINK
ABOUT- IS. THE HOT HOT BECAUSE
THIS IS CERTAINLY AN URGENT
NEED. AND A LONG STANDING NEEDS
SO- SO. I GET THE PLANNING AND
SO FORTH AND CERTAINLY THE
CHANGE IN SCALE FROM ORIGINAL
PROPOSAL BUT I ALSO THINK THIS
NEW PROPOSAL DOES RECOGNIZE.
THAT THERE ARE- THERE MANY
OTHER ISSUES IN ADDITION TO
WHAT WAS ORIGINALLY PROPOSED IN
JUNE IN JANUARY AND APPRECIATE.
THAT THE INVESTMENT LOOKING AT
AT- SO I JUST WANNA THINK IN
TERMS OF. ONE TIMELINE HOW LONG
DO WE NEED TO DO THE PLANNING
PART WE CERTAINLY NEED TO DO
THAT BUT THEN IS IT. ARE YOU A
BILL MOVE EARLIER THAN ONE
WHOLE FISCAL YEAR- THAT.
PRECEDE THE FACT THAT WE DO TRY
NEED MORE CLARITY KELLY HAS
TWENTY SET TWENTY TWO POSITION
SOCIAL SERVICES ONE PUBLIC
HEALTH ONE D. EIGHT CSL DOES IS
THAT REALLY THE RIGHT NUMBERS-
WHAT EXACTLY ARE THEY DOING-
BUT ALSO MAKE NOTE THAT I JUST
NEED A FEW COMMENTS- IN TERMS
OF- CAN WE TALK ABOUT THRESHOLD
LANGUAGES OFTENTIMES RACIAL
LANGUAGES ARE DEFINED. BY ABOUT
PERCENT OF PEOPLE WHO SPEAK
THAT LANGUAGE IN THE GENERAL
POPULATION BUT IF WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THE TYPE SERVICES- WE MAY
ALSO A LOOK AT. PROPORTION OF
PEOPLE SPEAKING THOSE LANGUAGES
IN RICARDO SERVICES WHICH MAY
BE A DIFFERENT. COMBINATION I
WOULD ALSO MAKE NOTES- IN THE
API COMMUTE FOR EXAMPLE ARE.
THEY FLYING PACIFIC ISLANDERS.
AS WELL- IS ONE SIDE OF THE
DISPARITIES- OFTENTIMES THEIR
LANGUAGES DON'T HIT THE
THRESHOLD SO- SO I WANTED TO BE
SURE WE ADDRESS THAT ISSUE
ABOUT WE THINK ABOUT
THRESHOLDS. AS WELL AND THEN
THE OTHER POINT IS THAT AND YOU
KNOW WE TALK ABOUT DOCUMENTS
AND SO FORTH. ARE THERE ARE
STILL SOME LANGUAGES. IN WHICH
THE MAJORITY POPULATIONS NOT
IT'S REALLY MORE OF AN ORAL
LANGUAGE THAN A WRITTEN
LANGUAGE AND I THINK IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT TO. GET TO WORK WITH
THE COMMUNITY. AND SO WE CAN
PUT SOMETHING QUOTE UNQUOTE IN
WRITING BUT IT MAY NOT BE THAT
ACCESSIBLE IS A WRITTEN THAT
YOU KNOW AND- IT. IT IT IT IT
IS A WRITTEN LANGUAGE AND PER
SE. AND- WHETHER THERE'S
ALTERNATE REASON WEBSITE WHERE
YOU ACTUALLY COULD. YOU KNOW
PUT SHOULD. ACTUAL OR READING
OF THAT BE MORE EXCESSIVE SO.
BE ABLE TO DO SOME OF THAT MORE
IN DEPTH WORK AS WELL- IN A
DEFINED WHAT'S THE BEST WAY TO
COMMUNICATE AND CONVEY THE
INFORMATION. TO PEOPLE SPECIAL
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THINGS LIKE
YOU KNOW THE SOCIAL THERE ARE.
AROUND HEALTHCARE SOCIAL
SERVICES SO FORTH WHERE. ALSO
YOU KNOW- I GUESS READING LEVEL
AND- LEVEL MAY HIM ALSO BE
BARRIER AS WELL LANGUAGE. AND
UP WITH- LEADERS- BE SURE TO
WE'RE- PUTTING BOTH IN LANGUAGE
ALSO THE RATE YOU KNOW. A
LITERACY LEVEL. FOR PEOPLE TO
BE TO CONNECT AND FOR ACTOR.
AND OF COURSE FEEDING BACK TO
COMPETE WITH ALL HAD STORIES
ABOUT. WERE SOMEONE OUT AND- A
CHECK. THANK YOU PEOPLE IN THE-
RE IT KNOWS VERY. THAN. AT THE
START THIS EFFORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ALL RIGHT
MOVING ON TO ISSUE NUMBER TWO
HEALTH INFORMATION EXCHANGE
LEADERSHIP. SURE MADAM CHAIR
THIS IS MARK ME CHICKEN WITH
THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY IN HERE AGAIN I
THINK YOUR STAFF DID A
EXCELLENT JOB AND KIND OF
OUTLINING AND THE PIECES IN THE
INTENT. OUT WHAT I WILL JUST
HIGHLIGHT HERE IS THAT THE IN
THE IDEA IS FOR US TO THE
FUNDING REQUEST IS FOR
RESEARCHERS AT THE STATE LEVEL
TWO POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
TO BE ABLE TO BEGIN TO BUILD
OUT ADDITIONAL LEADERSHIP- AND
ENGAGE WITH THE STAKEHOLDER
COMMUNITY AROUND HOW WE EXPAND
THE USE OF. THE EXCHANGE OF-DATA BOTH ON THE HOUSE SIDE AND
THE HUMAN SERVICES SIDE IN
ORDER TO IMPROVE OUTCOMES AND
OVER THE PAST DECADE BOTH WITH
HIGH TECH AND ARE ACTUALLY MADE
SOME SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS IN
BUILDING WHAT I WILL CALL THE
ROADS- THE PIPELINE OF THE
EXCHANGE OF DATA WHAT WE NEED
TO DO NOW IS GET MORE FOLKS ON
THAT RELY ON THOSE ROADS OR
WITHIN THOSE PIPELINES. AND
THINK ABOUT WHAT STANDARDS AND
FURTHER INCENTIVIZED- THE USE
OF THE SHARING OF DATA AND
INFORMATION AMONGST DIFFERENT
PROVIDERS AND DIFFERENT
ORGANIZATIONS THAT PROVIDE
SERVICES TO THE MOST VULNERABLE
AND AT RISK INDIVIDUALS IN
CALIFORNIA. THE GOAL HERE
REALLY IS TO COUPLE DATA TO
BETTER UNDERSTAND THE NEEDS OF
THE INDIVIDUALS WERE SERVING
BUT ALSO UNDERSTAND WHAT
SERVICES THEY ARE ACCESSING AND
HOW WE CAN FURTHER SUPPORT-
THAT THEIR- THEIR AXIS OF
ADDITIONAL SERVICES IN ORDER TO
ADDRESS THE NEEDS THAT WE MAY
BE DOING AND THIS IS WHAT I
WILL CLARIFY HERE IS THAT. THE
INTENT HERE IS NOT TO JUST
FOCUS ON THE EXCHANGE OF DATA
AMONG STATE ENTITIES ALTHOUGH
THAT'S IMPORTANT BUT IT'S A
LINE OF EFFORT THAT WE'VE
EMBARKED ON OVER THE COURSE OF
THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS AND
THAT THE HIS HIGHLIGHTED- THE
URGENCY OF IT UNDER THE COVER
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. BUT THE
INTENT HERE REALLY IS LOOK AT
HOW DOES A COMMERCIAL MARKET
AND PRIVATE BY PROVIDERS AND
ORGANIZATIONS REALLY EXCHANGE
DATA WHAT STANDARDS DO WE AS A
GOVERNMENT SAT ON THEM IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE FEDERAL
STANDARDS THAT ARE BEING PUT
FORWARD. TO BE ABLE TO
ACCELERATE THE EXCHANGE OF DATA.
IN A MORE HOLISTIC WAY SAW
BECAUSE THERE ANY ANSWER ANY.
YOU MAY. THANK YOU DEPARTMENT
FINANCE. TIGER WOODS FINANCED
NOTHING FURTHER THANK YOU OKAY
MISTER WHICH I'M GONNA IF I
DON'T SEE YOUR HAND ABOUT A
STOP CALLING ON YOU FOR AWHILE
OKAY. SOUNDS GOOD THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT MISS PANIC. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR CINEMATIC WITH THE
L. A. OKAY AND- THEN THE IDEA
IN THIS PROPOSAL SCENE YOU KNOW
IT REALLY APPEARS TO IT TO MAKE
SENSE BUT WE'RE STILL
REVIEWING. THE PROPOSAL AND I
WANT TO CONSULT WITH SORT OF
OUR L. A. I. T. EXPERT BUT WELL
YOU KNOW IF WE SEE ANY RED
FLAGS OR ANYTHING WILL BE SURE
TO CONTACT THE BUDGET SUB
COMMITTEE STAFF BUT- AS IT. AS
IT AS IT LOOKS I DON'T THINK
WE'RE GONNA HAVE CONCERNS WITH
THE PROPOSAL. OKAY MOST READ IT
CAN YOU CAN YOU TALK A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT THE TIMELINE I DON'T
SEE ANY TIMELINE- NUMBERS ABOUT
HOW. HOW SOON ARE WE GOING TO
BE ABLE TO DO THIS ARE YOU
ANTICIPATING THIS. WITHIN THE
NEXT BUDGET YEAR OR WHEN ARE
YOU ANTICIPATING THAT. THIS ALL
ALL THIS WILL BE DONE AND READY
TO READY TO GO. DISCORDANT
EXPECT. THE INTENT. IS TO GET
WORKING ON THIS WE'VE ACTUALLY
BEGUN LAYING THE GROUND WORK IN
TERMS OF. ACT CONVENING
INTERNALLY AND BEING ABLE TO
MAP OUT KIND OF WHAT ROLE WE AS
A GOVERNMENT ENTITY PLAY WE'VE
HAD CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
BIDEN MINISTRATION IN THE
FEDERAL- AND SEE. AROUND
STANDARDS OPINION TEND TO ISSUE
SO WE'VE ALREADY STARTED I WILL
SAY THAT I THINK THE GOAL IS
TO. HIT THE GROUND RUNNING AS
SOON AS THE BUDGET ACT ASSIGNED
TO BE ABLE TO BRING IN
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES THERE SOME
CONTRACT RESOURCES THAT ARE
WE'RE ASKING FOR- BUT THEN VERY
SOON PROBABLY WITHIN. THE FALL
PARAMETER CONVENE STAKEHOLDERS
TO BEGIN TO MAP OUT HOW WE
FURTHER ENGAGE. ON THIS
PARTICULAR TOPIC. SO WAIT YOU
CAN AND YOU'RE IN AND YOU'RE
GONNA START UP THE PLAY VERY
STARTED SOMEBODY GONNA START
THE PLANNING AND THE ONE AFTER
WERE TOGETHER INTERNALLY BEFORE
YOU BEGIN TO MOVE EXTERNALLY SO
TELL ME AGAIN WHEN DO YOU WHEN
DO WE THINK IT'LL ALL BE DONE.
SO I THINK THAT THIS IS AN
ONGOING EFFORT I DON'T THINK AT
NO POINT WILL WE EVER BE
COMPLETELY TEN BUT THIS
CONVERSATION OR THE THINKING
AROUND HOW WE EVOLVE TECHNOLOGY
CHANGES TO STANDARDS WILL
CHANGE. SO I THINK THAT THIS IS
GOING TO BE SOMETHING THAT WILL
HAVE TO CONTINUALLY REVISIT.
WHAT I WILL SAY IS THAT IN THE
FALL WILL WELL CONVENE EXTERNAL
STAKEHOLDERS. OVER THE COURSE
OF THE LAST COUPLE OF MONTHS
WHAT WE'VE BEGUN IS LAYING OUT.
HOW WE THINK ABOUT THIS
INTERNALLY WITH SOME OF THE
DEPARTMENTS WITHIN OUR AGENCY.
AND THEN LOOKING AT STANDARDS
TOWARDS THE END OF THE BUDGET
YEAR AND MOVING FORWARD.
OBVIOUSLY THIS IS ONE TIME
FUNDING THAT WE'RE LOOKING TO
PROPOSE I THINK WE'LL COME BACK
TO THE LEGISLATURE BASED ON THE
STAKEHOLDER CONVERSATIONS. TO
FIGURE OUT WHETHER OR NOT
THERE'S ONGOING FUNDING NEEDED
IN ORDER FOR US TO BE ABLE TO
ACCELERATE AND OR IMPLEMENT
SOME OF THIS WORK. THANK YOU.
TO DEPEND. THANK YOU. CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE. THIS IS VERY
IMPORTANT WORK- WELL QUESTIONS
I WANT ANSWERED THAT SKEWS IT
IS THAT- WELL EXPLOSIVELY ON
THE- ON THE SERVER
ADMINISTRATIVE SIDE YOU KNOW
WE'RE CREATING AND ALL CLAIMS
PAYER DATABASE RUSSIFIED AND SO
FORTH. I THINK ON THE CLINICAL
SIDE ONE OF THINGS WE NEED TO
DO IS THAT CERTAINLY IN ITSELF
THE HEALTH INFORMATION SIEGES
PORTENT BUT HE TALK ABOUT HOW
THIS IS GOING TO HOOK INTO
PUBLIC HEALTH SYSTEM SO FOR
EXAMPLE- WE DON'T KNOW PUBLIC
HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE- WE NEED
TO BE ABLE TO DO SURVEILLANCE
WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO DO- YOU
KNOW- DISEASE REPORTING- YOU
KNOW WE THINK ABOUT DOING KODAK
SCENES IN OUR VACCINE REGISTRY
HOW THAT HOOKS UP AS WELL SO
THERE'S- A POSSIBILITY OF
EXCHANGE APPROPRIATE CHANGE OF
DATA AS WELL TO SEND TO CERTIFY
VACCINATION STATUS TO. IDENTIFY
PEOPLE WHO STILL NEED VACCINES-
AND BY LATE SUCH AS KODAK
SCENES SO FORTH SO THERE'S A
LOT OF DATA YOU KNOW IMPORTANT
DATE AND I ONE THING I DON'T
ALSO WANT TO EMPHASIZE THOUGH
IS ONLY TALKING ABOUT DISEASE
SURVEILLANCE IT'S NOT JUST
CONTAGIOUS DISEASES. FOR
EXAMPLE- APARTHEID DEVELOP A
STRATEGY TO ADDRESS CHRONIC
DISEASES- THE ABILITY OF PUBLIC
HEALTH TO BE ABLE TO INTERFACE
WITH- CONNECT WITH A HEALTH
INFORMATION EXCHANGES TO THEN
DO SURVEILLANCE ON FOR EXAMPLE
RATES OF WHETHER IT'S DIABETES
OR- CAL THE COPD HIGH BLOOD
PRESSURE IT'S CETERA CAN BE
ACTUALLY EXTREMELY VALUABLE. TO
TO NOT ONLY THE STATE AND- AND
BUT ALSO TO THIS- ORGANIZATIONS
WELL TO HELP US. DEVELOP A MORE
ROBUST. AB HEALTH AND- WE THINK
OF BUILT IN. OF TYPES OF IN.
AND ALSO TO FIND OUT WHAT THE
RESULTS OUR INTERVIEW. ARE SO
DO YOU THINK ABOUT A MODERN DAY
PUBLIC HEALTH SYSTEM- THAT
ABILITY TO DO THAT KIND OF- TO
COLLECT THAT KIND OF
SURVEILLANCE DATA IS GOING TO
BE CRITICAL. AND THE WAIVER SO.
THE WAY WE'RE GONNA DO IT'S NOT
WHAT THE PUBLIC HEALTH GOING
AROUND AND RE COLLECTING ALL
THE DATA BUT HAVING SYSTEMS IN
PLACE. THAT ALLOW THE EXCHANGE
OF INFORMATION IN AGGREGATE OR
OTHER WAYS HEALTH COURSE OF
CERTAINLY MAINTAINING
INDIVIDUAL PATIENT PRIVACY BUT
BE ON THE LOOK AT THINGS AND
AGATES WITH INFORMATION COMING
FROM OUR VARIOUS. NOW HEALTH
PARTNERS RATE HOSPITALS HEALTH
SYSTEMS PHYSICIANS OTHER
PROVIDERS ETCETERA. AND SO BE
SURE ARE THE INFORMATION
SYSTEMS WE'RE DEVELOPING AS
WE'RE TRYING TO DEVELOP THESE
EXCHANGES. THAT ALSO
INFORMATION CAN BE- THERE'S
THAT THE SYSTEMS ARE DESIGNED
IN A WAY THAT INFORMATION CAN
FLOW- TO PUBLIC HEALTH AND EVEN
BACK- BACK AND FORTH- SO CAN
YOU SPEAK TO THAT. TO TALK
ABOUT YOUR SPOT ON- I THINK
THAT. ONE OF THE EFFORTS AS
PART OF OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
REVIEW AND CONDUCTOR GALLEY
SPOKE OF THIS YESTERDAY- IN IN
THE ASSEMBLY AND HE ALLUDED TO
IT ALSO IN THE CONVERSATION
THAT HE HAD WITH. WITH THIS
COMMITTEE EARLIER IN THE WEEK
IS REALLY ASSESSING THE
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY
PLATFORMS THAT WE CURRENTLY USE
ON THE PUBLIC OUTSIDE. BUT I
THINK WHAT YOU'VE IDENTIFIED IS
THERE'S TWO PRINCIPLES THAT
YOU'VE IDENTIFIED THAT I THINK
ARE REALLY IMPORTANT TO LIFT
THAT BAN IS WHAT WE'RE TRYING
TO. I THINK- LEVERAGE HERE AS
PART OF THIS CONVERSATION FIRST
AND FOREMOST. ON THE PUBLIC
OUTSIDE FROM A DISEASE
SURVEILLANCEPERSPECTIVE WE'RE
NOT ONLY FOCUSED ON INFECTIOUS
OR COMMUNICABLE DISEASES LIKE
COVERT NINETEEN OR ZEKE OUR
MEASLES. BUT LOOKING AT THE
CHRONIC DISEASES AS WELL AND WE
HAVE A SERIES OF CLINICAL
REGISTRIES THAT PROVIDERS LIKE
YOURSELF REPORT INTO. THE
CHALLENGE REALLY IS THE DATA
THAT WE SENT BACK I SAY WHERE
DATA RICH BUT INFORMATION POOR
WE COLLECT A LOT OF DATA BUT WE
DO NOTHING WITH THAT. EITHER WE
DON'T PROVIDE IT BACK TO YOU AS
A PROVIDER IN ORDER TO HELP
FUEL YOUR POPULATION HEALTH
MANAGEMENT TOOLS OR OTHER
EFFORTS AROUND HOW YOU.
BASICALLY ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF
THE POPULATION YOU'RE TRYING TO
SERVE NOR DO WE USE IT IN A
MORE ROBUST WAY TO THINK ABOUT
POLICY OR PROGRAM CHANGES STERN
FORMER THINKING. SO THERE'S TWO
ASPECTS TO THIS ONE IS
INCREASING THE CONNECTIVITY OF
THOSE REGISTRIES. TO BE ABLE TO
PUSH BACK THE INFORMATION TO
THE PROVIDER. OR THE HEALTH
CARE ENTITY IN ORDER FOR THEM
TO HAVE A BETTER SENSE OF WHAT
THEIR PATIENT POPULATION LOOKS
LIKE AND TRENDS THAT WERE SEEN.
AS WELL AS THE LOCAL PUBLIC
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS IN ORDER FOR
THEM TO ENGAGE AFFECTED
COMMUNITY LEVEL. BUT IT'S ALSO
IMPORTANT FOR US AS A STATE
COLLECTIVELY WITH OTHER
PARTNERS TO THINK ABOUT HOW
THAT FUELS PROGRAM DESIGNED
POLICY DESIGN AND RESEARCH
MOVING FORWARD TO HELP INFORM.
CHANGES AND THIS IS WHERE I
THINK OF BRINGING IN
CONVERSATIONS WITH OUR ACADEMIC
PARTNERS WE'VE BEEN HAVING
CONVERSATIONS. AROUND A
RESEARCH DATA HAVE REALLY NEDS
TO LINK BOTH THE CALL. AND DATA
WHAT WE KNOW RIGHT NOW WHEN
RESEARCHERS GET OUR DATA WE
DON'T REALLY LOOK AT RESULTS OR
WE DON'T GET A SENSE OF WHAT
THE RESULTS ARE. OF THE
RESEARCH TWO THREE FOUR FIVE
YEARS DOWN THE ROAD AND MOST
OFTEN HAPPENS WHEN IT'S
PUBLISHED IN ACADEMIC PAPERS
CAN WE ACCELERATE THAT
PARTNERSHIP AND BE ABLE TO.
HAVE OUR STATE WORKFORCE CO
CREATE WITH ACADEMICS TO BE
ABLE TO IN REAL TIME GET A
SENSE OF WHAT'S HAPPENING WITH
THE DATA TO INFORM POLICY
MAKING. IN ORDER FOR US TO
IMPROVE THE DELIVERY OF
PROGRAMS AND SERVICES AND THIS
IS EXACTLY THE- KIND OF THAT
THE ACADEMY OF WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO WITH THIS WORK
WITH THE H. ID. SO I APPRECIATE
THAT AND HAVING BEEN FORMALLY A
FACULTY MEMBER AT- DINNERS THE
CALIFORNIA DAVIS AND- DOING
HEALTH SERVICES RESEARCH SO I
WAS ONE OF THOSE DATA PEOPLE.
LOOKING AT SOME OF THESE LARGE
DATASETS- BUT YOU GET SO I
WOULD JUST SAY IS THAT- I HOPE.
THAT AS WERE- DOING THE BUDGET
WE HAVE STRONG SUPPORT FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR ACTUALLY- SO
I KNOW YOU HAVE PROPOSALS FOR
THIS COMING YEAR FOR LIKE THREE
MILLION ON THOSE. C. P. H. AND
HERE WE HAVE. TWO AND A HALF
MILLION BUT THEN FORGOT REALLY
SERIOUS ABOUT BUILDING OUT THE
SYSTEMS TENWE SHOULD BE
HAVING HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS
RESERVE HELD. BUDGETED IN DOUBT
AND WHETHER IT'S LATER THIS
YEAR IN THE OUT YEARS TO
ACTUALLY BUILD THE SYSTEM SO WE
CAN STUDY THEM BUT IF WE ARE
NOT HOLDING RESOURCES TO BE
ABLE TO BUILD THEM OUT- THEN-
IT'S A GREAT CONVERSATION BUT-
AND WE DO HAVE BE GREAT
ASSESSMENT. SO IS THAT THE
INTENTION ADMINISTRATION THEN.
CENTER I MEAN I THINK THAT TO
DOCTOR GALLEYS POINT EARLIER
THIS WEEK THE INTENT OF THE
ADMINISTRATION IS REALLY TO
LEVERAGE THE THREE MILLION ON
THE PUBLIC OUTSIDE TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION WITH OUR LOCAL
PARTNERS TO ASSESS THE GAPS AND
BETTER UNDERSTAND. WHERE WE GO
I THINK THE INTENT OF THE
ADMINISTRATION IS TO COME BACK
IN TWENTY TWENTY TWO. THAT'S
PART OF THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
TO MAP OUT. IN MORE EARNEST
SOME OF THE PIECES AND PUT
FORWARD ADDITIONAL FUNDING
REQUEST WHAT. AROUND THE SPACE
THE ONLY THING I WILL ADD HERE
IS THAT WE'VE MADE SOME
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS WITH
FEDERAL DOLLARS BOTH THE ERC
GRANT AND OTHER FEDERAL DOLLARS
THAT WE RECEIVED. TO BUILD OUT
THESE TECHNOLOGY SYSTEMS ON THE
PUBLIC OUTSIDE I THINK THE
CONVERSATION WILL BE AROUND HOW
WE CONTINUE TO FIND SOME OF
THOSE PIECES AND WHAT WE
CONTINUE TO LEFT UP. THAT WE'VE
ACCELERATED AND BELTS DURING
THE COVER NINETEEN PANDEMIC.
OKAY WELL LET'S WAS I HAVING
BEEN. ON THE BUDGET COMMITTEE
FOR A FEW YEARS AND SEEN MANY
IT PROJECTS I DON'T SOUND TOO
MANY THAT- THAT WERE ONLY GET
FOR A FEW MILLION- AND- SO I
ALREADY KNOW YOU KNOW JUST FROM
A SKILL STANDPOINT. I THINK YOU
KNOW. IF WE'RE EVER BEING
REALLY HONEST WITH OURSELVES.
AND IS THIS A DEDICATION OF THE
ABSENT AND ISSUES. IS MORE THAN
JUST IDENTIFICATION W'RE GOING
TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT. THEN
WE DO NEED TO THINK AS WE YOU
KNOW OBVIOUSLY WE PASS A BUDGET
A YEAR AT A TIME BUT IN TERMS
OF LOOKING AT OUT YEARS. WE
SHOULD DEFINITELY BE. CHECKED I
COMMIT THINKING ABOUT WHAT WE
KIND OF COMMITMENTS WE HAVE TO
MAKE IN ORDER TO ACTUALLY
FOLLOW THROUGH. AND WHILE WE
MAY NOT KNOW THE EXACT AMOUNTS.
I CERTAINLY- I CAN YOU KNOW
THINK PAST EXPERIENCE CAN
CERTAINLY TO HELP US ESTIMATE
AT LEAST THE SKILL OF FUNDS
THAT WE MIGHT WILL PROBABLY
NEED TO. ENSURE THAT. WE'RE
WE'RE WE'RE BUILDING IN TO MAKE
THIS HAPPEN OTHERWISE WE'RE NOT
BEING REALISTIC ABOUT IT RIGHT-
SO I DEBTS. SO HOPEFULLY- YOU
KNOW THAT'S PART OF THE
CONVERSATION OUT AGAIN I THINK
SIMILARLY FOR THE FIGHT TO SAVE
THE PREVIOUS ITEM AS WELL I'M
NOT SURE THE ASSESSMENTS NESTLE.
TAKE A WHOLE FISCAL YEAR. I
MEAN CERTAIN CERTAIN TO ME.
DIFFER PIECES AND PARTS SO WE
CAN ALSO GET A HEAD START ON
SOME OF THE-THINGS. AS WE- TO
GET. MOVING BUT I GUESS ON THIS
PARTICULAR ISSUE I JUST WANNA
BE SURE THAT AS WE'RE- BUILDING
OUT THE STANDARDS AND- SO FORTH
FOR OUR HEALTH INFORMATION
EXCHANGES WE ARE PUTTING BE
SURE WE ESTABLISH STANDARDS
THAT ALLOW US. TO BE ABLE TO DO
THIS KIND OF SAID DISEASE
SURVEILLANCE- CRYING DISEASE
ETCETERA. THAT THOSE STANDARDS
ARE GOING TO BE IN PLACE SO WE
HAVE THE POSSIBILITY AND THEN
WILL HAVE TO FOLLOW THROUGH ON
THAT POSSIBILITY INTERNET
REALITY WITH RESOURCES. AND
WHETHER IT'S LATER THIS NEXT
THIS FISCAL YEAR ARE. ARE NOW
YOURS THANK YOU. OKAY THANK
YOU- AND I. ANYBODY WHO HAS TO
FILL OUT A LOT OF A LOT OF-
FORMS AND DATA IT SOMETIMES CAN
FEEL LIKE YOU'RE JUST YOU KNOW
WEIRD WHERE DOES THIS
INFORMATION GO ARE BEING
REQUIRED TO DO ALL OF THIS AND
I NEVER SEE IT BACK AND I DON'T
SEE ANYTHING DONE WITH WHAT I
PUT IN SO I THINK IF WE HAVE
THAT MORE CIRCULAR FILE OTHER
WERE ACTUALLY USING THE DATA
THAT WE'RE ASKING FOR- I THINK
YOU'LL FIND EVEN THE COMPLIANCE
WITH EVERYTHING. WILL BEGIN TO
GO UP SO THANK YOU AND TAKE
SPECIAL NOTE OF- DOCTOR PANS
SUGGESTIONS OKAY MOVING ON TO-
STILL WITH M. SET TO THE ISSUE
NUMBER ONE INCREASE INCREASED
EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS. AND
RESPONSE CAPACITY. HI THIS IS
RICK TRUSSELL CHIEF OF
ADMINISTRATION OF THE EMERGENCY
MEDICAL SERVICES AUTHORITY. DR
DUNCAN SHOULD BE ON IN ABOUT
TWO SECONDS HE JOHN. HEY HI
FOLKS. SORRY JUST LEFT YOUR
OFFICE RIGHT. GOOD AFTERNOON.
I'M SHARING SENATE SUBCOMMITTEE
MEMBERS. I'M DAVE DUNCAN I'M AN
EMERGENCY PHYSICIAN AND THE
DIRECTOR OF THE EMERGENCY
MEDICAL SERVICES AUTHORITY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE OUR
INFORMATION TODAY ON THESE.
FIVE AMPS UP PROPOSALS- MISTER
RICK TRUSSELL WHO YOU JUST
MATTER OF A- WILL BE PROVIDING
A SUMMARY. OF EACH OF THESE
PROPOSALS BUT IN ADDITION
MYSELF OUR CHIEF DEPUTY LEWIS
BRONCHI AND OUR CHIEF OF
DISASTER MEDICAL SERVICES CRAIG
JOHNSON WILL BE AVAILABLE FOR
FOLLOW UP QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
WITH THAT- BACK TO YOU MISTER
TRUSSELL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
DR DON CAN GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THE DEPARTMENT
CURRENTLY HAS FIVE BUDGET
PROPOSALS UNDER CONSIDERATION
FOR AND IS CONTAINED IN THE MAY
REVISED. THE PROPOSAL NUMBER
ONE IS INCREASE PREPAREDNESS
AND RESPONSE CAPABILITY. I'M MS
IS REQUESTING EIGHT POINT FIVE
MILLION GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO AND FOURTEEN
PERMANENT POSITIONS REDUCING
THE ONE POINT SIX MILLION
ONGOING BEGINNING IN TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY FIVE. THE RESOURCES
WILL MAINTAIN CRITICAL
EQUIPMENT MEDICAL SUPPLIES
SCHOOL CHOIR DURING THE CALL
THE NINETEEN PANDEMIC. AND
PROVIDE LIFESAVING
RESUSCITATIVE AND MEDICAL SIR
SERVICES TO RELIEVE SUFFERING
FOR DISASTER VICTIMS DURING
PANDEMICS OR OTHER CATASTROPHIC
EMERGENCIES. SEVEN OF THE
REQUESTED POSITIONS THREE POINT
ONE MILLION DOLLARS FOR
WAREHOUSE SPACE TWO MILLION FOR
BIO MEDICAL EQUIPMENT
MAINTENANCE ARE BEING FUNDED ON
A THREE YEAR LIMITED TERM
BASIS. HE'S LIMITED TERM
RESOURCES WILL PROVIDE ENDLESS
SUFFICIENT TIME TO DETERMINE IF
POST PANDEMIC STAFFING
RESOURCES. ARE SUFFICIENT TO
MEET INCREASED DISASTER MEDICAL
PREPAREDNESS RESPONSE AND
RECOVERY OPERATIONS.
ADDITIONALLY FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND IN ONE TIME FUNDING IS
ALSO BEING REQUESTED TO UPGRADE
AND IS DEPARTMENTAL OPERATIONS
CENTER INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
EMERGENCY RESPONSE CASH IS
AVAILABLE WHICH CONTAIN MEDICAL
SUPPLIES AND EQUIPMENT- THE
SPEED OF BROWN'S ABILITY TO
PROVIDE EMERGENCY MEDICAL CARE
TO DISASTER VICTIMS IS CRITICAL
IN ANY DISASTER OR MAJOR EVENT.
WALLIAMS A CONTINUES TO STAND
READY FOR THREATS TO CALIFORNIA
RECENT PANDEMIC IN WILDLIFE
RESPONSE ACTIVITIES HAVE
REVEALED CRITICAL GAPS IN MS A
RESPONSE CAPABILITIES. MS IS
REQUESTING FUNDING AND
RESOURCES TO FILL THOSE GAPS
OVER THE PAST SEVERAL YEARS THE
TREND DEMONSTRATES INCREASING
NATURAL AND MAN MADE DISASTERS
NINETY TRANSIT TO
SIMULTANEOUSLY PREPARE FOR
RESPOND AND SUPPORT MULTIPLE
RESPONSE OPERATIONS. FOR
EXAMPLE AT ONE POINT DURING THE
CURRENT CODES IN NINETEEN
STATEWIDE WILDFIRE RESPONSES
ANGELES SUPPORTING SEVENTEEN
DIFFERENT MISSIONS STATEWIDE
SIMULTANEOUSLY. THESE MEDICAL
MISSIONS INCLUDED FEDERAL
MEDICAL STATIONS ALTERNATE CARE
SITES LONG TERM CARE FACILITIES
INCLUDING SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES ASSISTED LIVING
MEMORY CARE IT'S CETERA SHOULD
DO SHOULD HAVE THE CONTINUED
OPERATION SUPPORTING MULTIPLE
WAREHOUSES. AND DEPARTMENTAL
OPERATIONS CENTER LOCAL EOC
LIAISON ROLES MEDICAL HEALTH
COORDINATION CENTER ROLES AND
THE STATE OPERATIONS CENTER. I
AM SO SIGNIFICANTLY
UNDERSTAFFED AND UNDER RESOURCE
TO MEET THE NEEDS AND RELIED ON
OUTSIDE SUPPORT TO SUSTAIN
OPERATIONS RESULTING IN.
NUMEROUS SHORTFALLS AND
CHALLENGES. THESE WERE OUTLINED
FOR POLL WILL THE SIGNAL
DEFICIT STATEWIDE HEALTH
RESPONSE CAPABILITY. IBM'S A TO
AFFECTED WE MANAGE THESE
INCREASED RESPONSIBILITIES AND
SUPPORT THE NECESSARY
ACTIVITIES TO PREPARE FOR AND
RESPOND TO FUTURE STATEWIDE
DISASTROUS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OF MISS PATRICK. I HATE MADAM
CHAIR CINEMATIC WITH THE
EARLIER WE DO NOT HAVE CONCERNS
WITH- TO RAISE WITH THIS
PROPOSAL AND IN FACT- IT JUST
TO SAVE A BIT OF TIME WORK
WE'RE NOT RAISING CONCERNS WITH
ANY OF THEM SO THAT PROPOSALS
SO. THANK YOU VERY MUCH YEAH I
THINK I THINK WE'VE ALL SEEN
THEM. WE WILL BECOME MUCH MORE
FAMILIAR WITH THEM SAID DURING
THIS PANDEMIC- SO GAP WE AT WE
UNDERSTAND IT'S A IT IS CORE
FUNCTION IN A IN A MUCH DEEPER
WAIT NOW OPINION ANYTHING ON
THIS ONE. OKAY MOVING ON THEN
TO ISSUE NUMBER TWO MEDICAL
SURGE STAFFING PROGRAM. SOREN
MUTED MYSELF. MS IS REQUESTING
A PROPOSAL NUMBER TWO MEDICAL
SURGE STAFFING PROGRAM.
EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICES
AUTHORITY IS REQUESTING SIX
PERMANENT POSITIONS. ONE POINT
FOUR MILLION IN GENERAL FUND
AND ONE POINT THREE FIVE THREE
MILLION ONGOING. THE REQUESTED
RESOURCES WILL PROVIDE
INCREASED STAFFING OVERSIGHT OF
THE MEDICAL STATUS STAFFING
SURGE PROGRAM. CONSISTING OF
THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH CARE
PROGRAM CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSISTANCE TEAM PROGRAM AND THE
DISASTER HEALTHCARE VOLUNTEERS
MEDICAL RESERVE CORPS PROGRAM.
THE FOCUS OF THESE ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES WILL BE ON STATEWIDE
RECRUITMENT EFFORTS. ONBOARDING
PROGRAM MANAGEMENT EXERCISE AND
TRAINING AND DEPLOYMENT
MANAGEMENT OF THESE MEDICAL
SEARCH RESOURCES BOTH PRIOR TO.
AND DURING EMERGENCY RESPONSE
ACTIVATIONS. AGAIN THE TOP
WORRY ANY DISASTERS A STATEWIDE
TO MITIGATE SUFFERING WHICH
REQUIRES MEDICAL CARE RESOURCES
IMMEDIATELY. HAPPENED ON INTO
OF PERSONNEL TO PROVIDE
EMERGENCY MEDICAL CARE DURING A
DISASTER IS CRITICAL. THE
RECENT COVERT NINETEEN PANDEMIC
RESPONSE ACTIVITIES AS IDENTIFY
NEEDS AND CURRENT PREPAREDNESS
AND RESPONSE CAPABILITIES
INCLUDING THE FOLLOWING. WACKA
PERMANENT PERSONALITY RECTALLY
AFFECTING AND HIS ABILITY TO
IMPLEMENT AND MANAGE MEDICAL
STAFFING SURGE RESOURCES IN
ABILITY TO EFFECTIVELY MANAGE
THE INCREASE OF ALL IN TEARS
UNDER THE CALMAC MRC IN CHINA
GHG PROGRAMS. INTEGR
INTEGRATION AND ENGAGEMENT OF
THE HEALTH CORPS MEMBERS AND
ADEQUATE RESOURCES TO COMPLETE
THE VETTING AND PROCESSING OF
THE INCREASED CALDERON
APPLICATIONS IN A TIMELY
MANNER. AND ADEQUATE RESOURCES
TO EFFECTIVELY MANAGE THE
DEPLOYMENT OF THOUSANDS OF
COMMENTS STAFF STATEWIDE. THE
LACK OF COORDINATION AND
TRACKING OF OTHER EMERGENCY
MEDICAL PARTNERS PERSONNEL
INCLUDING CONTRACTED MEDICAL
STAFF DISASTER MEDICAL
ASSISTANCE TEAMS NATIONAL GUARD
STAFF FOR CALIFORNIA
CONSERVATION CORPS STAFF. WITH
THESE ADDITIONAL RESOURCES MS
ALL WILL ALSO BE ABLE TO
IMPROVE DISASTER MEDICAL
PREPAREDNESS AND IMPLEMENT
MANAGE RECRUIT THAT TRAIN ON
BOARD. INCREASE PREPAREDNESS
ACTIVITIES AND MANAGE THE
DEPLOYMENT OF THESE RESOURCES
WHEN NEEDED. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- I DON'T HAVE ANY ISSUES
WITH THIS RICHARD. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OKAY LET'S MOVE ON TO
ISSUE NUMBER THREE HUMAN
RESOURCES AND RESOURCES
WORKLOADS PORT MS IS REQUESTING
EIGHT HUNDRED FIFTY ONE
THOUSAND GENERAL FUND AND FIVE
PERMANENT POSITIONS IN TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO. REDUCING THE
FIVE HUNDRED THIRTY THOUSAND
GENERAL FUND ONGOING BEGINNING
IN TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE I
REQUEST RESOURCES WILL ADDRESS
MISSION CRITICAL WORKLOADS
SOCIALLY WITH INCREASED HUMAN
RESOURCE WORKLOAD EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS PERSONNEL
SERVICES. INTO A STATISTICIAN
RESOURCE DIVISION WITH THAT
WITH AN ANZAC. PROVIDING HR
SUPPORT FUNCTIONS IN THE STATE
DEPARTMENT IS A HUGE
UNDERTAKING AN EXTREMELY
CHALLENGING. VOLUMES AS A SMALL
DEPARTMENT FUTURE UNIT IS STILL
TASKED WITH PROVIDING THE SAME
STATE PROCESS PROGRAMS AND
LEGAL REQUIREMENTS AS ANY OTHER
STATE AGENCY. HR ANALYST IN
OTHER DEPARTMENTS MAY ONLY BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR CLASSIFICATION
PAY EXAMINATIONS ARE TRAINING
BUT MS A SOLE HR. LIAISON IS
EXPECTED TO PROVIDE LIAISON
SERVICES FOR ALL OF THESE TASKS
IN ADDITION TO PROVIDING
SUPPORT AND SUBJECT MATTER
EXPERTISE IN MANY OTHER PROGRAM
AREAS. PERSONAL NEEDS OF THE
DEPARTMENT HAVE INCREASED
PROGRAM EXPANSIONS WHICH
INCLUDE NEW POSITIONS INCREASED
RESPONSIBILITY BUT IT DESTROYS
OUR STAFFING RESOURCES HAVE NOT
BEEN PROVIDED. THE STORE CLEAN
ADMINISTRATIVE AND HUMAN
RESOURCES WITHIN A SINGLE
DIVISION ALL THIS COMBINED
RESPONSIBILITY MIGHT BE
MANAGEABLE FOR AN
ORGANIZATIONAL MORE STABLE AND
PREDICTABLE WORKLOADS MS IS
UNIQUE IN THAT DEPARTMENT
MANAGES PROGRAMS ENCOMPASSING
ROUTINE ACTIVITIES WITH ANOTHER
DISASTER MEDICAL SERVICES. IS
DISASTER RESPONSE ACTIVITIES
MAY AT ANY TIME EXPAND RAPIDLY
WHICH CAN REQUIREMENTS ARE
HIGHER LARGE NUMBERS OF
EMERGENCY STAFF THIS CAN RESULT
IN OTHER DIVISIONS PROGRAMS
REDUCING OR SUSPENDING
ACTIVITIES AND RE DIRECTING
BOTH FRONT LINE AND MANAGEMENT
STAFF TO HR FUNCTIONS.
CONCURRENTLY WITH THESE
DRAMATIC SHIFTS IN MS FOCUSES
THE NEED TO RECRUIT ONBOARD AND
MANAGE ADDITIONAL PERSONNEL IN
PREPARATION FOR FUTURE
EMERGENCY RESPONSE DEPLOYMENTS.
THE NUMBER OF THESE EMERGENCY
HIRES IS UNPREDICTABLE BUT THE
TREND IN RECENT YEARS HAVE SEEN
A SHARP INCREASE IN DURING THE
PANDEMIC RESPONSE. THE NUMBERS
OF BALLOONED EXPONENTIALLY. I
THIS. THEM OF MY TO WEAR SIMPLY
FORGO SOME HR FUNCTIONS. THIS
INCREASED AFTER REQUEST WILL
ALLOW THE DEPARTMENT TO MEET
MISSION CRITICAL HR ACTIVITIES
AND TIMELINES. STRUCTURALLY
MANDATED MANDATED REQUIREMENTS
ENSURE COMPLIANCE WITH BARBUDA
GRIEVANCE AND THE CREATION OF
OPERATIONAL EFFICIENCIES WITHIN
THE HR DIVISION. ADDITIONAL
POSITIONS WILL ALSO ALLOW THE
HR DIVISION TO INCREASE
CUSTOMER SERVICE LEVELS ARE
VERY CENTRAL PROGRAMS WITHIN MS
I BELIEVE MANY DELAYS IN
RESPONSE TIME TO EXECUTIVE
STAFF MANAGERS. ANOTHER CONTROL
AGENCY REQUESTS AND
REQUIREMENTS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NOTED RICHARD ADVENTURE
OKAY- ISSUE NUMBER FOUR-
STATEWIDE EMERGENCY MEDICAL
SERVICES DATA SOLUTION. MS IS
REQUESTING ONE TIME TEN MILLION
DOLLAR GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO AND TWO
POSITIONS THIS REQUEST WILL GO
TOWARD PROJECT PLANNING FOR THE
CALIFORNIA EMERGENCY MEDICAL
SERVICES DATA RESOURCE SYSTEM
OR CEDARS UTILIZING THE STATE'S
PROJECT APPROVAL LIFECYCLE AND
TO CONNECT THE ADDITIONAL INTO
CONNECTED DECISIONAL LOCAL
EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICES
AGENCIES TO AN EXISTING
NETWORK. OPPOSE CEDARS IS
INTENDED TO CREATE A LINK TO
VARIOUS SYSTEMS TO INCREASE
DATA INTEROPERABLE IT BETWEEN
HOSPITALS US AGENCIES AND OTHER
HEALTHCARE ORGANIZATIONS
ENSURING CONTINUITY OF CARE TO
CURRENTLY UNDER COVER AREAS OF
THE STATE. THE PROMISE OF USING
REAL TIME INFORMATION TO
IMPROVE PATIENT OUTCOMES TARGET
SYSTEM ENHANCEMENTS AND POWER
STATE OVERSIGHT ACTIVITIES
REMAINS A CRITICAL GOAL FOR
CALIFORNIA. HOWEVER
CALIFORNIA'S EMS DATA SYSTEM
LAGS BEHIND IS HEALTH CARE
PARTNERS THE ESSENTIAL
ACTIVITIES RELATED TO
STANDARDIZE DATA COLLECTION
EXCHANGE REPORTING AND
ANALYTICS. AND ANALYTICAL
CAPABILITIES. IS CRITICAL THAT
MEANINGFUL USE RESULTS OF DATA
ANALYTICS ARE SUPPLIED OF LOCAL
EMS AGENCY AND EMS PROVIDERS
THE USE OF DASHBOARDS AND OTHER
BUSINESS INTELLIGENCE TOOLS
THROUGH STATEWIDE DATA
ANALYTICS SUITE WOULD TURN DATA
INTO INFORMATION AND
INFORMATION AND ACTION.
ALLOWING LOCAL EMS AGENCIES TO
BENCHMARK THEIR ACTIVITIES
AGAINST OTHER CALIFORNIA
AGENCIES. TODAY HIM IN COUNTERS
ARE CAPTURED. BUT THAT DATA
REMAINS LARGELY USABLE ONLY AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL IS LIMITED
CONNECTIVITY OF THAT
INFORMATION ITH OTHER PATIENT
HEALTH INFORMATION VIA HEALTH
INFORMATION EXCHANGE AND THE
STATE HAS NO ACCESS TO REAL
TIME EMS DATA. THE TWO CURRENT
SYSTEMS ARE WILL SERVE AS THE
FOUNDATION FOR OVERCOMING THESE
GAPS ARE KIM SAYS WHICH IS THE
CALIFORNIA EMERGENCY MEDICAL
SERVICES INFORMATION SYSTEM AND
HIGH TENS WHICH IS THE HEALTH
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY YOU HAVE
A SYSTEM. BY LEAKING THE
SYSTEMS IT WILL PROVIDE A
CENTRALIZED ACCESS. TO
INFORMATION VITAL TO PATIENT
CARE. ONE YEAR PLANNING AND
DEVELOPMENT FUNDING OF TWO
POINT FOUR MILLION DOLLARS
BEING REQUESTED FOR THE DESIGN
OF A ROBUST AND SUSTAINABLE
STATEWIDE DATA HELP LINKING KIM
SYSTEM HIGH TENS. TO TRANSFORM
MS CAPABILITY TO GATHER MANAGE
ANALYZE AND REPORT CRITICAL EMS
DATA. TO ACHIEVE THOSE ENDS
REQUIRES A SUPPORT OF BOTH IN
HOUSE STAFF AND CONSULTANTS
SPECIALIZE IN ENTERPRISE
ARCHITECTURE ORGANIZATIONAL
CHANGE MANAGEMENT. SYSTEMS
PLANNING AND ARE SUBJECT MATTER
EXPERTS IN HEALTH CARE AND
UMASS DATA. MS IS ALSO
REQUESTING SEVEN POINT SIX
MILLION TO ON BOARD ADDITIONAL
LENDS US TO THE EXISTING HIGH
TEN SYSTEM. VIA EXISTING STATE
YOU CAN SEE OUR SYSTEM SOFTWARE
AND CONNECT ALL H. I. USE IN A
CHILD'S TO EMS DATA. CURRENTLY
ONLY SIXTEEN OF THIRTY THREE
LENSES ARE COVERED BY H. I.
EASE AND PLUS YOU KNOW SYSTEMS.
THIS LEAVES SEVENTEEN WHIMS OF
OUR POPULATIONS BEHIND WITH
REGARD TO QUICK ACCESS TO
PATIENT INFORMATION DURING
EMERGENCIES AND DISASTERS. MANY
OF THE- COVERED LENSES ARE ROLL
ROLL OR HAVE LARGE UNDERSERVED
POPULATIONS. IN THE SIX TO
CLOSE THIS GAP IN HEALTH
INFORMATION EXCHANGE BY
CREATING CONNECTIONS IN THESE
AREAS WHICH WILL INCREASE THE
INTEROPERABLE YOU BETWEEN
HOSPITALS EMS AGENCIES. ANOTHER
HEALTH CARE ORGANIZATIONS
ENSURING CONTINUITY OF CARE.
BETWEEN AND COVER AREAS OF THE
STATE- MS OUR PLANS WORK TO
NINE GRANT TO KIND ON BOARD
INTEROPERABLE HEALTH
INFORMATION EXCHANGE BETWEEN
YOU MUST PROVIDERS AND YOU MUST
RECEIVING HOSPITALS VIA. HEALTH
INFORMATION EXCHANGE
ORGANIZATIONS AS A WILL BE
PRIORITIZING THESE GRANTS TO
NINE COUNTIES THAT HAVE NOT
ALREADY IMPLEMENTED PLUS YUP
MASS OR HIGH TENS. HAVE AN
ESTABLISHED H. I. ON THEIR
COUNTY OR TO MULTI COUNTY
LENSES THAT HAVE NOT CONNECTED
HIGH TIMES OR HAVE ADDITIONAL
COUNTIES IN THE REGION TO
CONNECT. IS IT ESTIMATES THESE
PRIORITY COUNTIES AND LENDS US
WILL ADD FORTY SEVEN ADDITIONAL
CONNECTIONS WITH TWENTY FIVE OF
THESE YOU MUST PROVIDERS AND
TWENTY TWO CONNECTIONS TO
HOSPITALS. AIDING THESE
CONNECTIONS IN THESE AREAS IN
THESE RURAL COUNTIES WILL ALSO
ALLOW ACCESS TO ONGOING FEDERAL
FUNDING TO MAINTAIN CONNECTIONS.
PERHAPS MOST IMPORTANTLY THIS
FUNDING WITHOUT LAST ALLOWED MS
IT SHOULD MERGING ACCELERATE
THE IMPACT OF THIS TO MOST
IMPORTANT DATA INITIATIVES
CONSISTENT HIGH TENS THESE
RESOURCES WILL PERMANENTE TO AT
LAST SYNCHRONIZES FINISH
DOESN'T PERMIT CALIFORNIA TO
SUMA NATIONWIDE EMS LEADERSHIP
POSITION. BY ALLOWING EMS
PROVIDER AGENCIES AND LANDS AS
THE AND THE STATE THE ABILITY
TO EVALUATE THE CONTINUUM OF
BMS PATIENT CARE FROM THE TIME
OF THE NINE ONE ONE CALL TO THE
MOMENT PATIENTLY SO HOSPITAL
HAVING A MEDIAN RELIABLE ACCESS
TO PATIENT HOSPITAL OUTCOME
DATA. FOR THESE PATIENTS
TRANSPORTED BY EMS PROVIDERS
ALLOW EMS PROVIDER AGENCIES
WHIMS AS AN ANSWER TO FULLY
UNDERSTAND THE IMPACT OF THE
ARREST CARE PROVIDED IDENTIFY
BEST PRACTICES AND ENSURE
OPTIMAL PREHOSPITAL. CARE FOR
ALL CALIFORNIANS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- DR GRANT IT'S A
QUESTION. AN INMATE AND DECIDE
CLARIFY INTENT SO- V. C. TALK
ABOUT THE SEVEN POINT SIX TO
GET THE NINE GRANTS SO HOW MUCH
OF A GAP IS LEFT IF YOU'RE SO
SUCCESSFUL SO HE'S AT THE HIGH
PRIORITY BUT I'D JUST TRYING TO
BETTER UNDERSTAND. SO HOW MANY
LENSES ARE WHAT POPULATIONS
WOULD STILL NOT BE IN IF YOU
ARE SUCCESSFUL IN DOING THESE
NINE GRANTS AND BRING THOSE
ONES ON BOARD OF WHAT'S THAT
HOW PUBLIC IS THE GAP. SIX OF
THE SEVENTEEN NEVER BROUGHT ON
BOARD WE HAVE SEVENTEEN
OUTSTANDING LENDS US. OKAY SO
BASICALLY THE NINE I ASSUME
WOULD BE TO CLOSE THE GAP FROM.
SEVENTEEN TO. EIGHTEEN TEAMS TO
EIGHT CORRECT KAY AND THEN. ANY
THOUGHTS ON THE EIGHT EARLY
JUST MORE W. MORE CHALLENGING
ARE OBVIOUS THIS IS A JUNIOR AT
THE HIGH PRIORITY ONES. WE'VE
TARGETED THE MORE RURAL
POPULATIONS AT THIS TIME TO
EXTEND THE SYSTEM OUT TO
INCREASE. THEIR ABILITY TO
COLLECT AND PROVIDE YOU
MISSTATED TO CALIFORNIA OKAY SO
MAYBE JUST A CLEAR SO OF THE
EIGHT AND AGAIN YOU MAKE YOU
HAVEN'T EXACTLY DECIDED WHICH
ARE THE NINE YET I PRESUME- BUT-
WHAT'S THE POPULATION SIZE OF
THE ROOM. REMAINDER THAT STILL
NOT COVERED ADDED SO I KNOW
YOU'RE PRIORITIZING RULE
COMMITTEES THAT MAKE SENSE- ARE
THERE SOME URBAN COUNTIES THAT
ARE LEFT IN THAT EIGHT OR IS IT
MAINLY GROW ALL ROLLS ON THANK
YOU WHAT THE SIZE OF THE
POPULATION. YOU KNOW IF YOU'RE
TELLING ME L. A. COUNTY IS ONE
OF THE EIGHT AND I GUESS THE
REASON WE HAVE A REALLY LARGE
POPULATION PROBABLY ISN'T BUT-
JUST GETTING SENSE OF THE SIZE
OF THE MAGNITUDE OF THE GAP.
YOU KNOW I DON'T HAVE THAT
INFORMATION FROM ME BUT I CAN
FOLLOW UP WITH YOU AND PROVIDE
IT. OKAY SO I DID THAT AND THAT
WOULD BE HELPFUL JUST TO GET AN
UNDERSTANDING OF SEO HOW
COMPLETE THE SYSTEM IS. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU. BURKE THANK
YOU. OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
LET'S MOVE ON NOW TO THE FINAL
ISSUE ISSUE NUMBER FIVE.
STATEWIDE RESPONSE
EXPENDITURES. OKAY SO IN THIS
POPOSAL IS FOR. ONGOING
CULTURE RESPONSE FUNDING FOR
THE TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
FISCAL YEAR. MS REQUESTING
SIXTEEN POINT NINE MILLION ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND FOR ESTIMATED
DIRECT RESPONSE EXPENDITURES.
FOR CONTINUED MEDICAL STAFFING
AMBULANCE TRANSPORTATION
SERVICES AND OTHER RELATED
SUPPORT COST. TO CONTINUE
RESPONDING TO AND MITIGATING
THE IMPACTS OF COVERT NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. FAILURE TO PROVIDE
THE REQUESTED FUNDING WILL
SEVERELY LIMIT MS RESPONSE
ACTIVITIES ADVERSELY AFFECT OUR
ABILITY TO PROVIDE CRITICAL
MEDICAL CARE AND SUPPORT
CALIFORNIA'S CITIZENS WHO'VE
BEEN AFFECTED BY THE COVERT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. GIVEN THE
UNCERTAINTY SURROUNDING
PROGRAMMATIC AND FISCAL NEEDS
AT THIS TIME MS REQUESTING
THESE ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
UTILIZING THE FOLLOWING
ASSUMPTIONS. ONGOING
VACCINATION EFFORTS ACROSS THE
STATE FOR ALL AGE GROUPS
NECESSITATING THE DEPLOYMENT OF
AMBULANCES AND MEDICAL STAFFING
SUPPORT BOTH LOCALLY AND
STATEWIDE. CREASED VACCINATION
EFFORTS UILIZING PARAMEDICS
AND EMERGENCY MEDICAL
TECHNICIANS TO ENSURE THE HOME
BOUND CALIFORNIA CITIZENS ARE
VACCINATED. MEDICAL SURJECTIVE
HE'S ACROSS THE STATE WILL
DECLINE IN SUMMER FALL AND
SLIGHTLY INCREASED AGAIN IN THE
WINTER MONTHS ASSASSINATING THE
DEPLOYMENT OF ADDITIONAL
MEDICAL RESOURCES STATEWIDE.
DISASTER RESPONSE EMERGENCY
OPERATIONS ACCOUNT OR DRAFT
FUNDING WILL NO LONGER BE
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER. COVERT
NINETEEN VARIANTS WILL INCREASE
RESPONSE ACTIVITIES STATEWIDE.
AND DICK VIEWS BUT THESE
PROJECTIONS ARE ESSENTIALLY
BASED ON 30% OF OUR- RESPONSE
LEVELS DURING THE TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE FISCAL YEAR. THE
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES WILL ALSO
WILL ALLOW HIM TO CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE BOTH NEW. AND
CONTINUING CRITICAL RESPONSE
ACTIVITIES ENSURE THAT
RESOURCES ARE AVAILABLE SUPPORT
STAFFING LOGISTICAL NEEDS OF
BOTH MEDICAL AND VACCINATION
SITES THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I HIGH
AND CERTAINLY KNOW ABOUT. THE
IMPORTANCE OF THIS NOW THINGS
LIKE VENTILATORS AMBULANCE DOES
TRANSPORT. HEALTH CARE
PERSONNEL AND ESPECIALLY RIGHT
NOW I KNOW WE'RE TRYING TO
REALLY GET OUR VACCINES OUT
THERE IN MOBERLY GOING OUT AS
WELL TESTING AS WELL AS
PROVIDING. THAT AND WE
APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT YOU'VE
DONE ANYTHING SPECTRUM- THANK
YOU IN FACT IT'S JUST A
QUESTION INSTANCE SOMEONE ALSO
TIES TO ISSUE THREE HUMAN
RESOURCE BUT WHAT WHAT THIS M.
SISSY IS THE FUTURE OF THE
HEALTH COURSE SO I HEAR THIS
ROLE FOR HELPING OUT
VACCINATIONS. OF DISCRETE SIR
CREATED THAT IS FUNDS THE COVE
IT IS THE SOMETHING THAT
MINISTRATION IS WANTS TO
CONTINUE BEYOND THE SOME SORT
OF A RAPID NO I KNOW RAPID
RESPONSES RIGHT WORD BUT SOME
SORT OF EXTENDED RESPONSE OR IS
IT SOMETHING THAT AFTER WE GET
THROUGH BECAUSE OF IT AND WE
GET HOPEFULLY A LOT MORE PEOPLE
VACCINATED AND NEVIN'S GOT TAKE
A LITTLE TIME TO HAVE THAT
HAPPEN BUT THEN WE WOULD SHUT
DOWN SO. WHAT'S WHAT'S THE M.
S.'S VIEW I MEAN YOU'VE YOUR
ASK YOU DID ASK FOR YOU KNOW
HUMAN RESOURCES WORKLOADS
SUPPORT CENTER SO WHAT WHAT
WHAT DO YOU SEE THE. HEALTH COR
GOING INTO THE FUTURE. THE
CARD. IS A GREAT QUESTION
DOCTOR PAN. HEALTHCOR IS HAS
DEMONSTRATED ITSELF IS AN
INVALUABLE PIECE OF THE
RESPONSE PUZZLE AND- IS TO
MAINTAIN A HIGH LEVEL
PERSPECTIVE WHERE IT FITS
PASSED HIS FEELING SPECIFIC
SHIPS SO WHAT WE FOUND IS OUR
CALUMET TEAMS WE CAN DEPLOY A
WHOLE TEAM FOR A- CHUNK OF TIME
A WEEK TWO WEEKS TWO MONTHS.
THE HAVE A GREAT DEPLOYABLE
RESEARCH RESOURCE TO FILL A
NEED IN AN ALTERNATE CARE
FACILITY BUT NOT SO MUCH IN
HOSPITALS AND SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES AND EVEN
CORRECTIONAL. INSTITUTIONS IN
THOSE FACILITIES THEY'RE ALL
GEARED AROUND THE SHIFT WORK
AND WHAT HEALTHCARE GAVE US THE
ABILITY TO DO WHAT IS RAPIDLY
BRING UP BRING ON AND DEPLOY.
PEOPLE TO FILL SHIFTS
SPECIFICALLY WITHOUT YOU KNOW
AT WHERE WE DIDN'T HAVE A WAY
TO DO THAT PREVIOUSLY WE
COULDN'T TAKE A TEAM AND SEND
THEM TO THE HOSPITAL HOSPITAL
WHERE STAFF AND SAY YOU KNOW
TRYING TO FILL THE SHELVES. SO
IT'S ENDED UP BEING A REALLY.
CHEAP HEAD AGAIN- YOU KNOW-
WORLD HOLES TO HELP FILL SOME
OF THESE GAPS SO- WITH CALLUM
OUT TO HELP COR- SOLUTION HAS
HAS REALLY ENDED UP BEING
INVALUABLE. BUT IT DIDN'T END
UP BEING AS LARGEST SOLUTION AS
WE FORESAW BUT- IT'S REALLY
BECOME WELL INTEGRATED-
THOUSANDS OF SHIPS BEING FILLED
BY HEALTHCOR HUNDREDS OF FOLKS
BEING ON BOARD I DON'T KNOW
THOSE NUMBERS IN FRONT OF ME
BUT- IF YOU'D LIKE THOSE- I
THINK- CRAIG JOHNSON WHO MAY BE
ON THE CALL CAN ANSWER THOSE.
OR WE. CAN GET THOSE FOR YOU
BUT SOME. AS I GET YOUR CLOSE
TO A ANSWER WELL I GUESS I'M
REALLY A LITTLE TO THE FUTURE
AS WELL CERTAINLY WE LEARN
CERTAIN LESSONS. I WELL I WAS
TRYING TO GET AT AND APPRECIATE
YOUR ANSWER IS THAT. IT GIVEN
WHAT WE'VE LEARNED ABOUT HEALTH
CORNER IS PROBABLY PLAN TO
CONTINUE IT INTO THE FUTURE
BEYOND SENSE THE CODE TO
RESPONSE. AND IF WE ARE TO BE
GOOD TO HAVE A BETTER
ARTICULATION. OF THIS- THE ROLE
HEALTH CORE WOULD BE PLAYING
AND HOW WE PLAN TO BUILD IT OUT
AND THEN WHAT KIND OF ON GOING
YOU KNOW. FUNDING OR
INVESTMENTS WE NEED TO MAINTAIN
IT BECAUSE EVEN THOUGH MANY ARE
VOLUNTEERS RIGHT YOU HOUSE HR
ISSUES. OTHER TYPES OF THINGS
MAINTAINED A LIST OF PEOPLE
ETCETERA. SO THE SO IS THIS
GOING TO BE AN IDEAL IS THIS
GOING TO BE AN ONGOING
INVESTMENT. AS A PART OF A
RESPONSE IT HERE IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AND- THE PERHAPS
MORE SPECIFIC OR DETAILED LAN
OF HOW WE'RE GOING TO GO ABOUT
DOING IT IN THE NATURE OF THAT
ONGOING INVESTMENT. I THINK
WOULD BE HELPFUL GIVEN THE
LESSONS WE'VE LEARNED CELLS-
EVERY SEE WHAT HE SAID SO ON.
THE END AND I'M SURE THERE'S
GONNA BE SOME VERY INTERESTING
THINGS AND WHAT YOU COULD.
SHARE WITH ME ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED DURING TELL THAT BUT
I'M ALSO SAYING WELL WHAT ABOUT
GOING FORWARD SO. IS THIS A
LIKE A- COUPLE YEARS AGO FUNDUS
AND WESHUT IT DOWN BUT SOUNDS
LIKE THAT'S NOT THE ANSWER SO I
HOPE THAT TO AND PERHAPS IN THE
COMING YEAR- WE HAVE A BETTER.
AT A DESCRIPTION OF WHAT THE
FUTURE OF HEALTH CORE IS
ESPECIALLY SINCE IN FUTURE
BUDGETS WILL. BE PERHAPS MAKING
DECISIONS ABOUT NOT HELD BY
SUPPORT FOR. START.
DISORGANIZATION THEY ARE SLOWLY
DOING WILL GET YOU A- PER. NOW
AND IN THE- THANK YOU. AND I
THINK WELL WHEN THE THINGS THAT
DOCTOR PANTS ASKING OR OR MY
QUESTION IS. OF THE BANG FOR
THE BUCK MEAN FOR GONNA PUT A
BUNCH OF MONEY INTO THE
INFRASTRUCTURE ARE WE GOING TO
BE USING THEM- AN OFF TO BE
ABLE TO. TO MAKE IT WORTH OUR
WHILE IN IN SOME KIND OF ON
GOING. WAY AND I WILL JUST. I
WILL JUST KNOW MAYBE WITH A
SOUR GRAPES THAT I KNOW I AND-
AS AN LCSW AND DOCTOR WOULD.
BOTH APPLY TO BE A PART OF- THE
HEALTH CARE AND WE WERE
REJECTED- THEY SAID THAT WE HAD
A CONFLICT FOR SOME REASON BUT
ANYWAY JUST TO SAY. GOING
FORWARD YOU HAVE VALUED AT
PEOPLE WILLING TO VOLUNTEER
THEIR TIME. RIGHT IN FRONT OF
YOU SOMETIMES OKAY. EXCLUSIONS
IN. ADAM CHERUBS. AND- WHAT WE
DO IF I CAN ADD ONE MORE QUICK
CANCER- WE DO HAVE THE- BENEFIT
OF ECONOMIES OF SCALE IN THAT
THE SAME INFRASTRUCTURE IS
GOING TO BE UTILIZED FOR
CALMATTERS WILL BE USED FOR
HELP OR SOME MOVING FORWARD IT
WILL BE AN INVALUABLE TOOL THAT
WON'T COST US A LOT OF MONEY SO
I THINK THE BANG FOR THE BUCK
WILL BE WILL BE QUITE HIGH.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OKAY MOVING ON THE DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH CARE SERVICES. MISTER
LIBRARY OF GOING TO BE WITH US
FOR THIS AFTERNOON. YES I AM
SURE. OKAY YOU MIGHT SEE MISS
COOPER THERE IS WELL- ALL RIGHT
SO- NECK ISSUE NUMBER ONE IS A
MEDIC CAL LOCALIST INSTANCE
ESTIMATE FOR YOU WANT TO DO A
LITTLE OVERVIEW. BEFORE WE JUST
NEED TO THE- BUT I WOULD LIKE
TO QUICKLY SO OF DOOR HI. OF
THE- ALMOST NOT TOO BURDENSOME.
L. A. L. AND THEN YOU KNOW I'LL
HAVE TO. RESPOND TO SPECIFIC
AREAS OF CONCERN. OR OR
INTEREST- RT WHICH ORDER BE ALL
OVERALL STRUCTURE OF THE BUDGET
ON THE MAYOR REVISION PROPOSALS
ARE TALKING ABOUT A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY NINE POINT TWO BILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE SUPPORT GHC HAS
PROGRAMS AND SERVICES ALL ONE
POINT TWO BILLION ALL THAT
FUNDS ARE STATE OPERATIONS
OFTEN THIS INCLUDES ADDITIONAL
PROPOSED EXPENDITURE PARTY OF
FIFTY NINE POINT FIVE MILLION
ONES FOURTEEN MILLION WILL
GENERAL FUND. AND THAT SUPPORTS
UNDERGONE THREE POSITIONS
SEVENTY EIGHT WHICH PERMANENTLY-WILL ON THE QUIBBLING DROPPED.
TWENTY FIVE LIMITED CHARLES.
ALL THEN. THE REMAINING UNDER
AND TWENTY EIGHT SUPPORTS LOCAL
SYSTEM ALL THE DHS COSTS ON
TWENTY BILL OF THAT FUNDS THE
MEDICAL PROGRAM AND FOR BILLION
YES AND THE OTHER PROGRAM IN
THE NEW. HOUSE SMALL. HELLO ALL
THE ASSUMPTION IS ABOUT THE
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY WILL
CONTINUE TO THE END OF DECEMBER
AND THEREFORE THE COMBINATION
CALLED CONTINUOUS MODEL JUST
NOW OUR PRACTICE PLUS NEW
ENROLLMENTS IS ESTIMATED TO
INCREASE THE TOTAL PROGRAMS
UMBILICAL PROGRAM TO AN AVERAGE
OF APPROXIMATELY FOURTEEN POINT
FIVE MILLION. ALL PEOPLE AND
BUDGET YOUR- AFTER THIS BASED
THE CURRENT BATTLE. ALL WE WILL
BEGIN RE. DOWN SUBSTANDARD ALL
PART OF THAT HELP NURTURE CITY
AND ARE COUNTY WELFARE
DEPARTMENT SMALL THEREFORE HAVE
TO BE CATCHING UP ON MORE THAN
THREE MILLION DIFFERENT CASES
IN ADDITION TO THEIR REGULAR
CYCLE BEEN TAKEN ALREADY
TERMINATION. AND SO AFTER
CONSULTATION WITH. THE ACT OF A
BUDGET AT SEVENTY THREE
MILLION. ALL FORTY INCREASED
WORK- THE FAMILY HEALTH LOCAL
SYSTEM OF SYSTEMS ESTIMATES
FORECASTS THE CURRENT BUDGET
YOUR EXPENDITURES FOR THREE OF
THE ALL STATE ONLY PROGRAMS ALL
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN'S SERVICES
GENETICALLY HANDICAPPED PERSONS
PROGRAM AND EVERY WOMAN COUNTS.
ALL THESE PROGRAMS ASSIST
FAMILIES AND INDIVIDUALS ALL
BURKE SPECIAL HEALTH NEEDS WHO
DO NOT QUALIFY FOR ALL AND THE
MEDICAL PROGRAM AND WE'RE
ESTIMATING ALL SPENDING IN THE
CURRENT YEAR SHOULD BE ALL
THREE HUNDRED TWELVE MILLION
AND IN BUDGET YOU'RE ALL. TWO
HUNDRED AND SIXTY SIX MILLION.
ALL THAT DOESN'T INCLUDE FONG
SPENT COUNTY PART. ALMOST
PROGRAM. WILL BE. CREASE DOES
REALLY UP ALL CASELOAD TRAIN
MOST WERE YOU BECAUSE PEOPLE
ALONG MOVE INTO MEDICAL CALL.
SO THEY AREN'T LEAVING RECURSOS
BUT THERE MOVING THE. FEDERALLY
BETTER PROGRAM. ALL REPORT
COVERAGE DURING ON LIKE TO HIGH-
QUICKLY ALL IN JULY WE'RE GOING
BEGIN X. IT'LL CAL HERE'S
PORTENT FOR ADULTS AGE NINETEEN
TO SIXTY FOUR THIS IS WHAT WE
NOW REFER TO. SO COVER WILL BE
AT THE OUTLOOK POINT WILD
MUSCLE HELP ME GROW MARC. AND
WE BUDGETED DAHLE FOURTEEN
POINT THREE MILLION TOM FARMS
OUT OF WHAT YOU'RE DONALD BOND
ALL. TO SUPPORT THAT. SECOND
YES THE X. COAST OF COVERAGE
FROM SIX DAYS TWELVE. ALLIANCE
WITH YOUNG RED PLAN OPTION TO
THE STRAINS AND IS VERY IS
SINCE IT. LONG REQUIRE MENTAL
HEALTH DIAGNOSIS TO OFFER FULL
ACCESS TO PHYSICAL BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH SERVICES TO ALL YOUR
AFTER THE MOTHERS GIVE BIRTH.
ALL MALE CARRILLO BE PROVIDING
RISK. TO ALL MEDICARE BOOKS
BIRD OF REGRESSIONS BATTLES ALL
THIS WILL BE A FACTOR ALL
PEOPLE WALK. TWENTY TWENTY TWO
HELLO OF BASKETBALL- AND THE
BUDGETING SMALL NINETY POINT
MILLION FOR THE ADDITIONAL
BENEFIT TOP ABOUT AGAIN BEING
ON. DON'T WANT. TURNING
EXPANSION YEAH THE ADDITIONAL
CALLS DO A SEARCH ARE COVERED
BALLOT ALONE. POSTED AT DOLE
SERVED SAMPLES OF PREVENTIVE
BENEFITS TO INCLUDE PERSONAL.
HER PREGNANT THE GRADUAL
MCANALLY IS WELL PREGNANT LABOR
THE POST. ALL PUBLIC SERVICE
AVAILABLE TO ALL OF OUR DORM
BEING GRACED BY WOMEN THE OPERA
AMERICAN TO. AND WE BELIEVE
THIS HAVE BOB MEAN FOR. ON THE
AREA THIS BOOK. MATERNAL MORE
RATE AMONG BLACK WOMEN ALL THE
BENEFIT WILL IMPLEMENT ON JAN.
FOR TWENTY TWO AND THE BUDGET
INCLUDES FOUR AND TO CALL. OUR
TO PONDERED. THE OTHER MAJOR
EXT OF GOAL IS THE- ALL. RIGHT
CARD. ON DOCKING SO. SIXTY HOME.
ON RIGHT APPROXIMATELY SEVEN
EIGHT THOUSAND PEOPLE COMING
EITHER RESTRICT SCOPE MEDICARE
MORE FROM CURRENTLY. COVER
STATUS M. TROUBLES ARE COVERED.
OR TARGET IS RAIN WATER TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. BUT I DO HAVE TO
COPY A THIS IS GOING TO. ON
SUCCESS WATER SYSTEM RIGHT. ALL
AFTER WHERE THE STATE WIDE
WALKERS SPECIAL IN THE PROCESS
OF MIGRATING FROM THREE TO ONE
AND BUSINESS. CALIBRATING
PROGRAM CHANGES WENT OUT OVER.
WINDOWS ALL. THIS IS HOWEVER
VERY HIGH PRICE FOR AND ALL
WE'RE WORKING VERY CALL WITH
THE SOLE SUCH. ALL CREDIT
ENABLE ALL HEARING ABOUT ALL
TRYING FOR. ALL NORMALLY WE
ACTUALLY. WRITING GUIDELINES
FOR LONG CHANGES LIKE BURST
UNTIL AFTER FINAL BUDGET
ADOPTION. IN THIS CASE WE
CONSIDERABLE SUCH A PARTY AFTER
ALL WE ARE EVEN AS WE SPEAK
ALL. WRITING A PROGRAM
GUIDELINES SO THAT THE
AUTOMATION SYSTEM POKER ALL CAN
GET ON EIGHT THIRTY OFF QUICK
START ON THIS ARM BUDGET YOUR
WERE ESTIMATING- SIXTY EIGHT
MILLION DOLLAR TOTAL ON. ALL
AFTER ALL STARTING COST SAVINGS.
THOSE WHO ARE CURRENTLY LIMITED
SCOPE MEDI CAL- OUR. COVERAGE
THE SAME VERY ROSS. OF EXTRA
HELP COVERAGE THE MOST POPULOUS.
ALL HELLO WITH BOND COVERAGE OF
ALL. AGED SIX THE BILL'S LIKE
WHERE COLD. THE ALL TOO MUCH
GOAL OF NOT MORE COUPLE. ALL
YEAH BOB AREAS WHERE. AGREED
ALL ON FOR ENHANCED BUT SCIENCE
AND THE BOSTON ALL RETURNING
FROM OUT OF STATE PLATES. ALL
AND THE FIVE THING AM GOING. TO
AS MENTIONED IS ABOUT DAHLE BAR
BUT PROPOSAL ON THE OTHER
LEMONADE DENTAL MANAGED CARE
CONTRACTING LOS ANGELES. ACTIVE
ASSEMBLY FIRST ALL AND GOING
FORWARD WE ALL UP OF THE FOR
SERVICE IN. ALL ALONG. ONE CASE
OF THE- UNIFORM PROVIDE BENNETT
YOU KNOW EACH OTHER STATES
BASED. AND WE PROJECTS STATE
ARE TWENTY MILLION. IN THE
BUDGET MISTER. AND WE'RE. PASS
ALONG TO WON'T FROM COOPER.
THANK YOU I PARK COOPER. ALL SO
I'LL GO ISSUES BY THROUGH THEIR
AND AGENDA I'M IN PROVIDE COVER
OF THE DEPART PROPEL- FOR
STARTING WITH THAT YOU YOU
BEHAVIOR HEALTH A PROPOSAL I
KNOW THIS HAS BEEN PRESENTED-
IN FRONT OF NUMBER TWO SO I
WILL BE SPECIFIC TO ON THE
IMPACT OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES WILL BE
IMPLEMENTING. IN ADDITION TO
THE SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
FOR THE BEHAVIOR HEALTH
CONTINUUM INFRASTRUCTURE- IN
THE FOUR HUNDRED MILLION FOR
INCREASED ACCESS TO USED TO BE
YOUR HEALTH SERVICES IN THE
GOVERNOR'S JANUARY BUDGET ON
THE NAY REVISION IS A PROPOSING
AN ADDITIONAL TWO HUNDRED
TWENTY EIGHT MILLION LOCAL
ASSISTANCE AND TWENTY TWO
MILLION STATE OPERATIONS FOR
SEVENTY EIGHT POSITIONS I'M TO
IMPLEMENT THE CHILDREN USED
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH A PROPOSAL IN
THOSE DOLLARS ARE FOR TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO. I KNOW WE'VE
PROVIDED A MULTI YEAR ON A
BUDGET AND TO EVERYONE SO THEY
CAN UNDERSTAND HOW THOSE
DOLLARS ARE FLOWING OVER THAT
THE FIVE YEARS. OF THE
PROPOSED. BUDGET YES WE BE REST.
FOR THE B. HEALTH VIRTUAL PLUS
INCLUDING THE- BEHAVE HEALTH
SERVICES. IN CBO NETWORK AND HE
CONSOLES OF FUNCTIONS OF THE
PROPOSAL. AS WELL AS THE
CAPACITY IN INFRASTRUCTURE
GRANTS FOR THE BEHAVIOR HEALTH
SERVICES IN SCHOOLS. THE GRANTS
TO SUPPORT DEVELOPMENT AND
EXPANDING AGE APPROPRIATE
EVIDENCE BASED BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH PROGRAMS. THE ADDITIONS
TO THE BEHAVIOR HEALTH
CONTINUUM INFRASTRUCTURE.
PROVIDER TRAINING DYADIC
SERVICES WITH A MEDIC CAL AND
THE CONTINUATION OF CAL HELP
SUPPORT. STUDENT SUPPORT
SERVICES- ONCE THE FEDERAL
FUNDING EXPIRES GOING TO A
LITTLE BIT MORE INFORMATION ON
EACH OF THOSE A MAIN COMPONENTS
THAT THE DEPARTMENT HEALTHCARE
SERVICES WOULD BE BEATING.
SUPPORTERS STATEWIDE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH SERVICES AND SUPPORTS
VIRTUAL PLATFORM THE DEPARTMENT
BUT- YOU'RE A BUSINESS SERVICE
VENDOR TO IMPLEMENT ALL PAYER
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH- DIRECT
SERVICE AND SUPPORTS VIRTUAL
PLATFORM TO BE INTEGRATED WITH
SCREEN. I'M ASKING AFTER DAYS
SUPPORTS AND DIRECT BEHAVIOR
HEALTH SERVICES FOR CHILDREN
YOUTH UNDER. I'M TWENTY FIVE
AND YOUNGER. IT WOULD INCLUDE
THOSE TO SERVICE AS I'M
PREVIOUSLY AS WELL AS- MANY
FUNCTIONS INCLUDING ACCESS TO A
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH COUNSELING
COACHES AND PEER SUPPORT
SERVICES. IF THE CONSUMERS
NEEDS ARE NOT MET WITH THOSE
SERVICES THE CARE STEPS- TO
CONNECT THEM WITH THEIR ON
MANAGED CARE PLAN EITHER
COMMERCIAL PLAN OR MEDICAID
MANAGED CARE PLAN WOULD BE
TAKEN ON THE IDEAS THAT IT IS A
ONE OF A KIND OF ENTRY INTO
ACCESS IS AT A TIERED LEVEL. TO
MAKE SURE THAT BENEFICIARIES
NEEDS ARE BEING MET- HOWEVER
WOULD MAKE THOSE CONNECTIONS IF
ADDITIONAL SERVICES WERE BEING
NEEDED. THE BUSINESS PLATFORM
WOULD ALSO FACILITATE A STATE
WIDE YOU CONSOLE SYSTEM TO
ALLOW PRIMARY CARE PEDIATRIC IN
FAMILY PRACTICE PROVIDERS. TO
RECEIVE A SYNCHRONOUS SUPPORT
AND CONSULTATION TO MANAGE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CONDITIONS.
FOR THEIR PATIENTS AND THEIR
PRACTICES. IN ADDITION OF FOR
THE CAPACITY BUILDING WITH- THE
BEHAVIOR HEALTH IN SCHOOLS. IT
WOULD ALLOW US YOU ARE PROPOSED.
TRANSPORT INFRASTRUCTURE
PARTNERSHIPS CAPACITY BUILDING
TO INCREASE ACCESS TO THE ON
GOING BEHAVIORAL HEALTH-
SERVICES. ARE ON OR NEAR SCHOOL
CAMPUSES BY STANDING ACCESS TO
BEHAVIORAL SCHOOL COUNSELORS
YOUR SUPPORT IN BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH COACHES BUILDING A
STATEWIDE COMMUNITY BASED
NETWORK COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATION NETWORK AS WELL
THAT INDIVIDUALS ARE ABLE TO
ACCESS NOT JUST THE COUNSELORS
ON CAMPUS BUT ALSO TAPPING INTO
A- BROAD COMMUNITY BASED
NETWORK ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO ENSURE THAT WE
ARE CONNECTING THEM WITH. LOCAL
WELLNESS CENTERS IN
OPPORTUNITIES AS WELL.
ADDITIONALLY THE GRANTS TO YOU
WILL BE PUT IN PLACE FOR THE
DEVELOPMENT EXPANSION OF AGE
APPROPRIATE EVIDENCE BASED
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PROGRAMS FOR
CHILDREN AND YOUTH. THE MAY
REVISION DOES PROPOSED THAT THE
DEVELOPMENT SCALE UP AND SPREAD
OF THOSE INTERVENTIONS WE WOULD
BE WORKING WITH A BEHAVIOR
HEALTH THINK TANK THAT WOULD
HELP US IDENTIFY WHICH ARE THE
INTERVENTIONS THAT WE WOULD
WANT TO BE SCALING UP. IN
ANTICIPATION FOR THE GO LIVE OF
THE VIRTUAL PLATFORMS AS WELL
AS TO ENSURE THAT ALL OF THE
PROVIDERS YOU MAY BE ELIGIBLE
TO RECEIVE THOSE. GRANTS ARE
PROVIDED FOR PROVIDING
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE FOR THEM
INDIVIDUALS WHO WOULD BE
ELIGIBLE TO RECEIVE THESE TYPES
OF GRAMS WOULD INCLUDE
MEDICARE'S BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SYSTEMS TRIBAL ENTITIES HEALTH
CARE SERVICE PLANS MEDICARE
MANAGED CARE PLANS COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS. AND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PROVIDERS IN
ORDER TO SUPPORT THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
IDENTIFIED EVIDENCE BASED
PRACTICES. GRANTS FOR THE
MEDICARE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SYSTEM WOULD BE ADMINISTERED
THROUGH THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
QUALITY IMPROVEMENT. PROGRAM
ARE WHAT'S. KNOWN AS B. H. Q.
I. P. I GRANTS AND SENT INTO
WOULD BE A MATTER BY THE- OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES. IN
CONSULTATION WITH THE THIRD
PARTY ADMINISTRATOR.
ADDITIONALLY WE WOULD BE
PROVIDING PROVIDER TRAINING FOR
PEDIATRIC PRIMARY CARE AND
OTHER PROVIDERS IN REGARDS TO
THE FULL PLATFORM TO ENSURE
THAT WE ARE REACHING ACROSS THE
VARIOUS POINTS OF THE DELIVERY
SYSTEM NOT JUST SCHOOLS BUT
PRIMARY CARE PEDIATRIC OFFICES
TO ENSURE THAT THEY UNDERSTAND
HOW TO INFORM. OTHER PATIENTS
OF THE SERVICES THAT WOULD BE
AVAILABLE FOR THROUGH THE
VIRTUAL PLATFORMS AS WELL AS
MAKING SURE THEY UNDERSTAND THE
KEY ON THE U. CONSULTATIONS ON
HOW TO LINK ALL OF THE VARIOUS
OPPORTUNITIES WITH IN THE
CHILDREN YOUTH PROPOSAL. OKAY
AND I'M GONNA AND STOP EITHER I
THINK WOOD MISTER LEBRON. WAS
DOING AN OVERVIEW WE DIDN'T
KNOW HE WAS GONNA. GOOGLE GO
QUICKLY TO THE TO THE ISSUE SO
I'M GONNA. I'M GONNA ASK THE L.
A. OPEN APARTMENT FINANCE IF
YOU HAVE ANY ISSUES ON ISSUE
NUMBER FOUR. THAT WE JUST ISSUE
NUMBER FIVE THAT WE JUST WENT
OVER AND THEN WE'LL WORK OUR
WAY BACKWARDS HELLO. MISTER
SHEILA WHO'S SPEAKING HERE
COULD I SAY THERE YOU GO MR
SHOULD. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR I'M. THE FELLOWSHIP.
SYSTEM JUST TO BE COMMENTS MAKE
YOU KNOW WE WOULD FIRST NOTE
THAT THE- TRAILER BILL FOR THIS
INITIATIVE REMAINS UNAVAILABLE
FOR REVIEW AND THAT'LL THAT'LL
BE NECESSARY TO PROPERLY ASSESS
THE MERITS OF THE INITIATIVE AS
A WHOLE- NEXT AS AN OVER
ARCHING COMMENT ON MULTIPLE-
THE MULTIPLE DH CS COMPONENTS
OF THE INITIATIVE. YOU KNOW WE
WOULD STOP WE WOULD NOTE THAT
SOME OF THESE ONE TIME
PROPOSALS WOULD LIKELY RESULT
IN ONGOING COSTS THAT ARE NOT
CURRENTLY SCORED- THIS THESE
WOULD INCLUDE FOR EXAMPLE THE
DIRECT INCENTIVE PAYMENTS FOR
SCHOOL BEHAVIORAL HEALTH. AND
THE GRANT FUNDING FOR EVIDENCE
BASED PRACTICES WHICH ARE
INTENDED TO INCREASE ACCESS TO
SERVICES. IN THE AMOUNT OF
SERVICES PROVIDED. I IN
ADDITION WE'RE NOT WHY THE NEW
MAY. PROPOSAL FOR- IN PAYMENTS
FOR SCHOOLS. WOULD ALSO INCLUDE
MANAGED CARE PLANS AS AN ENTITY
THAT COULD RECEIVE FUNDS WHEN
THERE IS A SIMPLE A RELATIVELY
SIMILAR PROPOSAL. INTRODUCED IN
JANUARY TO CREATE AN INCENTIVE
PROGRAM. FOR SCHOOL SERVICES
SPECIFIC TO MANAGED CARE- NEXT
WE JUST KNOW THAT FOR MOST OF
THESE PROPOSALS. BENEFITS TO
CHILDREN USE WOULD NOT BE
REALIZED IMMEDIATELY AND WOULD
RATHER BE REALIZED- SOME YEARS
INTO THE FUTURE. AND THE
LEGISLATURE MAY WISH TO
CONSIDER HOW IT WANTS TO
PRIORITIZE A MORE IMMEDIATE
INTERVENTIONS FOR CHILDREN AND
USE IT THAT IS ITS WISH- NEXT
FOR THE VIRTUAL PLATFORM WE
WOULD JUST NOTE THAT THIS
PROPOSAL. TO BE VERY
SIGNIFICANT LEFT AND IF IT WERE
TO MOVE FORWARD THE
LEGISLATURE- ME WHICH TO SORT
OF VERY CLOSELY TO MONITOR ITS
IMPLEMENTATION ESPECIALLY WHAT
CHALLENGES MAY ARISE- WITH
SECURING THE BUSINESS VENDOR TO
IMPLEMENT THE PLATFORM- WE ALSO
HAVE A NUMBER OF QUESTIONS
ABOUT THE VIRTUAL PLATFORMS
SUCH AS- YOU KNOW HOW THE
ADMINISTRATION WILL ENSURE
ACCESS TO THE SERVICES PROVIDED
THROUGH THE PLATFORM- GIVEN
DISPARITIES IN BROADBAND
ACCESS- WHAT THE REIMBURSEMENT
RATES WILL END UP BEING BOTH
FIRST SORT OF COMMERCIAL AND
MEDICARE PLANS- FOR SERVICE
PRINCE SERVICES PROVIDED
THROUGH THE PLATFORM. AND JUST
SORT OF GENERALLY WHAT RULES
AROUND PARENTAL CONSENT WILL
EXIST. WHEN I CHILDREN ACCESS
SERVICES TO THE PLATFORM- THOSE
ARE THOSE ARE ALL OF OUR SORT
OF OVER ARCHING COMMENTS ON THE
INITIATIVE AT THIS TIME AND WE
ARE SO HAPPY TO PROVIDE FURTHER
ASSISTANCE WHERE. NEEDED THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. DEPARTMENT.
FINANCE ANYTHING ON ISSUE
NUMBER FIVE. AS AN OFFICE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NOTHING
FOR. TO ADD AT THIS TIME BUT
WE'RE TO ANSWER NUMBER. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND
ON THIS WHAT I WOULD SAY AND I
KNOW WE'VE BEEN THIS. PROPOSAL
IF YOU WILL BUT- AND I THINK
WE'LL HAVE A LOT OF QUESTIONS
AND I THINK THAT THIS IS STILL
A WORK IN PROGRESS AND- I WAS
GOING TO SAY. ALSO THAT I HAVE
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE SCHOOL
COMPONENT IN THE- INSIDE OF
COMPONENT WHEN THEY'RE WE HAVE
A PROPOSALS VERY SIMILAR TO
THAT. AND HOW ALL OF THESE
THINGS ARE GONNA WORK THROUGH
IT. I THINK WE'RE ALL INTRIGUED
WITH THE IDEA OF A OF A BIG-
PLATFORM- AS THE BACKBONE OF A
OF A OF A SYSTEM- BUT THEN YOU
ALSO HAVE TO THINK IT'LL IS IT
LIKE THE HIGH SPEED RAIL RIGHT
DO WE JUST WILL DO WE BUILD
THAT TRACK FIRST OR DO WE BUILD
ALL THE ARTERIES THAT WOULD
LEAD INTO IT FIRST BECAUSE-
PEOPLE CALL INTO SOMETHING
THERE HAS TO BE SOMETHING THAT.
ON THE GROUND FOR THEM THEM TO
BE REFERRED TO. AND THEN I
THINK WHAT WE'VE ALL OF
KNOWLEDGE WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
RESOURCES IN PLACE RIGHT NOW.
R. FOR BEHAVIORAL HEALTH- SO I
THINK YOU KNOW I GET THAT THIS
IS NOT FULLY ALTHOUGH FOR US
OUT. CAN WE GET THE FULL. WILL
BE ABLE TO EVALUATE IT BETTER
BUT I THINK THERE ARE SOME
CONCERNS ABOUT SOME
REDUNDANCIES- AND AGAIN THE
ISSUE OF WE HAVE A CRISIS ON
OUR HANDS RIGHT. AND WITH SOME
URGENCY THAT WILL NEED TO
RESPOND TO AS WELL. TECH DEPEND.
IT YOU AND AGAIN YOU KNOW WE'VE
WE- HEARD FOR. SOME OF THE-
OTHER A- AS WELL- AND- IT'S-
THAT. THERE'S ALWAYS A- I AM.
D. N. D. PROPOSED. BECAUSE WE
KNOW THAT- VERTICALLY TO. KOBE
WE- C. DOUSED BY. RATES MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUE- RELATED TO. WHAT
HAPPENED AND SO- APPRECIATE
THIS. INVEST AND THE CENTER TO
TODAY ISSUE- I THINK IT'S
CHAIRS NOTE WE MAY PREVIOUS
HEARING THERE AUDIO THERE'S A
MORE THERE'S ALSO THIS PHOTO
IMMEDIATE NEED AND I THERE'S A
LONGER. GILT FRAME AND THEN THE
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES- GOING TO
GO RIGHT AWAY EITHER- I GUESS
ONE I DO HAVE A IS ACTUALLY I
THINK AFFRONT IT UP IN THE LAW
YEAR AND TALKED ON BUT BASS
ACTUALLY. C. S. QUESTION A ONE
ONE THE COMPOSED. OF THIS. IS I
THINK. IS TO ACT BETTER DO
PRIMARY CARE PROVIDERS TRYING
TO CARE FOR. EVEN FOR AND TRAIN
VIA THE HAND MORE MY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH- THAT FROM THE NET.
PERSPECTIVE ARE FROM D. MET
CALPERS. I'LL TELL YOU I'M AND
SO SHIP TRAIN- BUSY OUT THE-
YOU DON'T TEACHERS GOT. SO
SHOULD TRAIN. BE GIVEN THE-
SIDE- TENDED TO SEE. CHILDREN
WHO HAD- HI RATES OF HEALTH.
HOWEVER AS A GENERAL. AND
SOMEONE WHO CARE OF A LOT CAL-
THE ISSUE WASN'T AT THAT.
TRADING ALTHOUGH I'M SAYING
HELLO TO THIS IS WE COULD TRY.
THE PEOPLE. XIN SAID MORE
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES- BECAUSE
ON THE PAYMENT SIDE. YEAH WE
FIRST OF ALL VIA CHALLENGES
WITH MENTAL HEALTH CODES
BECAUSE I WASN'T A QUOTE MENTAL
HEALTH PROVIDE ALL THE GENERAL
PEDIATRICIAN EVEN THOUGH IT WAS
THE- GOT EXTRA TRAINING- IN
ADDITION. THESE PATIENTS TAKE
MORE TIME- YOU KNOW YOU DON'T%
DEAL YOU KNOW IT'S NOT LIKE I
COULD SET UP FOR TEST FOR
MENTAL HEALTH I MEAN YOU
ACTUALLY SIT DOWN AND TALK TO.
THE PATIENT AND THE FAMILIES
AND SO FORTH. ARE WE GOING TO
THINK ABOUT THE REIMBURSEMENT
STRUCTURE. OUR OUR OUR- AND
ALSO IN INDIA WE'RE GOING TO
PLAN RICK PROCUREMENT AND ALL
THIS OTHER STUFF SO TO BE SURE
THAT. THE WAY THE PLANS PAY THE
PRIMARY CARE DOCTORS WHO
ACTUALLY SPENDING THE TIME
DOING THE YOU KNOW MODERATE.
MENTAL HEALTH THAT DAY
ACTUALLY- COURAGE TO DO THAT
AND SO. TO THAT FOR. A EVEN
THOUGH THE SKILLS. MY PAYMENT
SYSTEM IS IN A WAY THAT. MEANS
THAT I'M GONNA REFERRAL THESE
PEOPLE INSTEAD OF TRYING TO
TAKE CARE OF THE ONES I CAN
TAKE CARE OF MYSELF BECAUSE
BASICALLY THE PAYMENT STRUCTURE
DOESN'T REWARD. SPENDING THAT
KIND OF TIME. SOZOMEN SOME
THOUGHT INDEED CS ABOUT. THAT
ASPECT AGAIN EXTEND OUR WORK
FORCE EXTEND OUR CAPACITY. TO
TAKE CARE OF. CHILDREN WHO HAVE
MILD TO MODERATE ALBEIT FOR
HEALTH ISSUES. I THINK THERE'S
KIND OF TWO MAIN COMPONENTS
WITHIN THE PROPOSAL THAT WOULD
STOP POTENTIALLY SPEAK TO. SOME
OF THE POINTS THAT YOU'RE
RAISING THE FIRST ONE IS. OF
THE ADDITIONAL MEDIC CAL DYADIC
SERVICES BENEFITS THAT IS THE
ADDITION OF CODES THAT WOULD
ALLOW FOR MORE ABOUT INTEGRATED
SERVICE TO BE HAPPENING WITHIN
THE PRIMARY CARE. FOR PEDIATRIC
OFFICE WHERE ADDITIONAL CODES-
AND RATES TIED TO THEM WOULD BE
A BILLABLE FOR REIMBURSEMENT
FOR THOSE TYPES OF INTEGRATED
SERVICES WHERE YOU'RE DOING.
THE MULTI SAYS MEN ARE HEADING
OFF TO A SOCIAL WORKER WITH AN
OFFICE IF THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT'S AVAILABLE I'M IN
ALLOWING FOR THOSE SERVICES TO
BE BUILT- WITHIN THAT THAT
PLATFORM WE'RE HOPING TO GET
SOME INFORMATION OUT REGARDING
THAT- DYADIC SERVICES. A NEW
BENEFIT CODES AND DESCRIPTIONS
OF THE PEOPLE OF AN
UNDERSTANDING WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT BUT IT'S QUITE
COMPREHENSIVE IN REGARDS TO
YOU- REALLY PUSHING THE NEEDLE.
INTEGRATED APPROACH AND
ALLOWING FOR THE REIMBURSEMENT.
OF THOSE SERVICES- SO I THINK
THAT WOULD BE THE ONE PIECE
THAT POINT OUT NOT SPECIFIC TO
MEDICARE MOST OF THE CHILDREN
AND YOUTH IS ALL PAYER AS YOUR
TO TWENTY FIVE HOWEVER THAT ONE
PORTION IS FOR MEDIC CAL. A
BENEFIT PIECES ON THE DYADIC
CARE SERVICES AND THEN THE
OTHER PIECE WAS- DEPARTMENT
SHOULD EARLIER IS FOR PRIMARY
CARE PROVIDERS I'M SURE WANTING
SOME A CONSULTATION THERE WOULD
BE AND YOU CONSOLE. I TIED TO
THE VIRTUAL PLATFORM WHERE THEY
WOULD BE ABLE TO MAYBE GET SOME
CONSULTATION WITH- A
PSYCHIATRIC EXPERT- TO BE ABLE
TO INFORM. OF AND BUILD THOSE
PIECES BUT AS YOU MENTIONED IT
WASN'T NECESSARILY SO MUCH ON
THE TRAINING SIDE BUT I JUST
DID WANT TO MENTION THAT. I
THINK THE BIGGEST PART THAT
WORK CONSIDERING THAT WOULD BE
A BILLABLE- ON BEHALF OF
PRIMARY CARE PROVIDERS WOULD BE
THOSE DYADIC CARE SERVICES. SO
I GUESS SIR FIRST OF ALL. I
APPRECIATE THAT WE'RE GOING TO
TRY TO PROVIDE MORE E. TONSILS
FROM MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS TO PRIMARY CARE
SITES SO WHEN THAT DOES BE PAID
FOR SO THAT'S GOOD I'M ALSO
TALKING ABOUT THE PRIMARY CARE
DOCTORS BECAUSE WE EVEN HAVE A
COMPONENT. I KNOW IT'S ON THE
HOT SPOT SIDE THE TRAIN PRIMARY
CARE DOCTORS TO DO MORE MENTAL
HEALTH ON THEIR OWN RIGHT.
GIVEN THAT KIND OF TRAINING- TO
BE ABLE TO THE BILL BACK TO PAY.
AND- BUT- THAT THAT WILL BE
THAT EFFORT ALSO IN CARE TO
BEING TO MANAGE MORE WHICH
WOULD AND DEPRESSURIZED THE
AMOUNT OF REFERRALS TO ARE
STILL. ARE SORT OF CONSTRAINED
MENTAL. HEALTH WORKFORCE AND
THAT WE HAVE- REIMBURSEMENTS
THAT RECOGNIZE THAT SO THAT'S
WILL SEPARATE FROM THE ATTIC- I
APPRECIATE THE DYADIC PART BUT-
BUT JUST RECOGNIZING THAT NEED
DAN THIS IS A PRIORITY THEY
COMMUNICATE A CONVERSATION WITH
THE MENTAL HEALTH PLAN. BUT
THE- WITH THE- MANAGED CARE
PLANS MEDICAL MANAGED CARE
PLANS ABOUT WHAT YOU KNOW WHAT
KIND OF PAYMENTS ARE GIVING TO
PRIMARY CARE DOCTORS WHO
ACTUALLY PROVIDING MORE
SIGNIFICANT MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES OBVIOUSLY SEVERE IS
GOING TO BE YOU KNOW WHEN I GET
BEHAVIOR HEALTH SPECIALIST BUT-
BUT TO BE ABLE TO ACTUALLY
ALLOW THEM TO- WHEN THEY GOT IN
THE TRAINING TO BE ABLE TO RAMP
UP. THEIR ABILITY TO TAKE CARE
FOR MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES AND
THEN ACTUALLY JUST TO FOLLOW UP
ON THE DYADIC SERVICES AGAIN
REALLY APPRECIATE THIS BECAUSE
MORE OF A FAMILY APPROACH BUT
YOU DID MENTION. PEDIATRICS
AGAIN THIS IS A THE PERHAPS
ALSO COMMUNICATION THE PLANS
BECAUSE WILL HAPPEN IS THAT I'M
A PEDIATRICIAN SO FAMILY
POSITION LESS OF AN ISSUE THAT
SOME TEACHERS AND THEY SAY WELL
WAIT A MINUTE YOU DON'T TAKE
CARE OF ADULTS SO NOW YOU'RE
DOING THE FAMILY THING WITH THE
PARENTS. SO THAT'S ME VERY
CLEAR COMMUNICATION THAT IF I
PROVIDE SERVICES TO THE DIET
ADD HER TO THE FAMILY THROUGH
THE ATTIC SERVICES THAT I THAT
I CAN IS A PEDIATRICIAN I DON'T
HAVE SOME ADMINISTRATOR IN A
PLAN GOING WELL NO NO WE CAN'T
PAY FOR THAT BECAUSE YOUR
FUTURE SHOULD YOU DON'T TAKE
CARE OF ADULTS AND NOW YOU'RE
ACTUALLY BUILDING THE FIRST
SERVICE. THAT'S RELATED TO AN
ADULT THE PARENT OR GUARDIAN
HOWEVER FOR THE DYAD AND SO
THAT HAS TO BE REALLY CLEAR
BECAUSE AND BY THE WAY YOU GOT
TO DO SOME EDUCATION AND THAT
TOO BECAUSE THAT'S GOING TO BE
THE AUTOMATIC RESPONSE I CAN
SEE HAPPENING. AND THAT
HAPPENS. YOU KNOW. FEW TIMES
BEACH. ARE GO TO BE FOR US. IN
SAY WELL YOU KNOW I HAVE TO
SITE EVERY TIME ITO DO THIS TO
GET PAID. SO YOU SPEAK TO THAT.
YEAH I MEAN THAT THAT IS THE
INTENTION BEHIND THE NEW
BENEFIT SERVICES AND WE WILL
MAKE IT VERY CLEAR BOTH THE
PARTS THAT MEDICARE PROVIDER
MANUAL AS WELL AS ANY
INSTRUCTION TO THAT MANAGED
CARE PLANS. I APPRECIATED
BECAUSE OF SOMEONE'S RIGHT
PROVIDING TOBACCO COUNSELING
AND OTHER TYPES OF THINGS TO
PARENTS- YOU KNOW- DID DID DID
IT IS FRUSTRATING BECAUSE YOU
KNOW THAT TAKING CARE OF THE
CHILD ALSO INCLUDES THEIR HOME
ENVIRONMENT INCLUDES- HELPING
US SUPPORTING TO PARENTS BUT-
YOU KNOW USUALLY IT'S LIKE WE
JUST DO THAT WE DO THAT FOR
FREE BECAUSE WE DEBTS RIGHT
THING TO DO BUT WE KNOW THAT WE
WILL GET PAID FOR IT AND- AND
WE'RE GONNA DO EVEN MORE WHICH
I THINK IS GOING TO BE GOOD.
IT'S GOING TO BE VERY IMPORTANT
THAT'S COMMUNICATED TO ALL THE
INTERMEDIARIES BETWEEN THE
DOCTORS TO FRAME THE SERVICE
AND USE A STATIC CAL DIRECTOR
TODAY ALSO UNDERSTAND WHAT
YOU'RE TELLING. ME RIGHT NOW.
SO I APPRECIATE THAT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY- IF WE CAN GO
BACK. TO ISSUE NUMBER FOUR-
DEPARTMENT FINANCED TO HAVE AN
IMPACT ON THE STATE DEPARTMENT
FINANCE YOU HAVE ANYTHING ON
ISSUES ONE THROUGH FOUR. SO
I'LL TAKE THAT AS A NO- L. A.
DO YOU HAVE ANY ISSUES ON ISSUE
NUMBER FOUR FULL SCOPE MEDI CAL
COVERAGE FOR UNDOCUMENTED
SENIOR SIXTEEN OVER. I
MEDICARE- YES SO WE EARLIER
THIS YEAR WE RELEASED ON A COST
ESTIMATE OF THE BALLOT FOR
EXPANDING FULL SCOPE COVERAGE
TO ESSENTIALLY ALL CURRENTLY
INELIGIBLE UNDOCUMENTED
IMMIGRANTS- THAT ARE THAT ARE
OTHERWISE ELIGIBLE FOR MEDICARE
ALL- BASED ON THIS THIS
ASSESSMENT. THE
ADMINISTRATION'S COST ESTIMATE
FOR THE SIXTY AN OLD SIXTY AN
OLDER POPULATION APPEARS HIGHER
THAN WE WOULD HAVE ANTICIPATED
WE'RE WORKING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND THE ASSUMPTIONS
BEHIND ITS COST ESTIMATE- AND
ONCE WE GET SOME GREATER
DETAIL. WE WILL- SHARE IF-
SHARE ANY CONCERNS THAT WE HAVE
ABOUT THE REASONABLENESS OF THE
COST ESTIMATE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I THINK WE- I
THINK WE ALL SHARE THE GOAL OF
TRYING TO COVER AS MANY PEOPLE
AS WE CAN AFFORD TO DO. A
DOCTOR PAN ANYTHING ON THIS
ISSUE. I'LL JUST SAY IS THAT-
NEIL THE SENATE HAS FOR SEVERAL
YEARS ACTUALLY PUT FORTH IN OUR
VERSION THE BUDGET BUT- AND THE
FINAL. FOR ONLY SIXTY FIVE AND
OLDER I'M GLAD SEAT
ADMINISTRATION'S DOING SIXTY I
THINK WE RECOGNIZE ULTIMATELY.
ESPECIALLY WITH- EXPERIENCE
CODED BUT EVEN BEFORE-
HOPEFULLY WE CAN EVENTUALLY GET
TO THE POINT WHERE WE CAN
ACTUALLY COVER EVERYONE- AND-
BUT DEPRECIATE THE STEP THANK
YOU. OKAY MISTER JOHNSON HOW
ABOUT ISSUE NUMBER THREE
MATERNAL HEALTH INVESTMENT.
POST PARTUM AND DO A LOT OF
BENEFITS- NO CONCERN ON EITHER
ITEMS TWO OR THREE JUST HAVE
COMMENTS ON THE ISSUE ONE
THERE. OKAY AND I'M A I'M I'M
VERY HAPPY TO SEE BOTH OF THESE
THINGS ARE BOTH IN OUR AREA OF
INTEREST FOR ME HAVE DONE
LEGISLATION ON A- ISSUE. NUMBER
THE FIRST ONE ON THIS ONE- WITH
THE COVERAGE EXTENSION AFTER
POST PARTUM I THINK THIS IS
JUST A GOOD GOOD GOOD COMMON
SENSE AND GOOD PUBLIC POLICY.
WHICH ON- JUST MAKE THE
OBSERVATION TALK ABOUT DIETS
LITTLE EARLIER THAT OF COURSE I
SEE THE CHILD AND THEN I SEE
THE MOMS WITH THE CHILD. AND
THEN THE MOM DOESN'T HAVE THE
COVERAGE BECAUSE IT'S NOW
PASSED BY THE SIX WEEKS OR
SOMETHING SO- DIRT SIXTY DAYS
SO- I REALLY DO APPRECIATE
THIS. THE PERSON WHO ABSOLUTE
THAT ACTUALLY IS STILL SEEING
THE MOM AND ROOM EVEN THOUGH
I'M NOT THERE. TO CARE TAKER A
ON THE THEIR THEIR POSITION BUT
THEN HAVING TO STRUGGLE WITH
THE FACT THAT THE MOTHER
DOESN'T HAVE THE COVERAGE
SOMETHING. THE CHILD AND
RECOGNIZING THAT SHE MIGHT NEED
HELP. OKAY AS ISSUE YOU SAID
YOU DID NOT HAVE ISSUES WITH
ISSUE NUMBER TWO. MR JOHNSON
HELLO. YEP NO CONCERNS OR
COMMENTS ON ISSUES TWO OR THREE
THERE SO OKAY- DOCUMENT. IF YOU
TO THE QUESTION ON HOW TO THE A
FAMILY HEALTH ESTIMATES- SO FOR
EXAMPLE FOR CCS PERHAPS THAT'S
WITH G. H. P. P. BUT- I KNOW
THAT FOR EXAMPLE GOOD PORTION
OF CCS IS NEONATAL SELVES ON
KIND OF PREMATURE BABY THEY'RE
GOING TO BE AND- BUT I WAS
WONDERING WHAT THEIR DINNER. WE
SAW DURING CO BID- YOU KNOW
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT KIDS WITH
CHRONIC DISEASES SIGNIFICAN
DISEASES WHETHER THERE WAS SO
WE TALKING A CASELOAD HERE BUT
WHETHER DOES A DROP OFF IN
THEIR USE OF SERVICES DURING
COVE IT. AND THEN ALSO WITH
THEIR DAUGHER MIGHT HAVE BEEN
A DROP OFF IN PEOPLE COMING IN
WHICH MIGHT TAKE UP BECAUSE
WEDNESDAY COMING IN FOR REGULAR
CHECK UP SO THERE'S LESS LIKELY
DIRT AGAIN SCREEN FOR SONY
IDENTIFIED. AND THEN THEY MIGHT
BE IDENTIFIED LATER SO THE NON
NICK YOU KIDS BUT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT KIDS WHO MIGHT- BE TAKE
YEAH THIS PEOPLE GOING BACK TO
THEIR DOCTORS OFFICES AND BRING
THEIR CHILDREN AND THAT. WE
MIGHT SEE A LITTLE BIT OF AN
UPTICK IN PEOPLE WHO NOW
IDENTIFIED AS NEEDING CCS AS
WELL AS WHETHER FOR THE
EXISTING CCS POPULATION WAS A
DROP IN USE OF SERVICES.
BECAUSE OF COVERED. AND I KNOW
WE'RE DOING TELL. BUT IDEA KNOW
WHETHER WAS WE SAW THAT OR NOT.
YES THIS IS JC EVEN WITH TELL
WE SIGNAL. BURKE IN YOUR- OF
BOTH INPATIENT EMERGENCY ROOM
AND OUTPATIENT INCLUDING
PRIMARY CARE VISITS THIS FALL
SPECIALTY CARE VISIT SO. WELL I
DO KNOW A NUMBER OF PROVIDERS
WERE ABLE TO CAN BURKE CHIU
THAT THE TELEHEALTH MODALITY.
WE ACTUALLY STILL HAD QUITE A
FEW WHO WERE DOING BOTH IN
PERSON AND TELEHEALTH BUT STILL
EVEN WITH THOSE MENTALITY
SIGNIFICANT REDUCTIONS OF.
UTILIZATION ACROSS ALL DELIVERY
SYSTEMS EVEN INCLUDING
PRESCRIPTIONS. DURING THE
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY WE
CONTINUE TO LOOK AT THE TRENDS
IN OUR DATA- FOR BOTH INPATIENT
EVERY SO FOR BOTH MANAGED CARE
AND FEE FOR SERVICE-
UTILIZATION IS STARTING TO
INCREASE AGAIN. AS AS
EVERYTHING HAS STARTED OPENING
UP AND WILL CONTINUE TO MONITOR
THOSE SERVICES BUT- DECREASES
ACROSS THE BOARD. YEAH I JUST
WONDER WHETHER GET UNTIL
CANNELLA CALL REBOUND THAT'S
FINE AT THE RATE WE DESCRIBE A
LITTLE YOU'LL SEE A LOT OF
BILLIONS IN UPTICK IN THIS
COMING YEAR AS HOPEFULLY WE
ARE. A PEOPLE MORE COMFORTABLE
WERE OPENING UP MORE. THAT IS
WHAT WE HOPE THAT PEOPLE WILL
START GOING INTO REGULAR CARE
GET IT IS. PART NUMBER ONE
MESSAGES A POLICE ARE ENGAGING
IN THE NORMAL CARE GO BACK AND
GET YOUR ANNUAL VISITS IF YOU
MISSED- YOUR ASSESSMENTS WE
ASSUME IT WILL- INCLUDED NUMBER
FOLLOW UPS IN IN IN YOUR
PARTICULAR COMMENTS- POTENTIAL.
REFERRALS FOR THE CCS PROGRAM.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OF
ISSUE NUMBER TWO. IS A JOHNSON.
THE CARD FOR FINISH NUMBER.
THAT WAS ABOUT ISSUE NINETY TWO
OKAY EACH IS YOUR NUMBER ONE.
THERE YOU GO. THANK YEAH THANK
YOU BEN BEN JOHNSON WITH THE L.
A. L. WE HAVE PERFORMED- OUR
INITIAL ASSESSMENT OF THE MAY
REVISION MEDIC CALLOUS TO MET
AND OVERALL DH CS ESTIMATE AND
DON'T HAVE ANY MAJOR CONCERNS
OVER AT THIS TIME I JUST FOCUS
AND- I JUST FOR SOME BRIEF
COMMENTS ON THE
ADMINISTRATION'S CASELOAD-
ESTIMATES FOR MEDIC CAL AND- TO
NOTE THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
HAS SIGNIFICANTLY RIVER REVISED
DOWNWARDS ITS ESTIMATE FOR
MEDIC CAL CASELOAD- ACROSS
212-021-2120 TWO- IT'S ALSO
CHANGED SOME ASSUMPTIONS ABOUT
THE AVERAGE COST OF THE NEW
ENROLLEES THAT WOULD JOIN THE
PROGRAM- BECAUSE OF COVERT
NINETEEN. ALTERNATELY IF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S OUT REVISED
CASELESS OPTIONS TO REDUCE
COSTS ACROSS 202-120-2120 TWO
BY A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
GENERAL FUND AND- WE ULTIMATELY
FINDS THAT THE REVISED AT
KEESLER PROJECTIONS DO ALIGN
CLOSELY WITH WHAT THE L. A. O.
EXPECTED AND THEREFORE DON'T
RECOMMEND ANY CASE THAT. JUST
WANTS AT THIS TIME THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ARE AT NOW IT'S MOVE
ON TO NUMBERS. MISS COOPER.
OKAY AND I'M ASSUMING YOU'RE
WANTING ME TO STOP AFTER EACH
ISSUE SO YOU CAN GO TO THE
QUESTIONS I JUST WANT TO
CONFIRM YES THAT'S CONTENT THAT
IS CORRECT. GREAT THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT SO ISSUE NUMBER SIX
THAT BUDGET INCLUDES- AN
OVERALL TWO POINT FOUR FIVE
FIVE. BILLION TOTAL FUNDS OVER
THREE YEARS FOR THE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH CONTINUE ON
INFRASTRUCTURE PROGRAMS OF THIS
AMOUNT A MINIMUM OF TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION TOTAL FUNDS
AVAILABLE FOR THE INCREASED
INFRASTRUCTURE TARGETED TO
INDIVIDUALS. AGED TWENTY FIVE
AND YOUNGER. AND IS CONSIDERED
A PART OF THE CHILDREN AND
YOUTH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INITIATIVE DISCUSSED EARLIER. A
MINIMUM OF TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION IS ALSO- ALLOCATED
SPECIFICALLY FOR SERIOUS MENTAL
ILLNESS- FOR THOSE WHO ARE
DEEMED INCOMPETENT TO STAND
TRIAL. AND THERE IS AN
ADDITIONAL ONE POINT TWO
BILLION IN BUDGET YOUR PLUS ONE
I TO GO TO THE OVERALL
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE- SIMILAR TO THE
SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
OPPOSED TO THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. BUT BROADENING TO A
LARGER NUMBER OF BENEFICIARIES
WOULD BE ABLE TO APPLY FOR
THOSE APPLICATIONS. THE FUNDING
IS ALLOCATED TO PROVIDE
COMPETITIVE GRANTS TO QUALIFIED
ENTITIES TO CONSTRUCT A CHOIR
AND REHABILITATE REAL ESTATE
ASSETS TO EXPAND THE FULL
pTREATMENT RESOURCES. AND HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT
YOU HAVE. THE DALLAS. THANK YOU
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I'M COREY
ISSUE TO WHAT THE HELL ELSE-
JUST A JUST A FEW COMMENTS TO
MAKE- FIRST WE WOULD JUST NOTE
THAT ACCORDING TO THE
ADMINISTRATION THERE WILL BE
TRAILER BILL FOR THIS PROPOSAL
BUT IT'S NOT YET AVAILABLE FOR
REVIEW GOING TO NEED THAT TO
PROPERLY ASSESS THE MERITS OF
THE PROPOSAL AND IT'S-
ADDITIONAL COMPONENTS- WE FIND
THAT- YOU KNOW THERE ARE
FURTHER DETAILS ON THIS
PROPOSAL THAT'LL NEED TO BE
NEEDED TO CONDUCT MORE THOROUGH
REVIEWS SUCH AS HOW THE GRAND
RIVER. SUCH AS HOW THE GRANT
REQUIREMENTS- FOR APPLICANTS
WILL DIFFER DEPENDING ON WHICH
POPULATION BE WHETHER IT BE
CHILDREN AND YOUTH OR ICED TEAS
OR JUST OVERALL INDIVIDUALS AND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH NEEDS- IN
GENERAL THAT THE FACILITIES ARE
FOR- NEXT WE WOULD JUST NOTE
THAT ROBUST TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO LOCAL ENTITIES IN
TERMS OF BEING ABLE TO ENGAGE
IN REAL ESTATE ACQUISITION
ACTIVITIES IS GOING TO BE
CRITICAL TO ENSURE THAT THERE
ARE NO DELAYS IN GETTING THIS
GRANT FUNDING OUT FOR
FACILITIES- THERE HAVE BEEN
SOME ADJUSTMENTS MADE TO THIS
PROPOSAL TO SHIFT RESOURCES
TOWARDS- PROVIDING THAT
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE WHICH WE
FIND TO BE REASONABLE- NEXT WE
PROVIDE WE FIND THAT PROVIDING
FUNDS TO THIS PROPOSAL.
TARGETED AT THE I. S. T.
POPULATION IS REASONABLE AS
WELL- BUT WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT
THERE IS A MAJOR REVISION
PROPOSAL WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT
OF STATE HOSPITALS- FOR THE
STATE HOSPITALS TO CONTINUE OR
DISCONTINUE ACCEPTING LETTERMAN
PETROUS SHORT OR LPS PATIENTS-
FROM COUNTIES AND IF BOTH THESE
PROPOSALS WERE TO BE
IMPLEMENTED YOU KNOW WE FIND
THAT IT'S POSSIBLE THAT THERE
WOULD BE DEMAND FROM LOCAL
ENTITIES- FOR FUNDING THROUGH
THIS PROPOSAL FOR- FACILITIES
FOR THAT POPULATION THAT WOULD
BE SORT OF- NO LONGER BEING
TAKEN IN AT THE STATE HOSPITAL
FACILITIES- LASTLY WE JUST KNOW
THAT GIVEN THE SUBSTANTIAL
FUNDING ADDED TO THIS PROPOSAL
THAT. IT'LL BE IMPORTANT TO
CONSIDER WHETHER LOCAL ENTITIES
HAVE THE CAPACITY AND
WILLINGNESS TO PROVIDE
COMMITTED FUNDING FOR THE
ONGOING COSTS OF PROVIDING
SERVICES IN THESE FACILITIES-
GIVEN THAT THIS IS A ONE TIME
INVESTMENT AND THAT THERE WOULD
LIKELY BE ADDITIONAL SERVICE
COSTS THAT. THEY WOULD NEED TO
TAKE ON IF THEY WERE TO PURSUE
THIS FUND- ARE UNDERSTAND OF
THIS FROM. IS LOCAL AND- WOULD
NEED TO AGREE TO FUND THE ON
GOING COSTS OF OPERATING THESE
FACILITIES FOR A PERIOD OF
THIRTY YEARS- WHILE WE DON'T
HAVE MAJOR REASONS TO BELIEVE
THAT THESE ENTITIES WOULD NOT
BE ABLE TO DO THIS- WE WOULD
JUST NOTE THAT IF IT TURNS OUT-
THAT THESE LOCAL ENTITIES DO
NOT WISH TO AGREE TO THE
ONGOING SERVICE COSTS
COMMITMENT WITHIN THE PROPOSAL-
THAT MAY READ THE- RESULT IN
SORT OF REDUCE DEMAND FOR THE-
GRANT PROGRAM AS WELL- THOSE
ARE ALL OF OUR COMMENTS AT THIS
TIME AND- WE'RE HAPPY TO SORT
OF PROVIDE FURTHER ASSISTANCE
WHERE NEEDED. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- AND- THEN THIS OF COURSE
IS A PARTICULAR INTEREST TO ME
AG I HAVE. I HAVE BEEN LONG
POUNDING ON THE ISSUE THAT WE
NEED MORE. MORE APPROPRIATE
HOUSING AND HOUSING CHOICES FOR
PEOPLE WHO ARE SUFFERING FROM
SEVERE AND PERSISTENT MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES. AS WELL AS THOSE
ON THE- ON THE LOWER END OF THE
CONTINUUM. O I. SO WHAT WE ARE
WE ARE. VERY EXCITED TO LOOK
pDETAILS COMING ON THIS- I ALSO
HAVE A LOT OF QUESTIONS ABOUT
IT IT'S NOT IT'S NOT. JUST
ENOUGH TO BUILD THEM AND THEY
WILL COME IF WE DON'T HAVE THE
REIMBURSEMENT RATES AND THE-
SUPPORTS IN PLACE. TO BE ABLE
TO ACTION ACCURATELY STAFF
THEM. AS YOU KNOW FOR A LOT OF
OUR FOLKS WHO DO WHO NEED. SOME
OF THE MOST A CONSISTENT HELP
IT'S NOT JUST. A ROOM THAT THEY
NEEDED A LOT MORE WRAPAROUND
THAT NEEDS TO GO WITH THAT. SO
HOW WE'RE GOING TO FUND THOSE
KINDS OF THINGS AND HOW ALL OF
THESE. INITIATIVES WORK
TOGETHER I THINK- UNLESS YOU
HAVE ALL THE ANSWERS RIGHT NOW
MISS COOPER I STILL THINK A LOT
OF IT STILL. NEEDS TO BE BORNE
OUT TO SEE. WHAT THE WHAT THE
ACTUAL PLAN IS BEFORE WE SAY
YES TO THIS- BUT- WE ARE. I AM
VERY EXCITED THAT THAT WERE
ACTUALLY GONNA FOCUS ON THIS-
AND I AGREED THAT IF WE DO MAKE
THE MOVE FROM STATE HOSPITALS
AT THAT IS GOING TO. PUT EVEN
MORE PRESSURE ON THE SYSTEM.
AND WE DON'T HAVE ROOM OR
RESOURCES RIGHT NOW FOR THE
FOLKS WHO. WHO NEED TO BE IN
HIS BEDROOM. AT THE THOUGHT OF.
HAVING EVEN MORE. MAKES A
LITTLE HAS. AND WE ACTUALLY
KNOW WHAT THE PLAN IS TO BE SO.
I THINK WE- ARE I AM CERTAINLY
VERY. COGNISANT AND-
APPRECIATE. THAT THE PUTTING
THIS FORWARD BUT WE KNOW THAT
THERE'S- A LOT MORE THAN. THAT
WE NEED TO KNOW BEFORE WE CAN.
WALK BEFORE WE CAN TAKE ANY
ACTION ON. A DEPEND. THANK YOU
AND- THIS IS CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE- THIS EFFORT TO HELP
SUPPORTER I GUESS THE PHYSICAL
BRICK AND MORTAR INFRASTRUCTURE
HERE BUT I CERTAINLY AGREE WITH
THE CHAIR THAT FOR THIS TO BE
SUCCESSFUL THERE'S A LOT OF
OTHER FACTORS AT PLAY IN WE'D
LIKE TO SEE THIS TO BE
SUCCESSFUL SO CERTAINLY NOT
OPPOSED TO LOOKING AT THE ONE
BE SURE WE'RE DOING IT THROUGH
ENOUGH ANALYSIS AND- IT AND
DESERVE THINKING ABOUT THOUGH
AND THIS IS ONE PIECE OF THIS
LARGER PACKAGE BUT- I REALLY DO
THINK. ANYTHING MENTIONED
BEFORE IS THAT WE NEED TO DO-
YOUNG ASSESSOR EXISTING WORK
FORCE RIGHT SO WE HAVE- MENTAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS WHO ARE WORKING
FOR GOVERNMENT ENTITIES
COUNTIES IT'S ADDRESS WE HAVE
THOSE- WORKING SPRITE IN THE
PRIVATE SECTOR WE MAY HAVE SOME
WHO ARE RETIRED OR WHO MIGHT BE
WILLING TO COME BACK GIVEN THE
RIGHT CIRCUMSTANCES YEAH WE
TALKED A LITTLE ABOUT THE
PRIMARY CARE WORKFORCE CELL
WHO- WHO AND THE LEVELS- YOU
DON'T PRIMARY CARE PROVIDERS
WITH THE LEAD MAN OF MENTAL
HEALTH ANY BILL PROVIDE. YOU
KNOW WHAT THE MALL JUST SAYING
WE ARE FOR THEM ALL TO BE HERE
FOR HEALTH BECAUSE THAT WE
OVERWHELM THEM SO THEN WHEN WE
THINK ABOUT THIS PIECE NOW WHAT
IS A STAFFING RIGHT SO WE'RE
GOING TO DO EACH COUNCIL CA I
WANNA HAVE YOU CAN SEE THE
COUNCIL SO HOW MANY HOW MANY
PEOPLE WE NEED TO DO THE E.
CONSULS FOR THE SCHOOLS FOR THE
PRIVATE FOR THE PRIMARY CARE
PRACTICE HOW MANY PEOPLE THEY
NEED TO STAFF THESE FACILITIES.
WE NEED TO THINK ABOUT MAPPING
THAT OUT OF BED TO BE SURE WE
HAVE THOSE THAT AND THINK ABOUT
HOW WE MAXIMIZE THE WORK FORCE
AND THE VARIOUS RESOURCES WE
HAVE TO DO TO DO THAT SO I
THINK THE MAIN GATE THE NAME
WAS A SPEAKING PERHAPS A LARGER
PROPOSAL RIGHT AND WHERE WHERE
WHERE THE RESOURCE IS MOST
NEEDED IN TERMS OF THE
BOTTLENECKS IN ONE THE OTHER
CHALLENGES PERHAPS IS THAT IT
AND I APPRECIATE THAT YOUR BILL
THE STATE'S PRETTY FOR THE
MONEY BUT AS I THINK IS L. L.
POINTED OUT. THAT THE LOCAL IS-
COUNTY IF YOU'VE DEPEND ON THE
LOCAL PEOPLE TO PROVIDE THE ON
GOING OUT YOU KNOW OPERATIONS
QUESTIONS ARE GOING TO FIGHT OR
NOT OR TO GO BE. WILLING TO DO
THAT OR NOT- THERE'S EVEN LOW
CATION ISSUES RIGHT. THEN FOR.
AND I. HATE TO SAY THIS BUT-
NICE AS- TIME. WHEN SOMEONE'S
FOR. TO BUILD MEDICAL THIS. AND
PEOPLE WHO LIVE IN THAT AREA.
WANT IT- THERE AND- FOR EVEN
FINDING LOCATION. AND SO FOR.
MAYBE A CHALLENGE FOR SOME
CERTAIN AREAS AS WELL. AND YOU
KNOW- SO WE COULD IF WE COULD
END UP WITH A SITUATION WHERE.
WELL ON BECAUSE THE LOCALS HAVE
TO COMMIT TO PROVIDE THE THIRTY
YEARS OF SERVICE ETCETERA. AND
THAT BECOMES THE EXCUSE FOR
CERTAIN AREAS ACTUALLY DECLINED
BECAUSE- THE REAL REASON IS
BECAUSE PEOPLE IN THAT
COMMUNITY. YOU KNOW THEY HAVE
UNDUE OUR AND- NOW. THEY DON'T
WANT A MENTAL HEALTH FACILITY
IN YOUR AREA RIGHT. AND THEN
WHAT HAPPENS IS WE HAVE TO
DISTRIBUTE YOU KNOW WE THE
DISTRIBUTION OF THESE- THAT WE-
THE FUND. TURNS DOESN'T. MATCH
THE- DEMAND TO NEED OR DESIRE
DAY DON'T ADDRESS THE EQUITY
ISSUES THAT MIGHT BE AVAILABLE
THINGS LIKE THAT SO- SO. THESE
ARE NOT ALL THINGS THE REASONS
TO SAY NO TO THIS BUT THESE ARE
THINGS THAT WOULD BE GOOD TO
HAVE SOME ANSWERS ABOUT HOW
WE'RE GOING TO GO ABOUT DOING
THIS HOW WHAT KIND OF
INCENTIVES. AND ARE WE JUST AND
OTHER THAN THAT WE DISTRIBUTE
THE RESOURCES ARE PROBABLY L.
IS THIS THE RIGHT AMOUNT TO PUT
ON THE BRICK MORTAR SIDE. IS
THE AMOUNTS ARE BEING PROPOSED
FOR THE WORK FORCE SIDE THE
RIGHT AMOUNTS OF THAT WE
ACTUALLY WHAT IS THE WORK FORCE
LEVEL WE NEED TO GET TO. BE A
WAR WE NOW WE DO KNOW WE NEED
TO GET TO IN FOUR YEARS WITH A
BILL THIS OUT WE'RE GONNA NEED
TO GET TO IN FOUR YEARS. WE
BUILD OF THE I T. FLAT.
DISTANCE- VIRTUAL PLATFORM WILL
GET WE'RE GONNA NEED TO BE IN
FOUR YEARS RIGHT SO. THOSE
TYPES OF THINGS WOULD BE REALLY
HELPFUL I REALIZE YOU DON'T
HAVE ALL THE ANSWERS RIGHT NOW
BUT- WE GOT TO COME P WITH A
PROCESS TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
GET THOSE ANSWERS AND HOW. AND
CERTAINLY I THINK IS A
LEGISLATURE WILL BE SURE THAT
WE'RE ENGAGED IN THAT AND THAT-
AND THAT THERE'S A- NO
COLLABORATION AND TRYING TO
FIGURE THIS OUT- THE- SO THAT
WE'RE PUTTING THE RIGHT
RESOURCES IN THE RIGHT PLACES
THAT. THAT WERE YOU KNOW IN THE
END IT HAS TO BE DONE AND I
KNOW THIS IS OUR PURPOSE IS TO
HELP. NOW TO HELP THESE. THESE
CHILDREN. USE RIGHT AND SO
HAVING. KIND ASSESSMENT IS GOOD
YOU KNOW. IT IS TO BE A. I
WOULD JUST MAKE A FEW KEY ABOUT-
I WE DID PUT OUT SOME OF ON THE
PLUMBING ON SIGNET GAP THAT
EXIST IN THIS. OF IN THE
GOVERNOR BUDGET FAR BEYOND WHAT
WHAT A THE SEVEN HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION WOULD. NOT EVEN
INCLUDE THE SPECIFIC FOCUS ON
ICE TEA IN CHILDREN YOU SO
COMPLETELY ACKNOWLEDGING OF THE
COMMENTS AROUND THE OPERATING
HE SAYS THAT WOULD BE REQUIRED
BY THE LOCAL ENTITIES BUT GIVEN
THE AMOUNT OF THIS INVESTMENT
YOU'D BE PUTTING A BRICK AND
MORTAR WE DO NEED SOME
ASSURANCES THAT THOSE SERVICES
WOULD BE ABLE TO CONTINUE. ON
AND THEY WOULD BE ABLE TO BE
REIMBURSED FOR THEIR SERVICES
AND I'M JUST WHAT FLAG THAT- IT
IS TIMELY WITH THE MOVEMENT FOR
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CARE REFORM
AT LEAST FOR THE MEDIC CAL.
SERVICES BECAUSE THEN IT WOULD
ALLOW US TO GO OUTSIDE OF THE
COST BASED REIMBURSEMENT AND
INTO THE TO THE FEE SCHEDULE
REIMBURSED MANAGEMENT WHICH
WILL BE BENEFICIAL TO OUR
COUNTY PARTNERS AND SO JUST
WANTED TO MAKE THOSE TWO TWO
POINTS IN REGARDS TO SOME OF
THE COMMENTS BEING MADE AND WE
ARE VERY MUCH LOOKING AROUND
WHAT FLEXIBILITIES MAY BE
NEEDED. I'M IN THE LOCAL AREA
GIVEN THE HISTORICAL- YOU KNOW
PUSH BACK OF SOMEBODY'S TAX OF
FACILITIES GOING INTO VARIOUS
NEIGHBORHOODS OR COMMUNITIES
AND ARE TAKING THAT SERIOUSLY
AND HOPEFULLY WILL HAVE AN
UPDATED PROPOSAL. FOR YOU GUYS
SHORTLY SO YOU CAN SEE SOME
ADDITIONAL DETAILS OF THE
DEPARTMENT SPEAKING ABOUT. YEAH
I AND I APPRECIATE THAT AND WE
ALSO REALIZE THAT THIS ISN'T
STANDING IN ISOLATION RIGHT SO
WE TALKED MY S. T. WERE DOING
TELLING HIM THAT WE'RE TRYING
TO ACTUALLY GET MORE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH ON THAT END TOO SO. WOOD
WE ARE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW
THIS WHOLE THESE INTERLOCKING
PIECES OF WORK TOGETHER AND ARE
WE NOW GOING TO WRITE BALLOT SO
I APPRECIATE THAT BUT JUST
SERVICE ONGOING DIALOGUE ABOUT
OKAY. THE STATE WOULD DON'T
NECESSARILY DISAGREE WITH THE
PIECES THE QUESTION IS LIKE
WHAT HOW WE DETERMINE HOW BIG
EACH PIECES SO THAT WE'RE NOT
BY GO NOW WE HAVE FACILITY ARE
WE GET MONEY FACILITIES BUT THE
UPTAKE ISN'T THERE OR SO LEASE
BUT THERE'S NO ONE TO STAFF
THEM AND SO. DECIDED TO IT-
JUST TRYING TO GET TO FIGURE
OUT HOW WE FIGURED IT ALL OUT
AND- HOPEFULLY WE CAN HAVE A
FREE SHARING OF INFORMATION SO
THAT WE KNOW- SO THAT WE HAVE A
BETTER UNDERSTANDING. OF HOW
THESE PIECES COME TOGETHER-
WHEN I GOT AND I'VE FIRST GOT
ELECTED STAR CITY AND I RIPPED
CENTRAL STOCKTON DON'T AND
CENTRAL STAR AND NOT WAS HAVE A
LOT OF MEETING I WAS FOR THING
I WOULD HE TO ME GROUPON TOO
MANY TO HOMES IN IN
NEIGHBORHOOD AND- AND I NEVER
THOUGHT IT WAS THAT WAS THE
ISSUE IT WAS ISSUE THAT THEY
WERE VERY WELL RUN AND SO YOU
HAD PEOPLE OUT ALL OVER THE
PLACE WHICH IS AND WHAT BEGINS
TO PROVIDE THAT COMMUNITY PUSH
BACK WHEN THEY SEE WHEN THEY
SEE THINGS NOT GOING VERY WELL-
SO. ANYWAY WE KNOW WE HAVE WORK
IN FRONT OF US TO DO OKAY ISSUE
NUMBER SEVEN SUPPORT FOR PUBLIC
HOSPITALS. SO THE MAY REVISION
INCLUDES THREE HUNDRED MILLION-
OF. FEDERAL FUNDS TO PAY DIRECT
GRANTS TO THE DESIGNATED PUBLIC
HOSPITALS IN SUPPORT OF THEIR
HEALTHCARE EXPENDITURES. ON THE
DURING THE COPA NINETEEN
PANDEMIC- DESIGNATED PUBLIC
HOSPITALS HAVE BEEN INTEGRAL TO
THE PUBLIC HEALTH RESPONSE.
EFFORT INCLUDING THEIR EFFORTS
TO INCREASE SURGE CAPACITY
RAPID EXPAND INTO PLAY TESTING
ASSIST IN THE DEVELOPMENT. AND
DISTRIBUTION OF VACCINES AS-
SPECIFICALLY IN REGARDS TO A
LOT ABOUT POPULATIONS IN
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR HELP BEING
THAT THE STATE CLOSE. MANY OF
THOSE EQUITY GAPS ADDITIONALLY
A GIVEN THE NATURE OF THE
REQUEST BEING FOCUSED ON COULD
NINETEEN RESPONSE AND UTILIZING
FEDERAL FUNDS BEFORE. I GENERAL
FUND. AND THAT IS BY THE
DEPARTMENT FEELS IT IS MORE
APPROPRIATE TO USE THE CORONA
VIRUS. FISCAL RECOVERY FUNDS
VERSUS GENERAL FUND. AND HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU
HAVE. FOR MUCH THE L. A. O.
I'VE BEEN JOHNSON WITH THE L.
A. L. OUR OFFICE RECENTLY
RELEASED ANALYSIS OF HOW COULD
NINETEEN HAS AFFECTED
HEALTHCARE ACCESS AND
UTILIZATION- BUT A MAJOR
OUTSTANDING QUESTION THAT WE
FOUND CHALLENGING TO ANSWER WAS
WAS HOW THE PANDEMIC HAS
AFFECTED STATE HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS OUT FINANCES. AND
THEREFORE WE DON'T REALLY KNOW
HOW LIKE WHICH PROVIDERS WHICH
CLASSES OF PROVIDERS OR
pGREATEST FINANCIAL STRESS DUE
TO THE- DUE TO THE PANDEMIC
BOTH GIVEN THE REDUCTIONS THAT
WE'VE SEEN IN UTILIZATION AND
LIKE THE LIKELY THE ASSOCIATED
REIMBURSEMENT BUT ALSO GIVEN
THE FEDERAL- HEALTH CARE
PROVIDER FINANCIAL RELIEF
THAT'S BEEN. PROVIDED TO DATE
THROUGH FEDERAL LEGISLATION
GIVEN THESE OUTSTANDING
QUESTIONS- WE DO GUYS HAVE SOME
SOME FURTHER QUESTIONS ABOUT
WHY THE ADMINISTRATION HAS
PROPOSED FINANCIAL RELIEF FOR
ONE CLASS ONLY ONE CLASS OF
HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS AND SO
PRIOR TO DECIDING ON THIS
PROPOSAL WE WOULD- RECOMMEND
THE LEGISLATURE- ASKING THE
ADMINISTRATION- WHITE PUBLIC
DESIGNATED PUBLIC HOSPITALS
ALONE ARE TARGETED FOR THIS
RELIEF. AND WHAT INFORMATION ON
THE HOSPITAL'S NET FINANCIAL
POSITIONS- INFORMED THE
PROPOSAL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
TO THE CORRECT OF THAT QUESTION
IS COOPER OR SO- IT
SPECIFICALLY IS FOCUSED ON AND
THE DESIGNATED PUBLIC HOSPITALS
HAVE ISSUED A PUBLIC LETTER
REGARDING FEES- THIS REQUEST ON
THAT CAN BE PROVIDED TO YOU ARE
UNDESERVEDLY FOCUSES ON THE
FACT THAT THE DESIGNATED PUBLIC
HOSPITALS SELF FINANCED
MEDICARE FEE FOR SERVICE IN
REGARDS TO THE SERVICES THAT
THEY PROVIDE. VERY DIFFERENT
THAN MOST OF OUR OTHER
PROVIDERS IN MEDIC CAL I JUST
TO BE CLEAR AND GIVEN THE
SIGNIFICANT INCREASES OF
MEDICARE FEE FOR SERVICE
SERVICES DURING THE PUBLIC- THE
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY
SPECIFICALLY AROUND THE
INPATIENT STAYS TIED TO THE.
KOBE NINETEEN RESPONSE ON THAT
WAS WHY I WE LOOKED AT THIS
RISK AND WE TO THE POT UP
PUBLIC HOSPITALS THEIR CELL.
BINANCE AND THEY IT WORKS IN.
THANK YOU I KNOW- WE HAVE ONE
OF PUBLIC COST DE IN MY IN MY-
AND I KNOW PLANNED KNOW THINGS
BEEN A STRONG. YEAH I.
CERTAINLY UNDER. THE CHALLENGES
FACED WITH PUBLIC COST DURING.
THIS IS. ALSO SOME. FOR
PARTICULARLY. THINKING ABOUT
YOU KNOW THE PROVIDER NETWORK
FOR MANTA CAL- YOU KNOW RULE
HOSPITAL'S OTHER HOSPITALS
THAT- IT'S- THAT MIGHT BE IN
FINANCIAL DIFFICULTY THAT STAYS
CLOSE WITH AND DENY CARE FOR.
MEDI CAL- AND- ALSO EVEN
CLINICS OR PRIMARY CARE SITES
AS WELL PARTICULARLY IN AREAS
WHERE THERE'S- WHERE THEY'RE
NOT VERY DENSE OCCASIONS THEY
DID NOT A LOT OF THEM SO WELL.
THAT THAT WITH MY CREATE ACCESS
ISSUES HAS THERE BEEN ANY SERVE
ANALYSIS DONE BY DCS. OUT INTO
REGARD TO BE SURE THAT WE DON'T
HAVE. TO START DEVELOPING HOLES
IN. AREAS OF. MARKS ACTUALLY
HOW CARE PROVIDER NOT BE ABLE
TO DEAL WITH IT AND IN
FINANCIAL TROUBLE. WE HAVE NOT
BEEN MADE AWARE TO MY KNOWLEDGE
OF THAT BUT I WILL DEFINITELY
GO BACK AND CHECK WITH MY TEAM
JUST TO VERIFY THIS. OF ANY
REPORTS OF- YOU KNOW RURAL
HOSPITALS ARE CLOSING AT THIS
TIME WE HAVE BEEN IN PRETTY
CLOSE COMMUNICATIONS WITH THE
VARIOUS- HOSPITAL ASSOCIATIONS
DURING THE PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY OF BUT WE CAN
DEFINITELY TAKE THAT BACK AND
HOW CONVERSATIONS TO ENSURE
THEIR SOMETHING WE'RE NOT
MISSING IN THAT REGARD. OKAY I
NEEDED TO GET AND OBVIOUSLY AN
ACCESS ISSUE IF WE DON'T
ACTUALLY HAVE UNTIL CLINICS
HOSPITALS APPRECIATED THANK
YOU. IN CONVERSATIONS- THIS
MORNING WITH THAT CENTER
LAYERED HE MENTIONED- HAS
HOSPITAL WATSONVILLE HAVING
SOME ISSUES RIGHT NOW AND AGAIN
THAT'S AN AREA THAT THAT RURAL
AREA THAT SERVES A LOT OF- HIGH
RISK FOLKS RIGHT IN THE MIDDLE
OF OUR OUR SELLABLE. OF
CALIFORNIA SO- AND EVERY THAT
WE CERTAINLY DO NOT WANT TO BE
OVERLOOKED SO THANK YOU FOR
LOOKING INTO THOSE MISS COOPER
OKAY- ISSUE NUMBER. EIGHT
CAROLINE. FOR SO MANY OVER-
ACCOUNTING PROPOSALS THAT ARE
WITHIN THE- THAT THE BUDGET SO
THE FIRST ONE IS AROUND EIGHTY
POPULATION HEALTH MANAGEMENT
SERVICE OF THE BUDGET INCLUDES
THREE HUNDRED MILLION TOTAL
FUNDS- FOR LOCAL ASSISTANCE.
USING AND FIFTEEN MILLION TOTAL
FUNDS FOR STATE OPERATIONS OF
THE DEPARTMENT- IS LOOKING TO
PROCURE A BUSINESS SOLUTION
THAT WILL UTILIZE
ADMINISTRATIVE AND CLINICAL
DATA. AND INFORMATION FROM NOT
ONLY THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES- AS WELL AS OUR
MANAGED CARE PLANS COUNTIES
PROVIDERS BENEFICIARIES SOCIAL
SERVICES. OTHER STATE
DEPARTMENTS TO PULL IN ALL OF
THE VARIOUS- CLINICAL. AND
ADMINISTRATIVE DATA INTO ONE
KIND OF STANDARD PLATFORM FOR
MEDICARE BENEFICIARIES-
THROUGHOUT THE MEDICARE PROGRAM
MANY OF THE SERVICES ARE
PROVIDED IN NINETEEN YOUR
INDIVIDUAL ADMINISTRATIVE
FUNCTIONS SEPARATE. OF THE AND
THERE'S NO ONE SINGLE PROCESS
TO BRING ALL OF THOSE SERVICES
AND INFORMATION TOGETHER AND A
HOLISTIC APPROACH FOR
DELIVERING SERVICES TO MEDIC
HOW- BENEFICIARIES IN
CALIFORNIA. SO SOME OF THE
FUNCTIONS WILL INCLUDE- THE
PIECES ARE CALAIS AND A
POPULATION HEALTH MANAGEMENT
OUR STRATEGY WHERE THE
INFORMATION FOR THE BENEFICIARY
WOULD BE AVAILABLE FOR THE
STANDARDIZED I STATE RISK A
STRATIFICATION AND THE RISK
HERE THAT WE ARE BUILDING
WITHIN THE PROPOSAL. IT WOULD
HELP IDENTIFY GAPS IN CARE FOR
THE BENEFICIARY ALSO FOR THE
PROVIDER TO BE ABLE TO UTILIZE
TO BETTER UNDERSTAND BASED ON
ALL OF THE DATA COMING INTO THE
DEPARTMENT WHAT ARE THE
EXISTING GAPS IN CARE. IT WOULD
IDENTIFY GAPS IN BENEFITS YOUR
REFERRALS OF FOR EXAMPLE A
PREGNANT WOMAN WHO IS WITHOUT
WHICH OF THE SYSTEM WOULD BE
ABLE TO FIVE THOSE TYPES OF
REFERRAL FLAGS FOR PROVIDERS IN
MANAGED CARE PLANS. TO BE ABLE
TO ACT ON THE ALSO LIST- IF
THERE'S A CASE MANAGER OR CARE
MANAGER ASSIGNED TO THAT
BENEFICIARY THE PEOPLE
UNDERSTAND WHO TO CONTACT TO
ENSURE A COORDINATION WITH THE
NAMES ARE CARE MANAGER CASE
MANAGER. IT WOULD ALSO INCLUDE
ANY OF OUR STANDARDIZED
ASSESSMENTS THAT ARE BEING
EXPLORED DURING THE POPULATION
HEALTH MANAGEMENT STRATEGY AS
WELL AS PROVIDE INFORMATION AS
COLLECTED ON SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH.
IMPACTING THE BENEFICIARY'S
ABILITY TO GET BETTER CARE WILL
ALSO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE HEALTH
EDUCATION AND TIPS. FOR THE
BENEFICIARIES AND EMPOWER
BENEFITS HERE'S THREE OWNERS
THEIR OF THEIR OWN. THE GOAL IS
A IS THAT ALL PLAYING COVER.
AND HAVE ACCESS A COP.
LONGITUDINAL PATIENT RECORD
WITH ALL MEDICAL AND SOCIAL
INFORMATION AVAILABLE TO THE
DEPARTMENT TO SHARE WITH THEM
AND HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- DEPARTMENT
FINANCE. ONLY BECAUSE THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WE DON'T
HAVE ANY FURTHER COMMENTS ON
THIS ONE OR ISSUES- EIGHT
THROUGH NINE BUT WERE AVAILABLE
HERE TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
FOR FINANCE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR JOHNSON- HELLO AGAIN-
OVERALL WE FIND THAT THIS
PROPOSAL COULD. IMPROVE MEDIC
CALIFORNIANS. MONITORING AND
CARE DELIVERY IN ANALYSIS THAT
WE RELEASED ON CHALLENGE EQUITY
CONSIDERATIONS WE RAISE THE
QUESTION OF HOW CARRYING AND
HENCE MINTS TO MEDICARE MANAGED
CARE PLANS. POPULATION HEALTH
MANAGEMENT INFRASTRUCTURE WOULD
TRANSLATE INTO IMPROVED
STATEWIDE PERFORMANCE
MONITORING HEALTH EQUITY AND
QUALITY OUTCOMES SUCH AS
THROUGH PUBLIC REPORTING IN
DASHBOARDS. IN CONCEPT WE DO
BELIEVE THAT THE PROPOSED
SERVICE COULD FACILITATE THIS
IMPROVE STATEWIDE PERFORMANCE
MONITORING BY SERVING AS A
CENTRAL REPOSITORY FOR
ADMINISTRATIVE AND CLINICAL
DATA ACROSS MEDICAL DELIVERY
SYSTEMS- FOR EXAMPLE. IF THE
SERVICE COULD POTENTIALLY
COLLECT AND REPORT INFORMATION
ON MEDICARE BENEFICIARIES TALK
REPORTED HEALTH STATUS AND
HOUSING STABILITY WHICH WOULD
BE COLLECTED THE ASSESSMENTS
THAT MANAGED CARE. PLANS WOULD
BE REQUIRED TO GET THE MEMBERS.
HOW WE DO HAVE SOME OUTSTANDING
ABOUT THIS PROPOSAL- AND THESE
INCLUDE ONE- WHY EXACTLY- WHAT
IS THE ADMINISTRATION'S-
RATIONALE FOR NOT THINKING THAT
THIS IS A AND I. T. PROJECT
THAT WOULD BE SUBJECT TO THE
STATE'S IT PROJECT OVERSIGHT
RULES. WHAT IS THE FULL
INTENDED SKIRT WITH THE
FUNCTIONALITY FOR EXAMPLE HOW
MIGHT BE ARE. THE SYSTEM
INTERFACE WITH RELATED STATE
EFFORTS TO IMPROVE HEALTH
INFORMATION EXCHANGE
AVAILABILITY ON A STATEWIDE
BASIS. WE ALSO HAVE QUESTIONS
THEN ABOUT WHERE THE
ANTICIPATED TIMELINES FOR WHEN
THE SERVICE WOULD BE
OPERATIONAL AND WHAT ARE THE
ONGOING COSTS OF MAINTAINING
SERVICE. AND SO WE JUST FIND
THAT GATHERING SUCH INFORMATION
PRIOR TO TAKING ACTION ON THE
PROPOSAL COULD HELP THE
LEGISLATURE PARA VALUE WITH THE
PROPOSAL'S MERIT THANKS AND
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I HAVE. A
SPOUSE WITH A- WHO NEEDS A TERM
CARE SO WELL AT ONGOING CARE
WITH WITH THE BY DAY. HEALTH
CARE PLANS AND SO WHEN YOU TALK
ABOUT THIS I THINK WHAT RIGHT
THIS WOULD BE THIS WOULD BE
VERY VALUABLE FOR EVERYBODY NOT
JUST THE MEDICARE POPULATION-
BUT THE POPULATION AND IN
GENERAL. I THINK THIS WOULD
COULD COULD BENEFIT- AND I
WOULD AGREE THAT I THINK WE
NEED TO HAVE. TO MORE TO MORE
DETAILS- BLADE OUT- BUT I THINK
WE ALL ARE IN FAVOR OF- AND
INNOVATING MEDIC CAL- BUT CAN
YOU YOU TALK ABOUT THE ISSUE
AROUND Y. THE WHY YOU'RE NOT
THINKING ABOUT THIS IS AN I. T.
ISSUE. SINCE MOST OF THIS SEEMS
TO BE A AROUND A LOT OF ISSUES
ABOUT AROUND IT AND HOW HOW WE
PUT DATA IN AND BRING IT OUT
AND USE IT AGAIN. SURE I THINK
FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE YOU KNOW
THERE'S A LARGE NUMBER OF-
BENDERS TO PROVIDE THIS. UP
POPULATION HEALTH MANAGEMENT
SERVICE TODAY. AND SO REALLY
LOOKING TO PROCURE A SERVICE
PLATFORM. THAT WOULD ALLOW US
TO MEET THE OBLIGATIONS AND
EXPECTATIONS OF WHAT WE'RE
PUTTING FORWARD. ON INFORMATION
SHARING AND PIECES WISE BUT
ANALYTICAL BACKBONES AND
DIFFERENT COMPONENTS. WELL WE
WOULD BE- INCORPORATING DATA
INTO THAT SYSTEM WHICH IS VERY
COMMON WITH A LOT OF THE-
SERVICES THAT WE PROVIDE. UP TO
MEDICARE THAT OUR IT PROJECTS.
I'M JUST BECAUSE THERE'S DATA
FLOWING IN AND OUT DOESN'T
NECESSARILY MEAN THAT IT IS AN
IT PROJECT BECAUSE IT'S REALLY
AROUND A SERVICE PLATFORM FOR
BENEFICIARIES UNITS FROM HEALTH
EDUCATION. UNDERSTANDING THEIR
GAP CLOSURE- YOU KNOW EASILY
AT. THEIR FINGERTIPS AFTER A
ONE STOP SHOP. AS WELL AS
PROVIDERS. AND WE WOULDN'T BE
MAINTAINING OR BUILDING THAT-
I. T. INFRASTRUCTURE HERE AT
THE DEPARTMENT HEALTHCARE
SERVICES YOU WOULD BE
PARTNERING WITH. A VENDOR WHO
HAS A PLATFORM THAT WE WOULD BE
ABLE TO CUSTOMIZE FOR THE
EXPECTATIONS OF CALIFORNIA.
THAT WOULD ALLOW ALL THE
VARIOUS DATA POINTS TO FLOW
INTO THEIR WOULD BE INTERFACES
INTO THAT SERVICE PLATFORMS.
I'M BUT NOT NECESSARILY WHERE
WE ARE BUILDING AN IT PLATFORM
OURSELVES TO BE MAINTAINED BY
THE DEPARTMENT HEALTHCARE
SERVICES. DO YOU EVER SEE A
TIME WHEN YOU COULD. EXPAND
THIS BOTTLE. OR TO A LARGER
POPULATION. I'M SO WE DON'T GET
THAT QUITE. ALL APPLE AND- TO
BRING IN MANY DATA FOR OUR
DAUGHTER- I THINK WE'LL- WANT
TO BUILD IT FOR MEDIC CAL TO
START- AND THEN WE WOULD
DEFINITELY EXPLORE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS IN THE FUTURE.
THANK YOU THE DOCTOR CAN-
PATRICIA YOUR ANSWER THAT
YOU'RE GONNA USE A VENDOR SO
YOU'RE NOT BUILDING OUT YOUR
OWN IT SYSTEM I GUESS MY
QUESTION IS THAT- THE NATURE
YOUR AGREEMENT WITH THE VENDOR
WHETHER- IT IS GOING TO BE SUCH
THAT WERE THAT THE STATE IS NOT
NON AND DEPENDENT ON THIS
VENDOR RIGHT THAT- OBVIOUSLY
WILL HAVE THE PRIVACY HOPEFULLY
OUT ISSUES AND SO FORTH AND
WHATEVER CONTRACT BUT ALSO-
THAT- THE- THE STRUCTURE AND
DESIGN OF THE DATA IS DONE IN A
WAY THAT IS IN THE FUTURE WE
DECIDE THAT WE WISH TO GO TO
ANOTHER VENDOR. THAT'S NOT
GOING TO BE AN ISSUE CORRECT OF
COURSE THAT'S HOW WE WOULD
DESIGN THE OF THE CONTRACT IN
SIMILAR.
THAT I'M AT THAT TIME
AS WELL- SO WITHIN ISSUE NUMBER
NINE HOLD ON ONE SECOND LET ME
HOLD A MINUTE WAS COVERED CHECK
UP JOHNSON SORRY DID YOU HAVE
ANY ISSUES ON ON THE OTHER
ISSUES IN THAT SECTION- YEAH WE
WOULD JUST REYES ACTUALLY QUITE
SIMILAR- QUESTIONS AROUND THE
CALLIN PATH PROPOSAL WHICH IS
THE- THE CAPACITY BUILDING
FUNDING AND THAT THE DEPARTMENT
IS PROPOSING- TO ASSIST WITH
THAT CRIMINAL JUST LOCAL
CRIMINAL JUSTICE AGENCIES TO
SORT OF. GET UP T SPEED AND BE
ABLE TO MEET THE REQUIREMENTS
THAT WOULD BE PLACED ON THEM
UNDER CALAMP- IN A FUTURE YEAR.
TO PROVIDE. MASON ROLE MEANT IN
MEDICARE. AS WELL AS TO IN THIS
VARIOUS KINDS SERVICE DELIVERY-
BEFORE. TO ME PRIOR TO THE
RELEASE. AROUND I THE IN WITH
THE REALM OF BEHAVIOR HEALTH
SERVICES- HAPPY TO. ANY MORE.
ABOUT THE PROPOSAL OR R KICKED
TO THE DEPARTMENT IF THEY WANT
TO EXPLAIN IT SORT OF MORE MORE
FULLY- SO WE- WE DO BELIEVE
THAT THESE CALLOUS REQUIRE.
THAT I THAT I SORT OF DESCRIBE
CHIU DO- PRETTY. NEW ON THE
PART OF LOCAL CRIMINAL JUSTICE
AGENCIES AND ACCORDINGLY WHILE
THE FULL EXTENT OF EXISTING-
CAPACITY ON THE PART OF THESE
AGENCIES IS NOT CLEAR.
ASSISTING THEM WITH BUILDING
THEIR CAPACITY TO MEET THEIR
NEW RESPONSIBILITIES IT IS
LIKELY WARRANTED. HOWEVER ADDS
WITH THE- POPULATION HEALTH
MANAGEMENT SERVICE WE DO FIND
THAT THERE ARE SOME FUNDAMENTAL
DETAILS RELATED TO THE PROPOSAL
THAT ARE MISSING. FIRST
AVAILABLE BUDGET DOCUMENTS THAT
WE'VE REVIEWED DON'T INDICATE
WHAT WHAT KINDS BALLOT AND
AGENCIES WOULD BE ELIGIBLE
RECEIVE THIS FUNDING. HOW THE
FUNDING WOULD BE DISTRIBUTED.
WHAT EXACTLY WHAT CAPACITY
BUILDING ACTIVITIES WOULD BE
FUNDED AND THEN WHAT IS THE
RATIONALE FOR THE PROPOSED
FUNDING AMOUNT OF TWO HUNDRED
MILLION. MOREOVER WE DO FIND
THAT THERE IS SOME- SOME
UNCERTAINTY AROUND WHETHER OR
NOT FEDERAL MEDICAID WOULD BE
AVAILABLE. TO SUPPORT THIS
EFFORT UNDER THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL IT'S AT ONE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL FUND
ONE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
FEDERAL MEDICAID FUNDS- AND SO
IF TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
REALLY DOES REFLECT THE SORT OF
TRUE NEEDS OF THESE LOCAL
HEALTH AGENCIES. IF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT DOESN'T ULTIMATELY
APPROVED- THE PROUD THE
PROVISION OF FEDERAL FUNDING
FROM THE STATE MAY NEED TO.
CONTRIBUTE MORE RESOURCES TO
REALLY GET THESE AGENCIES UP TO
SPEED SO. THAT THAT CONCLUDES
MY THE REST OF MY COMMENTS ON
THE SITE AND THEN THANK YOU FOR
TURNING BACK TO US. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ANYTHING ABOUT BILLS
ON THE MEDICALLY TAILORED MEAL.
PILOT EXTENSION OR THE BEHAVIOR
HEALTH QUALITY. PROGRAM WE WILL
REYES QUESTIONS IN THE IN A
COMMON THAT WE PER TO LIVE
STAFFERS THIS MORE ON MEDIC
TAILORED MEALS PER ONE THE
QUESTION IS A SOUND THAT- KELLY
FOR TO MAKE MEDICALLY ME A- ON
INFLUENCER SPENT THAT WOULD BE
AVAIL THROUGH MANAGE CARE BIG
ON JAN FIRST TWENTY TWENTY TWO
NOW THE EXACT EXTENT TO WHICH
THOSE SERVICES WOULD GET UP AND
RUNNING OUT ON THAT DATE IS A
LITTLE UNCERTAIN THOUGH. PLANS
COULD SORT OF TAKE THE
OPPORTUNITY DO CONTRACT WITH
EXISTING PROVIDERS TO TRY TO
MAINTAIN SOME OF THOSE
SERVICES- THE MAY REVISION THIS
IS REALLY THE ONLY SERVICE THAT
TIES TO ONE OF THAT IN LIEU OF
SERVICES THAT'S GOING TO BE
AVAILABLE THROUGH KALYAN THAT
THE GOVERNOR'S BUT THE MAY
REVISION PROPOSES TO SORT OF
PROVIDE SOME ADDITIONAL SORT OF
PRE FUNDING OR BRIDGE FUNDING
TO AND SO WE JUST HAVE
QUESTIONS ABOUT SORT OF WHAT IS
THAT. WHAT IS THE RATIONALE FOR
TARGETING FUNDS AT THIS
SPECIFIC- SORT OF FUTURE IOS
BENEFIT BEFORE THAT BENEFIT GET
THOSE BENEFITS GET UP AND
RUNNING AND SORT OF WHY OTHERS
WERE NOT CONSIDERED FOR SUCH.
DOCUMENTATIONS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU OUR DEPARTMENT FINANCE. S.
THINKING I COULD EACH OF FINE
WHICH IS LIKE TO AND THE INTO
AND PROVIDING OF FOR MEDICALLY
MEAL AS OPPOSED SOME OF OTHER
AND OF SERVICES THAT WILL
BECOME UP THROUGH THE KALYAN
PROPOSED- THE REAL IN TEN HERE
WAS FILL IN ABOUT TEN GAP- IN
SERVICE THAT MAY. FOR THE CAN
OF PILOT PROGRAM TO WIN THE
SERVICES ARE RIGHT UP THE
MIDDLE LIKE TO POINT OUT THE
WITH THIS TO SOME OF THE L. A.
O. HAS RAISED WITH THE PASS.
CRIMINAL JUSTICE JUSTICE ORANGE
PROPOSED- WE EXPECT SOME OF
THOSE DETAILS HOPEFULLY BE
CLEAR FOR. IN THE BILL LANGUAGE.
YOU REALLY SHOULD. WORLD FOR
THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE- THE-
BILL TO SEE THE COUNT I THINK.
I'D LIKE I'D LIKE TO WHAT THE-
THINKING ABOUT THE PAST BECAUSE
I FOR LIKE THE HAVE FELT LIKE
THEY BEEN UNDER UNDER FIVE- AS
THE ONE TO DO A LOT ON THE WITH
A LOT OF THE COVERT STUFF SO I%
HOW ONE MORE- ONE MORE KIND OF
SHIFT DOWN TO THE- ALTHOUGH AYE
SIR SEE THE VALUE OF IT WHO CAN
BE UP WITH THREE. RIGHT THEY
THEY- THEY THE PER. SO I THINK
THAT I THINK WE TO LOOK AT THAT
ONE FURTHER- AND I AND I GUESS
WOULD JUST HAVE OR LIKE. IF
WE'RE GOING TO BE HOW. THE
MEDIC TAILORED MEAL PILAR. A
PER PROGRAM UP AND- THAT.
QUESTION ABOUT CON. THAT THAT
THE- LIKE I DON'T KNOW IF.
ALREADY THESE IN PLACE BECAUSE
IT SEEM LIKE IT WOULD BE- DEAR
DEAR. DEAR COORDINATING MADE
WITH A HOT. WHOSE PREPARE MEALS
DISTANCE. OUT A THEN HOW WOULD
HOW HOW DO WE HAVE PICKED.
ACROSS THE STATE WITH A PER.
LIKE THIS BECAUSE WE KNOW THE
SOME PARTS THAT. IT IS A VIEW
WAY UP ROLLED. A MEDICALLY-
PAID THE DETECTIVE THERE'D BE A
MIL T. YOU I THINK IT'S- TO BE
MY- MORE- TO. SO I BE IN. IN
HOW HOW DO SOME OF THOSE THINGS.
AS WE HAVE BEEN- DEPENDING MORE
AND MORE ON TELEHEALTH. BUT WE
STILL HAVE ACTUAL FOOD THAT TO
GET DISTRIBUTED TO PEOPLE. AND
WHERE THE SOME OF THE BEST WAYS
THAT WE'RE GOING TO BE ABLE TO
DO THAT. OCTOPATH. AT THE- YOU-
AND THIS IS PERHAPS A- CALLING.
SO MAYBE A WILL SPEND TOO MUCH
TIME TRYING TO ANSWER. IT BUT
JUST PUT IT OUT THERE- SIGN. SO
FIRST OF ALL NUMBER IS. IN
LOOSER. BY ALSO. UNDER PROPOSED.
STRUCTURE ITSELF ALL. BY THE
PLAY. SO THE PLAN INSIDE. TO
PURSUE ONE OR NO- AND- SO I
GUESS THE- COR I HAVE AROUND
MEDICALLY. MEAL IS THAT NOW I
THIS. IS FOR THE PIE TO FILL
GAP- D. DO YOU SEE WELL ITS
FIRST- SO AFTER THAT WHEN THE I
ABOUT THE PERFECT WAY
RESTRICTION IN LIEU PROGRAM IS
JUST EACH PLAN GETS WHICH IN
LIEU THEIR AGAIN DO OR NOT DO
ITS WE HAVE OF. IS THERE SOME
FOR THE TAKING SOME LIKE
MEDICALLY ME AND ACT- REQUIRING
PLAN. THAT HAVE POPPED. WHICH
THIS WOULD BE OF. BENEFIT TO.
DO THAT. GIVEN WHAT WE KNOW
FROM THE- SO THAT WE CAN
ACTUALLY. HOW WELL. THIS IN
LIEU PRO MAYBE IS A AS SAMPLE
TO ALL THE OTHER. WOULD WORK IN
WE DID IT MORE SYSTEM- SO THAT
I GETS A BIT CHEN WE- YOU KNOW
IT'S IF WE HAVE SOMETHING DOING
AT SOME PLANS NOW DOING AT AND
YOU YOU'RE- BACK TO SEE. YOU'RE
SEEN PAY IN SOME THEM LIVE IN
ONE SIDE OF THE BOARD AND SOME
ON THE OTHER. AND THEN SAY WELL
OKAY IF YOU WERE DO YOU LIVE I
GUESS YOU LIVE YOU GET THIS IF
YOU LIVE THERE SORRY DON'T-
AND- EVEN THOUGH THE THREAT OF
THE SECOND. ARE THE SAME SO CAN
PERHAPS SPEAK TO. FOR A QUICK
THE FOR OF THIS PILOT AND IN.
AND OUT TOGETHER WITH CAL AIM
TERMS OF THIS IDEA THAT THE
PLANS ACTUALLY DECIDE WHETHER
D GONNA DO IN THE SERVICE OR
NOT I MEAN DO YOU SEE MEDICALLY
TAILORED MEALS BASICALLY BEING
IS STILL UP TO THE PLANS
ENTIRELY OR- WHAT- DAYS SO THIS
PILOT AND IT'S ALL THE PLAN SAY
THEY DON'T WANT TO DO THAT ONE.
SO WHAT WHAT IS A PILOT SAID IN
RELATION- THE IN LIEU PROGRAMS
CURRENTLY PROPOSED. FOR CALLING.
SO THE- IS ONLY. A SELECT
COUNTY TODAY RIGHT NOW. AND
AVAILABLE ONLY JUST AT HER
FAILURE. ON THE PROPOSAL BY.
YOU IS TWO X. IT TO- TOWN- TO.
OTHER DIAGNOSE- BUT WHEN IT
COMES THE- BY IN LOWER SERVICES
THAT IS UP. WORK THAT. BONTA
FOR THE MANAGER CARE PLAN AND
FOR THE BENEFIT YEAR TRICKS. ON
THE LOWER SERVICES. THE IDEA
BEHIND IT TAKE UP HIGH THAT WAS
A IF YOU CAN. IN ITS- IT YOU TO
OTHER. IS TO HAVE. A MORE OF AN
AND- FOR INVERSE. PER GET. FOR
MANAGED PLANS TO ABLE TO CON.
WITH THE IN DID YOU FOR THE L.
THE WEBSTER. AND TO BE BRIDGE.
OF THE INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE.
THAT THE PIE PROGRAM AREN'T IN.
OFF EIGHT COUNTIES AND SO ON
THEY DID HOW TO EXPAND WITHIN
THE- THAT THEY HAD- TO PASS. IN
A TO GET THAT UP IN A ROW. AT
TO BE BUILT BETWEEN. THIS AND
THE LOWER SERVICE. IN K. DERE
WOULD BE THAT- THAT THAT WOULD
BE A- FOR THE SPANISH CARE
PLANS. YOUR AROUND IN LIEU OF
SIR. BEING OFF. AND BY. WE CAN.
UNDER HAT- AS MENTIONED IT IS
A RIGHT. OF THE- GOVERNMENT.
FOR THE A LITTLE SERVICE
APPROACH SINCE WE'RE NOT AT
EIGHT. CAPACITY TO ADD AS A
BENEFIT. A BIT OUT OF THE
DEPARTMENT ALSO. MY THE I. OF A
THE IN THE OF SERVICE. IS TO
GET SERVER THAT HE- HAVE NOT
OFFERED. THROUGH MEDICARE BILL.
STATEWIDE IN FIRST. INCOME WITH
PROVIDER. OF AND LINKAGES TO.
MAKE THEM A- AND- WHICH YOU
WOULD. HAVE THE DISPARITY
ACROSS THE STATE OF. I'M SO
THAT IS INTENTION OF. A VIA LOS
ARE IS. THAT CAN. OF BRINGING
UP THE INFORMATION. SO THAT CAN
OF. MAKE IT A MEDICARE BENEFITS
YOU WOULDN'T. ISSUES COUNTY TO
COUNTY. FOR BE DON'T HAVE THAT
TODAY- ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA OF THAT IS THE
INTENT OF BUILDING IN FIRST.
OVER TIME. THOUGH WAS TO SIGN.
OF THE COUNTIES ARE CURRENTLY
HAVE SAID PILOTS ONLY IN
CERTAIN COUNTY WE'RE GOING. TO
GET. IT'S IN RELATION TO. OUR
FILES ACCOUNT SO YOU HAVE A
PLAN IN THAT COUNTY AND THEY
SAY WELL YOU KNOW WE'RE NOT
INTERESTED IN DOING MEDICALLY
TAILORED MEALS THAT MEANS. IN
THAT COUNTY WHERE IT CURRENTLY
EXISTS AS A PILOT. IT GETS
DROPPED OFF. WE STOPPED DOING
IT HOW DO WE SET A STANDARD UP
AS A SEPARATE INDEPENDENT
PROGRAM- SO. ARE YOU JUST
HOPING THAT A WHOLE THE PLANS
THAT ARE IN THE COUNTIES WHERE
WE ACTUALLY HAVE THE PILOT.
THEY'RE GOING TO BE DOING IT-
THE LARA DEPARTMENT WOULD BE
ABLE TO ENCOURAGE THEM TO WE
WOULD MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
BROKER RELATIONSHIPS BETWEEN
THE PILOT- PROVIDER. AND THE
MANAGED CARE PLANS TO ENSURE
MANY OF THE MANAGED CARE PLANS
ALREADY HAVING CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE ENTITIES TODAY IN
ORDER TO PROVIDE THIS IN SOME
OF OUR MANAGED CARE PLANS ARE
ALREADY PROVIDING THESE
SERVICES EVEN THOUGH. IT'S NOT
A PART OF THEIR MEDICARE
CAPITATION RATE- TODAY. IN
ANTICIPATION AND BECAUSE OF THE
COST SAVINGS THAT IS OFTEN TIED
TO MEDICALLY TAILORED MEALS. SO
THE DEPARTMENT WOULD ENCOURAGE
BUT WE CANNOT REQUIRE. AS
MENTIONED EARLIER AND THEN THE
PILOT WOULD STILL EXIST UNTIL
THE FUNDING- IS COMPLETELY DONE
AS AN- AVAILABLE THROUGH THE
BUDGET- IF FOR SOME REASON I
MEAN IS YOUR PLAN DID NOT.
CONTRACT FOR THOSE SERVICES
THIS IS A CLEAR FINAL PLAN
DECLINES. THE BENEFICIARIES OF
THAT PLAN WHOSE IS THE COUNTY
BOARD THE PILOT CAN STILL
ACCESS THE MEDICALLY TAILORED
MEALS THROUGH THE PILOT
INDEPENDENT OF THE PLAN. THAT
IS CORRECT OKAY. I JUST WANNA
CLARIFY THAT OKAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OKAY- FISH. NUMBER
NUMBER EIGHT SUMMER NUMBER NINE
SO WE ARE. PERFECT ALL RIGHT SO
THE MAY REVISION PROPOSES TO
PERMANENTLY REMOVE ALL
SUSPENSIONS OF PROPERTY SIX
PAYMENTS AND OPTIONAL BENEFITS
CURRENTLY IN LAW. THE NAY
REVISION ALSO INCLUDES COSTS TO
ELIMINATE THE AB NINETY SEVEN A
RATE FREEZE FOR ICF G. AND- A
FREESTANDING PEDIATRIC SUB
ACUTE FACILITIES. INCREASE
REIMBURSEMENT RATES FOR THESE
FACILITIES SHALL ACCOUNT FOR
AND BE INCLUSIVE OF PROPERTY
SIX SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENTS OF IT
THE BUDGET INCLUDES TWENTY FOUR
MILLION TOTAL FUNDS FOR THIS
PURPOSE I'M ELEVEN A MILLION
GENERAL FUND. A FEW PIECES IN
REGARDS TO THIS RATE AS WE HAVE
HAD QUESTIONS- FINANCIAL
BENEFITS FOR THE FACILITIES
REALLY YOU KNOW INCLUDING ACS
ESTIMATES THATTHE PROBE
PROPOSAL WILL RESULT IN AN
AVERAGE OF THE 3% PER DIEM RATE
INCREASE ABOVE WHAT IS INCLUDED
IN THE JANUARY BUDGET FOR ICF
EDIE'S. I'M INCLUDING THE PROP
FIFTY SIX SUPPLEMENTAL WITH THE
RATE CHANGE BEING EFFECTIVE ON
THE RATE YOU'RE BEGINNING
AUGUST FIRST OF TWENTY ONE
ADDITIONALLY THE PROPOSAL WOULD
UNFREEZE THE RATE ON AN ONGOING
BASIS AND WOULD RESULT IN THE
RATE BEING UPDATED ON AN ANNUAL
BASIS MOVING FORWARD. I TO
REFLECT THE UPDATED COST REPORT
SUBMITTED BY FACILITIES
ALLOWING FOR ONGOING INCREASES
THE RATE METHODOLOGY WOULD
INCORPORATE- UPDATED COST
REPORT DATA TRENDED FORWARD FOR
THE RATE YEAR ALONG WITH OUT ON
TO ACCOUNT FOR COSTS TO COMPLY
WITH ANY FEDERAL OR STATE
MANDATES THAT WERE NOT
ACCOUNTED FOR IN THE COST
REPORTS. ADDITIONALLY THE
PROPOSAL INCLUDES ON THE
PROPERTY SIX FUNDED
SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENTS AS A PART
OF THE CALCULATION FOR THE
TOTAL UNFROZEN RATE IN ESSENCE
THE PROPERTY SIX FUNDING
BECOMES A PART OF THE UNFROZEN
RIGHT. AND LASTLY IN REGARDS TO
THESE FACILITIES AS THESE ARE
SERVING A 100% MEDICARE
BENEFICIARIES THE REVENUE FROM
THE MEDIC CAL PROGRAM IS
CRITICAL TO THEIR PHYSICAL
CONDITION WHICH IS WHY WE
BELIEVE IT IS AN IMPORTANT TO
UNFREEZE THE RIGHT METHODOLOGY
ON GOING. TO ENSURE THAT THE
REIMBURSEMENT LEVELS ARE ABLE
TO REFLECT THE COST OF
PROVIDING SERVICES GOING
FORWARD. AND HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR JOHNSON.
I WE NO CAN AT THE THIS BURKE
RECOGNIZING THAT THAT CUT WAS
LARGELY A BUDGETARY SOLUTION
DURING THE LAST RECESSION AND
SELL WOULD CERTAINLY DEFERRED A
LEGISLATIVE PROVOCATIVE BUT NO
I HAVE NO CONCERNS SPECIFICALLY
TO THE APPROACH BY THE
ADMINISTRATION THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I DON'T HAVE ISSUES WITH
THIS EITHER DOCTOR PAN. SO I'M
GLAD WE'RE FINALLY ON DOING
SOMETHING ANOTHER WEEK ANOTHER
RECESSION CUT THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OKAY MOVING ON TO
ISSUE NUMBER TEN. HELLO HELLO-
AS A PART OF THE IMAGE
MINISTRATIONS PROPOSAL TO
EXPAND TELEHEALTH FLEXIBILITIES
UTILIZED DURING THE PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY- WHILE
PROVIDING ASSURANCES OF
APPROPRIATE ACCESS TO IN PERSON
CARE DCS. I'M IS PROPOSING TO
ESTABLISH A RATE FOR THE AUDIO
ONLY TELEHEALTH SERVICES- AS
65% OF THE MEDICARE RATE. FOR
SERVICES RENDERED FOR FEE FOR
SERVICE INDIVIDUALS- ACT
MENTIONED PREVIOUSLY IN OUR
TELEHEALTH THIS WOULD GO ACROSS
FOR. MANAGED CARE AS WELL- AND
WE WOULD BE OFFERING A FEW
TERRIBLE ALTERNATIVE TO THE PPS
RATE FOR CLINICS TO MAINTAIN.
THE SERVICES- FOR ACCURACY IS
ALSO JUST TO MAKE SURE THAT'S
CLEAR FOR NON FQHC PROVIDER 65%
OF THE MEDICARE FEE FOR SERVICE
RATE. I'M IS WHAT WOULD BE
PROPOSED THAT WOULD BE FOR
ABOUT MANAGED CARE AND FEE FOR
SERVICE- AS WERE REQUIRING-
THAT BE CONSISTENT ACROSS ALL.
AS WELL AS FOR FQHCS THEY WOULD
BE ABLE TO PROVIDE AUDIO ON
EACH AT A COMPARABLE
ALTERNATIVE PPS RATES SIMILAR
TO A 65% RATE IF YOU FOR
SERVICE. HOWEVER WOULD JUST
KNOW AS PREVIOUSLY REPORTED IN
OTHER HEARINGS THAT WOULD BE
SUBJECT TO ACCURACY IS BEING
WILLING TO WAIVE THE PPS ENOUGH
GETTING FEDERAL APPROVAL TO
WAIVE THE PPS EMERGENT PAY THE
ALTERNATIVE PPS RATE. ON THAT
PIECE. WE ADDED SOME ADDITIONAL
UP COMPONENTS TO THE TELEHEALTH
PROPOSAL- MAINLY- REQUIRING
THAT ONLY PROVIDERS LOCATED IN
CALIFORNIA WORK ORDER
COMMUNITIES- AND ABLE TO
PROVIDE IN PERSON SERVICES TO
EACH OF THE CLIENTS SERVED BY
SYNCHRONIZED AUDIO ON THE
TELEHEALTH SERVICES. I CAN
CLAIM THE MEDICAL REIMBURSEMENT
FOR THOSE SERVICES I'M AND DH
YES WILL BE WORKING TO CONSULT
WITH SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTS IN
REGARDS TO WHICH ANY
UTILIZATION MANAGEMENT
PROTOCOLS. FOR TELEHEALTH
SERVICES THAT NEED TO BE
CONSIDERED AS WE MOVE FORWARD
OUT OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY- AS WE HAVE ADDED A
LARGE NUMBER OF TELEHEALTH
MODALITIES- IN THE- YEAR TO
ACCESS IN THE FUTURE. AND HAPPY.
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. MR XIA ANYTHING
ON THIS ONE. WE DO HAVE SOME
COMMENTS BUT I DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE MAY HAVE HAD THEIR OKAY
THE FIRST OKAY- THE DEPARTMENT
FINANCE. THANK YOU NIGHT
BECAUSE THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- THERE ARE JUST A
COUPLE POINTS THAT WE REALLY
WANT TO EMPHASIZE. WITH REGARD
TO BOTH THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
AND THEN NEVER. UNTIL HEALTH
PROPOSALS. ONE THE
ADMINISTRATION REALLY SEES THIS
PROPOSAL AS AN EFFORT TO BE
PROACTIVE. GIVEN THAT WE'RE
ASSUMING THE END OF THE PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY- AS OF
DECEMBER TWENTY TWENTY ONE. AND
SO WITH THE CONCLUSION OF THE
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY OUR
VARIOUS KOBELCO DATUM REGENCY
WAIVERS AND THE MEDICAL PROGRAM
WILL COME TO AN END. AND
THEREFORE THE CURRENT
TELEHEALTH LOOKS ABILITIES
THROUGHOUT THE PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY WILL CONCLUDE-
MOREOVER AND GIVEN THAT WE
ALREADY HAD VARIOUS TELEHEALTH
FLEXIBILITIES PRIOR TO THE
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY WE
REALLY SEE THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. AND THE NEIGHBOR VISION
PROPOSALS AS UPDATES AND ARE
NECESSARILY PREMATURE- AND THEN
WE ALSO JUST REALLY BELIEVE
THAT THE PROPOSED TELEHEALTH
POLICIES BEFORE US TODAY-
PROVIDE BILL CLINTON
CONTINUITY- BUT THEN REALLY
APPROPRIATELY BALANCED BOTH
FLEXIBILITY. ALONG WITH HIGH
STANDARDS OF CARE- AND THEN
LASTLY YOU KNOW AS THE
ADMINISTRATION- RECEIVES MORE
DATA FOR EXAMPLE UTILIZATION
DATA WITH REGARD TO TELL HEALTH
WILL CONTINUE TO MAKE UPDATES
TO THE TELEHEALTH POLICY AS
APPROPRIATE. IN THE FUTURE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER SHE
TO. THANK YOU THANK YOU CHAIR-
JUST- TO SOME COMMENTS TO MAKE
ON THIS ON THIS ISSUE- WE WOULD
NOTE THAT WE RELEASED RECENTLY
AN ANALYSIS OF THE GOVERNOR'S
JANUARY MEDIC HEALTH TELEHEALTH
PROPOSAL- IN THAT ANALYSIS WE
FOUND THAT WE FOUND THAT GIVEN
THAT MUCH ABOUT TELEHEALTH
SERVICE DELIVERY IS NOT WELL
UNDERSTOOD IN TERMS OF RELATIVE
EFFECTIVENESS OF CARE
ESPECIALLY ACROSS DIFFERENT
SERVICE MODALITIES- YOU KNOW
THE OVERALL FISCAL IMPACT OF
MAKING TELEHEALTH SERVICES.
MORE WIDELY AVAILABLE IS NOT
GENERALLY NOT WELL UNDERSTOOD-
AND HOW DIFFERENT PAYMENT RATES
AFFECT TELEHEALTH SERVICES
BEING PROVIDED IS ALSO NOT SORT
OF CLEARLY UNDERSTOOD- GIVEN
THESE CONSIDERATIONS YOU KNOW
WE FOUND IT WAS PREMATURE TO
ESTABLISH A MEDIC CAL
TELEHEALTH POLICY ON A
PERMANENT BASIS AND SUGGESTED A
TIME LIMITED EXTENSION OF THE
CURRENT MEDICARE TELEHEALTH
FLEXIBILITIES- IN FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO SORT OF DIRECT
THE ACS TO CONDUCT A WORK GROUP
TO. DEVELOP OPTIONS FOR LONGER
LONGER TERM MEDICARE TELEHEALTH
POLICY- WE ALSO NOTED IN THAT
ANALYSIS SOME CONCERNS WE HAD
ABOUT DISPARITIES IN ACCESS TO
CARE AS A RESULT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S JANUARY PROPOSAL- IN
PARTICULAR AMONG MEDICARE
BENEFICIARIES BETWEEN THOSE WHO
ACCESS CARE THROUGH HEALTH
CENTERS AND THOSE DO NOT AND
THOSE WHO DO NOT- ESPECIALLY
FOR AUDIO ONLY SERVICES.
GENERALLY WE FIND THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISE PROPOSAL
TO BE AN IMPROVEMENT OVER THE
JANUARY PROPOSAL IT PROVIDES
SOME FURTHER DETAIL ON WHAT
PAYMENT RATES FOR AUDIO ONLY
SERVICES WILL BE- AND WE FIND
THE ADMINISTRATION'S INDICATION
THAT IT WILL PROPOSE A COVERING
AUDIO ONLY SERVICES AT HEALTH
CENTERS ON A DISTINCT FEE
SCHEDULE FROM PPS- TO BE A
REASONABLE APPROACH- WE JUST
KNOW THAT FEDERAL APPROVAL OF
THIS ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT MODEL
REPEAT REMAINS UNCERTAIN AT
THIS TIME- WHILE WE DO FIND THE
GOVERNOR'S NAY REVISION
PROPOSAL TO BE AN IMPROVEMENT
OVER THE JANUARY MEDICARE
TELEHEALTH PROPOSAL. WE DO
STILL FIND THAT OUTSTANDING
QUESTIONS REMAIN FOR EXAMPLE-
AND BE ADMINISTRATION STILL
DOES NOT PROPOSED TO EXTEND THE
NEW. REMOTE PATIENT MONITORING
BENEFIT TO HELL STATE HEALTH
CENTERS. WHICH WE FOR REASONS.
ABOUT DISPARITIES IN CARE OF-
MEDIC BENEFICIARIES ON THIS WE
WOULD SUGGEST THAT THE
LEGISLATURE CONSIDER EXTENDING
THIS BENEFIT TO HEALTH CENTERS-
IN ADDITION YOU KNOW THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS STILL NOT
RELEASED A FISCAL IMPACT OF ITS
MEDICARE TELEHEALTH PROPOSAL.
YOU KNOW WE FIND THAT THERE IS
SIGNIFICANT POTENTIAL THAT THE
PROPOSAL WILL RESULT IN
ADDITIONAL ONGOING COSTS GIVEN
THE LIKELIHOOD OF INCREASE
SERVICE UTILIZATION. AS A
RESULT OF TELEHEALTH EXPANSION-
THE RELEASE OF THE FISCAL
ESTIMATE WOULD BE IMPORTANT FOR
THE LEGISLATURE TO MAKE AN
INFORMED DECISION ON THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL- FINALLY WE
FIND THAT YOU KNOW GIVEN
OUTSTANDING QUESTIONS REMAIN
SURROUNDING SERVICE QUALITY THE
IMPACT OF PAYMENT RATES ON.
SERVICE ACCESS AND OVERALL
FISCAL IMPACT WHEN IT COMES TO
TELEHEALTH SERVICE EXPANSIONS-
WE DO STILL FIND THAT
ESTABLISHING A MEDIC CAL
TELEHEALTH POLICY ON A
PERMANENT BASIS REMAINS.
PREMATURE ONE OPTION THAT THE
LEGISLATURE COULD CONSIDER
WOULD BE TO ADD A SUNSET DATE-
PERHAPS SEVERAL YEARS INTO THE
FUTURE TO THE PROPOSED
STATUTORY CHANGE WHICH WOULD
IMPLEMENT THIS PROPOSAL TO
ALLOW FOR. I'M SORT OF AN
EVALUATION OF THE PROPOSED
POLICY AND PROVIDE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO RECONSIDER THE
STATE'S ONGOING MEDICARE
TELEHEALTH POLICY. AS MORE
INFORMATION PARTICULARLY AROUND
SERVICE UTILIZATION- AND THE
IMPACT OF PAYMENT RATES ON ON
UTILIZATION ACCESS TO CARE AND
BECOMES MORE AVAILABLE. I THOSE
ARE ALL OF OUR OFFICES COMMENTS
AT THIS TIME BUT HAPPY TO SORT
OF PROVIDE FURTHER ASSISTANCE
WHERE NEEDED. OKAY THERE'S A
THAT THAT SUNSET MAKES A MAKES
A LOT OF SENSE TO ME I THINK
WHEN WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE
ALL WE'RE STILL FINDING OUT SO
MUCH. ABOUT TELEHEALTH AND THE
EFFECTIVENESS AND THE ISSUES
AROUND ACCESS- AS FAR AS IT
RELATES TO TECHNOLOGY- AND I
KNOW WHAT THE CLINICS HAVE NOT
BEEN PLEASED BUT- ALSO WE ARE
ALSO VERY PLEASED THAT. THAT
THE GOVERNOR HEARD THE
MINISTRATION HEARD LOUD AND
CLEAR AFTER JANUARY PROPOSAL
THAT- THAT IT PROBABLY WASN'T
GOOD TO JUST TAKE OUT AUDIO ALL
THE WAY- BUT WE'RE STILL NOT AT
AT PARITY WITH THAT SO I THINK
THESE THAT THAT'LL BE A TOPIC
FOR ONGOING CONVERSATIONS. BUT
I DO LIKE THE IDEA OF A SUNSET
DR PAN. YEAH IT'S- POLICY THIS.
IS BETTER THAN WAS ORIGINALLY
POSE FOR WE DON'T HAVE AUDIO
BUT I I'M I'M CONCERNED THIS-
DOESN'T GO FAR ENOUGH- FOR A
COUPLE REASONS- YOU KNOW- SO
MOST OF POORLY ACTUALLY IS AN
ACCESS ISSUE- WE KNOW THAT.
DURING CODED BUT EATEN WHAT WE
LEARNED FROM THE CALL THAT I
SHOULD SAY IS THAT- THAT.
PEOPLE HELP- WE HAVE RIGHT
ACCESS AS SHE IN SOME WAYS
BECAUSE WE WERE ABLE TO PROVIDE
AUDIO- TOO MANY MORE PEOPLE-
PARTICULAR PEOPLE ARE
VULNERABLE RIGHT IN THAT IT
ACTUALLY PEOPLE POINTED OUT
WHAT WE'RE DOING TELEHEALTH HOW
IMPORTANT WAS THAT WE INCLUDED
AUDIO ONLY BECAUSE YOU HAVE A
LOT OF. I MEAN OTHERWISE TELL
ME WHAT WHAT IS CALLED
TELEHEALTH AND- IT ENDED UP AND
IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT EQUIPMENT
AT THE PROVIDER AND IT'S A
MEDICAL AT THE EQUIPMENT THAT
THE PERSON HAS AT THE OTHER END
RIGHT- AND WHAT THEY HAVE
AVAILABLE BUT ALSO IT HAS TO DO
WITH THINGS LIKE PRIVACY. RIGHT
SO YOU'RE YOU'RE HOLED UP WITH
SOMEBODY AND THE NOW YOU HAVE
TO GO TO A COMPUTER WITH A
VIDEO WELL AND IF YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT SOMETHING VERY
SENSITIVE LIKE REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH OTHER TYPES OF THINGS
IT'S HARD TO MAINTAIN PRIVACY
IS SOMEONE CAN'T. OVER HERE ARE
LOOK OVER YOUR SHOULDER AND SEE
WHAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
RIGHT- YOU OF THOSE SSUES-
THAT THE OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
THINGS LIKE THAT GREAT SO-
AUDIO ONLY GIVES YOU MORE TOOLS
AND ALSO IMPROVE PRIVACY
ACCESS. AND WE LEARNED THAT
DURING COLD AND SO WE'RE KIND
OF DISCOURAGING THAT NOW THAT
KIND OF ACCESS. THE OTHER PART
IS PERHAPS MORE VOTES LONG
STANDING- BUT GREAT ABOUT AND
HEALTH CARE IS THAT HOW WE
ALWAYS SEEM TO UNDERVALUE
COGNITIVE SERVICES. AND THAT
THIS IS A CHALLENGE OF RUN INTO
PRIMARY CARE RIGHT. PROCEDURES
ARE OFTEN VERY WELL REIMBURSED
BUT- COGNITIVE SERVICE AND TO
FIND KIND OF IRONIC BECAUSE
I'LL TELL YOU WHEN I GO. GET
LEGAL ADVICE. MY ATTORNEY- I
SEEM TO GET BILL WHEN I ON THE-
FOR THE AMOUNT OF TIME I TALK
TO ACCOUNTANT. THING YET
DISPOSITION AND I GET YOU KNOW
THE PEDIATRICIAN I GET PHONE
CALLS FROM PATIENTS- FOR SOME
REASON THAT'S WOULD BE FREE. IS
IT. THE AMOUNT OF TRAINING I'VE
HAD NOT HAD VALUE. WHY IS IT.
WHY DON'T WE VALUE THAT
KNOWLEDGE THAT PRIMARY CARE
KNOWLEDGE THE SAME WAY AND SO
WE WONDER WHY DOCTORS GO INTO
SPECIALTIES AND NOT INTO
PRIMARY CARE- AND THAT IS SO- I
THINK WE SENT WERE SENDING OUT
WELL MOST IMPORTANTLY THE
ACCESS ISSUE I MEAN IT'S NOT
ABOUT IT'S NOT ABOUT THE
PROVIDERS IT'S MORE ABOUT THE
PATIENTS BUT BUT I THINK WE
ALSO THINK WE CAN MESSAGE WE
SENT TO YOU KNOW AND WE TALK
ABOUT WHAT WE WANT TO REDUCE
HEALTHCARE COSTS WILL GET MORE
PRIMARY CARE SUPPORT AND FOR
GOD SAKES THAN. WHAT YOU VALUE
PRIMARY CARE THEN TELL US WHAT
WE'RE WORSE TAYLOR SAID FOR THE
THINGS WE DO RIGHT AND NOT WHAT
WE WORTH A TASTE FOR THE THINGS
WE DID WITH THAT EXPERTISE IS
IMPORTANT AND- SO YOU KNOW IT'S
NOT 65% SHOULD BE 100% AT THE
THEN OF COURSE IF WE THINK
ABOUT CLINICAL JUDGMENT SO
NEEDS TO BE FACE TO FACE IN
FRONT US TO DO AN EXAM THEN
THAT SHOULD BE OUR CALL. RIGHT
FOR US TO PROVIDE THE SERVICE
IF YOU THINK WE'RE TRYING TO
TEACH YOU IN THAT WAY THEN WE
HAVE ANOTHER CONVERSATION WE
NEED TO HAVE. OTHERWISE IT
SHOULD BE UP TO OUR JUDGMENT AS
TO. WHAT WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO
DO TO PROVIDE THE QUALITY OF
CARE TO THE PATIENTS. AND- AND
CERTAINLY SHOULD BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THAT BUT WE
SHOULD BE ASSUMING UP IN THE
FRONT BY SAYING ALL WE ONLY GET
65% THAT WE'RE PROVIDING LOWER
QUALITY CARE JUST BECAUSE
SOMEONE'S OVER THE PHONE. AND
SO THE I GUESS THAT'S MY ISSUE
WITH THIS PROPOSAL WHICH IS
AGAIN IMPROVING FROM JANUARY
BUT- YOU KNOW I. I I'M
CONCERNED THAT- IS THAT FIRST
OF ALL WE'RE- NOW GOING TO TAKE
AWAY ACCESS FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE
ABLE TO GET ACCESS BECAUSE WE
WERE ABLE TO FINALLY. PROVIDE
THIS LEVEL OF ACCESS THROUGH.
TELL THE TO TELEHEALTH THROUGH
AUDIO ONLY- AND THEN ALSO- WE
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO ALSO
SEND THE RIGHT KIND OF MESSAGE
ABOUT. HOW WE VALUE THE YOU
KNOW HOW WE RELATIVELY VALUE
VERY SERVICE AND BY THE WAY
BEHAVIORAL ALTURAS OF SUCH
ABOUT PRIMARY CARE DOCTORS
RIGHT. IT'S ABOUT BEHAVIOR
HEALTH SO IF WE PROVIDE
COUNSELING OVER THE PHONE
THROUGH AUDIO ONLY. IF WE CAN'T
DOES THAT NOW SIXTY ONLY 65% OF
THE- FOR SOME REASON I MEAN I'M
NOT SURE M. OUT. VISUAL MADE
HELP BUT I'M NOT SURE THAT
AUTOMATICALLY DROPPED THAT MUCH.
AND AGAIN SOME DAY THERE'S AN
ACCESS ISSUE WHEN THAT
SENSITIVE- SO THAT THOSE ARE
ISSUES THAT I'M I'M REALLY
CONCERNED ABOUT IN TERMS OF
SAYING THAT WE SHOULD JUST DO
65% FOR- IS A RATE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIDE. I DON'T THINK
THERE'S A QUESTION I THINK IT
WAS JUST A THINGS FOR THINGS
FOR YOU TO HEAR. AND I WOULD
AGREED AS A BEHAVIOR HEALTH
PROVIDER SOMETIMES- PEOPLE'S
ANXIETY OR CONDITION BECAUSE
THE IT IS VERY HARD FOR THEM TO
MAKE EYE CONTACT AND- AND THE
PHONE IS A MUCH BETTER WAY AND
WE'VE WE'VE COME TO UNDERSTAND
THAT- WAS ZOOMING IN SCHOOL
SOME KIDS JUST DON'T WANT TO
HAVE THE CAMERA ON BECAUSE-
THAT- LIKE WITH THE BACKGROUND
LOOKS LIKE IN YOUR ROOMS
PERHAPS OR- WHEREVER THERE
HAPPENED TO BE SITTING- SO- WE
KNOW THAT THE- THE- SCHOOLS ARE
STILL. YOU KNOW I MEAN IT
DOESN'T COUNT OF SOMEONE'S
CAMERAS OFFER ON. THEM SO
ANYWAY OKAY MOVING ON TO ISSUE
NUMBER. ELEVEN MEDICATION
THERAPY MANAGEMENT PROGRAM. OF
THE NEIGHBOR VISION INCLUDES
TWELVE MILLION TOTAL FUNDS FOUR
MILLION GENERAL FUNDS TO
IMPLEMENT. A MEDICATION THERAPY
MANAGEMENT PROGRAM FOR
SPECIALTY PHARMACY SERVICES
EFFECTIVE JULY ONE OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. D. ADD MEDICATION
THERAPY MANGEMENT. IS
ADJUSTING SERVICE FOR OUR GROUP
OF SERVICES PROVIDED BY
PHARMACISTS AND IS. ESPECIALLY
EFFECTIVE FOR PATIENTS WITH
COMPLEX MEDICATION THERAPIES. I
PRESCRIPTION COSTS- OR HAVING
OTHER RISK FACTORS THAT MAY
RESULT IN THEM- A PATIENT'S
COMPLIANCE OR INSURANCE BUT
THEIR MEDICATION. A
COMPREHENSIVE MEDICATION
MANAGEMENT- ART THERAPY
MANAGEMENT SERVICE MODEL
CONTAINS FIVE KEY ELEMENTS. OF
MEDICATION THERAPY REVIEW OF
THE BENEFICIARIES CURRENT
MEDICATION A CREATION OF A
PERSONAL A MEDICATION RECORD.
DEVELOPMENT OF THE MEDICATION
RELATED ACTION PLAN. ONGOING
INTERVENTIONS AND OR REFERRALS
TO OTHER CORPORATE HEALTH CAREPROVIDERS AND DOCUMENTATION OF
ALL ACTIONS PROVIDED BY THE
PHARMACY AND ASSOCIATED
FALLOUT. AND. HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH HELLO. WE
CONDUCT A PER REVIEW AND HAVE
NO CONCERNS AT THIS TIME THANK
YOU BUT THE THING IS. OKAY
THANK YOU MOVING ON ISSUE
NUMBER TWELVE. RIGHT I'M SO
COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKERS OF THE
BUDGET INCLUDES- COST OF
SIXTEEN POINT THREE MILLION
TOTAL FUNDS- SIX POINT TWO
MILLION GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO FOR COMMUNITY
HEALTH WORKERS DCS IS PROPOSING
TO ADD COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKERS
AND I TO THE CLASS OF SKILLED
AND TRAINED- INDIVIDUALS WERE
ABLE TO PROVIDE CLINICALLY
APPROPRIATE MEDICARE COVERED
BENEFITS AND SERVICES YOU MANY
HEALTH WORKERS ARE SICK- YOU
KNOW HEALTH EDUCATORS WHO WORK
DIRECTLY WITH INDIVIDUALS AND
FAMILIES WHO MAY HAVE
DIFFICULTY UNDERSTANDING OR
INTERACTING WITH HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS DUE TO CULTURAL OR
OTHER LANGUAGE BARRIERS IN CAN
ASSIST WITH THOSE INDIVIDUALS
BY HELPING THEM NAVIGATE. THE
RELATIONSHIPS WITH THE
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS ASSIST
THEM IN ASSESSING HEALTH CARE
SERVICES PROVIDING VITAL HEALTH
EDUCATION AND CONNECTING
INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES WITH
OPPORTUNITY BASED RESOURCES OUR
COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKERS CAN
OFTEN BRIDGE GAPS IN
COMMUNICATION AND REDUCED
HEALTH AND MENTAL HEALTH
DISPARITIES EXPERIENCED BY
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES IN
CALIFORNIA WE ARE PROPOSING TO
IMPLEMENT THIS BENEFIT IN
JANUARY ONE OF TWENTY TWENTY
TWO- AND DO YOU THINK IT IS A
CRITICAL AS WE ARE LOOKING TO
YOU IN ADD BENEFITS AND CLOSE
DELIVERY SYSTEM GAPS IN REGARDS
TO IMPROVING HEALTH INEQUITIES
WITHIN THE MEDICARE PROGRAM AND
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THAT YOU MAY HOUSE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ILLEGAL. THANK YOU
MADAM AGAIN HAVE NO AND FOLLOW
ARE PRETTY. OR THANK YOU IT
DEPENDS. AND THIS IS ONE. THE
GIRLS. AN AGREEMENT ON THIS
OKAY. ISSUE NUMBER THIRTEEN
SEVENTEEN- SAN MATEO COUNTY AND
I WILL SAY AT THE STAFF WAS
BRIEFED ME ON THIS AND SEE THAT
WE GOT FROM YOU SAN MATEOCOUNTY AS A PILOT PLACE OF
COURSE I SAID SAN MATEO COUNTY
IS NOT SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY SO HE
PICKED A NICE ONE FOR ALL THE
PILOTS BUT THEN YOU GOT TO
EXPAND INTO THE REST THE STATE
SO ANYWAY LET'S HEAR ABOUT THE
SAN MATEO COUNTY DENTAL
INTEGRATION. PILOT YOUR STAFF
ARE CORRECT WE OFTEN DO YOU USE
SAN MATTEO A PILOT BUT I THINK
IT IS REFLECTIVE OF THE
DEDICATION FROM. THE STAFF AND
THE LEADERSHIP THERE IS THE
IDEA HEALTH PLAN AND- GIVE THEM
THE KUDOS FOR THAT BUT- AND YES
THE BUDGET- DOES INCLUDE AT SIX
HUNDRED NINETY SEVEN THOUSAND
TOTAL FUNDS- TWO HUNDRED
EIGHTY. THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED
FIFTY GENERAL FUND TO IMPLEMENT
A DENTAL INTEGRATION PILOT WITH
HEALTH PLAN OF SAN MATTEO. OF
PURSUANT TO S. B- EIGHT FORTY
NINE- THAT WAS PASSED IN TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHTEEN. OF THE
FISCAL IMPACT REFLECTS
DIFFERENCES IN THE TIMING OF
PAYMENTS BETWEEN THE FEE FOR
SERVICE AND MANAGED CARE
DELIVERY SYSTEM. NOT
DIFFERENCES IN COST BETWEEN THE
TWO DELIVERY SYSTEMS. I'M HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE. THANK YOU ARE. HELLO
HELLO MADAM CHAIR- WE NO
CONCERNS WITH THIS PROPOSAL AND
LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING THAT
THE- HOW EFFECTIVE THE
SATISFIED IN TRANSFORMATION IS
IN THE FUTURE THANK YOU FOR THE
LOVELY SAN MATEO COUNTY ON THE
COASTAL STATE PARKS. THE THIRD.
THANK YOU CERTAINLY IN SUPPORT
OF THIS PILOT AND SAN MATTEO
COUNTY BUT I WILL TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO ACTUALLY ASK
ABOUT MY AGE DISTRICTS
SACRAMENTO COUNTY BECAUSE I
KNOW THAT IT GUESTS AND THE
PROPOSAL IT'S NOT CLEAR FIGHT
IN THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL WE
HAVE DENTAL MANAGED CARE IN THE
COUNTY I KNOW THAT IT'S HAD A
SOMEWHAT CHEQUERED HISTORY
ALTHOUGH. AT LEAST TO DATE AT
THIS POINT TIME THE DENTAL
COMMUNITY ACTUALLY SUPPORTS
MAINTAINING DENTAL MANAGED CARE
THAT THAT CHANGES ALSO WE GET
BACK TO YOU- BUT YET I
UNDERSTAND THAT THE PROPOSAL IS
TO ELIMINATED IN SACRAMENTO
COUNTY SO CAN WE CLARIFY THAT.
THAT IS VERY. DR OKAY B. YOUR
UTILIZATION RATE SONG IN OUR
VIEW HAVE BEEN YOU KNOW
CONSISTENTLY LOWER AND THEN THE
FEE FOR SERVICE- DENTAL PROGRAM
AND IN THE PRIOR YEAR TWENTY
TWENTY THE PANDEMIC HERE. ALL
SO SIGNIFICANT DIFFERENCE IN
UTILIZATION HOME GIVEN THE
ADDED COST OF. WHICH CARE
MOBILE HOME THIS WE DON'T WE
DON'T CONSIDER JUSTIFIABLE TO
CONTINUE. OKAY WELL- THAT BE
INTERESTED IN LOOKING AT THE
INFORMATION BUT I THINK- THAT I
DO HAVE BEEN SOME CONCERNS
GIVEN THE FACT THAT THE DENTAL
COMMUNITY AND- AT LEAST MY
COUNTIES AS EXPRESS TODAY
ACTUALLY WHEN AND I KNOW WE'VE
HAD BACK AND FORTH ABOUT THIS
ACTUALLY ORIGINALLY WANTED TO
GET RID OF IT NOW WE WANT TO
KEEP IT- AND- SO I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT WE HAVE A MORE OF A
DIALOGUE ABOUT IT- ANTENNA AND
GET TO BUY INTO THE DENTAL
COMMUNITY- SO- FIVE TO MINUTES
TO. RIGHT NOW I DO HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT ENDING IT I I'VE
SEE YOU KNOW I THINK WC THE SAN
MATTEO PILOT IS AN EXAMPLE OF
HOW IT LOOKS LIKE YOU KNOW
THEY'RE MOVING PEOPLE INTO
MANAGED CARE. AND APPRECIATE
THE POWER. FOR EACH YEAR TO TRY.
ACTUALLY HAVE A BETTER HANDLE
OVER- MANAGED CARE IN
SACRAMENTO COUNTY OVERALL-
WHICH IS BEEN HIM. DIFFERENT AS
WELL GIVEN THE FACT THAT WERE A
YOU KNOW A- A- GEOGRAPHIC
MANAGED CARE COUNTY BUT- ON THE
DENTAL SIDE- I. GUESS I WOULD
ASK THAT- WE'D NOT. BEATS WELL
THAT'S THAT'S WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK TOGETHER AND- NOT MAKE
CHANGES THAT- MAY NOT BE
SUPPORTED BY THE LOCAL
COMMUNITY. SO WITH THAT- SO
ANYWAY THIS IS ONE BE SURE
BROUGHT THAT UP AND HOPEFULLY
WE CAN TALK ABOUT THAT. THANKS
THANK YOU. OKAY WELL THAT
CONCLUDED I WOULD THINK- MISTER
WHITE BORN IN MISS COOPER I
THINK THAT CONCLUDES AS PART OF
THE AGENDA FOR US TODAY WE
THANK YOU FOR ALL YOUR WORK ON
THE SAME DAY LMAO AND- AND THE
DEPARTMENT FINANCE AS WELL AND
NOW WE WILL TURN TO OUR PHONE
LINES- THE MODERATOR. ARE YOU
THERE. I AM HERE MADAM CHAIR.
OKAY AND I'M GONNA ASK WHAT
PEOPLE I'M GOING TO ASK PEOPLE
BEFORE THEY BEGIN PUBLIC
COMMENTS TO PLEASE TRY TO KEEP
YOUR COMMENT TO ONE MINUTE. AND
IF YOU FIND THAT YOU ARE
READING TALKING POINTS THAT ARE
REDUNDANT OF SOMEONE WHO SPOKE
BEFORE YOU I'M I WILL ASK US TO
MOVE ON. OKAY SO LET'S USE THIS
TIME JUDICIOUSLY. YOU ARE YOUR
INPUT IS VERY IMPORTANT TO US
AND WE DO WANT TO HEAR-
MODERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN THE
LINE. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT TODAY
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
THAT COMMAND AGAIN. ONE ZERO.
AND A LINE THIRTY TO HEAR MY
COULD OPEN. AFTERNOON I'M KELLY
BROOKS I WILL BE TESTIFYING ON
TWO ISSUES FIRST ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PUBLIC HOSPITALS AND HEALTH
SYSTEMS URBAN COUNTIES CAUCUS.
SANTA CLARA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS THE RIVERSIDE
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN
THE VENTURA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS WE SUPPORT THE
THREE HUNDRED MILLION PROVIDED
TO PUBLIC HOSPITALS IN THE MAY
REVISION PUBLIC HEALTH CARE.
SYSTEM EXPERIENCED A DRAMATIC
INCREASE IN THE NUMBER OF
MEDICAL PATIENTS REQUIRING
COBIT NINETEEN HOSPITALIZATION
PARTICULARLY THOSE REQUIRING
CARE INTENSIVE CARE UNIT
ACCORDING TO STATE REPORTS THIS
IS MANIFESTLY TRUE FOR MEDICAL
FEE FOR SERVICE PATIENTS WHICH
INCLUDE UNINSURED INDIVIDUALS
THAT SIGNED UP FOR COVERAGE
COVERAGE WILL GETTING CARE
UNDOCUMENTED INDIVIDUALS WITH
FUNDED GOT MEDICAL COVERAGE AND
OTHER POPULATIONS THAT ARE
CARVED OUT OF MANAGED CARE.
PUBLIC HOSPITALS HAVE BEEN
CRITICAL IN CALIFORNIA'S
RESPONSE EFFORTS BY EXPANDING
SURGE CAPACITY TO MEET AN
INFLUX OF THE NINETEEN POSITIVE
PATIENTS ASSISTING WITH THE
BACK BACK IN DEPLOYMENT AND
HELPING CALIFORNIA ACHIEVE AN
EQUITABLE DISTRIBUTION OF OUR
VACCINE WHEN I THINK THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR INVESTING IN
OUR SYSTEM. SECOND ON THE TELE
HEALTH ISSUE I'M TESTIFYING ON
BEHALF OF THE EIGHT PH AND THE
URBAN COUNTY THE CALIFORNIA THE
ADMINISTRATION TRAILER BILL
DOES NOT INCLUDE A TRANSITION
PERIOD FOR TELEPHONE BUT THAT
ARE ACTUALLY QUALIFIED HEALTH
CENTERS WHICH PUBLIC HOSPITALS
OPERATE TELEPHONE VISITS WILL
LIKELY FEATURE A COUPLE OF
YEARS AND SOME ALTERNATE.
METHODOLOGIES IN PLACE WE HAVE
A LOT MORE LEARN ABOUT THE NEW
ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT METHODOLOGY
METHODOLOGY STRUCTURE WE
ENCOURAGE THE STATE TO ENGAGE.
FURTHER WE URGE THE LEGISLATURE
TO USE AT THIRTY TWO AT THE
MODEL BUT THE TELEHEALTH
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MODERATOR CAN YOU. TELL ME HOW
MANY CALLS ONLINE. RIGHT NOW WE
HAVE. THIRTY NINE. ON THE RIGHT
LINE. AND WE- APPROXIMATELY
EIGHT PEOPLE ON THE ADA LINE.
THANK YOU WHY WE HAVE ON PEOPLE
AT THE LINE I WONDER. COULD I
GOT ISSUE ONE. OR THEY JUST IN
THE WRONG QUEUE. NO I SHOW-
ABOUT EIGHT PEOPLE ON THAT LINE
AND THEN FORTY ONE NOW ON THE
OTHER OKAY ALL RIGHT NEXT COLOR
PLEASED WITH THE EIGHTY LIKE
EIGHTY LINE FIRST PERHAPS. I
CAN DO THAT OKAY. BLIND TWENTY
ONE YEAR MY COULD OPEN. VENTURE
MEMBERS W. ON BEHALF HE W. I.
NAY AND JUMPED ON THE WRONG
LINE HERE THANK YOU FOR THE
HEARING TODAY WE SUPPORT OUR
THREE CDA ISSUED AN ITEM FORTY
ONE SEVENTY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I WOULD GUESS
THAT MIGHT BE THE EXPERIENCE
FOR MANY SO OKAY NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. BLIGHTED. THIRTY FIVE.
MADAM CHAIR FRED MADE ON BEHALF
OF OUR BASE THE PROGRAM FOR ALL
INCLUSIVE CARE FOR THE ELDERLY
AND WE WOULD LIKE TO. SUPPORT
AT TWO ITEMS IN ISSUE THREE
PARTICULARLY FOR THE DEPARTMENT
OF AGING SENIOR NUTRITION AND
THE AGING DISABILITY RESOURCE
CENTERS IT IS VERY IMPORTANT
FOR PATIENTS TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE OUR JUNIOR POPULATIONS
WITH ADEQUATE. FOOD
REQUIREMENTS AND THEN THEY A.
D. R. C.'S PROVIDED NO WALK
WRONG YOUR APPROACH TO
CONNECTING SENIORS AND PERSONS
WITH DISABILITIES WITH NEEDED
SERVICES INCLUDING PAGE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE. LINE.
THIRTY EIGHT. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
FARADAY TANG ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES I'D LIKE TO COMMENT ON
SEVERAL ISSUES I WILL BE FREE-
ISSUE FOUR ONE TWO ZERO M. BELL
WITH THE FOR ALL FIVE ISSUES-
SUPPORT FOR THE EMERGENCY
MEDICAL SERVICES AUTHORITY
HELPS OUR LOCAL MUMS OPERATE UP
BETTER AND WE ALSO LOOK FOR
SUPPORT ENDEMIC READY MIX AND
CAPACITY- ITEMS WITHIN THEIR-
IN ISSUE ITEM UP FOUR TO SIX
ZERO THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES. ISSUED BY THE
CHILDREN AND YOUTH BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH INITIATIVE WE ARE WIDELY
SUPPORTIVE OF THIS PROPOSAL IS
VERY EXCITED ABOUT IT HOWEVER
MANY MANY MANY DETAILS- NEED TO
BE NAILED DOWN- I WOULD NOTE
THAT- COUNTIES TYPICALLY
SERVICE THE AIR TRAFFIC
CONTROLLER- IN THAT NOT ONLY DO
WE RUN THE CHILDREN ESPECIALLY
MENTAL HEALTH PROGRAM BUT WE
ALSO RUN OTHER PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES ACROSS THE COUNTY
FINAL ALL THAT WILL BE HELPFUL
IN UNDERSTANDING HOW TO LAYER
THE FUNDING ON TOP OF THE
EXISTING FOUNDATIONS. OF COURSE
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH SCHOOL
HEALTH PLAN COMMUNITY BASED
PROVIDERS AND OTHER PARTNERS
ALTHOUGH I WILL BECAUSE THE
COMMON ISSUE SIX THE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH CONTINUE ON
INFRASTRUCTURE PROPOSAL I'M
VERY EXCITED ABOUT THAT WELL-
DOUBLING THE AMOUNT OF FUNDING
AVAILABLE IS JUST INCREDIBLY
EXCITING AND AGAIN- THE DEVIL
WILL BE IN THE DETAILS WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION ON THE.
LEGISLATURE TO HASH THE THAT.
ISSUES HUNDRED DOLLARS IN ONE
FUNDING PUBLIC HOSPITALS-
SUPPORTIVE OF THIS AND
COLLEAGUE MS BURKE I THINK. THE
QUITE CLEARLY ON THAT. AND IF
YOU EIGHT IN THE CALENDAR
PULLED- AGAIN WOULD OF. AND
LIKE TO NOTE THAT COUNTIES ARE
SO. OF THE HALF PROPOSED.
WRITING- UP TO TWO HUNDRED
MILLION FOR. TO A JAIL WARM
HAND OFF AND I. YOU CAN REACH.
ARE PART INMATE AND AGAIN CAP
ARE THE ONES THAT NOT ONLY
OPERATE THE JAIL BLOCK WITH
ELIGIBILITYFOR MEDICAL. AND
OTHER CORE FUNCTIONS AND SO- WE
ARE SUPPORTIVE OF THE PROPOSAL
AND LOOK FOR TO WORKING OUT
THOSE DETAILS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU VERY. MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. BLIND. FORTY
ONE. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
JOHN PRATT I AM PROUD TO DO IT
BUT WHAT WE CAN CALIFORNIA ALL
I CAN SAY THAT MY YOUNGER
BROTHER AND I ARE BOTH OKAY
THANK YOU AND CONSUMERS OF THE
HARBOR REGIONAL CENTER I MEAN
ACCESS TO MUCH NEEDED SERVICES
DURING A PANDEMIC I'VE BEEN
CRITICAL FOR PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES LIKE ME. I AM
GRATEFUL COMMITTEE HAS BEEN
DISCUSSING WHAT PROPOSED TO
ADDRESS. THE NEEDS OF MY
COMMUNITY. I AM CONCERNED THE
DISK. IN EQUITY AND QUALITY OF
SERVICES. A SERVICE ESPECIALLY
FOR CONSUMERS OF COLOR I
RESPECTFULLY INSIST THAT
MONITORING AND EVALUATION OF
PROGRAMS INCLUDING TO EXPANSION
OF SELF DETERMINATION SUPPORT
BE CONDUCTED. EXACTLY AT THE
MENTAL HEALTH CONDITION DOES
ADDRESSED THE A SUPPORT
ENSURING IT P. ALL I COULD
STATE I'M GLAD ABOUT. FOR YOU
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH BEING LINKED
WITH THE POOREST SCHOOLS. BUT I
CONCERNED THE INSURANCE SCHOOL
ARE BEING TOO MANY CALIFORNIANS
EXCUSE ME NOT BE ABLE TO
UTILIZE MEDICARE BENEFITS TO
ACCESS SERVICES IN THE
COMMUNITY OUTSIDE OF SCHOOL. I
REACHES TO ADDRESS THESE ISSUES
AND CONTINUE TO SUPPORT MY
VULNERABLE COMMUNITY DIRECTOR
DAMMIT AND INTO THE FUTURE
PLEASE DO NOT FORGET US THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. BLIND. FORTY
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS THIS IS
JULIE SNYDER WITH THE STEINBERG
INSTITUTE- WE WERE SPEAKING ON
THE ATSC ISSUES FIVE AND SIX
REGARDING BEHAVIORAL HEALTH FOR
YOU AND INFRASTRUCTURE- WE VERY
MUCH SHARE THE CHEERS
EXCITEMENT AT THIS
UNPRECEDENTED OPPORTUNITY TO
INCREASE TREATMENT. ESPECIALLY
FOR CHILDREN AND YOUTH KNOWING
THAT ROUGHLY THREE QUARTERS A
MENTAL HEALTH CONDITION APPEAR
BEFORE AGE TWENTY FIVE AND THAT
EARLY DIAGNOSIS AND TREATMENT
CAN GREATLY IMPROVE LONG TERM
OUTCOMES AND QUALITY OF LIFE SO
WE ARE REALLY THRILLED TO BE
WORKING WITH YOU ALL IAN TO THE
ADMINISTRATION TO CRAFT THESE
PROPOSALS AND STAND READY TO DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO HELP YOU
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. BY. THIRTY
NINE. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
AMY WEST PLAYING I'M CALLING
FROM THE ASSOCIATION OF
REGIONAL CENTER AGENCIES FIRST
AND FOREMOST WANT TO THANK THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR MANY OF
THESE FORWARD LOOKING PROPOSAL
IN THE GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISE
ALSO WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AS
WELL AS YOUR SPOUSE OR A
COMPREHENSIVE HEARING AND-
BRINGING FORWARD MANY OF THE
CRITICAL ISSUES IN OUR SYSTEM-
WE AGREE WITH THE L. A. L. AS
WELL AS WITH COMMENTS MADE BY
BOTH SENATORS AND MEN AND CAN.
RELATED TO THE NEED TO-
CONSIDER INVESTMENTS FOR
SERVICE COORDINATION AT
REGIONAL CENTERS THIS YEAR
RATHER THAN REFERRING ALL OF
THOSE INVESTMENT IN NEXT YEAR
WE ALSO APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS
AND AGREE WITH THEM RELATED TO
THE NEED FOR REAL INVESTMENT
IN- GREAT REFORM FOR SERVICE
PROVIDERS AS WELL AS MORE
EXPLORATION ABOUT WHAT
TECHNOLOGY NEEDS. HAS DONE HAS
AS THE TECHNOLOGY WE ARE
WORKING WITH IS IT MEDICALLY
AND DIFFICULT TO NAVIGATE
FINALLY IN RESPONSE TO THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE THAT WAS
POSTED THIS MORNING- OR IT
BLACK KNIGHT RELATED TO THE
SELF DETERMINATION PROGRAM WE
ARE STILL WORKING TO DIGEST IT
AND DEVELOP A POSITION RELATED
TO IT BUT WE LOOK FORWARD TO
EXPLORING HOW TO ENHANCE THE
SUCCESS OF THE SELF
DETERMINATION AND A LONG TERM
STABILITY AND APPRECIATE THE
PARTNERSHIP WITH. BMI JUST
LATER AND THE ADMINISTRATION
AND WILL NEVER THANK YOU. VERY
MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
BLIGHTED FORTY THREE. I'M SURE
MEMBERS AND WE HAVE TO KAISER
PERMANENTE HEY TO COME ON THE
HEALTH MISTER BEIJING BUT ISSUE
AROUND HELPING FROM EXCHANGE.
UNPAID THE MANY REQUESTS FOR
RESOURCES TO CREATE A BIT
COLDER ENGAGEMENT PROCESS. AND
INVESTED IN STATE LEADERSHIP TO
IMPROVE PUBLIC RELATION
EXCHANGE THEM THANK. AND THE-
FOR TAKING THE CORDON NEXT STEP
AND WE ALSO THANK THE SENATE
FOR ADVANCING LEGISLATION ALONG
THESE LINES. RESHAPED THE
AGENCY ACKNOWLEDGING THE
IMPORTANCE OF CONSIDERING
MODELS OF HEALTH INFORMATION
EXCHANGE THAT ARE CONSISTENT
WITH FEDERAL STANDARDS AND
WHILE WE DID TO THE NEW
TECHNOLOGY THAT SUPPORTS THE
ONE STATE WIDE AND NATIONAL
EXCHANGE. WE DO ALSO AGREE WITH
SENATOR HAND COMMENTS ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF CONNECTED HEALTH
INFORMATION SYSTEM THE PUBLIC
HEALTH DATA SYSTEM AND
MODERNIZING THE SYSTEMS TO
IMPROVE COORDINATION
INFORMATION SHARING GOING
FORWARD SHE KEEPS STRONGLY
SUPPORTS. UNIVERSAL IN
OPERABILITY IN EXCHANGE AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO OFFERING OUR
EXPERTISE TO THIS PROCESS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. A LINE FIVE.
GOOD AFTERNOON ANDREA SAN
MIGUEL WITH PLANNED PARENTHOOD
AFFILIATES IN CALIFORNIA I'M
CALLING TO SHARE CONCERNED
ABOUT EACH YEAR ISSUE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION POWER HELP
PROPOSAL- I FIRST WANT TO
APPRECIATE DR CAN'T COMMENT
ABOUT AUDIO APPOINTMENTS
OFFERING PRIVACY FOR PATIENTS
THIS IS CERTAINLY SOMETHING
WE'VE HEARD AGAIN AND AGAIN
FROM GRANDPARENT HEALTH CENTERS
WHO'VE BEEN OFFERING BUT THE
DEAL AND FOUND A POINT MEANT
FOR OVER A YEAR NOW UNDER THE
FLEXIBILITY- AND ALSO JUST ECHO
ALL COMMENTS MADE THAT PLACE
EQUITY AND ACCESS. FOR MEDICARE
BENEFICIARIES AT THE FOREFRONT
OF THE CONVERSATION WHICH IS
WHERE IT SHOULD BE- INDEED. OR-
ON A RELATED LETTER. RE FOUND
THAT MEANS. PARITY EXPAND OUR
TO CARE. AND INCREASED EQUITY
WITH COMMERCIALLY INSURED
PATIENTS- EQUITY BETWEEN MENTAL
HEALTH AND FISHERIES AND THE
COMMERCIAL ONLY- COVERED
INSURANCE. ASIAN PHOTO- WHICH
REALLY JUST ABOUT REDUCING
INCOME DISPARITIES. BETWEEN THE
GROUPS- AFTER YOUR OF. THE
FLEXIBILITY USE THAT HAVE BEEN
IN PLACE. THIS POPOSAL TO USE
A 65% GREAT FOR AUDIO. SIMPLY
BECAUSE THE PATIENT MAY NOT
HAVE ACCESS TO VIDEO OR FEEL
COMFORTABLE USING VIDEO. IS
TANTAMOUNT TO A RATE CUT RCG
NOT PROVIDERS. I'M ALSO JUST A
QUICKLY THAT IT WAS NOT
ADDRESSED IN THE REVISED THAT
WE URGE BUDGET LEADERS TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH- THE PROPOSAL THAT
WAS. SUBMITTED BY SENATOR STERN
AND CALM WATER- AND ALL SEVERAL
STAKEHOLDERS RELATING TO THE
HARMFUL E. PERCENT OF MEDICARE
CAP THAT. RIGHT NOW I'M POSED
ON LAB SERVICES A MEDIC CAL
UNDISTINGUISHED STI TESTS AND-
IT'S REALLY. AN ISSUE FOR CORE
SERVICES I WOULD SAY BECAUSE-
AND HEALTH CENTERS ALONE
PROVIDE ONE POINT FIVE MILLION
NEXT YEAR JUST A YEAR. DID YOU
CALL BACKS- ARE REALLY
UNSUSTAINABLE AND COST MILLIONS
THAT ARE NEED FOR PATIENTS
WITHOUT I JUST WANT TO BRING
THAT UP AGAIN FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR WORK TODAY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SIX COLOR PLEASE.
LINE ONE SIXTY. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS STEP IN
ROWS ON BEHALF OF THE FIRST
FIVE IS THE PATIENT WHICH
REPRESENTS THE FIRST FIVE
COUNTY COMMISSIONS IN ALL FIFTY
COUNTY. TAKING ON PART B. D. HM
DH CS ISSUE FIVE. REGARDING THE
CHILDREN AND YOUTH PAPER HEALTH
INITIATIVE. LIPSTICK AND ROBUST
INVESTMENT IN EARLY CHILDHOOD
IS VERY MUCH NEEDED AND WORKING
ALONGSIDE OTHER EARLY CHILDHOOD
MENTAL HEALTH PARTNERS WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST ONE
HUNDRED TWELVE MILLION OVER
THREE YEARS. TO EXPAND DIRECT
ACCESS TO EARLY CHILDHOOD
MENTAL HEALTH PROGRAMS
NONCRITICAL PUTTING INCLUDING
CHILD CARE HOMES AND
COMMUNITIES. SHARE DR GARY
YESTERDAY. IN YOUR SISTER SPOKE
ABOUT HAVING A MORE DETAILED
CONVERSATION WITH FIRST FIVE.
ON HOW THIS CRITICAL INITIATIVE
APPOINT THE MENTAL HEALTH OF
OUR YOUNG PEOPLE AND THE ADULTS
IN THEIR LIVES. LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING ON THE DETAILS AND VIEW
YOUR STAFF AND HHS ON THE ISSUE
TO INVEST IN THE HOLISTIC
MULTILAYER DURING A PARDON BUT
IN. ADDITIONALLY WE THINK THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
COMMITTEE FOR THEIR COMMITMENT
TO THE CREATION OF. THE DYADIC
CAN DO LIKE CARE BENEFIT.
WEEKLY CHART EGGMAN IN ADVANCE
TWELVE OF CONTINUOUS. BECAUSE
HEALTH CARE COMES. I REQUEST
CHILDREN TO AGE FIVE HAVE BEEN.
COVERAGE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
BLIND. ONE HUNDRED TWO. HI MAN
THIS IS JUDY MARC FROM
DISABILITY VOICES UNITED HAD
I'M NOT HEARING YOU AT THE LAST
HEARING ABOUT THE SELF
DETERMINATION PROGRAM AND THAT
RESTAURANT THAT PEOPLE ARE
DYING TO GET IN SH- WE JUST
READ THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
AND AFTER REACHING NOW ON THE
TOP THE TERMINATION PROGRAM WE
ARE SIGNIFICANT CONCERN SHE
CREATES NEW BUREAUCRATIC
BARRIERS THAT ARE ACTUALLY
LIKELY TO DELAY THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF PROGRAMS AND
INCREASED RACIAL AND ETHNIC
DISPARITIES. I KNOW THAT
DIRECTOR BARS WE TALKED EARLIER
ABOUT. FIFTEEN ABILITY TO
PROGRAM AYE AYE SURE IS
CONCERNED I'M GOING TO WORK
WITH HER ON SHOULD BE TROUBLING
WHICH GOES WAY BEYOND AND
ACTUALLY THE MICROMANAGE
DISABLED PEOPLE'S LIVES SHE
LIVES IN THE BEAST AND THE
CREEPING AUTHORITY ITSELF
DETERMINATION FOR SURE WE
BELIEVE THT THERE SHOULD BE
MORE ACCOUNTABILITY AND
OVERSIGHT IN THE WAY THE
PROGRAM IS BEING IMPLEMENTED
SENATOR LAYERED HAS AUTHORED SB
FIVE ONE EAT WHICH STRUCK OUT
AND APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
THIS MORNING. BUT OF COURSE
IT'S SUBJECT TO APPROPRIATION
FROM THIS BODY AND AN
ESTABLISHES THE OFFICE OF THE
OMBUDSPERSON FOR THE SELF
DETERMINATION. PROGRAM SHOULD
WE HOLD AND LOOK. FOR TO WITH
ON THAT MODEST FOR THE TO A
GREAT DAY THE CHANGES I JUST
WANT TO MAKE THAT THE STATE
BEING FLUSH ON THE GOVERNOR IS
STILL INCLUDED DIRECTOR OF FOR
THE REC PROGRAM SUCH THAT WERE
SUSPENDED IN TWO NINE AND
PARTICULARLY AT PEOPLE OF COLOR.
LEGISLATURE SUPPORTED DEBRA IN
THE PAST WEEKS REQUEST THAT YOU
A THIS FOR THE YEAR THANK YOU
SO MUCH AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT PLEASE. NEEDED IN OUR
COMMUNITIES HAVE PRO FAMILY
INCREASE SINCE THE PANDEMIC
BEGAN. OUR COSTS INCREASE
SIGNIFICANTLY AS WE NEEDED TO
PURCHASE MORE FOOD P. P. P.
HIRE ADDITIONAL PERSONNEL AND
PROCURE MORE DELIVERY VEHICLES
TO MEET THE DEMAND FOR MEALS.
ABA MAINTAINING SAFETY FOR
STAFF AND CLIENTS. FOR THE
FIRST YEAR THE PANDEMIC MILLED
ON THE CALIFORNIA SIDE I NEARLY
75% INCREASE MANY OVER THE
PRIOR YEAR. BARBARA THIRTEEN
THAT OF OUR MEALS ON WHEELS
PROGRAMS IN THE STATE HAVE
INCREASED THEIR NUMBER OF MEALS
SERVED BY MORE THAN ONE ENTERED
PERCENT. ADDITIONALLY GREAT
PLACE TO LIVE- PROGRAMS ARE
WINDING DOWN AND THOUSAND TO
SENIORS WHO ARE PROVIDING GREAT
PLACE WILL BE CONTACTING BUILT
ON WHEELS ORGANIZATIONS FOR
SERVICES. HEARING SACRAMENTO
COUNTY OVER TWO THOUSAND
SENIORS ARE BEING SERVED BY THE
GREAT PLACE PROGRAM WE HAVE
ALREADY STARTED ONBOARDING HIGH
RISK CLIENTS. WE APPRECIATE THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSED
FUNDING OF SEVENTEEN AND A HALF
MILLION ONGOING WITH ADDITIONAL
ONE TIME DOLLARS. YEAH WE DON'T
BELIEVE THIS IS ENOUGH TO MEET
THE NEEDS OF THOSE WE WILL
CONTINUE TO SERVE AS A NUMBER
OF SENIORS WITHOUT FOOD-
EMOTIONAL SUPPORT CONTINUES TO
GROW. ALL OF THESE REASONS NOT
ON WHEELS CALIFORNIA CONTINUES
ADVOCATE FOR DOUBLING THE BASE
AMOUNT TO THIRTY FIVE MILLION
ONGOING. WE'RE PROPOSING FORTY
MILLION IN ONE TIME
INFRASTRUCTURE GRANTS ASSISTING
IN ADDITION PROGRAMS INTO
FILLING THE NEEDS THAT A
COMPANY DRAMATIC INCREASE IN
THE MAIN. INFRASTRUCTURE SUCH
AS MAIL DELIVERY VEHICLES
AVANCE WALK IN REFRIGERATORS
GENERATORS. SUPPORT FOR LEASE
EXPANSIONS AND MUCH MORE WE
SIMPLY CANNOT PRODUCE AND
DELIVER MORE MEALS WITHOUT
THESE ITEMS. FOR THE MOST
VULNERABLE MANY MEMBERS
RESEARCH THE MAILS AND SOCIAL
CONNECTION WE PROVIDE THEM ARE
ALL THAT IS KEEPING THEM. FROM
DEVASTATING HUNGER AND
ISOLATION. WE LOOK TO WORKING
WITH THE LAST. AND TO ENSURE.
THERE IS ADEQUATE FUNDING TO.
FOOD PROGRAMS. FOR SENIORS BUT
ALSO THE- AND THEIR FAMILIES.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. A LINE OF.
ONE HUNDRED THIRTY. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM HAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME'S
MARK BLANTON EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
LIVING NETWORK. CAPE WIDE TRADE
ORGANIZATION WITH OVER ONE
HUNDRED AGENCY PROVIDER MEMBERS
LARGE AND SMALL ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTING SUPPORTED LIVING
INDEPENDENT LIVING EMPLOYMENT
PERSONAL ASSISTANCE AND RESPITE
SERVICES. THE IMPORTANT
SERVICES PROVIDED FACE TO FACE
THROUGHOUT THE PANDEMIC CAN
FEEL AND APPRECIATE THE EFFORTS
TO PROFESSIONALISE THE DIRECT
SUPPORT PROFESSIONAL BURKE PUTS
THE FOCUS ON TRAINING THREE CAN
BE SURE THAT THE CAREER PATH
FOR DSPS COULD SUPPORT OUR
RECRUITMENT RECRUITMENT AND
RETENTION EFFORTS ESPECIALLY
GIVEN OUR CURRENT BURGEONING
WORKFORCE I THINK. THAT YOU
GATHER WE CAN ALIGN WITH FUTURE
TRAINING WITH THE CURRICULUM
NOT WELL TRAINED- DIRECT
SUPPORT PROFESSIONALS THAT THE
COURT PEOPLE WITH ID BE IN
IDENTIFYING AND DEFINING AND
MEASURING SERVICE OUTCOMES THAT
NEED TO CHOSE MY LIFE. WE KNOW
THAT TRAINING ALONE IT'S NOT
UNCOMMON THAT TRAINING MUCH
ABOUT THEM COULD QUALITY OF
SERVICE IS A MUST LEAD TO
INCREASE WAGES A DIRECT SUPPORT
PROFESSIONAL. SENATE BUDGET
REQUESTED TEN MILLION ONE TIME
FUNDING FOR THE MEDIA THE
FALCON PILOT PROJECT WILL BEGIN
THE DATA. DATA DRIVEN PER YEAR.
PILOT LEVINE INCREASE ACROSS OF.
TO PEOPLE WITH ID D. ONE. YOU
BE USING STATEMENT. ADDRESS THE
RACIAL BUT- CONNECT. AND
FUNDING TO THAT HAVE CHALLENGE
AND THEM NUMBER THREE ON THE
PAGES OF THAT WORK WHEN IT
COMES TO PROVIDE A STATE
WELCOME ON BBS UPCOMING WE CAN
DO NOT AGAIN YEAR AND GET
NOTHING OR WRITTEN SOMETHING.
ASIDE FROM A PODIUM NOT
POLITICAL BILL THE MAIL I NEED
SUPPORT AND ALL OF THESE ARE.
OF GOING TO BE. TO RESPECT ASK
SUPPORT THE TEN MILLION DOLLARS
BY REQUIRE. YOU DOES NOT HAPPEN
TO RIGHT NOW. INCREASE IN.
WAGES ECONOMIC DOWN ROAD.
TWELFTH WHICH. FOUR NINE. MEDIA
YOU KNOW WHAT TO JOB IN OAKLAND
ABOUT THE PUNDITS TO CHECK ON
TREE AND- A BUDGET MANY. IN
PROJECTED WAGES A PATH FROM
PARTITION IN TRAINING WHERE THE
CURRICULUM FOR EITHER YET TO
THE BALLOT. THE COMPANY. I
SECOND IN THE BRIEF HOLD A
CHEAP THAT CRITICAL NEED A
COMPETITIVELY JUST. EIGHTY
THREE YEARS AGO THIS WEEK WAIT
ADDRESS RATE COULD I. IRAP OKAY.
THANK YOU I'M WE ASK YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND JUST HER PER
COLORS IF YOU HAVE A VERY LONG
STATEMENT IS VERY BETTER TO
SEND THAT INTO WRITING FOR US
BETTER BE TO BE ABLE TO ADD TO
IT TO GET THE FULL IMPACT OF
YOUR STATEMENT. THANKS CALLER
PLEASE. A LINE OF ONE HUNDRED
THIRTY ONE. MY ABOUT A FEW
CLIENTS FIRST ON BEHALF WHICH
WILL BE AMERICA OPERATION ABOUT
FIVE FIFTEEN OVER THIS WEEK
SHOULDN'T BE IS VERY SUPPORTIVE
OF THE CHILDREN BE ABLE HEALTH
COMMISSION INDIAN ASPECTS
SITUATION BE GIVEN TO THE
COMMISSION PARENT EDUCATION THE
POSITIVE PARENTING PROGRAM
STRENGTH IN ACCOUNTING SKILLS.
SECOND WE HAVE A CARD WE ARE
VERY PLEASED TO THE SUPPORT OF
ISSUE NUMBER THREE THE CURRENT
EXTENSION OF MEDICARE
ELIGIBILITY PROPOSED PARDON
INDIVIDUALS WE'RE STILL VERY
INTERESTED IN DIALOGUE TO
ENSURE ALL PRETTY INDIVIDUALS
BECAUSE THE STATURE ELIGIBLE
AND THAT THEY REMAIN COVERED
BETWEEN THE PROPOSED IN THE
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY ENABLE
TWENTY TWENTY TWO THE PROPOSAL
START OF TO EXTENSION. ON
BEHALF OF CMA AND ELECTION
ISSUE NUMBER TWO AND NUMBER TEN
HEALTH INFORMATION EXCHANGE AND
TELEKINETICALLY ON ISSUE NUMBER
THREE SEED MAN- CHEN LIKE TO
EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSAL THE
STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT FOR THE
HEALTH INFORMATION EXCHANGE ON
ISSUE NUMBER TEN WELL THEY
CREATE EXTENDED FLEXIBILITY FOR
CERTAIN HEALTH SERVICES- TO SEE
MAY REMAIN DEEPLY CONCERNED
WITH ADMINISTRATION PROPOSAL TO
HAVE A SEPARATE REDUCED BE
SCHEDULE. FOR AUDIO ONLY
SERVICES TELESERVICES REIMBURSE
AT PARITY BECAUSE MODALITY AND
WHEN A CURSE THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE TO LOOK TOWARD EIGHTY
THIRTY TO ASK MODEL FINALLY SEE
MAY LINDA SUPPORT TO THE PUBLIC
HEALTH AFTER YOUR QUESTION ON
GOING FUNDING TO BUILD THE
HEALTH INFORMATION OUR HELP
REPUBLICAN OLD INFRASTRUCTURE
IN CC H. I. NAVIGATOR PROGRAM
FOR DUAL ELIGIBLES. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT. CALLER PLEASE. WHITE
ONE TEN. THANK MARTY A MOTOR
I'M MAN AND I'M CARE OF
EXTENDED FAMILY OF A PER WITH A
DOWN SYNDROME- AND ALSO A
MEMBER OF THE OF SERVER HAVE
FORCE OF THE PLAN FOR YOU CAN.
SUBCOMMITTEE JUST ON TO OUR IN
THE INTERESTS OF STRONG SUPPORT
FOR THE CALIFORNIA AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCIES- LANGUAGE
ACCESS PROPOSAL WE THINK IT'S
CRITICAL TO EVERYTHING- THAT IS
IMPORTANT TO PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES AND SENIORS
BECAUSE IT TREATS OR IS
IMPORTANT- IN TERMS OF TREATING
A PERSON. AS A WHOLE PERSON
ACROSS DIFFERENT SYSTEMS- AND
WE AND EVEN THOUGH WE
APPRECIATE THE L. A. L.'S
CONCERNS AND ALL THEIR WORK WE
DO AN URGENT ASSESSMENT NOW IN
LARGE PART BECAUSE TOO OFTEN
THE STATE SPENDS TIME ON
DEVELOPING DETAILS AND PLANS
BUT NEVER FUNDS IT AND- AT THE
RATE STUDY FOR DDS IS A GOOD
EXAMPLE SO WE DEFINITELY URGE
THAT THE LEGISLATURE US SUPPORT.
THIS PROPOSAL LAST WEEK. THE
OTHER MAY REPLY PROPOSED- UNDER
THE- DEVELOPMENT OFFICER NAY.
HAVE CONCERN ABOUT THE SELF.
PROPOSAL THOUGH- AND AGREE WITH
THE CONCERNS RAISED BY THE LA-
ESPECIALLY ON THE ISSUE OF
LEASE COPY PROVIDER- IN IN
EVERY INSTANCE OF THE MAY
REVISE. WE AGREE WITH DR PAN
AND ALSO THE CHAIR. EVERY
PROPOSAL NEEDS REPORTING
MONITORING IMMEASURABLE
OUTCOMES THAT ARE PERSON
CENTERED AND NOT JUST ABOUT
UTILIZATION LAST WEEK IT'S A
BIG THANK YOU TO THE
SUBCOMMITTEE STAFF- TO SCOTLAND
TO RENEW TO FURTHER FOR THE
AGENDAS. AND ALSO THE MEMBERS
OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NICE COLOR
PLEASE. LINE. ONE HUNDRED
FIFTY. HI MY NAME IS KATHY
KELLY EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
BAY AREA CAREGIVER RESOURCE
CENTER. WE WANT TO LEND OUR
SUPPORT TO THE CDA REQUESTING
ISSUES ONE TWO THREE FOUR
INCREASE WEIGHT THE SERGEANTS.
FOR THE SERVICES AND ABSENT A
COURT FOR- EXPANDING SERVICES
TO OLDER ADULTS WE'VE BEEN ABLE
TO OPEN IN CARE UNPAID FAMILY
CAREGIVERS THERE ONE WITH THE
GOAL OF WITH THEIR MIND WITH
AND- STRENGTHENED BUT GOALS OF
THE MASTER PLAN ON AGING THANK
YOU. THANK. YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. BY ANYONE WHO
FIFTY. MEMBERS CAPTAIN OFFERED
UP HAPPEN TO OPEN ONE IF THOUGH
SHE NINE UNTREATED MEDICAL I
SEE A STANDALONE PIECE OF ACUTE
THE DEVELOPMENT OF SERVICES
THAT WILL BRING I BE HOME
AFTERWARDS CARE FOR IT TO THE
WITHIN. DEVELOPMENTAL AND
EVERYTHING PDF PUBLIC UTILITY
PHILIP FACILITIES HELP
MEDICALLY FOR CHILDREN PLAY
ALIVE BE HEALTHY OF THE DEAL
WITH VERY DIFFICULT MEDICAL
CONDITION WHAT THE GOVERNOR'S
ME REVISIONS ELIMINATE THEIR
RATE FREEZE WHICH IS LONG
OVERDUE VERY MUCH APPRECIATE IT
IT ALSO WOULD ELIMINATE AN
URGENT COVERED NINETEEN RATE
ADJUSTMENT AS OF DECEMBER
THIRTY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
THE LITERAL NET IMPACT OF
REMOVAL OF THE RATE FREEZE AND
THE BAY REVISED BETTER
CALIBRATED JUDGMENTS ABOUT ICS
AND PEDIATRIC SUB ACUTE
PROVIDERS A QUICK TO A FLAT
FUNDING FOR OUR HOME AND FOR
OUR SCHEDULE THESE DISTRICTS
ONE OF THE TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO FISCAL YEAR AND WITHOUT
CONTINUATION OF THE COVERT
SUPPLEMENTAL WILL LEAVE US WITH
A RATE CUT. JUST YEAR THIS
WOULD TAKE THESE PROVIDERS TO
THE BRINK OF FINANCIAL DISASTER
ALL OF THE TWELVE YEAR RETREAT
THE CONSUMER PRICE INDEX
INCREASED CLOSE 230% IN THE
RIGHT PLACE TO GET THE
DEPARTMENT TODAY SUGGESTS
PROVIDING A 3% INCREASE FOR
ONLY SIX MONTHS. ONE TO COVERT
THE COLD NINE THE CODE NINE.
RATING WELCOME PROVIDE ARE HOW
PERCENT WERE. ON THAT CAL RIGHT
HAVE BEEN. A TO CONTINUE BASIC.
PROVISIONS TO THE GREAT FOR.
OVER THE LAST AT APPLY HAD. OF
COURSE MORE SO OR SOCCER.
DRAMATICALLY BASED ON TODAY'S
COVER. WITH HOPE THAT COMMITTEE
CAN OPEN TO MORE DISCUSSION ON
THERE. AT THIS POINT. BASED ON
WHAT WE HAVE HEARD FROM THE-
AND WHAT WE IN THEY'RE NOT.
THIS ALTERNATELY BE A RIGHT CUT
THE THIS CALL YOUR FOR BOTH
DEVELOPMENT SERVICES NETWORK.
SHOWS AND HOW AND PEDIATRIC SUB.
PROBLEMS WE ARE CELEJ. TO BE A
SIX ONE SIX. OF THE NINETY
RATED JUST THROUGH JUNE
THIRTIETH TWENTY TWO TWO. THE
TWO ALLOW OUR THE DAY. STAND
EQUAL CUNNINGHAM. AND WE WILL
BUT WE LOOK FORWARD WORKING
WITH THE- OF RIGHT SIZING OVER.
OF WE MOVE FORWARD THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OCTOBER. WE GO A- BONTA
BEFORE WE GO TO THE NEXT WE DO
HAVE SOMEBODY. IN PERSON. TO
TESTIFY SO WE'RE TO GIVE HIM.
HIS PARTNER MANAGER ON BEHALF
IN GOODNESS AN PER DROPPED.
HERE ON TO. FOR ON BEHALF OF L.
A. IS A- I'M HERE TO SEE. US
REQUEST FOR EXTENSION FOR FIVE
YEARS AT THREE MILLION OF YEAR.
FOUR AN LS HOLDS A MODEL OF. OF
CARE FOR PERSONS LIVING WITH A
LS AND THEIR FAMILIES HOWEVER.
AS WE'VE SUBMITTED TO THE
COMMITTEE WE THINK IT'S
ESSENTIAL AND CRITICAL. THAT
THERE BE BUDGET CONTROL
LANGUAGE AND- BUDGET TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE IN THE EVENT ONE
DOES NOT INCLUDE THE OTHER.
THAT SPECIFICALLY OUTLINES THE
PROPORTIONAL DISTRIBUTION OF
THE FUNDING. THAT CALLS FOR
TRANSPARENCY IN REPORTING ON
HOW THE FUNDS ARE SPENT. AND
ACCOUNTABILITY IN TERMS OF
DIRECT GRAN TOURER GRANTEE
RELATIONSHIPS BETWEEN THOSE
THAT MAY EARN A GRANT. AND THE
FUNDING DEPARTMENT IN THIS CASE
THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH. THE REASON IS PRETTY
STRAIGHT FORWARD. OUT OF THE
LAST CYCLE OF FUNDING WHICH OF
ALL OUR CHAPTERS SUPPORTED AND
WORKED HARD TO ACHIEVE. VARIOUS
AREAS OF THE STATE
UNFORTUNATELY INCLUDING THE
TWENTY FOUR COUNTY AREA SERVED
BY- THAT SERVES YOUR DISTRICT
MADAM CHAIR AND CENTER PANTS
DISTRICT. RECEIVED LESS THAN
ONE SEVENTH OF THE FUNDS THAT
WERE PORTION OR ESSENTIALLY THE
EQUIVALENT OF. ONE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS A
YEAR. THREE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
EIGHT THOUSAND DOLLARS OVER THE
THREE YEAR PERIOD. ONE CHAPTER
ALONE RETAINED 87% OF THE
FUNDING. SO WITH THAT WE'D
CERTAINLY HEARD. SUPPORT WITH
APPROPRIATE CONTROLS. VERY
BRIEFLY ALL AS THE PA BUDGET.
ON THE GENETIC THE SCREENING
PROGRAM WE ENCOURAGE THE
COMMITTEE TO CONTINUE ITS
EXAMINATION. OF THE SAVINGS
ASSUMPTIONS ADVANCED BY THE
DEPARTMENT. THAT ARE LARGELY
PREDICATED ON DECLINING CHILD
BIRTH RATES IN THE STATE. TO
ENSURE THAT THE DEPARTMENT IS
NOT UNDER RESOURCE ITS
TRANSITION TO CELL FREE DNA
NONINVASIVE PREGNANCY TESTING
ALMOST CERTAIN TO PRODUCE
BETTER QUALITY RESULTS. AND
SAVINGS OVER THE LONG HAUL WITH
THAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU MISTER VALENCIA. MODERATOR
HOW MANY CALLS IN THE QUEUE AT
THIS POINT. MADAM CHAIR RIGHT
NOW WE HAVE FORTY ONE PEOPLE
WAITING ALL RIGHT AGAIN- COLORS
I WOULD REMIND YOU THAT YOU CAN
ALWAYS EMAIL US YOUR STATEMENTS.
YOU HAVE A LONG STATEMENT TO
MAKE IT'S PROBABLY EASIER FOR
US TO TAKE IT IN IF IT COMES IN
AN EMAIL FORM AND I WOULD ASK
THE NEXT COLOR TO GO AHEAD
PLEASE. LATER. ONE HUNDRED
SIXTY ONE. GOOD AFTERNOON
NICOLE BORNEMANN ON BEHALF OF
THE CHILDREN'S PARTNERSHIP
COMMENTING ON THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES ISSUES
THREE FOUR FIVE AND TEN. AND IF
YOU TREAT THE MEDIC CAL
ELIGIBILITY EXTENSION FOR
POSTPARTUM INDIVIDUALS WE WOULD
LIKE TO THANK THE GOVERNOR FOR
THIS PROPOSAL AND IN ADDITION
REQUESTING CREATION OF
CONTINUOUS COVERAGE FOR YOUNG
CHILDREN UP TO AGE FIVE IN THE
FINAL BUDGET. WE WOULD ALSO
RECOMMEND AMENDING THE
EFFECTIVE DATE FROM APRIL
TWENTY TWENTY TWO TO JANUARY
TWENTY TWENTY TWO TO COINCIDE
WITH THE END OF THE PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY CONTINUOUS
COVERAGE. ON ISSUE FOR WE
SUPPORT MEDICARE COVERAGE FOR
UNDOCUMENTED SENIORS AND WITH
THE POSITIVENESS ABOUT THE
BUDGET AND SURPLUS WE SUPPORT
TAKING EVEN BIGGER STEPS TO
REMOVE THIS EXCLUSION AND
INCLUDE AS MANY UNDOCUMENTED.
PEOPLE AS POSSIBLE AND MEDICARE.
ONE ISSUE FOR THE CHILDREN AND
BEHAVIORAL TECHNICIAN. AND
EFFECTIVE RESPONSE TO THE
PANDEMIC MUST INVOLVE A WHOLE
CHILD WHOLE FAMILY WELLNESS
APPROACH THAT INCLUDES A FOCUS
ON EARLY CHILDHOOD PREVENTIVE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES. TO
MIGLIORI THE POTENTIAL FOR
MENTAL HEALTH DIAGNOSES OR
CRISES LATER IN LIFE AND
SYSTEMATIC ATTENTION TO THE
PREPARATION AND PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT OF OUR EARLY
CHILDHOOD WORKFORCE. BOND
INCLUDING HOME VISITORS AND
OTHER FAMILY SERVICE PROVIDERS
WE ARE I THINK THE LEGISLATURE
TO MAKE A ONE HUNDRED TWELVE
MILLION EXPLICIT INVESTMENT IN
EARLY CHILDHOOD MENTAL HEALTH
STRATEGIES IN NON CLINICAL
SETTINGS TO ENSURE SERVICES
LIKE EARLY CHILDHOOD MENTAL
HEALTH CONSULTATION. AND TRAUMA
INFORMED CARE TRAINING FOR
SERVICE PROVIDERS REACHES OUR
YOUNGEST CALIFORNIANS. UNTIL
HEALTH WE ARE STRONG SUPPORTERS
OF INCREASING ACCESS TO
TELEHEALTH FOR FAMILIES OF
COLOR AND LOW INCOME FAMILIES
WE URGE THE LEGISLATURE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION MAINTAIN CURRENT
PHD TEL HELP SUPPORT AND ENSURE
COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTERS
ESTABLISHED PATIENTS USING.
ASYNCHRONOUS TELEHEALTH AND BE
REIMBURSED FOR AUDIO ONLY
TELEHEALTH. ASYNCHRONOUS AND
AUDIO ONLY TELL HEALTH ARE BOTH
CRITICAL MODALITIES OF CARE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OKAY BECAUSE I'M GONNA
START LIMITING YOU TO ONE
MINUTE OKAY SO GOING TO GET ONE
MINUTE OF TESTIMONY AND THEN
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON AND
AGAIN HE CAN AND I'VE GOT MY
TIMER HERE AND SO IF YOU IF YOU
HAVE SOMETHING LONGER YOU WANT
TO SAY. PLEASE EMAIL THE
COMMITTEE AND OR CALL OKAY NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. BLIND. ONE
pAFTERNOON HI MICHELLE THE VIDEO
FROM VALLEY CAREGIVER RESOURCE
CENTER AND WE SUPPORT THE CDA
REQUEST BECAUSE THERE
STRENGTHENS THE CARE
INFRASTRUCTURE REQUIRED FOR THE
MASTER PLAN ON AGING INCLUDING
SUPPORT UNPAID FAMILY
CAREGIVERS THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
FILE ITEM ONE HUNDRED SIXTY
FOUR. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEGAN PHILBRICK ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA HEALTH CLUBS
ADVOCATE FOR COMMUNITY CLINICS
AND HEALTH CENTERS WE FULLY
SUPPORT ISSUE NUMBER FOR HELP
FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS OVER SIXTY
AND SUPPORT THE LEGISLATURE
TAKE HOLDERS REQUEST TO EXPAND
ACCESS TO ALL ADULTS REGARDLESS
OF IMMIGRATION STATUS. AN ISSUE
NUMBER TEN AN AUDIO ONLY
TELEHEALTH WE APPRECIATE THE
REVISED TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
AND A TECHNOLOGY. MEANT THAT
ACCURATE SHE SHOULD BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE ID ONLY CCESS TO THE
PROGRAM FOUR MILLION PEOPLE WHO
GET THEIR CARE HEALTH. WE HAVE
CONCERN WITH THE UPPER OF THE
LANGUAGE AND WHAT IT WOULD MEAN
FOR THE BUT THE TIME THE
FEDERAL HOW EMERGENCY AND WINDY
H. YES MIGHT BE ABLE TO OBTAIN
FEDERAL. FOR ALL PAIN AT THE
COMMITTEE NOT WE- THINK IT'S AN
THAT WE AND THE AND IN ACT TO
BE A HEALTH SH AUDIO ONLY BUT
THAT HAS A FORTY PAGE A LOT AT
THE TIME WE ARE ALLEGED TO
ADOPT THE THAT AB THIRTY TWO
AND OF THIS PURPOSE TRAILER.
AND THEY DIDN'T TO AND IS A
POTENTIAL GAP IN K. AND PROVIDE
THE APPROPRIATE CREEK BRIDGE
PERIOD AND ALSO INCLUDES AN
EVALUATION REQUIREMENTS THANK
YOU THANK. YOU VERY MUCH THANKS
CALLER PLEASE. WELL I ONE
HUNDRED. EIGHT ONE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MAN CHAIR THEN IN
BLOOM WITH A COW ASSOCIATION
HEALTH OF HERE TO ON JAN PART
BEAT THE EIGHT A. B. C. ITEM
NUMBER NINE HOWEVER THE CALM
MADE BY KATHY MARC BYRD WITH
THE DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES
NETWORK CATHOLIC PROCEEDSTHAT
DTS HAS ADDRESSED A LONG
STANDING ISSUE OF FOR THE
MEDICAL RATES FOR OUR AYE CFDT
HOME AND OUR PEDIATRIC SUB
ACUTE FACILITIES HOWEVER THESE
RATES HAVE BEEN FROZEN SINCE
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT THIRTEEN
YEARS. IT WILL TAKE TIME TO
ADJUST THE ANNUAL COST OF
PROVIDING CARE NOW WITH THE
MEDIC HOW REIMBURSEMENT THAT
REFLECTS THAT OUT IN ADDITION
THE UPCOMING BUDGET YEAR
ADMINISTRATION DOES NOT PROPOSE
ANY SOLUTION TO THE CURRENT
UNDER FUNDING OF THESE
FACILITIES TO ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE PATH IS ASKING FOR AN
EXTENSION OF THE 10% META
CALIBRATED JUST MEANT FOR THE
CAN DOWN THE ROAD I JUST LOOK
MONTHS THROUGH JAN THIRTY
TWENTY TWENTY TWO THE SOLICITOR
THAT THESE FACILITIES THAT ARE
A 100% MEDICAL FUNDED IN
NINETEEN EXISTING STAFF AND
WAITED. WHILE THEY STARK
CONTRAST TO THE UNFREEZING OF
THEIR RATE EFFECTIVE AUGUST
TWENTY TWENTY TWO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. A LINE OF ONE. SIXTY
NINE. GOOD AFTERNOON KAREN
NUMBER ONE EIGHT THAT LOCAL
HEALTH AND THE POWER. IT'S A
FOR THE INTERNET PROPOSAL
EXPAND NOT ACCOUNT I'LL TO
UNDOCK AND OVER AGE OF FIFTY
AND EXPAND MEDICAID ELIGIBILITY
ARE AN INDIVIDUAL THEY'RE ALSO
IMPORTANT ADDING COMMUNITY
HEALTH WORKERS AS A MEDICAL
PROVIDER TYPE. LOCAL PLAN FOR
THE NUMBER OF QUESTIONS ABOUT
YOU THE PROPOSAL INCLUDING THE
YOUTH AND HERE I'LL FINISH IT
AND THE KALYAN POPULATION
HEALTH MANAGEMENT PROPOSAL
WRITING YOU CAN EITHER
ALTERNATIVE LOCAL PLAN THE
CLOUDED EDUCATION FOCUSED ON
THE IRAQ AND MONITOR CHILDREN.
WHATEVER IT THE COMMITTEE IN
OTHER MARKETS WE BELIEVE OUR
DETAILS ARE NEEDED INCLUDING
HOW ALL THE PROPOSAL PUT
TOGETHER AND THE ROLE THAT
INDIGENT FOR MEDICARE MANAGED
CARE PLAN. WE ALSO HAVE
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE TALLY IN
POPULATION HEALTH MANAGEMENT
PROPOSAL AND LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE DEPARTMENT TO
LEARN MORE ABOUT IT INCLUDING
HELD THE IMPLEMENTED WITHIN THE
CONTEXT OF THE BROADER
POPULATION HEALTH MANAGEMENT
APPROVAL AND TELLING THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. BLIGHTED ONE HUNDRED
SEVEN. GOOD AFTERNOON THAT WENT
AWAY WE WESTERN ONLINE POVERTY
TO COMMENT MULTIPLE IN BE WE
THE AGENCY ALLEGE ACCESS CARGO
REQUEST HAS BEEN DONE NEEDED.
THE PERFECTLY INC TO TRANSLATE
MATERIAL ACTUALLY UNDERSTOOD WE
APPRECIATE THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL TO EXPAND MEDICARE
ELIGIBILITY TO UNDOCUMENTED
ADULTS AGE SIXTY CLASS AND COST
ESTIMATE DIFFERENCES ARE WORKED
THROUGH WE WOULD NOTE THAT THE
L. A. THE LOWER COST ESTIMATE
UNFORTUNATELY SUPPORTED BY THE
FACT THAT THE AVERAGE LIFE
EXPECTANCY SO TO SPEAK I THINK
FARMWORKERS AND ONLY FORTY NINE
YEAR. OLD EXISTING INEQUALITIES
HIGHLIGHT THE NEED TO COVER ALL
AND APPRECIATE THIS CYNICAL.
DISCIPLINE THAT. WHEN THE
ADMINISTRATION NOT. IN THE- OF
THE MEDICAID AFTER THAT THAT
WOULD AFFECT ME TO THINKING
YOU'RE APPRECIATE THAT AND- OF
THE. SHE CAN DRESS IN THE-
EQUITIES INCREASE ACROSS CARE
PLANNING. BURKE PART OF
INDIVIDUALS AND NEW TO A
BENEFIT. IT FOR THE FUNDING
INCLUDE FOR THE FOR OF THE TWO
THEM AT THAT. BY KNOWING
ALIGNMENT WITH PASS FUNDING TO
BUILD. WE REQUIRE ONE TO TWENTY
MILLION FUNDING BEING. BE MADE
TO OUT CAPACITY AT HOME SERVICE
PROVIDERS TO CALL WITH MATT CAL
PLAN PROVIDE HOUSING SUPPORT
SERVICE AS WE NO HOW THE CARE
COORDINATION AT. PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE DO KNOW THANK. YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE. A LINE
OF ONE HUNDRED TWO. HELLO MY
NAME IS MITCH MATHEWS
REPRESENTING HEALTH PRODUCTS
CENTER IN CENTRAL CALIFORNIA WE
URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE CARE
GIVER RESOURCE CENTERS ON THEIR
PERMANENT AUGMENTATION OF
COURSE SERVICES IF YOU ARE
CALIFORNIA AS WELL AS YOUR
SUPPORT FOR EXPANDING THE M. S.
S. P. SERVICES. AND THE FUNDING
TO SUSTAIN THAT WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THE WORKING GUYS
DON'T THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. LINE. ONE HUNDRED
EIGHTY SIX. CALLER LINE ONE
HUNDRED EIGHTY SIX YOU'RE MY
COULD OPEN. LET'S MOVE ON THE
MODERATE GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS RONALD KOEMAN
HERE ON BEHALF OF FEET AND THE
CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK HERE TO COMMENT ON A
FEW ITEMS AND THE PART BE
AGENDA ON ISSUE ONE WE VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THE AGENCIES
RECOGNITION THAT LANGUAGE
ACCESS RESOURCES ARE
DESPERATELY NEEDED ACROSS THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTHY HUMAN
SERVICE AGENCY WE SUPPORT THE
TWENTY MILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT BUT BELIEVE THAT THE
STATE WANTS TO MAXIMIZE ITS
INVESTMENT SHOULD FIND FIELD
TESTING TRANSLATED DOCUMENTS BY
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
THAT REPRESENT IMPACTED
POPULATIONS. THE STATE PAYS
CONSULTANTS AND CONTRACTORS FOR
TRANSLATION WORK BUT IT DOESN'T
INVEST IN ACTUALLY MAKING SURE
THAT WAS TRANSLATED MESSAGES
RESONATE WELL WITH COMMUNITIES
BASIC TO TARGET AND WE BELIEVE
THAT THESE RESOURCES SHOULD
ALSO GO TO CONTRACTS WITH THOSE
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATION.
WILL GO FAR FOR THE STATE'S
LIMITED ENGLISH PROFICIENT
RESIDENTS RELY ON THIS
INFORMATION CORNISH CHIU FORTY
CAN SUPPORTS THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL EXPAND MEDIGAP
UNDOCUMENTED ADULTS AGE SIXTY
READING THE GOVERNOR AND THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD WORK
TOGETHER TO GO FURTHER AND
EXPAND TO ALL UNDOCUMENTED
ADULTS REGARDLESS OF STATUS TO
MAKE GOOD PROGRESS ON THE ISSUE
OF THE YEAR THE TO MANY. TO ANY
UNDOCUMENTED CONTINUE TO SUFFER
WITHOUT ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE
SPECIFICALLY BECAUSE OF THEIR
IMMIGRATION STATUS THAT'S
UNACCEPTABLE AND WE NEED TO IN
THE RACIST EXCLUSION
ADDITIONALLY WHEREVER THIS
CONVERSATIONAL ANSWER THIS YEAR
C. BEEN BELIEVE THAT MADE HER
VERY MUCH COME ON THE WAY WE'VE
BEEN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. BUT I KNOW WANT
NINETY. AFTERNOON AND MEMBERS
JERRY WITH NEAREST HELP BECAUSE
APART EIGHT EIGHTY Q. TWO THE
CALPERS SPENT OVER OUTRAGED
SUPPORT THE FUNDING PROPOSAL
BUT. THEY CAN GO FOR. NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. BLIND WILL. TWO
HUNDRED ONE. THANK YOU FOR HER
EGGMAN MGBS ON BEHALF OF YEAH
YOU ALIFORNIA LOOK AT THE
MONITOR TO ISSUE BIRTH ME
STRONG SUPPORT THE THREE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR ONE TIME
FUNDING TO HELP OUR PUBLIC
HOSPITAL THEM OFF BUT THE COSTA
CRITICAL THE NINETEEN PATIENTS
WHO NEED IT I MEAN AND HOSPITAL
FROM THE SENATE. AND MARKER
WHICH WERE UNINSURED AND ARE
UNDOCUMENTED AND DID NOT HAVE
HEALTH COVERAGE AT THE TIME
THAT THEY GOT YEAH. WE
APPRECIATE THE SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENT IN COMMUNITY ACCESS
TO BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES
AND A LONGER TERM THINKING AND
HOW TO BUILD UP THE ACTUAL
WORKFORCE BOTH IN THE DATA
PLATFORM BUT ALSO IT WORK WORK
PROGRAM BUT WE DO HAVE A LOT OF
QUESTIONS REGARDING THE
PROPOSAL- IN BOTH INITIATIVES
WE ARE A LITTLE BIT
DISAPPOINTED THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL DID
NOT INCLUDE ANY EXPLICIT
RECOGNITION OR ACTUAL
INVESTMENT. IN OUR EXISTING
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
WORKERS WHO HAD BEEN RESEARCH
CHALLENGE TIME AND TIME AGAIN
THEY NEED FUNDING NOW IN ORDER
TO HIRE MORE STAFF AND MEET THE
PENT UP DEMAND FOR SERVICE
ESPECIALLY AS OUR STATE AND
GOLD. ONLY WE OPEN. I'M HOW
MUCH OF THE COULD BY. ON TO BE
OUT I THINK THE BILL. THANK YOU
VERY COLOR NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
BLIND IN ONE HUNDRED SO NINE.
IF ANYONE WOULD BE ARE YOU
QUALIFY ONE OF COMMENT ON A
ISSUE IN PART A HUNDRED THEY
SHOULD BE A WHILE THE SUPPORT-
I'VE BEEN TO LOOK FORWARD
WORKING WITH DIMINISH AND THE
FOUND SHORT TERM BILL LANGUAGE
REFLECTS CAN TO REDUCE CASELOAD
AND WE ALL OF THE- BRIDGE BY TO
ENJOY BOTH LOCAL AND- APPROACH.
SIMILARLY IS BY THE TO DO FEES
AND THE QUARTERBACK ON THE DO
AND PART B. UNDER THE AGE YET
SUPPORT ISSUE. GROUP AND I'M
NOT- EXPAND TO UNDOCK FILIPINO
AND THE COURT IS LINE ELEVEN
WAS AN INSIDE TO THE GREAT
THINGS THANK YOU CAN. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH COLOR. BLIND TO.
THREE AFTERNOON ATTENTION
MEMBERS DON'T ON THE OF THE
DOCTOR HOSPITAL WARM HERE TO ON
TO A ITEM FORTY SIXTY ISSUE WE
SUPPORT THE MEDICARE AND SHE
HAVE COVERAGE ON DOCTOR THING
SIXTY AND OLDER SOMETHING ITEM
ISSUE CAN WITH RESPECT TO
TELEHEALTH WE SUPPORT OF AB
THREE TWO AND URGE AND ALL OF
THAT MY OF THE ALTERNATE THANK
YOU MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. BLANK.
HUNDRED SIX. HELLO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MY NAME IS ERICA AND
I'M THE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA FOOD MEDICINE
COALITION AND I'M CALLING ABOUT
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT THE DIFFICULT
THE MEDICALLY TAILORED MEALS
EXPANSION PROGRAM AT FIRST
UNITED. I THANK THE DEPARTMENT
HEALTHCARE SERVICES AND THE
GOVERNOR FOR THEI SUPPORT OF
THIS PROGRAM. IN ADDITION THE
CALIFORNIA'S WITH MEDICINE
COALITION STRONGLY SUPPORT
FIFTY NINE POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS ONE TIME FUNDING FOR
THE MEDICALLY TAILORED MEALS
PROGRAM. PROGRAM IS VITAL TO
ADDRESS CRUCIAL NUTRITION NEEDS
OF HIGHLY VULNERABLE MEDICALLY
FRAGILE INDIVIDUALS FROM
CHRONIC AND ACUTE AND ACUTE
ILLNESSES. PEOPLE WHO WILL
BENEFIT FROM THIS ARE LARGELY
FROM UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES
AND HAVE BEEN
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED BY
COOKING. NINETEEN AND BY MANY
OTHERS. YOUR QUESTION IN THE
CARE COOLEY ROCKING AND HEALTH
PROBLEM THAT HAS BEEN
EXACERBATED DURING NINETEEN IN
OCTOBER NINETEEN AND IT
CONTINUES TO BE A MAJOR
CHALLENGE. THIS PROGRAM WILL BE
VERY IMPORTANT TO DELIVER
HEALTHY MEALS. TO PROVIDE-
NUTRITION THOSE PEOPLE AFTER
HOMES. AND THE PROGRAM ALSO
HOLD. HOLD THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
IT YEAH THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU NICE COLOR. BLIND.
TWO HUNDRED TWO. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR BARKER GLAZER WITH
A CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION I'M HERE TODAY AND
RECORDED THREE ISSUE ON HEALTH
INFORMATION EXCHANGE T. HA IS
SUPPORTIVE OF EFFORTS TO COVER
pINFORMATION CALIFORNIA'S
EFFORTS TO EXPAND DATA EXCHANGE
THAT ALIGNS WITH FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT NETWORK OF NETWORKS
APPROACH AS WELL AS THE
EMERGING API MODEL PERFECT
CHANGE WE APPRECIATE THE
ADMINISTRATION'S EFFORTS TO
INCLUDE ALL STAKEHOLDERS TO
LOOK. FORWARD TO CONTINUED
CONVERSATION. ORDER THAT SHE
THREE WHICH IS THE EXTENT OF
MEDICAID L. PROPOSED PART IN
INDIVIDUAL AND SUPPORTED THE
CORD EXTENSION OF PULL CAL
BENEFITS TO ADULTS SIXTY YEARS
OF AGE AND OLDER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. BLIND TWO HUNDRED. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
MONICA MILLER REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION CRACKED
OKAY SERVICES AS WELL AS
ALZHEIMER'S ORANGE COUNTY WE
WANT TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
ITEM- FORTY ONE SEVENTY PART OF
DEPARTMENT OF AGING RELATED TO
THE FEEDBACK PROGRAMS AND THE
TEN ADDITIONAL CONDITIONS ON WE
REALLY HELP YOU OUT WITH A
QUICK ADMITTING PARDON THANK
YOU CANNOT HAVE A GREAT DAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. BLIND TO HER EIGHT. I
DON'T REMEMBER IS JUST AROUND
THE CALIFORNIA DENTAL
ASSOCIATION ARE CALLING ON A
FEW ITEMS ON THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES WE ARE
SUPPORTIVE OF ISSUE THAT MEANT
THAT MEDICAL AGILITY OPPOSE
PARTY IN THE MIDDLE AS WELL AS
I DON'T GORGE EXPAND MEDICAL
AGILITY TO A DOCUMENT SENIORS-
WE ARE ALSO IN THE COURT OF
ISSUE THIRTEEN- THE PILOT WILL
TEST A FULLY INTEGRATED MODEL
WITH BOTH DENTAL AND MEDICAL
SERVICES PROVIDED AT THE HEALTH
PLAN. THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. A LINE OF. HUNDRED
EIGHTY. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBER OF PLANNING
SURGERIES ARE REPRESENTING THE
ALZHEIMER'S ASSOCIATION WE'RE
TALKING TO THEM IN SUPPORT OF
THE ADMINISTRATION
UNPRECEDENTED PACKAGE A
PROPOSAL THAT WILL BENEFIT
THOSE IMPACTED BY ALZHEIMER'S
MALL YOU CAN USE THAT THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR INCREASED
INVESTMENT. PARTICULARLY WITHIN.
RAINBOWS AND THAT. THEY WERE
SPEAKING OF THE COURT OF THIS
UNIQUE DREAM FOR THE DEPARTMENT.
VIA ALL ADULT RECOVERY HUNDRED.
FUNDING FUNDING AND CRUCIAL.
MANAGER OF THE ABUSE HERE TO
REPORT AN ADDITIONAL THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE WE ARE ALSO. THE
TO INCLUDE UP IN YOUR BILL THE
IN MEDIC CAL AND CREATION OF
THE AUTHOR OF MANY AND OKAY AND.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
CALLER PLEASE. LATER HUNDRED SO
ONE. GOOD AFTERNOON I'M SOVIET
YOUNG OF THE ARE HEALTH AND WE
ARE THE TITLE FEDERAL FAMILY
PLANNING PRO IN OUR STATE AND
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
EXPANDED USE OF TELEHEALTH
WE'RE CONCERNED THAT THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE PROPOSED
BY THE ADMINISTRATION- AND WE
ECHO THE COMMENTS ARE COLLIE
THAT PLANNED PARENTHOOD THAT
THE PROPOSAL WOULD REDUCE
ACCESS. TO ESSENTIAL AND TIME
SENSITIVE ACTUALLY REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CARE SERVICES BY NOT
PROVIDING PAYMENT PARITY FOR
AUDIO AND VIDEO VISIT LAST FALL
WE CONDUCTED A SURVEY OF OUR
TITLE TEN PROVIDER NETWORK AND
NEARLY 60% OF THEIR VIRTUAL
SEXUAL AND REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
VISITS LIKE FOR BIRTH CONTROL
STI SCREENINGS WERE CONDUCTED
BY TELEPHONE. SIMILARLY A GROUP
OF TEAMS THAT WE SURVEYED WITH
OVER FOUR HUNDRED FROM ACROSS
CALIFORNIA 40% SAID THEY WOULD
PREFER TELEHEALTH VISITS BY
PHONE PATIENTS SHOULD BE ABLE
TO CHOOSE THE MODALITY OF
SERVICE DELIVERY THAT BEST MEET
THEIR NEEDS AND PROVIDER SHOULD
BE REIMBURSED BASED ON THE
SERVICE THEY PROVIDE RATHER
THAN THE MODALITY SO WE URGE
THE LEGISLATURE TO ADOPT. THE
TELEHEALTH LANGUAGE AS OUTLINED.
IN AB THIRTY TWO. THANK YOU FOR
MUCH CALLER. LINE ONE HI
THIRTY. GOOD AFTERNOON CURRIN
JONES DIRECTOR OF THE U. S. F.
P. SERVING LAKEN MCKINNEY
MENDOCINO COUNTY THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND THE COMMUNITY
FOR YOUR EFFORTS WE SUPPORT ALL
CDA ISSUES UNDER TWENTY ONE
SEVENTY I AM A MASTER PLAN ON
AGING I WANT TO URGE YOUR
SUPPORT OF THE PERMANENCY OF
THE KURDS IN AT THAT RATE WHEN
RESTORATION OF STOCK ALLOWED BY
FEDERAL AUTHORITIES SO WE CAN
SERVE MORE GROW CALIFORNIA'S
SENIORS WE'VE BEEN A BLESSING
TO OLDER ADULTS ALL OVER IT BUT
ESPECIALLY IN RURAL AREAS LIKE
MINE. I URGE YOU TO KEEP THAT
BACK IN THE FOREFRONT OF YOUR
BUDGET TWO GENERATIONS AND
AGAIN THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. BLIND ONE HUNDRED
EIGHT. I. EIGHT ONE ONE HUNDRED
TWENTY EIGHT. ONE ONE HUNDRED
TWENTY YES GOOD AFTERNOON
EVERYONE THIS IS DOCTOR FROM ON
THE PHONE HEY I'M THE DENTAL
DIRECTOR FOR SACRAMENTO
COMMUNITY CLINIC I WANT TO SHOW
MY SUPPORT FOR THEM TO MANAGED
CARE APPROVING THE ELIMINATION
OF MANAGED CARE AND MEDICARE
HAVE A DENTAL PROGRAM- I HAVE
WORKED WITH DENTAL MANAGED CARE
FOR MORE THAN A DECADE AND I
THINK THAT BEEN. MANAGED CARE
HAVE HAD BEEN MENTALLY TO
PROVIDE GOOD QUALITY OF CARE TO
MY PATIENTS ON MEDICARE KIND
PATIENT TO PROVIDER THE BUDGET.
THAT'S PROVIDERS TO PROVIDE
CARE TO THE PATIENT AND MONITOR
THEIR PROGRESS WE DON'T
EXTENSIVE INVESTIGATION AND
RECORD REVIEW- IT ALSO BUILDS A
GOOD PATIENT PROVIDER
RELATIONSHIP AND ENHANCES
QUALITY OF CARE- MANAGED CARE
HAS ALSO NEED REFORM TO
PATIENTS WITH THE EASY IT WILL
BE SIMPLE TO FIND FOR EXAMPLE
AN ORAL SURGEON'S OFFICE ON
THEIR OWN SOMETIMES THAT MIGHT
TAKE MONTHS FOR THE BEACHES TO
GET IN APPOINTMENT WITH THE
WORLD. MY GOODNESS TO GET SO
MUCH EASIER I HAVE BEAT UP
RECORD BANDS GET TO GET
PATIENTS REGULARLY FOR EXAMPLE
FOREIGN LEGION WHICH AGAIN
WHICH MIGHT BE CANCER AND BE
WILLING TO GET THEM WITHIN. OUR
IS THE HELP TO A PATIENT WHO
DON'T HAVE TO DEAL WITH THE
HASSLE OF CALLING AROUND
LOOKING FOR TO THIS OFFICE TO
BE SEEN IN THE TIMELY MANNER I
KNOW THAT MANAGED TO GET HAS
BEEN AGREED TO OUR FUNDERS
PATIENT POPULATION THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME AND THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK THANK. YOU
VERY MUCH TAX COLOR PLEASE.
BLIND TO HER SAN. CHARLOTTE SIX
ON AM A MEMBER OF THE CAL
KELABIT BELONG TERM SERVICES
SUPPORT AND SUPPORT A EXACT TO
OF THE CAL. I'M CALL TO SUPPORT
THE CALIFORNIA OF THE WITH
UNDER FORTY ONE SEVEN S. THE
OLDER ADULT RECOVERY AND PACK-
AND POLICE TOOK IMPLEMENTING OF
THE MASTER PLAN FOR AGING THANK
YOU. REMATCH NEXT COLOR. FIND.
ONE HUNDRED SEVENTY FOUR. HELLO
LOW YES GO AHEAD PLEASE. YES HI
GOOD AFTERNOON ADDS ANOTHER
EGGMAN INJURED MEMBERS MY NAME
IS NOT EVEN ON WHO MY DAD I AM-
COMPOUNDED OF THE INTEGRATED
CLINICAL ALLERGIES I KNOW THAT
YOU NEED CHILD YOU KNOW
SOMEONE. IN AN ACCIDENT ON THE
BIKE THE CARD IS BUDGET NINETY
NINE P. TO RAISE MY CONCERN
ABOUT THE PPL WE GOT TO TALK TO
pAT THE FLYING TO PROVIDE
FREEDOM AND FLEXIBILITY NEEDED
TO BE AT WORK AGAIN BACK INTO
WILL IMPACT. THE COMPANY'S MARK
STONE THAN A. NEGATIVE WAY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT PLEASE. LEVINE. FORTY SIX.
LINE FORTY SIX. MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS QUITE HIM ON BEHALF OF
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
FIRST WE WANT TO EXPRESS OUR
DEEP APPRECIATION PARINEETA AND
COTTON THE COMMITTEE FOR THE
TREMENDOUS WORK ON CAPE HEARING
THE RP UPADHYAY THE
ADMINISTRATION COULD
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS
INCLUDED IN THE MAY BE BY WE DO
THINK ADDITIONAL DETAIL ABOUT
MANY OF THE PROPOSAL AND WILL
TAKE JUST A MOMENT HERE TO
SHARE SOME OF OUR CONCERNS.
WITH REGARD ISSUE ONE WHILE WE
APPRECIATE THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL TO SUPPORT THE DEAF
COMMUNITY WE KNOW THAT ACTIVE
COMPASSIONATE SERVICE
COORDINATORS ALONE WILL NOT
SUFFICIENTLY ADDRESSED THE NEED
TO DEATH CONSUMERS SPENDING BUT
ALSO NEEDED TO DEVELOP
COMMUNITY RESOURCES AND
PROGRAMS DIRECTLY SERVING THAT
CONSUMERS INCLUDING ASL
INTERPRETATION AND OTHER
ESSENTIAL COMMUNICATION. APART
OUR ISSUE. COURTS AND FUNDING
FOR THE IMPLEMENT BUT WE ARE
EXTREME DIFFICULT WITH THE
TRAILER BILL ON TOP THE
TERMINATION THAT WAS RELEASED
THIS MORNING BUT TRAILER BILL
INTRODUCED NEW STATUTORY
LANGUAGE THAT DIRECTLY
CONTRADICTS THE CORE PRINCIPLE
AT THE HEART OF SELF
DETERMINATION. SURE WE
APPRECIATE IF SUPPORTERS I'M
GOING TO FUNDING OUR COMPANY.
NINETEEN THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANKS CALLER PLEASE. WELL I
KNOW ONE HUNDRED TWELVE. FIND
ONE HUNDRED TWELVE. HELLO GO
AHEAD CALLER NEAR ME YES WE CAN
GO AHEAD. ALL OKAY THIS IS
CHERYL BROWN IT'S GOOD TO HEAR
YOU- BOTH OF THE PAN AND-
SENATOR EGGMAN- I'M CALLING
ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA- RESOURCE
CENTER THE CARE GIVEN RESOURCE
CENTER AND- THE ONLY PROGRAM
THAT WE HAVE. NOT MEANS TESTED
AND WHAT HAPPENS THE ANYBODY
CAN USE THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN-
HOPING THAT YOU WILL HELP SAVE
A LIFE. THE R. THREE AND- BUT
LEAVING THE FLIGHT ITSELF FOR
THOSE WHO DON'T. I THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. PINE TO HER.
TEN GOOD AFTERNOON DOCTOR
NANTUCKET PAN FELIX IN WITH
BLUE SHIELD OF CALIFORNIA WE
ARE CALLING UNFORTUNATELY WITH
SOME SERIOUS CONCERNS ON THE
ISSUE TO FORTY HIV STAKEHOLDER
PROCESS I'M NOT THE GOAL OR THE
STOCK REQUEST OF THE TIMELINE
TO HOLD SCHOOL NEAR ST JUNE
TWENTY TWENTY THREE ASSEMBLY
WAY. TOO LONG TO GET OUT WHAT
WE ALREADY KNOW. ARE YOU TODAY
SIMPLY NOT HAVE A GOOD ANSWER
WHICH IS A- VISUAL RECORD- THAT
COULD BE SHARED BY PATIENT AND
THE CARE A LIFE. A DOCTOR
COUNTERPOINT THE PANDEMIC ONLY
HIGH HOW IT IS FOR THE UP AND
WILL WE CLUSTER AT THE
CONCLUSION A LOT SOONER. NO
BIGGER NO THERE'D CHECK MONTHS.
IN A SIMILAR VEIN FOR ISSUE
EIGHT HUNDRED CALLING WELL WE
ARE INTRIGUED BY THE PROPOSAL
TO BUILD A PACKAGE OF MEASURES
ARE IMPLEMENTED CAL WE THINK
YOU SHOULD EXTEND TO OTHER
PROGRAMS TO COVER SOURCES BY
COVERED. CALIFORNIA AND CALPERS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MEXICO PLEASE. LINE TO HER
ELEVEN. MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
AND APPLE WITH THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION EXPRESSING
GRATITUDE ON BEHALF OF OUR
MEMBERS FOR THE HISTORIC
INVESTMENT IN BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
REFLECTED IN THE MAY REVISE
QUICKLY WANTED TO COMMENT ON
JUSTA FEW MISSION IS ISSUE
FIVE HUNDRED THE CHILD AND
YOUTH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INITIATIVE WE SUPPORT MANY OF
INITIATIVE AND I WANTED TO
POINT OUT IN PARTICULAR LIST IN
PARTICULAR THE SCHOOL LINKED
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES AND
THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CONTINUUM
INFRASTRUCTURE FOCUSED ON
CHILDREN AND YOUTH. ON ISSUE
SIX STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
BEHAVIOR HEALTH CONTINUE ON
INFRASTRUCTURE EXPERIENCE
ACTION TWO POINT THREE BILLION
DOLLARS TO BE SPENT OVER
MULTIPLE YEARS A TRANSFORMATIVE
AMOUNT ISSUE THREE IF YOU EIGHT
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH QUALITY IMPROVEMENT
PROGRAM AND FINALLY ISSUE FOR
POLITICAL MEDICARE COVERAGE FOR
UNDOCUMENTED SENIORS VERY
EXCITED ABOUT THAT PROPOSAL AS
WELL THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE. BLIND
TWO HUNDRED TWELVE. HELLO THIS
IS JORDAN IN THE WITH R. T.
THROUGH PAUL THE CALIFORNIA.
SPEAK BRIEFLY ON THE DENIA
BUDGET ITEMS FOR CALIFORNIANS
WITH INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES IN
THE FAMILY THE GOVERNOR'S MAY
REVISE BOMB HIT AND ONE GIANT
MET THERE ARE SOME ITEMS WE
INTO THE ACT WITH THE PORT
INCLUDING THE PROPOSAL FOR
TRAINING AND CERTIFICATION FOR
DIRECT SUPPORT PROFESSIONALS I
WAS- GRATEFUL TO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT THAT
TOPIC IN YOUR HEARING JUST TWO
WEEKS AGO. BUT MAYBE BY
PROPOSAL HOWEVER IS NOT THE
COME BACK PLANNED FOR
CALIFORNIANS WITH DID IN THEIR
FAMILIES INSTEAD THIS IS THE
BACK TO BEING BARELY TOUCH THE
ANIMAL PLAN THIS BUDGET DOES
NOT INCLUDE ANY INVESTMENT TO
MAKE PROGRESS ON REMAINING ONE
POINT FOUR BILLION DOLLARS
UNDER FINDING A DENTIST BY THE
MEDIA THREE THIRTY. CONSIDERING
THE TRANSFORMATIVE INVESTMENT
THAT MAY REVISED INCLUDES FOR
MANY SERVICES INSPECTOR WE FEEL
LIKE WE'VE BEEN GIVEN A SECOND
THOUGHT AND COME BACK PLAN WE
LOOK AT THE PROPOSAL OF
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO ME
REVISED ONLY CONTINUE INCREASED
MEDIA SERVICES BY SIXTY FIVE
MILLION FOR NEXT YEAR AND
NOTHING IN IT IF THE DOLLAR
TOWARD REDUCING THE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. UNDERFUNDING AT THE
RATE STUDY THANK. YOU NEXT CALL
PLEASE. BLIND TO THIRTY. HIS
MADAM CHAIRED CAL FOR THE COME
SO SHE OF VERY AGENTS ON A
SPEAKING- ON BEHALF OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF EIGHTEEN BUDGET
FIRST OF ALL MONEY THANK YOU
AND YOUR COMMITTEE FOR YOUR
SUPPORT TEN EIGHTEEN SERVICES
ITMEANS A VERY VERY LACTOSE.
SECOND I'D LIKE TO RECOGNIZE
THE WORK THAT THE DEPARTMENT
ADMINISTRATION HAS DONE IN
TERMS OF ENHANCING. DOLLARS
FORCING YOU PROGRAMS- HOWEVER.
THERE ARE TWO BUDGET REQUEST
THAT I WANNA REMIND THE
COMMITTEE ON. ONE IS SET TO WE
ARE SEEKING TO INCREASE
BASELINE FOR EVERY AGENCIES ON
AGING. AND THE SECOND IS IN
REGARDS TO THE BUDGET FOR
NUTRITION HELLO- THE DEPARTMENT
HAS COME FORWARD WITH.
SEVENTEEN POINT FIVE MILLION- I
REQUEST TO SEEKING THIRTY FIVE
MILLION. THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
BLIND. TWO HUNDRED FIFTEEN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
PROBABLY TOWARDS ON BEHALF OF
HEALTH ACTOR CALIFORNIA I AM
CALLING ABOUT HEARTBEAT PHD
AFTER ISSUE NUMBER FOURTEEN THE
EXPANSION OF MEDICAID OFFER AND
DOCUMENTED PEOPLE OVER THE AGE
OF SIXTY. THE STAFF FROM THE
ADMIN. AND WE BELIEVE THAT OUR
HEALTH SYSTEM AND BETTER WILL
BE. BETTER BUT WHEN EVERYONE
HAS ACCESS TO COVERAGE BUT WITH
THE RECENTLY ANNOUNCED BUDGET
SURPLUS AND I'M GOING TO MAKE
IT EVEN MORE URGENT TO COVER
ALL DOCUMENTED ABOUT. THE STEP
FORWARD AND WE URGE THE
LEGISLATURE AND ADMINISTRATION
TO CONTINUE THE WORK TAKE
FURTHER STEPS. IN REACHING TRUE
HEALTH FOR ALL BY COVERING ALL
INDOCUMENTADOS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH TAX COURT PLEASE.
PINE. TWO HUNDRED FOURTEEN.
GOOD MADAM CHAIR I'M
GOING TO HAVE A PROGRAM OFFICER
FOR THE GARY AND MARY WEST
FOUNDATION IN SAN DIEGO WHICH
PROVIDES YOU A DEDICATED OUR
LIVES TO THE COULD BE AGING
IT'S BEEN VERY HARD TO WITNESS
SO MANY OLDER ADULTS OFFERED
THROUGHOUT THIS PANDEMIC. IN
OUR STATE IS NOW PRESENTED WITH
A HISTORIC OPPORTUNITY TO
DOUBLE DOWN ON ITS COMMITMENT
TO OLDER ADULTS ISSUES LIKE
MALNUTRITION ALL AND SOCIAL
ISOLATION HAVE A DEVASTATING
IMPACT ON SENIORS HEALTH AND
WELLBEING AND THEY ALSO IMPACT
THEIR HEALTHCARE SYSTEM LEADING
TO BILLIONS OF DOLLARS. IN
PREVENTABLE SPENDING. THE SMART
ABOUT I. IN THE NOW PLAN FOR A
AND BY I FOR ONE. YEAR WELL NOT
ONLY IMPROVE THE WELL BEING OF
SENIORS BUT ALSO RESULTS IN THE
LOWERING OUR STATE HEALTHCARE
STAND THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. ONE ONE HUNDRED FIVE.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS. THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO COMMENT
TODAY. DR SHELLEY HOOVER I AM
ON THE BOARD OF DIRECTORS FOR
THE ALS ASSOCIATION GREATER
SACRAMENTO CHAPTER AND A PERSON
LIVING WITH A LS. ALS IS A
STUNNINGLY BRUTAL DISEASE AND
HAS ROBBED ME OF MY VOICE AND
ABILITY TO MOVE. THANKS TO THE
SUPPORTS AND SERVICES OF THE
GREATER SACRAMENTO CHAPTER I AM
STILL ABLE TO COMMUNICATE AND
LIVE MY LIFE TO THE FULLEST
EXTENT POSSIBLE. REGARDING
FUNDING I SUPPORT FUNDING BEING
DISTRIBUTED EQUALLY PER PERSON
AFFECTED BY ALS IN CALIFORNIA.
THIS CAN BE ACCOMPLISHED BY
ENSURING ALL CHAPTERS IN
CALIFORNIA RECEIVE FUNDING
BASED ON HOW MANY PEOPLE THEY
SERVE. AS SOMEONE WHO BENEFIT
FROM THE SERVICES OF THE
GREATER SACRAMENTO CHAPTER IT'S
UNFAIR TO DISPROPORTIONATELY
AFFECT TWENTY FOUR NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA COUNTIES. STARTING
WITH SAN JOAQUIN AND GOING UP
TO READING. THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK ON BEHALF
OF PEOPLE LIVING WITH A LS IN
OUR GREAT STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. WIND. TWO HUNDRED NINE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS MARY JORDAN
AND I'M REPRESENTING THE PEOPLE
YOU REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
COVERED IN HEALTH INITIATIVE
I'M CALLING THIS AFTERNOON AND
THE COURTS ASSEMBLY MEMBER VOTE
BUDGET REQUEST THE MEDI MEDI
NAVIGATOR PROGRAM THIS FUNDING
WILL HELP TO STRENGTHEN AND
EXPAND THE ALREADY EXISTING AND
EFFECTIVE PILOT PROGRAM AS WELL
AS DROPDOWN ADDITIONAL. FUNDS
ADDING ONE TO ONE MATCH- I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION AT THIS
BUDGET REQUEST WHICH WILL HAVE
GREAT IMPACT. ON OUR BOOKING
HERE TO- AND PEOPLE OF COLOR.
THANKS AGAIN FOR CONSIDERING
THE MEDI MEDI NAVIGATOR PROJECT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. BLIND. TWENTY GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS AMY FOR
THE MODEL AND I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE ALS ASSOCIATION
GREATER SACRAMENTO CHAPTER OR
CHAPTER THE ONLY HEALTH RELATED
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION
PROVIDING WRAPAROUND CARE TO
PEOPLE LIVING WITH A LS IN
TWENTY FOUR NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
COUNTIES FROM SAN JOAQUIN UP TO
THE OREGON BORDER WE'RE HERE
TODAY TO ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
AND YOUR THE REQUESTED THREE
MILLION OVER THE COURSE OF FIVE
YEARS. OUR CHAPTER WHICH WORKED
WITH ALL OF OUR SISTER CHAPTER
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
SUPPORT ANALYST SERVICES
FUNDING THE CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT BUDGET CONTROL
LANGUAGE AND RELATED BUDGET
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE THAT
WOULD INSTITUTE FUNDING
DISTRIBUTION CONTROL THAT WOULD
BE RETAINED BY THE STATE AND
NOT GET WITH DELEGATED TO
ANYONE CHAPTER AT THE
INTERMEDIARY FOR THE REST OF
THE STATE IMPROVE
PROPORTIONALITY IN THE FUNDING
TO BE DISTRIBUTED AND
TRANSPARENCY IN THE FORM OF
PUBLIC REPORT IN DETAIL HOW THE
FUNDS ARE EXPENDED AND WHO IS
THIRD WE'VE COMMUNICATED THIS
CENTRAL CONSIDERATION TO THE
SUB COMMITTEE AND STAFF. HERE
DISTRICT STAFF SERVING OUR
BERRIES TO CD P. H. AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WE HOPE
IN THE FASHION TO AVOID AND
YOUR LIST OUT COME IN PRIOR
FUNDING THAT IS SPECIFICALLY
APPROPRIATED IN THE TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN BUDGET TO THE
MAIL TROPIC LATERAL SCLEROSIS
ASSOCIATION AS A WHOLE BUT
DISTRIBUTED BY CDPH EXCLUSIVELY
TO ONE CHAPTER WE THANK YOU AND
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT YOU
CONSIDER AND FIND AT THIS
CRITICAL FUNDING FOR THE L. S.
COMMUNITY IN CALIFORNIA. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. SLIDE ONE. A. ONE
MONICA JONES. GO AHEAD PLEASE.
YES I'M CALLING AND I'M AN
ACTIVIST AND CITIZEN WITH LIVED
EXPERIENCE IN NAVIGATING ALL OF
THESE SYSTEMS. AND I- I WOULD
URGE MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS TO
CONSIDER HOW DANGEROUS IT IS ON
THE STATE DEPARTMENT CONTINUES
TO PACKAGES CRITICAL. RIGHT
AND- CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT INTO
AND PUT IT INTO A FORMAT. LIKE
THE SELF DETERMINATION PROGRAM.
INSTITUTIONAL READY INSURANCE
ITS FREEDOM. TO CHOOSE AND WHEN
YOU PACKAGE IT INTO A PROGRAM
THE WAY IT R. RESTRICTED PEOPLE
TO OUR ABILITY TO CHOOSE AND
THEN YOU CREATE- EVETS- SYSTEM
WHERE PEOPLE HAVE I HAVE TO- TO
CONTINUE TO- OKAY THANK YOU.
EIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR CALL
TODAY NEXT COLOR PLEASE. BLIND.
TWO HUNDRED SEVENTEEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON JAMIE MINOR WITH THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY TWENTY
WERE REPRESENT TWENTY FOUR
COMMUNITY CHOICE AGGREGATORS
PROVIDING ELECTRICITY TO MORE
THAN ELEVEN MILLION CUSTOMERS
IN OVER TWO HUNDRED CITIES AND
COUNTIES ACROSS THE STATE- WE
SUPPORT- THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TO PROVIDE ONE BILLION
TWO UTILITY AIR. AEROJET OF THE
DEVASTATION THE PANDEMIC ON LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES HAS.
RESULTED IN MANY RATE HERE AND
BEING UNABLE TO PAY THEIR
ELECTRIC BILLS BETWEEN OF
AROUND ONE POINT SIX BILLION
CURRENT VECTOR ON UTILITY
CUSTOMERS ALONE. WE KNOW THAT
THAT DOLLAR ABOUT WILL BE
ELIGIBLE AND HOW THE MONEY WILL
BE DISTRIBUTED ARE ALL DETAILS
THAT NEED TO BE WORKED OUT. AND
AS THE CONVERSE CONS
CONVERSATION PROGRESS WE JUST
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT. EPA
CUSTOMERS ARE NOT LEFT OUT OF
THAT CONVERSATION ABOUT IN THAT
THE FUNDS THAT ARE DARGIS
TREATED. EQUITABLY AMONG ALL
ENERGY PROVIDERS BUT THE
BENEFIT OF THEIR CUSTOMERS WE
WILL FOLLOW UP WITH YOUR
COMMITTEE IN WRITING AS WELL
AND WE REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
BLINDER FORTY TWO. IT ZERO HI
MY NAME IS DIANE WOULD BE. THEY
YOU RURAL- ALLOWING DEAD DEAD
JIM BY WOOD. ASSEMBLY ZERO.
ADDED BUT THEN THEN AND-
MALAYBALAY YOU. NAIL AS THE NEW.
THE JEAN- WHEN AND THE OF IT-
THE GOOD JAB. GEN NEWS IN THE
TEAM I WOULD HAVE MORE MY-
GAVIN THERE MIGHT WILL ENGINE
AND BUT AB WOULD BE IN THEN YOU
LEARN IN THE- MY- WORD AND NOW.
LITTLE. IN YOU VERY MUCH DESK
PLEASE. BLIND HUNDRED NINE-
OPENING OSCAR SANDOVAL- THE
GOVERNOR SENIOR MANAGER THE
BUCK KNOW COLD FOR HEALTHY CAL.
I'M JUST CALLING ON BEHALF OF
SUPPORT I HOPE ALL HI TIME WE
MEDICAL KERR TO OF OUR
DOCUMENTS IN YOUR AND INCLUDE
UNDOCUMENTED I KEEP OUR STATE
AND DONE DURING THE CALL OF THE
ENTIRE AND ARE STILL STREET
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. BLIND TO
HER TWENTY. HELLO MY NAME IS
LOOK AT YOUR GOLF I'M CALLING
ON AMBER OF BUILDINGS LEGAL
CENTER OUT OF THE INLAND EMPIRE
PAULINE IS THE PART OF THE
EXPANSION OF MEDICAID TO COVER
AND BLOCKED MINUTE SENIOR. WE
ARE VERY WE ARE ZERO. WE ARE
STILL THERE WE ARE VERY HAPPY
TO HAVE HEARD THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S INVESTMENT IN THE
BUDGET FOR MAY BE IN A BETTER
DAY REVISED BUDGET. REPORT OF
US SENIORS ESPECIALLY
UNDOCUMENTED SENIORS WE ARE
ASKING FULL SUPPORT. OF THE
POPULATION AS WE HAVE SEEN MANY
OF OUR SENIOR THOUGHT PASSED
AWAY DUE TO COAL BED NOT HAVING
ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE WHAT THEY
HAVE GIVEN ALL THEIR LIVES TO
THE- WHERE. ALL THEIR WORKING
TO WORK. IN OUR STATE OF
CALIFORNIA NOW IT'S OUR TURN TO
STEP UP OUR SENIORS WE ASK FOR
YOUR THE COURT OF THE EXPANSION
COULD DOCUMENT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH JOBS
TOMORROW THIS GONNA DURING
INTAKE TWO MINUTE RECESS SO
THIS COMMITTEE WILL BE IN
RECESS FOR TWO MINUTES.
OKAY
MODERATOR LET'S BRING THIS UP
BUDGET HEARING BACK TO ORDER
HOW MANY CALLS DO WE HAVE LEFT
IN THE QUEUE NOW. RIGHT NOW WE
HAVE EIGHT MORE PEOPLE OKAY
LET'S TO TALK WITH THOSE EIGHT
PEOPLE FOR ONE MINUTE EACH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. BLIND. TWO HUNDRED
TWENTY ONE. GOOD AFTERNOON
ALEXANDRIA MET WITH LEADING H.
CALIFORNIA LEADING FATE LEADING
EDGE CALIFORNIA HAVE THE
PRIVILEGE OF PARTICIPATING IN
THE MASTER PLAN FOR AGING
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS AND IT'S
CLEAR TO SEE MANY OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS INCLUDED IN A
REVISED. MANY OF THE MASTER
PLAN RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
VALIDATE CALIFORNIA SENIORS AND
BOTH TIMES THE CREIGHTON
COMMENT BUT THE STATE FARM
CUTTING OUT YOU NEED BEEN NEEDS
OF AGING STATE WE URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO PRIORITIZE THE
MASTER PLAN FOR AGING PERFECTLY
TODAY I'D LIKE TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT THE FOLLOWING PROPOSALS
I. AYE SHE ONE TWO AND THREE
THE DEPARTMENT OF AGING AND
ISSUES FOR AN EIGHT COURT
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES PROPOSALS. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING THE
RECOMMENDATION FROM THE MASTER
PLAN FOR AGING- BECOME
CALIFORNIA'S REALITY THANK. YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR CALL NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. BUT A ONE SIXTY.
HELLO MY NAME IS MATTHEW.
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS- I'M A PATIENT WITH ALS-
COMMONLY KNOWN AS WELL AND I'VE
HAD ELECTIONS TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN ROUGHLY TWO YEARS NOW.
YOU HEARD FROM- MISTER VALENCIA-
PHOTO FROM SHELLEY HOOVER HIGH
AND I COULD NOT SAY IT BETTER
THAN THEY HAVE I'M JUST URGING
YOU TO FOLLOW THEIR
RECOMMENDATIONS ON THE
CONTINUED FUNDING FOR A LEFT
THE BOARD I HAD SEEN THE WORK
THAT SACRAMENTO ASSOCIATION
DOES AND- IT MAY SERVE THE
MEMBERS- AND THEIR CLIENTS-
SACRAMENTO AND THE SURROUNDING
AREA EXTREMELY WELL I URGE YOU
TO AGAIN- HELLO THERE EATEN
THERE THE GESTIONES. AND THEIR
REQUESTS TO FUND A LEFT HAND
BEND IT WITH- BUDGET OVERSIGHT
AND REVISION BUT AND THE WAY
THAT THAT MONEY IS DISTRIBUTED
SO THAT ALL CHAPTERS. ARE
SERVED FAIRLY. HAVE A GREAT
AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THE WORK YOU'RE DOING.
YOU HELP MAKE SACRAMENTO AND
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA BETTER
PLACE TO BE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE. BLIND.
TWO HUNDRED TWENTY FOUR. HI HOW
ARE YOU MAN I'M SURE MY NAME IS
JOHNNY HATCHED AND I AM
CRISTINA CANTARELLA JOHNNY'S
MOM- JOHNNY IS A TWENTY THREE
YEAR OLD YOUNG MAN WHO RECEIVE
SERVICES UNDER DDS DH CS AND
DSS. WELL THERE'S SO MUCH
DISCUSSED TODAY IMPACTING NOT
ONLY MY SON JOHNNY BUT OUR
COMPLEX CARE NEEDS COMMUNITY
WE'RE FOCUSING ON THE MOST
PRESSING ISSUE TO US AS WHICH
IS STP SELF DETERMINATION.
JOHNNY'S BEEN A REGIONAL CENTER
KEEP CONSUMERS FOR OVER THREE
YEARS THERE'S NO QUALITY DAY
PROGRAM THAT WILL ACCEPT THEM
BECAUSE OF THE LEVEL OF SUPPORT
NEEDS HE HAS. AN BECAUSE
REGIONAL CENTER CANNOT FIND ANY
SOCIAL AND RECREATIONAL
PROGRAMS. ANYMORE OUR CONCERN
IS FOR THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE THAT DDS IT'S
PRESENTED TODAY ON THE SELF
DETERMINATION PROGRAM WE NEED
TO REMEMBER THAT CHOICE AND
FLEXIBILITY IS THE BASIS OF
STP. IT IS SELF DETERMINATION
DDS DETERMINATION NOR REGIONAL
CENTER DETERMINATION WE NEED TO
ENSURE STP IS FOCUSED ON THE
INDIVIDUAL WITH DISABILITIES
AND URGE THE COMMITTEE TO WORK
WITH THE DEPARTMENT TO IMPROVE
THIS LANGUAGE. SO WHAT YOU SAID
SENATOR EGGMAN EACH INDIVIDUAL
WITH A DISABILITY CAN RISE TO
THEIR FULLEST POTENTIAL AND
HAVE ACCESS TO LIVE MEANINGFUL
AND QUALITY OF LIFE. THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME TODAY AND
FOR ALL THE EFFORT THAT ALL OF
YOU PUT IN THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
BY TWO HUNDRED FIVE. HELLO
THANK YOU PRAYER RAM UP AND TO
IN AGING FIRST ONE THANK YOU
BECAUSE SUBSTANTIA IMPACT TO
IMPROVE HUMAN SERVICES PROGRAMS
AND HEALTH CARE PROGRAMS FOR
OLDER ADULTS AND TO SUPPORT THE
MASTER PLAN FOR AGING WE
SPECIFICALLY WANNA- IN AND THE
COURT ITEM FORTY TO SIXTY ISSUE
FOR- EXPANDING ELIGIBILITY TO
UNDOCUMENTED OLDER DOGS AND-
URGE THE COMMITTEE TO LOWER THE
AGE EVEN FURTHER SO THAT WE CAN
ACHIEVE HEALTHCARE FOR ALL WE
ALSO WANT TO SUPPORT BY THEM.
DOUGHERTY ONE SEVENTY THE GDA
ISSUES ALL THREE WE SUPPORT BUT
WE PARTICULARLY WANT TO CURRENT
OR THE BEHIND THE OLDER- ADULTS
RECOVERY AND RESILIENCE FUNDING
WE WANT TO URGE THE LEGISLATURE
TO ELIMINATE THE MEDIC HOW
AFTER TAX WHICH IS NOT
APPEARING THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. SO THAT WE CAN
INCREASED PARITY AND EQUITY IN
THE MEDICAL PROGRAM. AND
INCREASE STABILITY AND-
ECSENIUS ABILITY. AND TO PUT
THE OLDER ADULTS THANK YOU
THANK YOU MUCH THANK PLEASE.
BLIND TWO HUNDRED SIX. HI THERE
NAME IS HOLLY CORREA I AM THE
MOTHER OF AN ADULT WITH
INTELLECTUAL AND DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES. RULER BILL
KRISTOL CONTAMINATION. A CLEAR
REVERSAL. CONGRESS BUT THE
COMMUNITY IS MADE WITH THE
PROMISE OF HELP DETERMINATION
THE GOAL OF THE PROGRAM IS TO
EXPAND OPPORTUNITIES FOR EACH
INDIVIDUAL PERSON CENTRED
PLANNING MUST REMAIN THE
FOUNDATION UPON WHICH WE COULD
SEE. FULLER BILL MUST BE
REJECTED BECAUSE IT CONTRADICTS
KYLE SEVENTEEN WHICH ENSURES
THAT INDIVIDUALS WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
HOWEVER RIGHT TO SERVICES CORD
AND CHOICE ABOUT HOW WHERE AND
WHOM THEY LIVE THEIR LIVES
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR HEARING
ME THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. ONE IN A. ONE
EIGHTY ONE. HELLO MY NAME
DEMONTE JONES AND I'M VERY
FORTUNATE I'M TRYING EARLIER
BUT I THINK THAT THIS IS A
BUILDER IN. THE DEPARTMENT
CONTINUES THE PACKAGES OF ALL
RIGHT INTO PROGRAM PERFORMANCE
SUCH SHOPPING ARE RETENTION
ALTHOUGH ALL IT IS A GOOD
PROGRAM- AND RIGHT SYSTEM RIGHT.
BUT STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION
IT ALREADY IS OUR CONSTITUTION
RIGHT TO HAVE. THE FREEDOM TO
CHOOSE. AND I DO BELIEVE- WE
SHOULD BE ABLE TO. PROGRAM THAT
RIGHT OUT OF A PROGRAM BUDGET
OR RELIGION THANK YOU THANK YOU
MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE. BLIND.
TWO HUNDRED TWENTY SEVEN. GOOD
EVENING MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE STAFF THIS IS
MICHELLE GAYLE ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU CENTER I
AM CALLING REGARDING PART B.
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES ISSUE NUMBER FOUR
MEDIKAL EXTENSION ARE LOW
INCOME DOCUMENTS CALIFORNIANS
ARE LOCKED OUT OF ACCESS TO
HEALTH CARE AND ARE DYING FROM
TREATABLE CONDITIONS. OR DIE
DUE TO LACK OF CARE BECAUSE OF
WHERE THINGS ARE GOING REALLY
PREACH AMERICORPS. BEFORE
HEALTHCARE FOR ALL. IN OVER
ABOUT WITH SUCH SURPLUS. MOSTLY
TIME TO CLARIFY ALL A DOCUMENT
COMMUNITY MEMBERS THAT BEEN
EXCLUDED FROM HER CARE BECAUSE-
ANOTHER COMPLEMENT THE SYSTEM
SOME. URGE THE GOVERNOR AND TO
SUPPORT FOR ALL INVOLVED THANK
YOU YOUR- THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
FIND TO HER TWENTY. HI MY NAME
IS LI SAID MENDELSOHN I WORK
FOR THE INLAND COALITION FOR
IMMIGRANT JUSTICE ALSO KNOWN AS
IC FOUR A. J. HERE IN THE-INLAND EMPIRE- RIVERSIDE AND
SAN BERNARDINO COUNTIES- AND
ALSO CALLING IN SUPPORT OF-
HELD FOR ALL- WE ARE HAPPY TO
HEAR THAT THERE IS A SURPLUS IN
OUR IN OUR STATE BUDGET- EVEN
SUPER GRATEFUL TO KNOW THAT
WE'RE WINNING. THE COR
COMMUNITY EASIER AFTER YEAR-
AND WE WERE- AND YOU KNOW WE
WERE HOPEFUL THAT WE WOULD GET
SOMETHING FOR OUR OLDER LAST
YEAR- BUT OF COURSE YOU KNOW WE
GOT A- CONTINUE TO REALIZE WHY
HELP FOR ALL- IS NECESSARY AND
THAT WE CAN NO LONGER INCLUDE
ARE UNDOCUMENTED- COMMUNITY-
YOU KNOW YOU NEW CAR THIS TIME
AND TIME AGAIN WE OFFER SO MUCH
TO OUR- OUR COMMUNITY IS
ALREADY AND ECONOMICALLY- IT IS
ONE OF THE MOST POWERFUL WAY
THAT WE ALSO SUPPORT- IN A LOT
OF THE FOLKS THAT. ARE IN THE
SHADOWS AND PROVIDING THESE
ESSENTIAL PRODUCT ESSENTIAL
SERVICES WERE THE ONES THAT
WERE EXPOSED TO A COLD IT IN SO
MANY OTHER- THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON NOW BUT
BUT WE CERTAINLY. HEAR YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. AND MADAM THERE ARE
FURTHER COMMENT AT THIS TIME
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR HELP IN YOUR WORK AT AS
MINIATURE MODERATOR WE
APPRECIATE IT- AND- IF YOU DID
NOT GET A CHANCE TO. MAKE YOUR
STATEMENT TODAY OR YOU CAN GET
A CHANCE TO SAY EVERYTHING YOU
WANT TO SAY YOU CAN PLEASE
ALWAYS REACH OUT TO THE
COMMITTEE. WE WOULD LIKE TO
HAVE YOUR INPUT- AND WITH THAT
I WILL THANKS TO THE DEPARTMENT
SHE ADMINISTRATION- THE
COMMITTEE STAFF UP THEY
CERTAINLY. SCOTT ORBISON AVENUE
TO POKE CERTAINLY SHOULD GET
AWARDS FOR. ALL THIS WORK
THEY'VE BEEN DOING THAT. THE
ADMINISTRATION SENT OUT OUT
SOMETIMES KIND OF AT THE LAST
MINUTE AND THEY DO THEIR VERY
BEST TO ANALYZE IT. AND THEN
BRIEF US ON IT AND THEN. HAVE
THE HEARINGS- WE ALSO
APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT OF ALL
THE STAFF WHO ARE HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOMS WITH US TODAY TO-
SO WITH THAT THAT CONCLUDES
OUR- BUDGET SUB THREE HEARING
FOR TODAY.